TO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN HERE.
ON PRESENT BATES [inaudible]
PRESIDENT VALLI [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
SKINNER.
STERN BY CASKEY HERE.
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM AND I
APPRECIATE ALL THE MEMBERS
GETTING HERE -- LET'S START WITH
US HOWEVER CHANGES HERE TO
PRESENT AB -- SIXTY EIGHT BACK
RULING EIGHTY YEARS [inaudible]
GEN.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR -- FIRSTLY TO START BY
THANKING ALL OF REPEAT MYSELF
OVER THE NUMBER OF BILLS THAT WE
GOT BUT JUST A FEW IN YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF WORKING WITH US
ALL ARE.
ALL OUR BILLS -- THIS IS A BILL
THAT IS WE BELIEVE ONE OF THE
SOLUTIONS TO OUR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS.
AT USE ARE ONE OF THE FASTEST
MOST AFFORDABLE WAY TO BUILD
HOUSING IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS.
DOESN'T CREATE A HUGE AMOUNT OF
DENSITY IN A CONFORMS TO OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS THE SAME TIME
THEY'RE BUILT BY.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD SO WE THINK IT'S
ONE OF THE FASTEST WAYS THAT WE
CAN SEE DEVELOPMENT.
THIS BILL REALLY STREAMLINES A
NUMBER OF PROVISIONS IN STATE
LAW TO MAKE SURE THAT CITIES
CANNOT -- ALLEY HAVE ARBITRARY
SQUARE FOOTAGE OR LOT SIZES IN
ORDERTO RESTRICT A TO USE IT
ALSO STREAMLINES EIGHTY USE THAT
ARE ON A TWO EIGHT EIGHT HUNDRED
SQUARE FEET AS WELL AS JUNIOR
EIGHTY USE UP.
TO FIVE HUNDRED SQUARE FEET --
WITH THAT WE HAVE -- ONE WITNESS
ASK HIM TO PRESENT IF THAT'S
OKAY.
LOUIS BRONTE WITH THE ACT
CALIFORNIA ME THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS.
WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT AB SIXTY
EIGHT BECAUSE EIGHTY USE COST
LESS TO BUILD AND TO RENT THEN
COMMENCE HERBAL -- MARKET RATE
UNITS ACCORDING TO RESTRICT
RESEARCH AT UC BERKELEY THEY CAN
BE A NATURALLY OCCURRING SOURCE
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND THEY CAN STABILIZE
HOMEOWNERS NOW WHO ARE FEELING
THE PINCH OF CALIFORNIA'S
IMMENSE HOUSING CRISIS.
I AB SIXTY IS IMPORTANT IT
BUILDS UP SUCCESSFUL STATE
LEGISLATION.
ENACTED IN -- TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN MANY
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA IS
SPECIALLY LA HAVE SEEN REAL
LARGE INCREASES IN THE NUMBER OF
THEIR EIGHTY YOU PERMITS WHICH
ARE SMALL INFILL HOUSING AND
TYPICALLY VERY ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY -- THIS -- THIS BILL
BILLS OFF THE SUCCESS -- IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES -- CARRYING
SOME OF THOSE LESSONS FORWARD I
STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY.
YOUR VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
[inaudible]
S..
TODAY THE BAY AREA HOUSING
ADVOCACY COALITION STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WHAT WAS CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE MON
AGAIN WE HAVE THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION IN
SUPPORT -- MEMBERS NIKITA CREDIT
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL EIGHTY USE ARE
IMPORTANT SMART GROWTH CLIMATE
STRATEGY IN SOMEONE STRONG
SUPPORT. FIFTY VAN FOR BRIDGE
HOUSING SUPPORT.
THURSDAY NIGHT AT WHITE HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
AND PH SB AT HOME AND TMZ
PARTNERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SYLVIA FOR HIM TO
HAVE A FACEBOOK IN SUPPORT. FOR
SO I CAN JUST HEAR ON BEHALF
LESS INTERESTED AMERICA.
IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT I DO WANT TO VOICE
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
[inaudible]
RAISE CONCERNS.
GOOD MORNING CARE AWESOME BEHALF
OF THE CITIES OF BURBANK SAN
MARCOS MARIN COUNTY COUNCIL
BEERS ACCOUNTS MEMBERS WE THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR THE WORK THAT'S
BEEN DONE ON THE BILL BUT WE
STILL REMAIN CONCERNED.
ABOUT A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT
ISSUES THERE'S A LOOPHOLE IN THE
BILL AROUND HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS THAT WE REMAIN
CONCERNED ABOUT -- WE ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PROHIBITION
ON OWNER OCCUPANCY REQUIREMENTS.
AND THEN FINALLY WE REALLY DO
REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PROHIBITION ON THE PARKING
RESTRICTIONS THIS IS ESPECIALLY
CONCERNING IN OUR AREA SAID
HELLFIRE ISSUES.
WE GET VERY NERVOUS ABOUT --
ROADS THAT WHERE THEY ARE VERY
NARROW IN SOME OF OUR MORE RURAL
COMMUNITIES WHERE IF YOU CANNOT
GET A FIRE TRUCK DOWN IF YOU
HAVE.
A CARS PARKED ON THE SIDE OF THE
ROAD SO THAT'S ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT WE REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT
SORT THANKFUL FOR THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE BUT STILL
REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
OTHER FOLKS HONOREES CONCERNS.
OKAY THE MATTERS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS
THOUGHTS.
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR COULD YOU
SPEAK TO THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS CONCERN THAT WAS
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION.
YEAH THE END OF THE DAY MY MY
STAFF JUST MATCHING THAT WITH
HEALTH AND SAFETY STANDARDS WE
HAVE [inaudible]
ON THE FIRE STORIES HAVE THE
ULTIMATE FRIDAY ON WHETHER TO
PERMIT NEEDY YOU I'M SO IF --
AND EIGHTY YOU ISN'T BEING TO BE
AND STAY FOR ANY REASON THEN
ULTIMATELY WILL BE PERMITTED
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY QUESTIONS OF ZERO CASKEY.
WITH THE PLOT FOR A FIVE EIGHTY
BILLS THAT WE HAVE.
AN AGREEMENT WITH AUTHORS BOB-HARMONIZATION WE HAVE FRIENDS
SINCE THE EIGHT HUNDRED SQUARE
FEET VERSUS SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
FIFTY THEY'LL THEY'LL BE
SOMETHING THAT THAT -- I WILL
NOTE THAT THE ARGUMENTS IN
SUPPORT FROM THE NATIONAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL TALKS
ABOUT THIS BILL REMOVING THE
REMAINING BARRIERS.
ROOM SOME OF THE RAINY BARRIERS
FOR SOME TO GO OUT BUT EXISTING
LAW IS THE STAFF AND THE AUTHOR
HAVE.
INDICATED THAT DOESN'T ALLOW US
THE FIRE DISTRICTS TO MAKE A
FINDING THAT IT SAID IT THAT THE
AREA IS A FIRE DANGER IT DOESN'T
GIVE THEM AN AUTOMATIC YOU.
YOU HAVE RESTRICTIONS ON PARKING
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE CURRENT
STATE LAW ALLOWS NO ADDITIONAL
PARKING IF YOU LIVE WITHIN A
HALF MILE OF TRANSIT SO THERE'S
THERE'S AN OVERLAY THAT GOES IN
BUT IF YOU'RE OUTSIDE THAT.
THAT AREA THEN THEN YOU'D --
THIS LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE A
OPPORTUNITY -- TO BLOCK IT SO
WITHOUT MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
THE QUESTION I BY SIR YES I JUST
LIKE TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE ISSUE
REGARDING ENOUGH SAFETY PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUES.
ARE OUT LOT COVERAGE HAS
EVERYTHING TO DO WITH THE SAFETY
OF IT GOING ON ON BOUGHT FOR
ACCESS.
FOR THE PUBLIC SAFETY REASONS
FIRST RESPONDERS AND IN
PARTICULAR THE PROXIMITY TO THAT --
WELLINGS NEXT DOOR SO I DON'T
THINK OF I THINK IT'S AWFULLY
SIMPLISTIC TO SAY THAT THE FIRE.
FOLKS WILL MAKE A DIFFERENCE ON
OUT BECAUSE IT'S REALLY PART OF
THE ZONING.
SO THAT REALLY NEEDS A DEEPER
DIVE A STRONGER LOOK AT WHETHER
THAT CAN BE SOMETHING THAT
FUNDING MEDICALLY MINISTERIAL
LEE -- EXEMPTED BECAUSE THE IT
HAS AFFECTED OUR PROPERTIES IN
LAGUNA BEACH WITH THE FIRES
THERE.
MIGHT REMEMBER THE THE DEBATE
THAT WENT ON REGARDING GRANNY
FLAT SO WHEN THAT WAS BEING
INCORPORATED YOU MAY NOT BECAUSE
THAT WAS BACK IN.
THE LATE EIGHTIES BUT I'M REALLY
REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT ALSO.
WE HAVE MANY -- DWELLINGS AND
SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY THAT ARE
BUILT ON CALL THE FAX.
IN THOSE HAVE VERY FEW -- CURB
pREASON SO THAT PEOPLE DON'T PARK
ON THE STREET.
OUR BECAUSE YOU CANNOT GET OUT
OF THOSE TRUCKS DOWN AND OUT THE
FIRE THIRTY ACTUALLY DID WEIGH
IN ON SOME OF THE DEVELOPMENT
FROM NOW I'LL EARLY AND MIDDLE
NINETIES.
NOT APPROVING BECAUSE INDUSTRIES
WERE TOO NARROW.
THAT THOSE COME AFTER THE FACT
IN WHEN YOU'RE JUST DOING AND
EIGHTY YOU.
KNOW THAT CAN EASILY BE MALE SO
THAT SOMETHING I THINK NEEDS A
REALLY CLOSER LOOK AT SO WITHOUT
I'M GONNA LAY OFF TODAY BECAUSE
I THINK AB USE ARE REALLY.
A GOOD PATH TO OUR HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY ISSUE.
THAT WE CANNOT I THINK DENY WITH
ALWAYS BEEN PART OF GOOD
PLANNING AND IT WAS THEIR
SPECIFICALLY -- TO ENSURE THAT
WE HAD PUBLIC THE SAFETY AND
HEALTH ISSUES OF COMMUNITIES ARE
ADDRESS THROUGH GOOD URBAN
PLANNING.
AND I THINK YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE
POINTERS THAT ARE VERY VERY WELL
TAKEN -- I WOULD JUST GIVE ONE
EXAMPLE SOME OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGHT AGAINST HIS WE
HAVE THE CITY OF PEOPLE ON WHICH
IS AND AND YOU KNOW VERY CLOSE
TO MY CITY -- THEY HAVE A
REQUIREMENT OF A MINIMUM EIGHT
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT LOT TO
BUILD AN EIGHTY YEAR AND THAT
SEEMS A LITTLE BIT -- BEYOND TO
FIRE SAFETY ISSUES I THINK I
THINK YOUR ISSUES AROUND FIRE
SAFETY ARE VERY IMPORTANT AND
YOU KNOW WE'LL WE'LL TAKE A
CLOSER LOOK AT THAT BUT I THINK.
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGHT AGAINST.
OKAY THIS IS ABOUT QUESTIONS YES
SENATE ON THE SCHOOL REAL QUICK
SO ON THE EIGHT THOUSAND AS
QUITE A FEW IT DEPENDS ON WHAT
IS ALREADY THE EXISTING THERE.
SO IF YOU HAVE A YOU KNOW THE
SIX THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT HOME
YOU'RE IT SO THAT THOSE ARE NEED
TO BE SOMEWHERE IN THE I MEAN IT.
WAS.
THAT CHAT WAS STOP FOR SECOND I
MEAN THERE HAS TO BE SOME
ABILITIES DO AS WE COMMONSENSE
ME HAS TO HAS TO WORK.
FOR THE DIVISIONAL SQUARE FOOT
EASIER PUTTING IN THERE SO I'M
ASSUMING THAT -- THAT WILL BE
AVAILABLE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO
SAY HEY FOR THE FIRE IF THERE'S
NOT ACCESS EGRESS.
THOSE ISSUES NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED WE'RE TRYING TO WE'RE
TRYING TO DO THIS IN A WAY THAT.
WHAT WILL COMPLEMENT A COMMUNITY
AND NOT HINDER IT?
AND COMING OUT OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT UNDERSTANDING AND
APPROVING MANY DIFFERENT DOES
SUBDIVISIONS -- AND WE WE GOT
WITH THE THE GRANNY FLATS AS
WELL IN THERE GOOD TOOL THEY'RE
ACTUALLY HELPFUL FOR THE
COMMUNITY -- WHERE THEY MAKE
SENSE BUT SOME PLACES THE LOT
SIZES DON'T MAKE THAT THEY JUST
DON'T MAKE SENSE AS WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE GIVE THE
ABILITY? FOR THE LOCALS TO BE ON
THE WAY IN.
WHERE THEY WERE DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE AND WHERE DOES MAKE SENSE
ALLOW THEM TO BE ABLE -- TO YOU
KNOW IF.
PUT IN THOSE SAID ADDITIONAL
UNITS.
AT LUIS PARTE AYE AYE I JUST
ECHO THE THE THE COMMENT THAT
WHILE WE TAKE THOSE CONCERNS
SERIOUSLY -- THE BILL WOULD NOT
AFFECT CALIFORNIA'S BUILDING
STANDARDS CODE WHICH CONTAINS
THE FIRE CODE WHICH DESCRIBES --
BOTH BUILDING MATERIALS THAT
SHOULD BE USED PREVENT FIRE BUT
ALSO SET STANDARDS FOR INGRESS
AND EGRESS.
THOSE ISSUES WOULD NOT BE
AFFECTED BY AB -- SIXTY EIGHT
SIMILARLY -- STATE EIGHTY YOU
LAW HAS A PROVISIONS THAT ALLOW
A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO ENSURE AS
A PART OF THE SAID THAT THE
SETBACK THAT THEY WOULD.
BE BE ALLOWED TO IMPOSE THEY IT
ALLOWS THEM TO CONSIDER FIRE
SAFETY AS A PART OF THAT -- SO I
WOULD DEFINITELY ECHO THAT WE
TAKE THOSE CONCERNS OR SAY
[inaudible]
OKAY.
YEAH I CAN FOR MY COLLEAGUES
THAT THE PROBLEMS NOT SO MUCH
THAT THE HAVE SIX THOUSAND
SQUARE FOOT HOUSE ON AN EIGHT
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT LOT EACH OF
AN EIGHT THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT
LOT YOU HAVE AN EIGHT HUNDRED
SQUARE FOOT HOUSE.
THAT WAS BUILT IN NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN AND THE CITY WANTS TO SAY
YOU'RE RESTRICTED 240% OF YOUR
EXISTING HOME THAT'S WHAT YOU.
GO TO BERKELEY WONDERFUL NANCY
CENTER SO I CAN SAY THAT.
YOU HAVE THEY HAVE IT'S IT'S THE
FLIP FLOP OF WHAT WE THINK WOULD
BE A CHALLENGE.
BY THE WAY THIS THIS BILL WILL
BE GOING TO GOVERN TO FINANCE IT
PASSES OUT COMMITTEE TODAY SO
THEY'LL BE LOOKING ON THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
LAKE IT'S EXPECTED SINISTER.
SMILE I WILL I WAS SITTING IN MY
OFFICE WORKING ON SOMETHING ON
RELATED TO THIS BILL IS WATCHING
ON TV SO I APOLOGIZE FOR MISSING
THE PRESENTATION IS ACTUALLY
COMPELLED BY -- WHAT I HEARD
FROM SOME MY COLLEAGUES IN SOME
OF THE CONCERNS IN THE LEAGUE I
JUST?
I WASN'T PLANNING TO HOLD OFF ON
THE BILL TODAY I I JUST NEED TO
DO WAY IN BECAUSE WHAT I HEARD
LET'S GET SPECIFIC HERE ON FIRE
CODE ISSUE COMING DRILL DOWN ON
THAT IT JUST.
GETS SO ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT
BUILDING INSPECTION ARE YOU
ACTUALLY TALKING ABOUT
TRANSPORTATION AND LAND USE
PLANNING [inaudible]
THERE IS.
THERE'S TWO PIECES AND LUIS FEEL
FREE TO JUMP IN BUT I THINK
THERE'S THE BUILDING CODES THAT
GET INTO HOW YOU BUILD.
THE EIGHTY YOU -- TO INSURE THAT
IT'S SAFE AND AS YOU KNOW SAFE
IN CASE OF FIRE AND THEN THERE'S
THE INDIVIDUAL PERMITS WHERE AND
THE BUILDING PERMIT.
IS DEPENDENT ON IN THIS CASE IF
YOU MEET THE REQUIREMENTS BUT
THE PENDING THE APPROVAL OF THE
FIRE AUTHORITIES.
THAT IS KIND OF TO ENSURE THE
THE BILL COVERS BOTH.
SO THE BILL DOESN'T HATCH EITHER
OF THOSE THAT'S JUST EXISTING ON
AND SO -- WHOM WHO DECIDES IN
THE TRANSPORTATION LAND USE
ELEMENT YOU'RE SAYING THIS THAT
THAT WOULD BE PREEMPTED LIKE
THAT.
YOU COULD ORROW EIGHTY USE IN
CERTAIN AREAS THROUGH THE THAT
THIS SPECIFIC PLAN OR THE
GENERAL PLAN IN THE AREA.
THAT YOU CONSULT YOU COULD ZONE
THAT OR NO GOT TO SELL THE BILL --
REQUIRES THAT WHERE HOUSING
RESIDENTIAL ZONING IS REQUIRED
THAT YOU CAN'T BAR EIGHTIES FROM
BEING BUILT IN THAT SPACE.
BUT IT DOESN'T REQUIRE THE
EIGHTIES BE BUILT IN IS DOWN IN
AN AREA THAT'S NOT ON FOR
RESIDENTIAL USE.
SO IF A LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAS
DECIDED THAT THERE'S A HIGH FIRE
RISK FOR AN AREA AND SAYS THAT
RESIDENTIAL USES ARE NOT
PERMITTED IN THAT AREA.
AB SIXTY EIGHT WOULD NOT COMPEL
THEM TO GO ALLOW THE HOUSING
RIGHT PUTTING NEIGHBORHOODS YES
YOU YOU IN OTHER WORDS YOU COULD
IN AT THE LAND USE LEVEL YOU CAN
THAT THE FIRE -- DEPARTMENT --
MARSHALL I GUESS IN THIS CASE
MARSHALL COULDN'T COME IN IT'S
MORE ABOUT THE LIKE IF THE SPACE
ITSELF LIKE DEFENSIBLE SPACE
ISSUE SORT OF THAT SET BACK
ISSUES MORE ABOUT.
THAT THEY LIKE TRAFFIC
BOTTLENECK EVACUATION ISSUES
THAT ARE TO SAY YES THAT'S TRUE
ALTHOUGH WE WOULD ASSUME THAT
LOCALS ARE TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION HOW DOES OWN.
RESIDENTIAL AREAS TO INCORPORATE
FIRE SAFETY I GUESS THAT.
WE LAID OFF TAKE THAT IN
CONSIDERATION SOME AS WHEN YOU
GET BERKELEY AND YOU CAN'T YOU
KNOW THESE HILLS AND THEN IT
JUST THINGS JUST SORT OF
HAPPENED YOU FIND THESE
MEANDERING NEIGHBORHOODS THAT
JUST SORT OF BECOME.
AND IT'S AND IT'S JUST A IT'S A
TRICKY NEEDLE THREATEN THOSE.
WE DON'T TOUCH EXISTING LAW THIS
IS ALL EXISTING LAW.
SO OUR BILL DOES NOT.
TOUCH ANY OF THAT.
IT'S A GOOD THING ON A GO
FORWARD BASIS YES.
EVEN ON MY PRIOR SAFETY YEAH WE
DON'T TOUCH FAR SO YEAH.
WE WE UNDERSTAND YOUR ISSUE WITH --
YES IS IT THIS IS WHAT WE'RE
ARTICULATING IS JUST WHAT IS
EXISTING LAW IT HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH.
OKAY OUR OUR CABLE DOES NOT
TOUCH YOU CAN JUDGE I GOT YOU.
ALL RIGHT SORRY FOR JUMPING IN I
JUST -- YEAH THIS IS A BIG DEAL
BACK HOME OF COURSE -- YEAH I'M
SENSITIVE ABOUT IT SO I'M I'M
GONNA HOLD OFF TODAY BUT I DO
WANT TO DRILL DOWN FURTHER AND
JUST GET SOME CLARITY AND WALK
THROUGH EXACTLY WHAT THE
MECHANICS WILL BE BECAUSE I
THINK.
WHAT I HEAR YOU SAYING IS THE
INTENT ISN'T TO OVERRIDE FIRE
SAFETY?
THAT THAT THAT'S NOT IN THAT ONE
FACT WE DON'T TOUCH FAR SO YOU
DON'T EVEN TOUCH IT SO IT'S ALL
RIGHT SO IT'S ALL THE ALL THE
CONCERNS YOU ARE.
ADDRESSING WE'RE JUST
ARTICULATING WHAT CURRENT LAW IS
OUR BILL DOES NOT OKAY DO
ANYTHING UNDERSTOOD ON THIS
ISSUE.
IN REGARDS CARP HELPS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER.
YEAH SENATE OLLIE.
SO THIS MAKE SURE MAKE CLEAR SO
IT AT EXISTING SET BACKS IN THE
SUBDIVISION.
HAVE TO BE MET [inaudible]
EXISTING.
THE FARMERS ARE TO COME OUT AND
SAY YES YOU ARE ALLOWED TO BE
ABLE TO PUT THE SECOND UNIT IN.
BECAUSE IT WILL MEET THE
STANDARDS THAT IS STILL SAFE.
IF THEY DON'T MEET THOSE
STANDARDS THEY CAN'T THEY'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO THEN MOVE FORWARD.
AS A REALLY TO FIRE SAFETY AND
AND THEN THE SET BACKS FOR LOT
SIZES BECAUSE IF YOU'RE GONNA
ADD ANOTHER UNIT IN THERE.
IF YOU HAVE A SET BACK OF TWENTY
FEET FROM THE FROM THE PROPERTY
LINE YOU HAVE TO STILL MEET THAT
SET BACK CORRECT.
THE BILL WOULD CURTAIL -- SOME
ABILITY TO IMPOSE OR DO YOU
EXISTING LAWS ALREADY HAS --
SOME IMPOSITIONS ON ABILITY TO
DETERMINE THINGS LIKE LOTS OF
OUR OR SETBACKS -- BUT AS A
REALLY TO FIRE SAFETY IF THERE'S
A FIRE SAFETY ISSUE IMPOSED BY --
THE THE STEP BACK AND THEN THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COULD IMPOSE
[inaudible]
YES.
THEY CAN DâN SO THIS SET BACKS
UP TO STAY THE SAME OR NO.
AS A REALLY TO FIRE SAFETY THEY
WOULD HAVE TO STAY THE SAME BUT
OTHER SETBACKS COULD BE WAIVED
BY THE MINISTER PROVISIONS OF
THE AB [inaudible]
SIXTY THE SERVER.
I'M JUST READING WHAT THE
DIGESTIVE SAYING ABOUT THE THE
BILL ITSELF AND I THINK WHAT WE
HAVE HERE SOMETHING THAT'S GOING
TO BE VERY CONFUSING AND OUT
PROBABLY IS WHERE YOU NEED.
TO KIND OF FOCUS IN GOING
FORWARD IT SPECIFICALLY SAYS
THIS DIGEST THIS IS ON OUR ITEM
NUMBER C. PROVIDES AT A LOCAL
EIGHTY YOU OR DANCE CANNOT
IMPOSE Là COVERAGE STANDARDS.
REQUIRE MINIMUM LOT SIZE OR
CERTAIN SET BACKS AND I THINK --
GOES ON ABOUT THE PARKING WHICH
IS ANOTHER ISSUE THAT I THINK
THE FACT BACK ISSUES IS.
SIGNIFICANTLY HUGE IN TERMS OF
WHO'S GONNA SAY -- THAT YOU CAN
OR CANNOT BUILD THIS PARTICULAR
EDIE YOU BECAUSE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS GOING TO BE IN A
VERY CONFUSING POSITION SAYING
YOU KNOW THIS OF THE LAW SAYS
ACT.
AND IS NOW WE HAVE TO CALL THE
FIRE FOLKS IN.
AND THEY MAY HAVE ALREADY
APPROVED IT MINISTERIAL COULD
ABOUT ALREADY GONE THROUGH SO I
THINK THAT JUST NEEDS TO BE.
REFINED A LITTLE -- YOU KNOW
MORE SPECIFICALLY ARE THAT THAT
HAS TO BE SUBJECT TO MAYBE
THAT'S WHAT THE LANGUAGE I READ
A SUBJECT TO REVIEW BY THE LOCAL
FIRE FORTY YEAR.
FIRE SAFETY COUNCIL WHATEVER
EXIST IN A PARTICULAR
JURISDICTION.
BECAUSE IT IS ABOUT THE SET BACK
THERE'S ALSO NOISE STANDARDS
THAT ARE SIGNIFICANT IN CERTAIN
CITIES WHERE YOU FEEL THE THAT
BACK AREA WITH EQUIPMENT.
THAT'S RIGHT.
YOU KNOW AIR CONDITIONERS OR
WHATEVER AND THOSE ARE THOSE ARE
THINGS THAT ARE PART OF HEALTH
AND SAFETY TO SO.
I THINK THERE HAS TO BE A LITTLE
MORE.
SPECIFICITY ON WHO HAS THE RIGHT
TO OVERRIDE THE MINISTERIAL
REVIEW IF THERE'S AN ISSUE
SOMETHING THAT WOULD.
YOU KNOW DEFINE IT SO YOU DON'T
HAVE THIS CONFUSION AND THEN YOU
GOT LITIGATION.
YEAH I THINK I'M FOR HALF TAKE A
LOOK THAT WOULD TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
WHY?
EIGHT I'M GONNA HAVE OUR STAFF
TALK -- TO THE GOVERNMENT
FLOATED IF IF THE BILL PASSES
OUT TODAY I MEAN DOES.
HAVE STAFF GALLAGHER WITH THE
GUN FINANCE.
COMMITTEE STAFF.
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL THE ISSUES
THAT WERE RAISED HERE TODAY ARE --
RELATED TO THAT COMMITTEE.
SO THAT THEY CAN KIND OF TAKE A
PASS AT A NUMBER OF THESE
CONCERNS GLAM AFFECT.
NUMBER ISSUES OF AN RAISE THAT I
THINK OF MERIT A LITTLE MORE
DEEP DIVE.
SO I'M CERTAINLY HAPPY -- TO YOU
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION WITH
THIS BILL TODAY BUT I DO THINK
TO SOME MORE WORK TO BE DONE THE
NEXT COMMITTEE. FOR OKAY HARM TO
ANY FOR THE QUESTION SAID CENTER.
LET'S MOVE BY SENATOR CASKET
PLEASE CLOSE.
DISTANCE PERFECT PLACE PRIVATE
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE ALL
THE FEEDBACK I THINK IN
PARTICULAR.
AROUND FIRE SAFETY WE UNDERSTAND
THE CONCERNS ARE LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS WILL BE HAPPY.
TO WORK WITH EVERYONE TO ADDRESS
IN THE NEXT.
OKAY.
THE CAMPUS CORE.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB.
SIXTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED THE SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR ALLEN HI ALAN HI BATES
[inaudible]
DOLLY [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
LAKE OWSKI I CASKEY AYE OKAY
WE'LL HOLD THE ROLE OF BEEN --
FOR THAT.
I'M. TO TWO ZERO SO FAR I'M SO I
YOU CAN HAVE THIS ON HOLD AGAIN
OKAY ALL RIGHT.
I'M.
THE THIRD THING IS GRACIOUSLY.
DIFFERENT A SUMMER HOLD ANY OF
YOU HAVE A I'D LIKE TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE -- SOMEONE EVER TING
OF FOR HIS -- WILLINGNESS TO
ALLOW ME TO PRESENT OR WILL BE
BRIEF -- WE ARE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS A TWO A. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT THAT WERE
AGREED TO AND NATURAL RESOURCES.
AND LET ME JUST SAY THAT.
ARE WE WANT TO ALSO EXPRESS THAT.
WE HAVE REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL.
THERE ARE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
OLD AND POTENTIALLY LEAKING OIL
AND GAS WELLS IN CALIFORNIA.
SOME OF THESE SITES ARE IDLE
DESERTED OR HAZARDOUS AND THOSE
ARE THE FOCUS OF THIS BILL.
LIKE ACTED PRODUCTION SITES IDLE
DESERTED AND HAZARDOUS OIL AND
GAS WELLS CAM LEAK.
POTENTIAL EMISSIONS FROM IDA
WELLS INCLUDE METHANE AND BEEN
SAME.
METHANE IS A CLIMATE CHANGING
GAS MANY TIMES MORE POWERFUL
THAN CARBON DIOXIDE WHILE OTHER
CO ADMITTED HERE POLLUTANTS LIKE
BENZENE CAN CAUSE CANCER.
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT WOULD
MAKE THIS INFORMATION ON LEAKS
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE CREATING A
BODY OF INFORMATION THAT IS
IMPORTANT TO KNOW IN THE SIZE
AND SCOPE OF EMISSIONS FROM
OTTAWA DESERTED WELLS.
A. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTY ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
CREATING A SCIENTIFIC STUDY OF
THESE WELLS AND REQUIRES THE
DATA COLLECTED BE MADE PUBLIC.
I HAVE WITH ME LOREN OF OUR FROM
AN ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND TO
DISCUSS THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
LEGISLATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
HI LAUREN OF OUR WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND WERE
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT BUT
RESPECTING YOUR TIME TODAY HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. FIVE
OTHER FOLKS TO ONE ADELINE
SPORTS.
SECURE CREDIT WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
BILL ALLEY -- ENVIRONMENT
WORKING GROUP NOT IN THE FORMAL
ANALYSIS YEP IT WE WILL BE
SUBMITTING A LETTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THE VICE CUFF NEXTRA
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
AMONG OTHER SUPPORT PERSON.
IS BACK OKAY I OTHER FOLKS WANT
TO RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
OPPOSITION NOW.
YOU'RE JUST TRYING TO GET
THROUGH YEAH.
THE OTHER TRIED ON BEHALF OF
STEEL CV IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
OKAY.
OKAY -- CIRCUMCISION.
YES OF I'M SORRY OPPOSITION.
CONCERNS NOW OKAY SO IT ASKING
ALL I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL
IT'S I THINK IT'S LONG OVERDUE
AND STANDARDIZING.
THIS FELLA PERIOD FOR NOTICES
AGAIN LONG OVERDUE.
YEAH THE SENATOR [inaudible]
OKAY.
QUESTION STATS I I'VE BY HERE'S
AN ACOSTA MOVING THE BILL WITH
SPRING IT TO ME -- IF YOU'D LIKE.
TO I HAVE CLOSE RESPECT TO ASK
HER OUT OKAY AS MOVED BY.
SOME OBSERVER CASKEY.
TECHNICALLY SCORE.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
HI ALLEN RIGHT BATES RIGHT BATES
AYE DALY.
THE ONLY AYE HILL [inaudible]
SKINNER STERN.
WHY CASKEY THE CASKET
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO THAT'S FOUR ZERO
HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET APPLE
HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE MEMBERS OUT
ON GRADUATION THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT OKAY WILL
BRING US SOME
.
OKAY THIS IS THAT ITEM THREE IN
YOUR PACKETS NUMBERS AB ONE
SIXTY ONE YES -- MEMBERS --
AGAIN AGAIN THANK THANKS AGAIN
FOR YOUR IN YOUR COMMITTEES --
WORK WE TOOK AMENDMENTS IN
JUDICIARY. TO REMOVE THE DIGITAL
RECEIPT MANDATE.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS STARTING
ON JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
TWO WOULD REQUIRE RECEIPTS BE
AVAILABLE ONLY UPON REQUEST IN
FOR THOSE RECEIPTS TO BE BPA PPS
FREE AND NO LONGER?
THAN NECESSARY -- WE'VE SEEN A
DOCUMENT REPORTS ABOUT HOW MUCH
RENEWABLE RESOURCES ARE USED FOR
PAPER RECEIPTS.
BUT THERE'S THE THREE MILLION
TREES WITH THE NINE BILLION
GALLONS OF WATER NATION WIDE IN
THE THREE HUNDRED AND TWO
MILLION POUNDS OF WASTE -- AS
YOU KNOW PROCEEDS ARE NOT
COMPOSTABLE AND THEY'RE VERY
VERY DIFFICULT TO RESPOND CALL
ESPECIALLY WITH THE TOXIC PAPER.
OUT WITHOUT RESPECT YOURS FOR
AYE VOTE AB ONE SIXTY ONE WE
HAVE TWO WITNESSES.
GOOD MORNING OFFICE OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE.
THIS BILL REALLY TACKLES ONE OF
THE LOW HANGING FRUITS IN TERMS
OF WASTE REDUCTION.
AND THAT'S THE CATEGORY OF
PRODUCTS THAT WE GET HANDED THAT
WE DON'T WANT -- WHEN WE BUY A
MORNING CUP OF COFFEE OR DOWN AT
WE DON'T NEED A RECEIPT FOR THAT?
WHEN WE GO TO CVS AND END UP
WITH A FOUR FOOT LONG WORSE THE?
AGAIN I DON'T THINK ANY OF US
WANT A FOUR FOOT LONGER SEE THE
ALL THE BILL SAYS IS THAT IF YOU
DON'T WANT A RECEIPT.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GET -- ONE
SAID IT'S IT'S A SOURCE
REDUCTION STRATEGY BUT ALSO
MAKES FOLKS AWARE OF THE WAYS
THAT THEY CONSUME ON DAILY BASIS.
THEY MIGHT NOT BE AWARE OF AND
THEN SECONDLY IT ELIMINATES A
SOURCE OF CONTAMINATION AND
COMPOSTING AND RECYCLING.
THAT BPA AND BE PS -- END UP AND
COMPOST AND IN THE RECYCLING
STREAM THE THERMAL COATINGS MAKE
THE PAPER HARD TO RECYCLE.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS THIS IS A
REALLY COMMONSENSE BILL THANK
YOU.
NO ALLEY -- FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP -- ALL FOCUS ON
THE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
AFFECTS OF THIS IS BILLS WITH
TOXICS AND THIS.
BILL AB ONE SIXTY ONE DEALS WITH
A TOXIC MATTER AND THAT IS THE
BEST BEING ALTERED BPA BE PS AND
THE RECEIPTS -- IN TWENTY ELEVEN
THIS LEGISLATURE AND WAS CHAIRED
BY SENATOR WITH HOUSEKEEPING AND
CHAIR OF THE S. AND COMMITTEE
PASSED.
A BILL BANNING BISPING ALL A AND
BABY BALLS AND SIPPY CUPS SIGNED
BY THE GOVERNOR.
AND IS NOW LAW AND WHAT THAT DID
WAS LEAD THE WAY LEADING TO THE
INDUSTRY SITTING DOWN WITH THE
U. S. FDA SAYING WE'LL JUST TAKE
IT OUT OF THESE THINGS SO
CALIFORNIA WAS A LEADER.
AND THAT ENDED UP IN A CASCADING
OF OF MARKET CHANGES THAT GOT
THIS TOXIC CHEMICAL OUT OF
CONSUMERS PRODUCTS WE THINK THE
SAME SHOULD BE DONE FOR PAPER
RECEIPTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OKAY AFFECTS ONE OUT
ON A SUPPORT. TEN OF ELEVEN ON
ON BEHALF OF THE CLEAN SEIZE
LOBBYING COALITION AND SUPPORT
HIM [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE [inaudible]
EITHER.
CATHERINE GARCIA ON BEHALF OF
YOUR CLUB CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
OKAY OUR OPPOSITION TRUCKS
HONOREES CONCERNS BUT THE BILL
[inaudible]
GO.
FOR I'M IN BETWEEN -- SIGNED NOT
OPPOSE A SIMILAR POSITION IS A
PUZZLE CEMENT ON AIR RIGHT NOW
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA GROCERS
ATION -- WE'VE BEEN TALKING TO
MR TING IN IS -- STAFF BOB GREAT
TO WORK WITH OUR CONCERN IS THAT --
AS YOU ALL KNOW GROWS JUST HAVE
TO CAST BE TWO SEVENTY WHICH
MEANS WE DON'T HAVE THE SINGLE
USE PLASTIC BAGS.
AS A RESULT A LOT OF CUSTOMERS
NOW AND YOU'LL GO TO THE STORE
AND SEE YOURSELF SURGERY THE
WALK OUT THE STORE WITH THEIR
FOR THE PRODUCTS IN THE CART.
IN THEIR HAND IN THEIR OWN BAG --
BECAUSE OF THAT WE HAVE ASKED OR
WE WOULD.
ASK THAT THE CHAIRED OR MISTER
TING TO ACCOMMODATE US THE BILL
CAME OUT OF ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS WITH.
A SORT OF OFFRAMP FOR PEOPLE
LIKE US WHERE -- WE CAN PROVIDE
THE BBB PSP RECEIPTS WE JUST
NEED TO GIVE THE RECEIPT TO
FIGURE OUT WHO'S BOTCHED UP WHEN
THE STORE -- WE WOULD ASK THE
SAME THING HERE BECAUSE THE
FAULT IS STILL NO RECEIPT AND WE
NEED TO GET THE RECEIPT TO
FIGURE OUT WHO'S BOUGHT STUFF TO
DO AS MUCH STUFF SO.
OUR REQUEST ASSEMBLY THAT -- FOR
FOLKS WHO ARE SUBJECT SB TWO
SEVENTY AS GROCERS ARE AND AND
SPEAKING TO WASTE REDUCTION
WE'VE GIVEN AT THE OFFICE TO TO
USE THAT TERM -- WE'RE OKAY WITH
GONE BPA PPS FREE ADDRESSING THE
TOXICS ISSUE AND WE'VE LET --
MISTER TING STAFF KNOW THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GO OUT THERE BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TO ELIMINATE.
AB PSP RECEIPTS WE JUST AS A WE
CAN STILL GET THE RECEIPT
BECAUSE SHOPLIFTING IS A BIG
PROBLEM RECEIPTS ARE WAY TO
FIGURE OUT WHO HAS AND HAS ABOUT
STUFF AND AND THAT'S OUR
POSITION TO SUPPOSE WAS AMENDED
WE ASK FOR THAT.
AMENDMENT -- TO BE TAKEN AT SOME
POINT.
BEFORE YOU GO LET'S WHAT
DISTURBS ME PEOPLE HERE WHEN WE
ASK ABOUT THIS BECAUSE THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT I I HEARD RAISED
EARLIER -- WE'LL TRY AND COURAGE
PEOPLE YOU KNOW -- TO TO NOT USE
THE BAGS -- THAT'S A WASTE
REDUCTION ISSUES BECAUSE WELL SO
PEOPLE ARE COMING WITH THEIR OWN
BAG THEIR OWN SHOPPING CARDS.
ARE THAT'S ALL GOOD BUT IT MAKES
IT EVEN MORE DIFFICULT I WOULD
THINK TO VERIFY THAT SOMEONE
ACTUALLY PURCHASED THE ITEMS
THAT THEY'RE WALKING OUT OF THE
STORE WITH -- OBVIOUSLY THIRD
THERE WITH THAT STORE PROVIDING
BAGS IT PROVIDES A LITTLE MORE
OF AN INDICATION SO.
HOW DOES HOW DOES A STORE --
DEAL WITH THIS QUESTION -- IF
THEY'RE USING THEIR OWN BAGS AND
AND THERE'S NO RECIBE PROVIDED I
THINK IT'S A GREAT QUESTION MISS
MARINO HAS ASSOCIATIONS BEEN
BEEN GREAT TO WORK WITH WE HAVE
A DIALOGUE -- IF YOU THINK ABOUT
IT -- IT'S GREAT ARGUMENT
HOWEVER MOST STORES DON'T CHECK
RECEIPTS UPON LEAVING THE STORE.
SO FROM MOSCOW DEFINITELY DOES
COSCO DOES BUT MOST GROCERS
DON'T IF YOU'RE IN A SAFE WAY
YOUR LUCKY.
YOUR IN A ALBERTSON'S -- SAVE
MART I CAN'T REMEMBER THE LAST
TIME THEY CHECKED OR THERE ARE
CERTAIN RETAILERS COSCO BEST BUY.
I BELIEVE SAM'S CLUB WALMART
THEY THEY DEFINITELY DO THAT.
MOST RETAILERS DO NOT RITE AID
WALGREENS WE CAN GO DOWN THE
LIST TO ME WHEN YOU GET A
RECEIPT.
YOU WALK OUT HI I'M NOW I DON'T
EVEN TAKE BACK ALL ALL WALK OUT
WITH THE STUFF IN MY ARMS -- HOW
TO REMEMBER THE LAST TIME
OUTSIDE OF THOSE THOSE FEW
INSTANCES WHERE WE HAVE CHECKED
AGAIN?
I THINK WE'RE HAPPY TO CONTINUE
A DIALOGUE TO SEE IF WE CAN FIND
A SWEET SPOT AND WE HOPE WE CAN --
I THINK IN 80% OF THE SITUATIONS
YOU ARE NOT EVER ASK FOR A
RECEIPT UPON EXITING THAT STORE
RIGHT TO THE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
20%.
WELL THE POINT IS I THINK WORK
WE'RE HAPPY TO CONTINUE THE THE
DIALOGUE TO SEE IF WE CAN FIGURE
IT OUT [inaudible]
HELLO.
TO UP WITH PERSON OBVIOUSLY --
TO AS A MEMBER KINGS POINT --
YET OBVIOUSLY SAFE WITH THERE'S
NO PEOPLE CHECKING RECEIPTS ON
THE WAY OUT BUT THERE IS
SECURITY EITHER -- HIGHER
SECURITY OR UNDER HAVE SECURITY
THAT WHEN PEOPLE ARE GOING OUT
THE DOOR SOMETIMES SOMETIMES I
DO CHECK IT'S NOT AS COSTS GO
WITH A FORMALLY DO IT AS AN
OPERATIONAL -- THING THAT THEY
DO BUT FOR A LOT OF STORES WHERE
PARTICULAR THERE'S HIGHER
INSTEAD OF SHOPLIFTING AFTER
THING THEIR SECURITY WHO WILL
WHO WILL ASK TO SEE RECEIVE IT'S
NOT A FORMAL PROCEDURE BUT
CERTAIN TIMES A DAY OR OR
CERTAIN PLACES.
AGAIN WHEN PEOPLE LEAVING THE
STORE THOUGH SOMETIMES HAS TAKEN
AS THE RECEIPT BECAUSE YOU KNOW
IT'S SOMETIMES WILL DISMISS WHEN
YOU SEE SOMEBODY LEAVING THE
STORE THE CART FULL OF YOU KNOW
CASE OF BEER AND DID YOU BUY IT
OR NOT.
YEAH I MEAN ALMOST IT'S USUALLY
A MAKES YOU WONDER ONE OF THE
COMMENTS MADE BY A ONE OF THE
PROPONENTS WAS THAT YOU KNOW
PEOPLE DON'T.
ASK FOR FOUR FOOT -- RECEIPT AND
THAT'S TRUE.
THAT'S HELLO MY AGE BUT MAYBE
THERE'S A WAY.
TO ALLOW STORES TO PROVIDE
SOMETHING MUCH MORE --
DISTINCTION SMALL.
THAT WOULD HAVE THE KIND OF
WASTE -- ISSUES ASSOCIATE WITH A
FOUR FOOT RECEIPT WHILE ALSO AT
THE SAME TIME ALLOWING FOR SOME
FORM OF VERIFICATION IN THOSE
STORES WHAT WHERE THERE IS A
HIGH SHOPLIFTING RIGHT.
I THINK ALSO IF YOU -- THAT THE
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT OPTIONS --
IF YOU'RE OUT LIKE THE TARGET
THE TRACK IT BASED ON YOUR
CREDIT CARD -- YOU KNOW APPLE
HAS BEEN HIGHLY PUBLICIZED IN
TERMS OF PEOPLE ACTUALLY GOING
IN THERE AND AND SHOPLIFTING.
THEY'RE ONE OF THE STORES WERE
YOU CAN'T GET A PAPER SEE AND
AND AGAIN.
THE BILL APSLEY ALLOWS OUT FOR
PAPER RECEIPTS UPON REQUEST SO
IF YOU WANT A PAPER RECEIPT YOU
CAN ALWAYS REQUEST.
FOR THEM TO JUST ON THIS ONE
PARTICULAR ISSUE OUT ON THE
GROCERY YEAH.
YES CENTER -- BECAUSE WHERE I
LIVE THERE'S BEEN A EITHER
LIMITS ON BAGS OR JUST A KIND OF
PUBLIC.
NOT WANTING TO USE BAGS AND
SINCE MOST OF US.
FORGET.
THE BAGS YEAH YEAH YEAH SO
BASICALLY MOST PEOPLE ARE
CARRYING AROUND RIGHT THE THINGS
THEY PURCHASED.
AND SO OF COURSE VERY MANY
STORES ARE THAN NERVOUS WILL
THAT MIGHT MEAN -- YOU STONE OR
WHATEVER BUT WHAT THE WHAT'S
COMMON IN MY AREA AROUND SOURCES
THE PORTAL STICKER.
THEY'LL EITHER STAMP LIKE YOU DO
WHEN YOU GO TO A CONCERT AND
THAT MEANS YOU BOUGHT IT. FOR A
LITTLE STICKER IN THAT WAY THERE
OR THEIR OR SECURITY OR EVER
DOESN'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THE
FACT THAT YOU'RE WALKING AROUND
WITH A BUNCH OF GOODS IN YOUR
ARMS THAT YOU BOUGHT.
SO THEY DON'T YOU DON'T NEED THE
RECEIPT TO SHOW THAT YOU BY.
YEAH I LOOK I GUESS MY POINT IS
IF WE'RE IF WE'RE JUST.
YOU KNOW AT WHAT AT WHAT POINT
DOES THE HERE WE ARE.
STEPPING IN AND TELLING STORIES
WHAT TO DO AND WHAT POINT IS THE
WASTE REDUCTION ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS.
I OUTWEIGH THE WASTE YOU KNOW
THERE THERE'S ME NEW WASTE
PRODUCED BY THE STICKERS PERHAPS
AND MAYBE THERE CAN BE LESS
RECYCLABLE THAN THAT RECEIPTS.
YOU KNOW WHAT RIGHT AND UP ON
THE FLOOR YOUR RAISE ONE OTHER
POINT THAT AS MY UNDERSTAND HAS
MEMORIES SO WE ARE.
THE DOMAIN WE HAVE IN THIS
COMMITTEE IS THE ISSUE OF WASTE
[inaudible]
BUT MOST RECEIPTS.
ESPECIALLY AFTER CREDIT CARD.
ARE THE HEAT SENSITIVE.
THE HEAT SENSITIVE TECHNOLOGY
REQUIRES EPA THIS FINALE.
THERE IS RECENT DATA THAT SHOWS
IF YOU USE HAND SANITIZER.
YOU CONCENTRATE THE BPA.
ON YOUR HANDS AND DUST YOU YOU
HAVE A HIGHER YOU ABSORB MORE
[inaudible]
AND SO.
IN LOOKING AT PEOPLE WHO WORK AT
STORES AND HANDLE RECEIPTS.
ALREADY AMERICANS HAVE THE
HIGHER LEVEL OF BPA.
IN THEIR BLOOD IN THEIR BODY
BODY COUNT OF AND STORE CLERKS.
HAVE THE HIGHEST.
OF AMERICANS BECAUSE OF THAT SO
WHILE THAT'S NOT THE DOMAIN OF
OUR I COMMITTEE.
IS A FACTOR THAT SHOULD END
THERE.
YEAH OKAY THANK YOU -- OTHER
FOLKS TO ONE OF HIS OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS STUART HOMAN
CHIEF SCIENTIST AMERICAN FORCING
PAPER ASSOCIATION.
I'M SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION AB.
ONE SIXTY ONE I'M HERE TODAY TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE MISLEADING
STATEMENTS ABOUT PAPER RECEIPTS
THAT ARE BEING USED TO SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL ON APPRECIATE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO OFFER SOME FACTS
ABOUT OUR PRODUCTS.
PLEASE LET ME START WITH
INFORMATION ON BISCAYNE ALL A IS
A DATE ARE REAL FAST.
AND THEN COMPARE BY ANALOGY TO
BISPING ALL S..
THAT IS ACTUALLY USED IN
RECEIPTS.
NUMBER ONE PAPER RECEIPTS OR
SAFE FOR CONSUMERS AND POINT OF
SAFE SALE PERSONNEL TO HANDLE.
MAJORITY BPA EXPOSURES FROM FOOD
FDA'S CURRENT PERSPECTIVE BASED
ON ITS MOST RECENT SAFETY
ASSESSMENT.
IS THE BPA IS SAFE AT THE
CURRENT LEVELS OF CURRENT FOODS.
TO DATE NO STUDIES HAVE BEEN
LINKED VOTER TO BE PA WITH
CANCER IN HUMANS.
AND ANIMAL STUDIES SUPPORT THIS
VERY SCIENTIFIC GROUPS INCLUDING
THE US TOXICOLOGY PROGRAM.
AND THE E. U. THEREFORE
CONCLUDED THAT BP IS BPA IS NOT
A CARCINOGEN.
THE NDP ALSO CONDUCTED THAT
THERE IS INSUFFICIENT EVIDENCE
TO LINK CONSUMER OR COCKING
BIGGEST OCCUPATIONAL EXPOSURES
TO BPA.
WITH REPRODUCTIVE AFFECTS OUR
DEVELOPMENTAL EFFECTS IN HUMANS.
ALTHOUGH BPA HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED
AS A POSSIBLE AND THE PRINTER
DISRUPTOR SUBSEQUENT STUDIES
EXAMINING DEVELOPMENTAL
REPRODUCTIVE ARM UNIFICATION
ANIMALS AND HUMANS.
DO NOT SUPPORT THE OCCURRENCE OF
SUCH ADVERSE EFFECTS.
BOTH THE FDA AND AFTER CONCLUDE
THAT ANTICIPATED CONSUMER
EXPOSURES TO BPA POSES NO HEALTH
RISK.
ANTICIPATED OCCUPATIONAL
EXPOSURE TO BE P. A. SUCH AS BY
CASHIERS ARE ALSO JUDGED TO BE
SAFE.
WE CAN PROVIDE YOU WITH
CITATIONS IN THE LITERATURE
SHOWING THAT THE WEIGHT OF THE
EVIDENCE AND LET SUPPORTS THAT
OCCUPATIONAL EXPOSURE IS SAFE.
SIMILAR OR EVEN LESS B. P. S.
GETS INTO THE BODY FROM THERMAL
RECEIPTS THE BPA.
BASED ON STUDIES IN CELLS IN
SIMPLE ORGANISMS PPS HAS SIMILAR
OR LOWER RESPONSE AND BPA.
THIS IMPLIES THAT BE PS
CONCENTRATIONS CONSUMERS IN CASH
YEARS MIGHT BE EXPOSED WILL BE
SAFE.
CONTRARY TO CLAIMS BY BILL
SUPPORTERS THE E. U. IS NOT
BANNED BE PS AND THERMAL RECEIPT
PAPERS.
THAT YOU BàN APPLIES TO BE PA
ONLY ALSO THAT NO MAN US
MANUFACTURERS AND NONE OF THE
MAJOR IMPORTERS.
WHO WE REPRESENT USE PAPERS WITH
BPA COATINGS?
THIS LEGISLATION SHOULD NOT BE A
VEHICLE THE MAN BE PS AND
RECEIVE PAPERS.
PROP SIXTY FIVE REQUIRES
BUSINESSES PROVIDE WARNINGS
ABOUT SIGNIFICANT EXPOSURE TO
CHEMICALS.
THE LIST INCLUDES OVER NINE
HUNDRED CHEMICALS AND ALSO
INCLUDES THE SAFE HARBOR LEVEL
FOR EACH CHEMICAL IF ONE HAS
BEEN ADOPTED.
IT ALSO IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THE
PROP SIXTY FIVE LIST DOES NOT
INCLUDE THE P. S..
IF CALIFORNIA WANTS TO
APPROPRIATELY REGULATE BE PS IN
RECEIPT PAPER IT SHOULD DO SO BY
THE VEHICLE.
BUY THIS VEHICLE OR THROUGH THE
SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCT PROGRAM
TO AVOID CHEMICAL USE BANDS THAT
LACKS SIGN TO SCIENTIFIC
FOUNDATION.
FURTHERMORE SOME THERMAL RECEIPT
PAPER INCLUDING CALIFORNIA STATE
LOTTERY TICKETS PARKING TICKETS
BOARDING PASSES AND OTHER
GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS USE BE PS.
IF THESE PRODUCTS POSE A HAZARD
AS AB ONE FOR SIXTY ONE CLAIMS
THE STATE SHOULDN'T NOT EXEMPT
ITSELF WHAT PENALIZING CONSUMERS
AND SMALL BUSINESSES.
SO IN SUMMARY -- I. R. G. OPPOSE
AB ONE SIXTY ONE WHICH IS AND
AND RUN AROUND CALIFORNIA'S
RIGOROUS AND PROTECTIVE PROCESS.
FOR REGULATION OF CHEMICALS IN
CONSUMER PRODUCTS THANK YOU.
WHAT CHAIR MEMBERS ADAMANTLY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE?
I'LL KEEP MY A OPPOSITION
RELATIVELY BRIEF --
FUNDAMENTALLY OPPOSED THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY.
THE SKIP THE SLIP CONCEPT WE
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE THAT IS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE FOR ALL
RETAILERS.
SPECIFICALLY ALLOWING THE
CUSTOMER TO CHOOSE WHETHER OR
NOT TO RECEIVE A RECEIPT.
MAY MAKE SENSE IN CERTAIN
CONTEXTS SUCH AS COFFEE OR OTHER
PERISHABLE GOODS WE ARE NOT
LIKELY TO RETURN IT.
BUT FOR MANY RETAILERS IT'S NOT --
PRACTICAL -- TO HANDLE RETURNS
OR LOSS PREVENTION OR CHECKING
RECEIPTS AT DOORS WHEN THE
CUSTOMER IS THE ONE WITH THE
OPTION AS TO WHETHER OR NOT TO
RECEIVE THE RECEIPT -- THIS BILL
DOES NOT ALLOW -- FOR THE
RETAILERS WHICH IN MANY
INSTANCES ALREADY OFFER.
THE NO RECEIPT BUT THEY DON'T DO
SO FOR EVERY PRODUCT WHEN YOU GO
BY YOUR TELEVISION OR MAJOR
ELECTRONIC GOODS.
IT MAKES NO SENSE THAT THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW THE CONSUMER TO SAY
I'M NOT TAKING A RECEIPT.
AND THEN PUT THE BURDEN ON THE
RETAILER TO HAVE TO DECIDE LATER
WHETHER TO TAKE THAT -- PRODUCT
BACK THAT'S A MAJOR PROBLEM FOR
MANY BRICK AND MORTAR BUSINESSES
WERE ALREADY STRUGGLING IN AN
ONLINE MARKETPLACE.
THAT'S ONE MAJOR ISSUE
FUNDAMENTALLY WITH THE BILL AS
THE SIP THE SLIP IS THE
CONSUMER DRIVEN OPTION THAT THEY
CAN DECIDE WHETHER TO ON ANY
PRODUCT WHETHER TO TAKE THE
RECEIPT THAT'S A PROBLEM FOR
MANY RETAILERS -- WITH REGARD TO
THE BBS BPA.
MOST RETAILERS MOST BUSINESSES
IN CALIFORNIA ALREADY DO NOT USE
BPA IN THE RECEIPT PAPER -- THE
ISSUE REALLY IS B. PS PAPER IN
THE PRESIDENT.
BàN HERE IN CALIFORNIA ON THE
PS RECEIPT PAPER WHEN WE HAVE A
SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM
WERE MOVING WITH -- SB THREE
NINE TWO WITH NO INDUSTRY
OPPOSITION WHICH IS TO EXPEDITE
THIS EVER CONSUMER PRODUCT
PROGRAM THIS BILL CIRCUMVENTS
THAT PROGRAM AND BASICALLY PUT
THE BE PS BàN WE WE KNOW THAT
IT'S A CANDIDATE CHEMICAL THAT.
PTSD IS STUDYING SO WHY ARE WE
CIRCUMVENTING THE PROGRAM THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE IS TRYING -- TO
SUPPORT WITH SB THREE NINETY
WHICH WHICH IS YOUR BILL MISTER
CHAIR AND LASTLY -- IF.
IF BIBI A AND B. PS PAPER IS
REALLY A HEALTH CONCERN FOR
RETAILERS -- FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS -- FOR THE CASHIERS
WIRE WEEKS AND IN THE ENTIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ALL AGENCIES
IF THERE'S A HUGE ISSUE WE ARE
PUTTING THE ENTIRE BURDEN ON
PRIVATE BUSINESSES AND THAT
FUNDAMENTALLY.
WE FEAR FEEL IS ON JUSTIN ON
WARRANTED AND IF IT REALLY IS
CONCERNED IT SHOULD BE PLACED O
ALL.
BASICALLY STATE AGENCIES LOCAL
AGENCIES AND BUSINESSES OF
REALLY THAT BIG OF A CONCERN AND
THEY'RE ALL EXEMPTED FROM THE
BILL.
THANK YOU YEAH LET ME JUST WHILE
YOU'RE HERE WE FOLLOW UP ON THIS
ONE QUESTION OF OF EXPENSIVE
APPLIANCES ALIKE.
I WHAT WHAT.
WITH THE BILL ALLOW.
A COMPANY TO REQUIRE A RECEIPT
FOR RETURN TO THAT IF THE YOU
HAVE A CONSUMER KNOWS LIKE
THERE'S BUYING SOME SUNDRIES AND
THERE'S JUST NO WAY THEY'RE
GOING TO RETURN AND THEY CAN --
THEY YOU KNOW THEY THEY COULD
FEEL REAL COMFORTABLE OPTING OUT
OF GETTING A RECEIPT BUT IT BUT
FOR SOMETHING SUBSTANTIVE THAT
MAY INVOLVE A WARRANTY -- WHAT
WE'RE THAT WHAT WERE THE RULES
FOR THAT AND I GUESS THERE WILL
STILL BE WARRANTY TYPE MATERIALS
FOR TELEVISION YOU?
YOU KNOW THE SERIAL NUMBER IT'S
AGAIN YOU LOOK AT APPLE APPLE
ACTUALLY HAS NO PAPER RECEIPTS
EVERY RECEIPT IS -- PAPERLESS.
IF YOU LOOK AT TARGET WHAT
EGGMAN DOESN'T HAVE FEMALE.
DID YOU HAVE TO TALK TO A COUPLE
I DON'T KNOW.
HOW I UNDERSTAND HOW THAT WORKS
NO?
BUYING EMAILS TO BANG BANG APPLE
SO BUT I'M TALKING ABOUT THE
PLANS THAT -- OF REFRIGERATOR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT WHAT THE
FRIDGE RIGHT AGAIN YOU COULDN'T.
WE WE DON'T BAND PAPER SEATS YOU
CAN GET A PAPER RECEIPT UPON
REQUEST OF YOU BY REFRIGERATOR
YOU WOULD LIKE A PAPER RECEIPT --
YOU CAN OPT OUT FOR NOW WITH THE
CUSTOMER DOESN'T ASK.
FOR ONE AND THEN ONCE A RETURN
IT WELL THEY HAVE TO HAVE A
PROOF OF PURCHASE.
RIGHT YOU HAVE TO DEMONSTRATE
THAT THAT THAT'S UP TO THE
RETAILER HOW THEY WANNA.
HOW WITH A DEMONSTRATED THEY
DON'T THEY THEY COULD DO THAT
THROUGH A CREDIT CARD
TRANSACTION?
GEN GENERALLY SPEAKING.
WHAT WAS DIFFERENT I CASH?
WELL THEN USUALLY YOU WOULD ASK
FOR A RECEIPT.
OKAY AGAIN WHICH WHICH AGAIN YOU
CAN ASK.
FOR SO -- YEAH AGAIN THIS THIS
IS VERY LOW HANGING FRUIT IN
TERMS OF A WASTEFUL PRODUCT THAT
MOST PEOPLE IMMEDIATELY THROW
THE TRASH EVERY TIME I NEED TO
RETURN SOMETHING IS VERY HARD
FOR ME TO FIND A PAPER SEAT
ACTUALLY.
MUCH EASIER FOR ME TO FIND IN
THE MAIL I GOT A STACK OF PAPER
RECEIPTS AT HOME IN INVARIABLY
WHEN I NEED TO RETURN THE
PRODUCT THAT I PURCHASED I CAN'T
FIND.
HELLO SO FADED IT IS RIGHT AND
YOU KNOW SO THE OTHER THING IS
IN TERMS OF THE CAL CHAMBER IF
THE IF THEY'RE INTERESTED IN
REMOVING OPPOSITION IF WE ALSO
INCLUDE STATE A CALIFORNIA WE'RE
HAPPY TO CONSIDER THAT I DON'T
THINK THAT'S WHAT THEY SENT.
AGAIN THE THIS THIS PAPER THESE
RECEIPTS ARE NECESSARY THE
CONSUMER MAKE THE MAKE THE
DECISION WHEN IT IS NECESSARY SO
AGAIN IF YOU HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE YOU HAVE A PRODUCT YOU
MIGHT WANNA RETURN.
ABSOLUTELY I WOULD I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO ASK FOR PAPER
RECEIPT MAKE SURE YOU IT'S ON
YOUR CREDIT CARD.
EXCEPT I THINK ALL OF THOSE --
ARE ARE CAN BE TAKEN TO ACCOUNT
TERMS OF THE GREEN CHEMISTRY AND
DTS SEE -- WE'VE HAD CHALLENGES
IN TERMS OF ACTUALLY EVALUATING
MUCH OF THESE TOXICS I DON'T
BELIEVE THIS IS A CIRCUMVENTION
OF THAT PROCESS.
BUT AGAIN THIS IS REALLY MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE A PRODUCT THAT
MOST PEOPLE PUT IN THE TRASH AND
REALLY ASKING PEOPLE BEFORE YOU
ASK FOR THAT PRODUCT.
DO YOU REALLY NEED IT IF YOU
DON'T NEED IT FOR US.
FOR IF YOU WANNA MAKE ONE FATHER
WILL GADD LIKE TO RESPOND.
THE THE ISSUE IS REALLY THAT
THIS BILL.
ALLOWS THE CONSUMER WITH THE
ENTIRE CONTROL OVER WHETHER TO
RECEIVE A RECEIPT OR NOT AND FOR
FRAUD PREVENTION THE RETAILER
THEIR AT THEIR BY HAS NO ABILITY
TO REQUIRE THAT FOR LARGE
PURCHASES.
PURCHASES THAT ARE LIKELY TO BE
RETURNED THE CONSUMER CAN OPT TO
NOT TAKE A RECEIPT AND THEN COME
BACK AND DEMAND BASICALLY YOU
HAVE TO TAKE THIS PRODUCT THE
THE THE THE THE THE STORE COULD
SAY -- YOU KNOW.
RICK RETURNS WILL ONLY BE
GRANTED IF YOU HAVE WHETHER IT
WITH ABOUT OR SEE.
WE CAN CHANGE IT WILL GET AB ALL
RETAILERS CHANGE THEIR RETURN
POLICY IS TO BASICALLY MAKE IT
OVER SEAT ONLY AND THEN PUT THE
BURDEN ON RETAILERS TO DO THAT ---WE THINK WE CAN THAT WE THINK OF
THIS BILL PASSES THAT WOULD BE A
WISE THING BUT WOULD MAKE MUCH
MORE SENSE ALLOW RETAILERS FOR
CERTAIN PRODUCT CATEGORIES TO
ALLOW THE CONSIDER RETAILER TO
BE THE ONE TO DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT TO OFFER RECEIPT OR NOT
AS OPPOSED TO LINE.
CONSUMERS DICTATE THAT AND THAT
MEANS OF FUNDAMENTAL CHANGE
ACROSS THE ENTIRE RETAIL CHAIN
YEAH I MEAN IT'S THE LEAST OF
OUR WORRIES HERE OKAY BUT I I
HEAR YOU LET'S HEAR FROM -- FROM
OTHER OPPOSITION.
MARGARET PLEDGING ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
UP MY POSITIVE JUST LIKE TO ADD
ONE SENTENCE THERE US CURRENT
STATUTORY.
AT LIMITATION FOR RETAILERS TO
OFFER THE RECEIPTS IN A CLEAN
AND TREAT FOR FASHION OBVIOUSLY
SOME PEOPLE HAVE CHOSEN TO DO IT
IT'S A SONG BEVERLY CREDIT CARD
ACT.
I'M NOT REALLY THE SUBJECT OF
THIS COMMITTEE BUT RETAILERS
HAVE TO BE VERY CAREFUL IN THE
WAY THEY OFFER YOU WERE SIEGE
WHICH IS WHY SOME RETAILERS HAVE
CHOSEN TO DO IT AND OTHERS ARE
VERY CAUTIOUS IN IMPLEMENTING
THAT POLICY.
SO -- THAT'S OBVIOUSLY FOR
ANOTHER COMPUTER CYBERSECURITY
REASONS WHAT WE KNOW AT THAT.
THIS SONG WE'RE REALLY CREDIT
CARD ACT AS A STORK ACTED VERY
BUT PROHIBITS THE COLLECTION OF
INFORMATION -- ALONG WITH.
A CREDIT CARD TRANSACTION AND
THERE'S A CLASS ACTION PENALTIES
FOR VIOLATIONS OF THAT -- AND SO
THERE AND WE TOWARDS VERY
CAUTIOUS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
TRANSACTION IS FINISHED AND THEN
THEY ASK IF YOU WANTED THE
RECEIPT -- WE'D LOVE TO TALK TO
THE FOLKS OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
THE AUTHOR ABOUT FIXING ON
BEVERLY PARTICULARLY BY THE
PASSIONS OF CCPA THE MAN.
OKAY BILLS NEXT.
GOOD MORNING DANIEL KESSLER
KAISER ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
WE WE REMAIN OPPOSED AND IT'S
IMPORTANT WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
TO THE COMMENT ABOUT THE APPLE
STORE -- AS WE ALL KNOW THEY
OFTEN JUST GIVE US THE RECEIPTS
BUT JUST LAST WEEK I PURCHASED A
PHONE FROM MY DAUGHTER.
AT THE APPLE STORE AND THEY GAVE
US A PAPER RECEIPT. FOR MY
DAUGHTER'S PHONE SHE HAD TO
RETURN THE OLD PHONE FOR TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLAR CREDIT.
WHICH OBVIOUSLY IS HER MOTHER I
WANTED THAT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS BACK -- SO I HAD TO HAVE
A PAPER RECEIPT. TO GET THAT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DON CAP KEY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS
AND TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION ALSO
IN OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
STATED THANK YOU.
CARE MEMBER SUGGESTED WITH
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL --
FOR THE REASONS STATED THANK
[inaudible]
THE HERE.
STRUCTURE MEMBERS MET CERTAIN
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL FOR THE REASONS STATED.
AND FOR THE ADDITIONAL REASON OF
THE LIMITATIONS ON COMMUNICATION
ON RECEIPTS WITH REGARDS TO OUR
COMMUNICATION WITH GAS.
THERE'S SOME LIMITATIONS IN
TERMS OF THE SPEECH AND IT CAN
ONLY BE LIMITED TO ITEMS
ESSENTIAL TO THE TRANSACTION SO
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT A LOT OF
THE CHARITYPROGRAMS.
AND OTHER THINGS THAT WE DO AND
RECEIPTS THAT AREN'T BIG LONG
ADVERTISEMENTS.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE
MULLIGAN O BEHALF OF THE FOREST
PRODUCTS INDUSTRY NATIONAL LABOR
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MR TERRA CAPULETS
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN FOREST
AND PAPER ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION.
AND I THINK AND SALAS ON BEHALF
OF THE WESTERN CAR WASH
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLICIS YUSHIN THE FAMILY WHEN
MAKERS.
OF CALIFORNIA AND BE P. IN
OPPOSITION.
JOHN LINGER ON THE OTHER
CALIFORNIA FEELS A CONVENE ITS
ALLIES WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONCERNS ON THE COST IMPACT ON
BANNING PPS READ POST.
CRAP THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WANTS
TO AND IN.
ALRIGHT.
SIR CASKEY.
ON PAGE FOUR OF OUR GUESTS START
TO THE END OF THREE AND FOUR
LET'S JUST ZERO IN ON WASTE
REDUCTION BECAUSE THE AMERICAN.
FOREST AND PAPER ASSOCIATION
ESTIMATES THAT THERE'S A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY THOUSAND TONS OF
PAPER RECEIPTS.
IN IN GRAND VIEW RESEARCH
ESTIMATES HERE'S AN ADDITIONAL
300-820-00500 OF THERMAL PAPER
RECEIPTS EACH YEAR.
PUTTING ASIDE BPA AND WHETHER
CHOICES THE RETAILER SAID THAT
THE IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THE
POTENTIAL REDUCTION OF WASTE IS
INCREDIBLE GIVEN THE TONNAGE
THAT YOU HAVE.
ON CURRENTLY BEING CAUGHT.
INTENT.
DO YOU HAVE ANY MODELING OR ANY
ESTIMATES FROM YOUR A SPONSORS
ABOUT WHAT.
IT'S POSSIBLE FOR THE REDUCTION
OF OF THIS THIS WASTE.
WE DON'T HAVE ANYTHING INITIALLY
POSSIBLE WILL BE SEEN AS AGAIN
WHEN WE MOVED AWAY FROM FROM
PLASTIC BAGS WHEN WE MOVED AWAY
FROM STRAWS JUST BY TAKING THAT
INITIAL ACTION.
IN ASKING CONSUMERS TO REALLY
THINK TWICE BEFORE THEY ASK FOR
IT I THINK COULD HAVE A HUGE
IMPACT ON CONSUMER BEHAVIOR.
SO WE WE THINK THAT BY
CALIFORNIA AGAIN TAKING THE LEAD
ON THIS ISSUE WE COULD.
GUYS TAKE A SIGNIFICANT CUT OUT
OF THAT -- WASTE [inaudible]
THEM.
AT THE PROPER TIME OPERATING
MOVED TO SPELL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THIS IS A FORMALLY MAKE A
STATEMENT START WITH FIRST OFF.
I LOVE THIS COMMITTEE I ASKED
FOR TOXIC TWENTY FIRST CAME TO
THIS EMILY AND FOR LOTS F
REASONS THERE ARE OF THEM I
BELIEVE A LOT OF ENVIRONMENTAL
GOOD WORK WE CAN DO AND I THINK
THERE'S ALSO.
AN AREA WHERE WE NEED TO FOCUS
ON WHAT WE'RE REALLY LOOKING AT
HOLISTICALLY HERE SO I WANT TO
SAY.
THIS IS NOT DIRECTED TOWARDS
YOUR BILL IS DIRECTED TOWARDS WE
HAVE A DEPARTMENT TALKS ABOUT
PROP SIXTY FIVE WE HAVE A LOT OF
REASONS THAT WE DON'T.
GO INTO LONG DELIBERATE --
DEBATES AND BRING SCIENTISTS AND
TO FIGURE OUT.
WHAT WE'RE REALLY TALKING ABOUT
HERE AND AND ALL OF US ARE
EXPERTS IN SOME FIELD BUT NOT
EXPERTS IN ALL FIELDS?
SO I THINK THAT WE AND WE SEEN
ONE OFFS AND AND THIS IS TO ME
MORE OF ANOTHER ONE OFF AND WE
REALLY NEED TO HAVE GOOD DATA --
BACKED UP BY DTS OR PROP SIXTY
FIVE OF WHAT I JUST LEARNED FROM
MY COLLEAGUE HERE ABOUT.
HAND SANITIZER WHAT IT DOES TO
THIS PRODUCT ACT -- I DO I DON'T
THAT'S FACTUAL OR NOT.
I BELIEVE HER BUT I DON'T KNOW
IT SHE SHE'S A SCIENTIST THAT
REALLY.
HASN'T STUDY THAT.
SO WE HEAR LOTS OF INFORMATION
THAT'S BROUGHT TO OUR COMMITTEES
ABOUT YOU KNOW IT'S TIME IS
DRIVEN BY MOTION.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY.
I'M SOMEBODY WHO'S IN BUSINESS
AND THE COST OF DOING BUSINESS
IN CALIFORNIA'S CONTINUE TO
SKYROCKET AND IT'S MAKING US NOT
COMPETITIVE.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME ALSO WILL
DO THE RIGHT THING.
TO CONSUMERS AND CLARKSON PEOPLE
ARE HANDING HAILING THIS PRODUCT
BUT I'M NOT CERTAIN THAT.
I'M DOING THE RIGHT THING DRIVEN
BY MOTION AND AND I'M BACK FACTS
THAT ARE STATED IT DIDN'T DURING
THESE COMMITTEE SO.
I THINK WE NEED TO STEP BACK AND
AND AS A COMMITTEE AND AS YOU
KNOW POLICYMAKERS AND SAY.
WE NEED EXPERTS TO TELL US
WHAT'S THIS IS REALLY DOES OR
DOES NOT DO NOT JUST LEGISLATORS
OR OR SOME.
YOU KNOW WHATEVER LOBBY GROUP
FOR THE DATE IT FEELS LIKE
THEY'RE DOING SOMETHING SO I
IT'S NOT DIRECTED TOWARDS THE
THE MEMBER THAT'S BRINGING THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION FOR A WE'VE
SEEN THIS.
OVER AND OVER AGAIN OVER THE
LAST SIX AND A HALF YEARS THAT
I'VE BEEN HERE [inaudible]
SO. FOR THAT REASON AND MANY
OTHER REASONS THAT THIS IS GOING
TO DRIVE UP THE COST OF DOING
BUSINESS AND I ALSO KNOW THAT
20% OF THOSE.
PEOPLE WHO ARE WALKING OUT THE
DOOR WITH LESS THAN NINE HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLARS WORTH OF
MERCHANDISE. TO A BUSINESS
THERE'S A WE HAVE LAWS THAT
ALLOW YOU JUST.
BASICALLY STEAL UP TO NINE
HUNDRED DOLLARS AND A
MISDEMEANOR -- THAT IMPACTS
BUSINESS AS WELL SO I THINK WE
NEED TO SLOW DOWN.
MAYBE GET SOME MORE.
SCIENTIFIC DATA ON A LOT OF
ISSUES THAT COME TO THESE
COMMITTEES AND AND GIVE IT BACK
THAT'S WHY WE TO BE.
PUT IT IN THE HANDS OF DTS C. SO
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY.
NOT HAVE TO SIT THROUGH FOUR
HOURS OF COMMITTEE HEARINGS
WHERE WE HAVE SCIENTISTS
DEBATING BACK AND FORTH WHAT'S.
ON A PIECE OF PAPER WHAT THE
CHEMICAL ACTUAL DOES AND I
ACTUALLY WANT TO KNOW IF IT'S
HARMFUL NUMBER.
ONE AND NOT JUST DRIVEN BY
WHATEVER CLUB OF THE DAY IS
TRYING TO POSE ITSELF.
SO I'M JUST MAKING A STATEMENT I
THINK WE NEED TO SLOW DOWN WE'RE
SEEING A LOT OF ONE OFFS TYPES
PIECE OF LEGISLATION COME
THROUGH ARE WE GOING.
TO TAKE THAT ROLE THAT'S THE
ROLE WE WANT TO TAKE AND I I
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE SCIENTISTS
COMING YEAR TELLS.
FACTUALLY WHAT THEY'VE STUDIED
IN WHAT THE PRODUCTS ACTUALLY
DUE TO PEOPLE SO. FOR THAT
REASON I'M GONNA BE OPPOSE IN
THE BILL.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO YOU KNOW.
MORE COMMONSENSE APPROACH AND
NOT DO THESE ONE OFFS AND AND I
THINK IT WILL BE BETTER SO WE
CAN ACTUALLY GO OUT TARGETS THAT
YOU SAY THIS IS WHAT'S ACTUALLY
HAPPENING TO YOU IF YOU HANDLE
THIS PRODUCT.
NOW I KNOW THAT MY BUSINESS THAT
I HAVE A WHOLE LIST OF THINGS
THAT CAUSE CANCER.
THE STATE CALPERS AS A COST
CANCERS PROP SIXTY FIVE WHICH IS
BEEN STUDY HAS BEEN POSTED THERE.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS AND JUST
FOR THAT STATEMENT I'D LIKE.
TO WAY AND I'VE I HOPE THEY
NEVER KICK ME OFF THIS COMMITTEE
BECAUSE I ACTUALLY LOVE THIS
KIND OF STUFF AND IT'S WHAT WE
SHOULD DO GOOD WORK IF SOMEBODY
IS IF WE DON'T KNOW THE
INFORMATION WE SHOULD GET THAT
INFORMATION SO. FOR THOSE
REASONS I WILL BE OPPOSE IN THIS
PIECE LEDGES AND MANY OTHERS
THAT COME TROUGH HERE.
THAT ARE DRIVEN NOT OFF OF GOOD
SCIENCE DATA.
THANK YOU FOR THE FOLLOW UP ON
YOUR ON YOUR COMMENT -- I THERE
IS AN INTERESTING DISTINCTION WE
WE KEEP MISSING BE PLEASANT BPA
IN THE SAME BREATH.
BPA IS A PROP SIXTY FIVE LISTED
CHEMICAL BBSS NOT -- CAN YOU
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT TOO YEAH WE
ACTUALLY HAVE THE ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP THEY CAN SPEAK TO
OKAY YES.
AND WHILE HE'S COMES UP AND IN
JUST OF MY COLLEAGUE WE START ON
U. S. CAME TOGETHER IN THE
ASSEMBLY -- IF YOU JUST FOCUS ON
THE WASTE PIECE OF IT.
THIS IS JUST THE SAME TO
CONSUMER IF.
I DON'T WANT THAT PIECE OF PAPER
YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE TO GIVE IT TO
ME I'VE BEEN IN SO MANY
RETAILERS SITUATIONS WHERE.
I DON'T WANT THAT RECEIPT THE
PRINTED OUT IN THE THROAT IN THE
IN THE TRASH SO I GUESS THEY'RE
MORE EFFICIENT ABOUT FOR WORKING
IN THE TRASH.
BUT THEY JUST DID SOMETHING THAT
I DIDN'T NEED WE DON'T NEED AND
THEN IT GOES INTO OUR WASTE
REMAINS IS UNNECESSARY SO I
THINK IF YOU JUST LOOK AT JUST
THAT PIECE OF IT.
EMPOWERING THE CONSUMERS TO NOT
BE FORCED TO TAKE A PIECE OF
PAPER THAT'S TOXIC BUT THEY
DON'T WANT.
THAT THAT'S THE CRUX OF THIS. TO
ALLOW YOUR ENVIRONMENT WORKING
GROUP ON THE DPA VERSES BE PS
DISTINCTION YES BPA IS THE ONLY
ONE ON THE PROP SIXTY FIVE
LISTED SO REPRODUCTIVE TOXICANT
IT'S AN AND CAN DISRUPTOR.
IT IS HAS ESTROGENIC EFFECTS
THAT MIMIC THAT CHEMICAL IN YOUR
ABOUT HORMONE IN YOUR BODY
WHETHER YOU'RE MALE OR FEMALE.
BAD NEWS BE PS IS TURNING INTO
WHAT'S KNOWN AS THE CLASSIC
REGRETTABLE SUBSTITUTION.
I JUST PULLED UP HERE IN THE
AUDIENCE -- TWENTY FOURTEEN
REPORT FROM A IN SCIENTIFIC
AMERICAN SAYING IS BE PSA FOR
AND THEY'RE SAYING ALL THE EARLY
DAD IS IT'S NOT.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE IT HAS MORE
MOAN LIKE ESTROGENIC EFFECTS IN
THE BODY AND THEY THINK ONE DAY
IT'LL BE PHÃN JUST THE SAME I
CAMERA WHICH WAY IT GOES NOW.
ONE IS EXTRA EXCRETED MORE
RAPIDLY FROM THE BODY PPA VERSES
BE PS THE OTHER RESTAURANT
ARRESTOR JENNINGS TAX BUT
THEY'RE KIND OF APPLES AND
ORANGES BUT THE SAME THING IN
YOUR BODY.
AM I ALSO PUT POINT OUT THAT --
BPA CONTRARY THE SCREWS ME THE
WITNESS EARLIER HAS BEEN PROVEN
TO BE BAD FOR YOUR BODY PPS IS
ON ITS WAY THE PROBLEM WITH THE
GREEN CHEMISTRY.
AT THE TNC IS IT TAKES YEARS AND
YEARS AND YEARS AND SO THE
STUDIES ARE UNDERWAY ABOUT THE
THE S. AND P. P. F. THIS BEING
ALL FLUORIDE.
THEY ALL APPEAR TO ACT THE SAME
IN THE BODY WE THINK IT'S A GOOD
BILL THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SHOULD JUMP AHEAD OF
THE SLOW SCIENCE AND EVEN SLOWER
IF OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
SAY LET'S GET THESE OUT OF
CONSUMER PRODUCTS.
THANK YOU.
OKAY HI MAN OF A CERTAIN.
A YEAR FROM JUST A COUPLE
QUESTIONS.
THAT CAME UP -- REGARDING ALL
THE IMPACT ON STATE NO.
AND WHETHER.
WE ARE GOING TO BE EXEMPTED AS
THE STATE SENS FIVE LOTTERY
TICKETS WHICH AMEND ARE PRINTED.
ON HOW DO WE ADDRESS THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM YOU KNOW
AGAIN WE WERE SILENT TO IT YEAH
AGAIN IF THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
OPPOSITION IS REALLY INTERESTED
IN -- WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
HIM ON THAT ISSUE.
WELL I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT IF
YOU HAVE A FOR ABOUT WASTE AND
IT'S ABOUT TIME PUBLIC HEALTH IN
TERMS OF THE EMPOWER.
ALL ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR
CHEMICAL HOUSE ON YOU KNOW OUR
BODIES IN THE STATE OUGHT TO BE
INVOLVED SO MAYBE TAKE OUT FOR
IT.
SECONDLY I THINK THAT FOR MYSELF --
MOST RECENTLY I HAD TO RETURN A
NUMBER OF THINGS AND I'VE BEEN
ASKED FOR A RECEIPT.
IF I DIDN'T ASK FOR THE RECEIPT
WHEN I BOUGHT THE PRODUCT I
WOULD HAVE BEEN IN TROUBLE.
I THINK THAT THAT'S CLEARLY ONE
OF THE BIG ISSUES HERE AND THE
IMPACT TO THE BRICK AND MORTAR
STORES.
AND I THINK THAT THEY NEED TO BE
GIVEN SOME TIME WHERE THEY COULD
ADDRESS HOW THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
TO ENSURE PROOF OF PURCHASE WHEN
ITEMS ARE RETURNED I MEAN WHEN
YOU HEAR.
THE FINANCIAL IMPACT THAT IS
MAKING ON THE STORES WE WE'RE
DRIVING BRICK AND MORTA YOU
KNOW OUT OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I HAPPEN TO BE ONE OF
THE OLD GUARD THAT LIKES TO GO
TO THE STORE AND SHOP -- I
ACTUALLY SEE A LONGER LINES AT
THE RETURNED OUSTER PEOPLE
WHO'VE ORDER THINGS ONLINE --
AND STORES ARE ACCOMMODATING
ABOUT THAT WE ARE PUTTING AWFUL
HUGE BURDEN ON THEM IN A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME TO CHANGE THE WAY
THEY DO BUSINESS SO.
I THINK ON ACCOMMODATION HAS TO
BE PROVIDED AND I WOULD HOPE
GOING FORWARD YOU'LL CONSIDER
THAT BECAUSE OF THAT IS.
THE SALES TAXES GENERATED ALL OF
THOSE THINGS THAT ARE SO
IMPORTANT TO OUR ECONOMY. TWO
JOBS YOU NAY MEANT -- FOR
GOVERNMENTS AND WHERE THEY GET
THEIR REVENUES THIS IS A HUGE
HERE -- ON OUR OUR OWN ECONOMY
AND CERTAINLY OUR RETAIL ECONOMY.
PLEASE TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION BECAUSE WHEN I
READ THIS I THOUGHT WOW THAT'S A
LOT OF TRASH WITHOUT THOSE ARE
BY DEGRADABLE WE SHRED I'M IN
THAT.
YOU KNOW IF THE IF IT'S HUGE WE
NEED TO LOOK AT THAT BUT I THINK.
FIRST AND FOREMOST WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THE THE COMMON
DENOMINATOR HERE IS THAT WE ARE
HURTING BUSINESS WE ARE HURTING
JOBS.
AND WE'RE SENDING A HUGE I I
GUESS IT'S ALMOST FUNDAMENTAL TO
THE ECONOMY OF OUR NATION.
OUT OF BUSINESS -- IN PERHAPS A
SHORTER TIME THAN YOU WOULD
IMAGINE SO THAT'S WHILE BE
OPPOSING IT TODAY BUT I
APPRECIATETHE FACT THAT YOU
LOOK AT THESE THINGS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TEAM AND WE WE NEED TO DO
THAT FLOW -- GOOD FOR YOU ON
THAT OUT BUT BETTER FOR YOU IF
YOU TAKE A STEP BACK AND AND
CONSIDER SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP.
BY OUR FINE FINE RETAIL
INDUSTRIES FAIR MANUFACTURES.
I'VE ACTUALLY JUST A QUICK
COUPLE POINTS OUT AGAIN THE BILL
DOESN'T GO INTO EFFECT ON
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WAS SO WEAK THAT PLEA FACTOR
THAT IN.
WE EXEMPTED OUT SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT GROSS UNDER TWO MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR.
WHICH WE THINK BALK EXAM THE
HUGE MAJORITY OF SMALL
BUSINESSES SO THAT WAS SOMETHING
THAT WE ACTUALLY TOOK INTO --
INTO OUR THINKING.
IN TERMS OF RESTAURANTS WE WERE
VERY SENSE ABOUT RESTAURANTS
EVEN THOUGH THEY REMAIN OPPOSED.
THAT DAY AGAIN IT'S VERY COMMON
FOR THEM 2% A BILL TO YOU SO
THAT BILL IS NOT.
TOUCHED IN TERMS OF THE BILL
WHEN THEY PRESENTED TO YOU
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S A PAPER BILL --
AND SO AGAIN -- WE DID NOT.
DISALLOW THAT OBVIOUSLY IS JUST
BASICALLY IF YOU PAY FOR A
CREDIT CARD WHETHER OR NOT THAT
CREDIT CARD BILL COMES BACK THE
SECOND TIME IF YOU DON'T WANT
THAT THAT'S WHERE WE WILL BE A
PART.
WELL IT'S INTERESTING SOME OF
THE RECEIPTS THAT WE GET A LATE
FEE FROM OFF.
THOSE WHO ARE ON GIVING COUPON
SAVING COUPONS.
ARE I GET A RECEIPT THAT SHOWS
HOW MUCH MONEY I'VE SAVED BY
BUYING CERTAIN PRODUCTS ON THE
OTHERS THAT'S THE THING IT'S
GREAT CONSUMER INFORMATION.
THAT WILL BE ELIMINATED.
I AM NOT SURE THAT THAT'S IN THE
BEST INTERESTS OF CONSUMERS
EITHER IN THE MARKETING THAT OUR
RETAILERS DO THAT HELP US MAKE
BETTER CHOICES. TO STRETCH THAT
DOLLAR THAT WE HAVE FULL OF THE
THINGS NEED TO BE CONSIDERED
ISSUE GO FORWARD.
THAT INFORMATION TERMS OF HOW
MUCH MONEY YOU SAVE SAY FROM THE
GROCERY STORE IS NOT UNLIMITED.
IT'S IT'S JUST BASICALLY ALL THE
FIVE FEET AFTER THAT IF IF THEIR
COUPONS OR PROMOTIONAL SO.
THOSE WOULD BE ELIMINATED.
IF YOU PUT HIM ON THE BACK OF
THE RECEIPT THAT'S TOTALLY FINE
BECAUSE AGAIN WE'RE ASKING FOR
RECEIPT THAT'S NO LONGER THAN
THAT THE TRANSACTION INFORMATION.
I CAN JUST GET A JUST TO KIND OF
ZERO ELEVEN YOU'RE DOING TWO
VER DIFFERENT THINGS HERE RIGHT
YOU'VE GOT THE ISSUE OF WASTE
REDUCTION.
AND THEN YOU'VE GOT THE B. P. A.
B. PS -- BAN EFFECTIVELY.
AND I GUESS I JUST WANNA HAVE
SCRATCH SERVICE LITTLE MORE MAY
I HEAR YOU IN TERMS OF EARLY
INDICATORS -- BUT THE QUESTION
IS DO WE HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO
THIS CONCERN ABOUT ABOUT ONE
AWESOME PART OF WHY I WAS
PURSUING THE GREEN CHEMISTRY
BILL YOU KNOW VERY WELL IS THAT
WE ACTUALLY HAVE.
A MORE SYSTEMATIC APPROACH --
THE GREEK CAM SHE PROGRAM WAS
ABSOLUTELY NOT STRONG ENOUGH AND
WHAT DIDN'T HAVE THE KIND OF
TOOLS THAT I NEED TO DO THE WORK
IT IT NEEDS TO DO.
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE TRYING TO
GIVE THEM THOSE TOOLS AND I DO
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
INDUSTRIES YEAH Và WANT TO WORK
WITH US ON THAT -- YOU KNOW IT
THERE ARE CERTAIN PRODUCTS THAT
ARE.
CLEAR IT'S OBVIOUS -- BUT BUT
EARLY INDICATORS IS THAT ENOUGH.
TO TO DO A ONE OFF BAND.
YEAH I THINK -- AS I TESTIFIED
EARLIER THE LEGISLATURE CAN AND
SHOULD DO ONE OFFS ON OCCASION
AND DTS YES HE SUPPORTED AB
THIRTEEN NINETEEN THE BPA BAND
AND TWENTY ELEVEN SAYING.
THE GREEN CHEMISTRY PROGRAM WILL
BE MOVING KIND OF SLOWLY FOR
THAT WAS FORESHADOWING.
AND SAID WE HAVE NO PROBLEM WE
SUPPORT THAT AFTER THAT THE STM
ANY Q. PASSED AND WAS SIGNED.
I THINK IT'S THE SAME THING HERE
THERE'S STRONG EVIDENCE NOW
ABOUT THE P. S. 81%.
OF AMERICANS HAVE BE PS IN THEIR
YEAR AND THIRST THAT SAYS NOT
JUST BE PSP PS SO I THINK IT
WILL BE -- FORMALIZES
REGRETTABLE SUBSTITUTION ONE DAY
BY PROP SIXTY FIVE BECAUSE OF
THE REPRODUCTIVE EFFECTS OF THIS
HORMONAL LIKE CHEMICAL IN YOUR
BODY.
IN THE LEGISLATURE I THINK
SOMETIMES HAS TO STEP OUT A
LITTLE BIT AHEAD SAY THERE'S
GOOD EVIDENCE NOW WHAT ARE WE
WAITING FOR LESS LEAD THE NATION
LIKE WE DID WITH BPA.
IN BABY BOTTLES AND BY THE WAY
BPA THE REASON I CAME UP AND BE
PS IS IT IT MAY NOT LEECHES
READILY OUT OF PLASTIC BOTTLES.
SO YOU SEE BPA FREE DRINKING
BOTTLE IS PROBABLY GOT PPS BUT
IT'S JUST AS LITTLE MORE
RESILIENT TO SIGN IN HOT WATER
THINGS LIKE THAT.
BUT IN THERMAL PAPER IT'S
READILY LEACHED SO THAT'S A
DIFFERENT APPLICATION AND WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT APPLICATION
FOR PPS.
YEAH I MEAN ALL I ALSO ONE OF
THE THING YOU KNOW THAT THAT
BOTH BECAME THE PS ARE
CONSIDERED CONTAMINANTS BY THE
WASTE INDUSTRY WITH THE REST OF
THE PAPER RECYCLING STREAM.
OF COURSE THERE A LOT OF
CONTAMINANTS -- INCLUDING PETE
AGREES -- THAT IMPACT THE
ABILITY OF US -- YOUR ABILITY --
TO TO YOU KNOW -- TO TO RECYCLE
PAPER BUT YEAH THIS IS.
THIS IS THE THIS IS A TOUGH
ISSUE BECAUSE I YOU KNOW YOU'RE
DOING A LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS
HERE AND AND I WONDER WHETHER
WHERE.
WHAT I I I I JUST WANT I I'M I'M
I GUESS I'M STRUGGLING WITH LIKE
THE EXTENT TO WHICH WE?
RESPECT THE EXISTING SYSTEMS
THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE WHICH ARE.
AND MAN MADE WHAT MAYBE TODAY WE
DON'T FEEL AS OF THE EXISTING
SYSTEMS ARE.
ARE.
ACTIVATED ENOUGH FOR FAST ENOUGH
RESPONSIVE ENOUGH AND I
CERTAINLY AGREE WITH THAT THAT'S
WHY I'M RUNNING THE OTHER BILL
AND AND EVEN IF THE BILL PASSES
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE FAST ENOUGH
FOR ME MANY RESPECTS AND THAT'S
WHAT KIND OF LEADS ME IN FAVOR
THIS BUT I AM -- I CONTINUE TO
BE ABLE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
[inaudible]
ABOUT.
THE THE THE THE RIGOR WITH WHICH
WE ADDRESS THESE KINDS OF ISSUES
SO THE RICHER OFFRAMP FOR THE
BILL WAS TO GO THE THE RECEIPT
DIRECTION -- BASED ON PRIVACY
CONCERNS IN BASED ON CONCERNS
THAT PEOPLE DIDN'T NECESSARILY
READILY EMBRACE THE HE RECEIVED
OFFRAMP THIS WAS A COMPROMISE
THAT WAS TAKEN OUT OF THE SIMPLY
PREPARATIONS TO TO GO FOR THE
GPS TO BPA FREE.
PAPER I THINK OUR ORIGINAL FOCUS
AND OUR OUR FOCUS REMAINS IS THE
GOING BACK TO CENTER MY COUNTIES
POINT THE PRODUCTION OF THE
WASTE.
AT THE ACTUAL RECEIPT THAT YOU
DON'T NEED THAT YOU DON'T REALLY
WANT HOW DO YOU REDUCE THAT AND
SO IT'S REALLY THE FOCUS ON THE
RECEIPT UPON REQUEST.
MAKING SURE THAT THAT CAN BE
ACCOMMODATED -- THE COMPROMISE
WAS ALSO ALLOWING PEOPLE OF
CONSECUTIVE.
THESE ARE STORES THAT WANTED TO
CONTINUE.
TO GIVE RECEIPTS OR ADAM ABOUT
RECEIPTS LIKE LIKE THE GROCERS
YOU HEARD FROM MISTER MARINO.
ON MAKING SURE THAT THEY HAVE
THAT OPTION TO HAVE BPA PPS FREE
PAPERS SO AGAIN THAT WAS THAT
WAS SORT OF LIKE THE COMPROMISE
BUT THE FOCUS WAS REALLY.
MAKING SURE THAT EVERY RETAILER
WE COULD ACCOMMODATE THE PAPER
SEE TOMORROW.
RIGHT GET THAT BUT BUT NOW THAT
THE BILL DOES.
IT DOES IT JUST PRY THE OPTION
IT SAYS THAT THE PAPER PROOF OF
PURCHASE IF PROVIDED -- SHALL
NOT CONTAIN BPA OR BBS CORRECT
SO IT'S NOT A IT'S NOT AN OPTION.
RIGHT SO THAT THAT WAS AN
AMENDMENT THAT WE TOOK OFFICE IN
THE PREPARATION THAT'S RIGHT.
SO SO WE PROVISIONS ADDED THAT
IN CORRECT [inaudible]
GET MORE [inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY -- OKAY WHAT'S YEAH THAT'S
THE BUT LET'S IT AS A THAT'S
INTERESTING RIGHT THAT'S A VERY
DIFFERENT MOVE ON THE BILL THE
BILL IS A BILL ABOUT WASTE
REDUCTION NOW IT'S TURNED INTO A
GPS.
WE ALL TAKE A MOMENT OF
APPROPRIATIONS THAT -- WE HAVE
TO ACCEPT AS YOU KNOW.
OKAY I'LL JUST LET ALL THE I
WOULD JUST LEAVE IT AT THAT.
ALL RIGHT WELL YOU KNOW LOOK I
AND WE ALL OF OUR PROPRIOCEPTIVE
YEAH.
NO WE DO WE DO -- WELL LOOK I I
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW -- APPRECIATE
IN SUPPORT.
THE BROAD GOALS THAT YOU HAVE
HERE I I DO CONTINUE TO RAISE --
CONCERNS ABOUT.
THE RIGOR OF OF OF THE THE THAT
THAT PARTICULAR [inaudible]
A BAND.
HI AN INFINITY OF THE INTERPLAY
WITH OUR EXISTING RESEARCH AND
THE STATE'S REGULATORY APPROACH
TO THIS STUFF -- I ALSO HEAR YOU
KNOW HERE BUT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING --
ABOUT.
ALL THE DATA WE HAVE SO FAR AND
I ABSOLUTELY AGREE THAT THE YOU
KNOW THE PROCESS IS NOT MOVE
QUICKLY ENOUGH -- ON THE
REGULATORY SIDE AND ON THE
SCIENCE SIDE HI THE STATE
AGENCIES SO -- COULD I MADE MY
COMMITMENT TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY BUT I I THINK THAT --
TODAY'S DISCUSSION CONTINUES TO
RAISE SOME.
CONCERNS AND AND MORE THAN HAPPY
TO AGAIN YEAR AFTER THE
COMMITTEE -- DISCUSS THE PPA PPS
FREE ISSUE.
AGAIN WE WE WANT WE WANT TO STAY
JUST VERY FOCUSED ON THE ON THE
WASTE REDUCTION PART WHICH IS.
MAKING SURE THAT THAT CONSUMERS
HAVE THAT ABILITY TO NOT HAVE A
RECEIPT WHEN THEY WALK OUT THE
DOOR.
OKAY ALL RIGHT I TO MOVE BY
CENTER CASKEY -- OTHER QUESTIONS
THAT CENSORSHIP IS COLOR.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB ONE SIX ONE
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALLEN'S AYE ALLEN AYE BATES.
BATES NO DALI.
DALI NO HILL.
SKINNER.
RIGHT SKINNER AYE STERN.
I CASKEY.
MAKOWSKI AYE.
OKAY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR MESSAGE WHEN
WE TAKE A MOMENT I THINK WE MAY
I KNOW THIS LIKE PEOPLE STANDING
THE BACK ON LET'S THIS IS HERE
LET'S SAY HERE MOTION FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
OUR SYSTEM OF BY MY CENTER DOLLY --
SIX THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THIS -- ITEM.
THIS ITEM TWELVE IS A. B. EIGHT
THIRTY FOUR BY QUIRK ITEM
THIRTEEN AB EIGHT THIRTY SIX BY
WICKS ITEM FOURTEEN A. B. NINE
TWELVE BY MURATSUCHI. TWENTY ONE
I AM TWENTY ONE A. B. THIRTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN BY QUIRK AND ITEM
TWENTY THREE AB FIFTEEN A THREE
BY EGGMAN.
SECTOR PLEASE COLOR ON THE
PERFECT COUNTER.
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS NUMBER
TWELVE THIRTEEN FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE AND TWENTY THREE ALLEN HI
ALLEN ALL RIGHT BATES.
BATES HI DOLLY.
DOLLY AYE HILL [inaudible]
SKINNER.
INNER AYE STERN.
AYE CASKEY.
MY CAST PI.
OKAY SO THAT HAS ENOUGH VOTES.
TO GET OUT THAT'S A FIVE TWO
ZERO VALLEJO THAT OPEN FOR THE
OTHER TEAM MEMBERS.
TO ADD ON AND I WILL HEAR FROM.
THE SUMMER TINGS NEXT COULD
CONTROVERSIAL BILL THIS IS A
ITEM MODEL THIS IS ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN IN YOUR PACK MEMBERS IS
AB.
SEVEN NINETY TWO REALLY THE
MINIMUM RECYCLED CONTENT
STANDARDS.
THANK YOU MISTER YOU'RE YOU'RE
VERY WELL AWARE ON FUN.
THE CHALLENGE WE HAVE WITH
RECYCLING -- EVER SINCE CHINA
STOP TAKING OUR RECYCLING WE'VE
A VERY DIFFICULT TIME -- KNOWING
WHERE EVERYTHING THAT WE'RE
PUTTING IN OUR BLUE BINS IS
GOING.
WE USED TO THINK THEY BEGIN
RECYCLED NOW CHANCES ARE THEY'RE
EITHER GETTING INCINERATED OR
GOING TO THE LANDFILL -- A. B.
SEVEN NINETY TO ESTABLISH THE
TIME FRAME FOR PLASTIC BOTTLE
BEVERAGE MANY FACTORS TO USE
MINIMUM RECYCLE CONTENT.
IN THEIR PLASTIC BOTTLES WITH
THE GOAL OF GETTING 275%
RECYCLED CONTENT BY.
TWENTY THIRTY WITH THAT I WAS
GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO MY
JOINT AUTHOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR
ONE AND SHE COULD GO TO THE
DETAILS.
OF THANK YOU MISTER TANG MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
AB SEVEN NINE TWO IS AN
IMPORTANT BILLS BOTH TO INCREASE
THE CONTENT OF RECYCLED
MATERIALS AND BOTTLES BUT ALSO.
TO CHANGE THE MARKET WITHIN THE
RECYCLING INDUSTRY. TO ENSURE
THAT THIS BILL WILL BE WORKABLE --
FOR BOTH RECLAIMER SANTA
MANUFACTURERS WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH TO A CAUGHT IN THIS
FROM BROWN UNIVERSITY AND FROM
UC SANTA BARBARA. TO ANALYZE THE
CURRENT MARKET THEIR INITIAL
ANALYSIS SUGGESTS THAT THE
TARGETS IN THE BILL ARE WORKABLE
AND THAT THE MARKET WILL ADJUST
TO ENSURE THERE IS ADEQUATE
SUPPLY.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT
THEIR ANALYSIS INCLUDES
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO AVOID
POTENTIAL MARKET FAILURES ONE OF
WHICH IS TO INCREASE RECYCLING
DATA TRANSPARENCY MOVING FORWARD --
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THIS BILL ALONG SIDE --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING AND THE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
YES WITNESSES.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK MURRAY
WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
CALIFORNIA'S AGAINST WASTE AND I
THINK THAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MADE A REALLY GOOD POINT ABOUT
SEXUALLY AND ECONOMIC BILL --
THIS IS A BILL THAT IS DESIGNED
TO UPDATE THE ECONOMICS OF
RECYCLING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
RIGHT NOW I THINK THAT WE
PERCEIVE THAT WERE RECYCLING IS
THE THING THAT WE DO AT THE
CURBSIDE RECYCLING BIN.
AND THE WHOLE SITUATION IN CHINA
HAS COMMUNICATED TO US THAT THAT
IS NOT RECYCLING.
WHAT -- CENTER SKINNER HAS TOLD
US SINCE DAY ONE IS THAT
RECYCLING IS WHEN SOMEBODY BUYS
THE MATERIAL WHEN THERE'S A
MARKET FOR THE MATERIAL.
AND WE'VE DONE A LOT IN THIS
LEGISLATURE TO COMPEL CONSUMERS
TO DO MORE ON COLLECTION WE'VE
COMPELLED LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
MATERIAL RECOVERY FACILITIES TO
COLLECT AND PROCESS AND SORT
THIS MATERIAL.
THE ECONOMY HAS MOTIVATED.
INDIVIDUAL ENTREPRENEURS TO SET
UP -- PROCESSING TO SHRED AND TO
CLEAN THAT MATERIAL BUT ALL OF
THAT IS A WASTE OF TIME UNLESS
SOMEBODY IS WILLING TO BUY THE
MATERIAL.
AND THIS BILL IS KIND OF IS THE
IS THE CAP ON OUR RECYCLING
OBJECTIVES IN TERMS OF
COMPELLING THE MANUFACTURES. TO
TO BE THE THE FINAL PARTNER IN
THIS RECOUP CYCLING EQUATION BY
BUYING THE MATERIAL THAT THE
CONSUMER HAS DUTIFULLY SET ASIDE
FOR RECYCLING THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND CURBSIDE
PROVIDERS HAVE PROVIDED IN
SEGREGATED AND SORTED.
ALL OF THOSE STEPS IN THE
PROCESS REQUIRE AN INCREASED
COST THE ONLY WAY TO OFFSET
THOSE COSTS IS AND THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COSTS IN THE
ECONOMIC COSTS.
IS WHEN SOMEBODY IS WILLING TO
BUY THAT MATERIAL AT THE END AND
USE IT IN INCORPORATING THIS
THIS NEW PACKAGE.
WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT BEVERAGE
MANUFACTURES THROUGH IMMENSE A
NEW SHOULD'VE AND CREATIVITY AND
FORESIGHT HAVE FIGURED OUT HOW
TO PUT?
A 100% RECYCLED CONTENT IN A
JUICE.
PACKAGE 50% 2100% RECYCLED
CONTENT IN A WATER PACKAGE -- WE
KNOW HOW TO DO THIS NOW THE IDEA
IS TO COMPEL MANUFACTURES TO DO
THIS ACROSS THE BOARD AND EVEN
PLAYING FIELD POLICY THAT
REQUIRES EVERYONE TO PLAY BY THE
SAME RULES. TO DO WHAT THESE
MANUFACTURERS OF ARE ALREADY
DOING AND TO HELP TO OFFSET THE
COST RECYCLING SO THIS IS THE
NATURAL NEXT STEP.
IN TERMS OF CONTROLLING OUR OWN
DESTINY IN OUR RECYCLING FUTURE.
AND WE WE URGE AN AYE VOTE.
HI MY NAME IS ALEX DEL LINCOLN
OUR COMPANY VERTICAL RECYCLING
WHICH IS BASED IN SOUTH GATE
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE LARGEST
PRODUCERS.
OF FOOD GRADE RECYCLE PT
PLASTICS.
TOGETHER WAS OTHER CALIFORNIA
COMPANY MEMBERS OF OUR
CALIFORNIA RECYCLING COALITION
WE HAVE INVESTED TENS OF
MILLIONS.
INTO CALIFORNIA RECYCLING
ECONOMY CREATED OVER ONE
THOUSAND GREEN JOBS OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS.
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVED
QUALITY OF OUR PRODUCTS IN ORDER
TO MEET.
EVER MORE STRINGENT REQUIREMENTS
OF BEVERAGE COMPANIES AND TODAY
YOU CAN FIND BEVERAGE CONTAINERS
MADE FROM 100% ARE PASSED ON THE
SHELVES.
OF OF OUR STORES.
THESE PLASTIC BOTTLE CONTAINING
RECYCLED BG CAN BE -- PROCESS
BACK INTO BEVERAGE CONTAINERS
MANY TIMES OVER AND THAT
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCES CARBON
FOOTPRINT OF PLASTIC PACKAGING
IN EL ELIMINATES LARGE AMOUNTS
OF NON RECYCLABLE PLASTIC WASTE.
HOWEVER OUR INDUSTRY IS IN
CRISIS AND HAS BEEN FOR THE LAST.
SEVEN EIGHT YEARS JESS IS AS IN
STATE CAPACITY TO PRODUCE HIGH
QUALITY FOOD GRADE RECYCLE BG
HAS INCREASED. TO THIS DATE OUR
PRODUCT WHICH IS RECYCLE P. T.
IS CONSIDERED BY THE BRAND
OWNERS AND BEVERAGE CONTAINER
MANUFACTURERS TO BE A COMMODITY.
AND WE HAVE TO COMPETE ON PRICE
WITH THE HYDROCARBON BASED
VERSION PT INDUSTRY.
INCREASING DOMESTIC PRODUCTION
AND SUBSIDIZED IMPORTS OF VIRGIN
RESIN HAVE LED TO LOWER
COMMODITY PRICES.
VIRGIN BT PRICES ARE LOWER TWO
DAYS AND THEY WERE A TEN YEARS
AGO.
NO SUSTAINABLE PLASTICS
RECYCLING INDUSTRY CAN BE BUILT
WITHOUT SUSTAINABLE DEMAND.
THERE WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN TWENTY
AND NOBODY WOULD HAVE INVESTED
MILLIONS INTO RENEWABLE ENERGY
HAD THE FIRST LARGE SCALE SOLAR
POWER PLANTS HAD TO COMPETE ON
PRICE WAS COAL POWER GENERATION.
WE NEED ROBUST PLASTICS
RECYCLING INDUSTRIES IT THAT
WOULD UTILIZE SUPPLY GENERATED
IN THE STATE AND WOULD
MANUFACTURE PRODUCT USED IN THE
STATE.
PLASTICS RECYCLING COMPANIES ARE
ALWYS OPEN TO WORKING WITH THE
BEVERAGE INDUSTRY IN OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO WHAT'S BEST
STANDARDS OF CIRCLE OUR ECONOMY.
TO THAT EXTENT WE SINCERELY
APPRECIATE WILLINGNESS OF THE
LARGEST BOTTLED WATER COMPANIES
TO WORKS WITH US. TO DEVELOP
SUSTAINABLE YET MEANINGFUL
MATTER TO RECYCLE CONTENT
TARGETS FOR BEVERAGE CONTAINERS
MANY OF WHICH WERE INCLUDED IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
THAT YOU'LL HAVE WE KNOW THIS IS
GOOD FOR CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
GREEN JOBS AND OF WOULD.
ADD YIELD LESS LANDFILL IN WATER
WEIGHT PLASTIC POLLUTION FOR
THOSE REASONS WILL CONTINUE TO
WORKS WITH AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TING. TO MOVE THIS FORWARD AND
WE AT ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
OF AB SEVENTY SEVEN NINE TWO
TODAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- FOLKS ONE ADAM IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
MISTER CHAIRMAN
MY ON A MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE POLITICS READ I ON
BEHALF OF THE PLASTIC RECYCLER
RECLAIMER -- PROCESSOR COALITION
INCLUDES FOR DECO CARBON LIKE
GREEN FIBER PENINSULA.
RE PAT MARYLAND H. P. -- HPC AND
PENTAX WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORTED
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE KIDS.
THIS CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKUP PRAYER WITH A
PRIME A KELLY ON BEHALF OF
REPUBLIC.
SERVICES WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHORS FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE FORWARD AND HELPING
CREATE A MARKET FOR RECYCLED
PLASTIC WE DRIVE UP.
GENEVIEVE ABIT ON BEHALF OF THE
CLEAN SEIZE LOBBYING COALITION
AND HEAL THE BAY AND SUPPORT.
WE KEEP A CROWDED WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
CATHERINE GARCIA ON BEHALF OF
THE OUR CLUB CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
NATALIE NEXT ON BEHALF OF
RETHINK WASTE IN SUPPORT.
ANDREW EVAN TURNER WITH CLEAN
WATER ACTION IN SUPPORT.
ANIMAL REPRESENTING RE PLANET
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING STEPHANIE MORAL
REPRESENTING RECOLOGY IN SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TONY
GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF NORTH
COMMON NORTH AMERICAN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
J. STRUCTURAL BEHALF OF THE SOUL
HUESO STATION OF NORTH AMERICA
WESTERN PLASTER WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY AND ALAMEDA STOP
WASTING STRONG SUPPORT.
TELL TRYING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE CONSERVATION
BORDERS IN SUPPORT.
OR BRONTE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA REFUSE RECYCLING
COUNCIL NORTHERN DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
JIM WHEN BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
TO CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY -- ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
AND MOVIES HERE FROM OPPOSITION.
WITH ONE OF HIS CONCERNS ABOUT
THE BILL.
L. TO THE IT WAS MORE.
WE HAVE THE PLASTIC RECYCLING
CORPORATION CALIFORNIA THE
AMERICAN BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION
MANAGED IN A CELL BE ANI
UNFORTUNATELY WE MUST OPPOSE
THIS.
BILL UNLESS IT IS AMENDED WE
PROVIDED US SOME.
RECOMMENDATIONS ON ON HOW TO
AMEND THAT.
THE BILL IS THAT PROVIDES
BASICALLY UNREALISTIC GOALS AND
TIMELINES FOR THE RECYCLED
CONTENT MANDATE.
I DO WANT TO COMPLIMENT THE
STAFF ON THE TIME THEY PUT INTO
THIS AND LOOK AT THE ECONOMICS
AND AND THAT AND FRANKLY.
A TRYING TO MINIMIZE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THE MARKETS AS
THE THE AUTHORS AND THE
PROPONENTS BUT THE DISCUSSED.
THIS IS A BILL ABOUT.
MARKETS ABOUT TRYING TO CHANGE
MARKETS WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
CHINESE SOARED P. E. T. WAS NOT
IMPACTED.
SIGNIFICANTLY BY THE CHINESE
STORE THERE WAS NO P. E. T. THAT
WENT INTO LANDFILLS.
ON MARKET MORE TALK ABOUT US THE
CHINESE SORT THAT'S THREE THREE
SEVEN SO WHEN WE LOOK AT PT THAT
IS A A GLOBAL MARKET.
AND SO THE REAL QUESTION IS WHAT
WILL CALIFORNIA'S NUMBERS IN
THIS MANDATE WHICH AGAIN WE
SUPPORT A MANDATE -- WITH
RECYCLED CONTENT BUT AGAIN WELL
MEASURED APPROACH AND OF WAR
SHORTER TERM TIMELINE.
THE WHAT'S THAT GOING TO DO A
ONE OF THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES SO WE WOULD SAY.
LET'S START THE OF THE THE
MANDATE AND LET'S GET IT ROLLING
AND GO THROUGH. TO TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE AND THEN AFTER THAT THERE'S
OTHER BILLS ARE GOING TO HEAR
TODAY -- TEN EIGHTY AND THAT'S
ANOTHER SIDE BILLS THAT WILL
TAKE OVER THE OUT YEARS AND
MINIMIZE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
SO.
MOM WE SUPPORT.
ME PT IS A RECYCLING SUCCESS.
THIS.
TALK ABOUT BOX WATERS BETTER
ABOUT THIS UPSTAIRS IN OUR DEAL
IN THERE'S A PERCEPTION THAT
THIS IS BETTER.
THIS IS SEVENTY SIX RECITE
PERCENT RECYCLE ACCORDING TO
THEIR OWN WEBSITE.
THIS BOTTLE IS 1100% RECYCLED.
THIS BOTTLE IS NOT REALLY RISKS
ARE BOXES NOT REALLY RECYCLED IN
OUR CURRENT SYSTEM THIS BOXES
RECYCLE OUT A 75% RATE.
THIS BOX IS ALSO NOT COMPOSED
DOUBLE ZERO COURT IN THE WEBSITE
IS ZERO POSSIBLE IF YOU LOOK
INTO IT NO PASSED AROUND.
IT HAS METAL ON THE INSIDE
FOOTBALL BOX WATER BUT IS BETTER
IS A GREAT TRADE MARK.
IT'S ACTUALLY NOT REALITY SO
WHEN WE LOOK AT THESE WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THE REALITIES OF THE
ROWS OF PT VERSES THREE THROUGH.
SEVEN THE REALITIES OF THE
MARKETS AND WHAT THIS IS GOING
TO GOING FORWARD WE ABSOLUTELY
AGREE THAT WE SHOULD PROP UP THE
MARKET. TO GET TO GO ON HEALTH
RECLAIM RESULT THE P. R. C. C.
HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN THIS FOR
THIRTY TWO YEARS IN TRYING TO
BUILD DOMESTIC MARKETS A
CALIFORNIA.
THERE ARE TWO PRODUCTS AND THE
VAST MAJORITY NINETIES PERCENT
PLUS.
E. T. RECYCLE CALIFORNIAN AND
PRODUCED CALIFORNIA.
STAYS A CALIFORNIA GOES.
TO TO MARKETS BOTTLES AND FOOD
PACKAGING.
THOSE ARE THE TWO THINGS THAT WE
MAKE IN CALIFORNIA HERE.
AND SO WE DO HAVE A CLOSED LOOP
AND WISH THEN ABSOLUTELY.
WELL FOOD PACKAGING AGAIN WILL
BE MORE IMPACT BY TEN EIGHTY THE
BOTTLES.
OF WILL CONTINUE TO CLOSE THAT
LOOP EVEN MORE MORE AND AGAIN WE
SUPPORT.
MOVING FORWARD WITH A MORE
MEASURED APPROACH.
SIMILAR TO THE E. U. THE E. YOU
STUDIED THIS FOR SEVERAL YEARS
THEY WENT THROUGH -- AND DID YOU
KNOW ECONOMIC MODELS AND CREATED
A MODEL THAT SAID BASICALLY 25%
BY TWENTY A TWENTY FIVE AND 30%
BY.
TWENTY THIRTY THOSE TYPES OF
NUMBERS ARE ARE REALISTIC AND WE
LOOK AT THE MEMBERS THE AMERICAN
BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION MANY OF
THEM HAVE SIGNIFICANT PLEDGES.
AND AND WE STAND BY THAT THAT'S
WHY WE SUPPORT A MOVING.
SOMETHING FORWARD THAT HAS A
MORE MEASURED APPROACH.
BUT THERE'S OTHER.
INDEPENDENT BALL SKEWS ME STORE
BRANDS AT THAT HAVE.
ZERO AT THIS POINT SO TO GET TO
THE NUMBERS THAT ARE IN THIS
BILL OR SUGGESTED BY THE
CONSULTANT IN ONE YEAR ONE YEAR.
OF FROM ENACTMENT IT WILL CREATE
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES FOR ALL
PLAYERS IN THE INDUSTRY BOTH THE
BOTTLER.
BUT THE RECYCLER THE THE
RECLAIMER AND THEN FINALLY
BEFORE WE GET DONE WE'VE ALSO
SEEN.
SOME OF THE ENTITIES ARE ON THE
FRONT AND REAR REDUCED IN AND
COLLECTED MATERIAL SO WE NEED TO
DO BETTER AND HOW MUCH MATERIAL
WE COULD GET COLLECTED THE E. U..
HAS A GOAL OF 90% A COLLECTION
WORDS SEVENTY FIVE BUT WE'RE
STILL A SUCCESS STORY THAT'S
PROP THAT'S THE BEST COLLECTION
RATE.
IN THE UNITED STATES AND A
BETTER THAN EVEN A EUROPE ON PT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE THE CONTENT
AS A WHOLE SO WE'RE DOING WELL
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO DO BETTER?
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO CLOSE THE
LOOP BUT WE NEED TO AVOID
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES WITH
MARKETS IF AGO TOO QUICK TOO
FAST TOO EARLY WE WILL SKEW THE
MARKETS.
AND MAKE ENCOURAGEMENT TO
ACTUALLY FOR BOTTLE MANUFACTURED
ACTUALLY O OUTSIDE.
AND SOURCE MATERIAL FROM FROM
OTHER PLACES RATHER THAN IN
CALIFORNIA AND AGAIN WE SUPPORT
SPECIALLY THE PLASTIC CYCLE
CORPORATION CALIFORNIA SUPPORTS
THE CALIFORNIA MARKET AND HAS
FOR THIRTY TWO YEARS THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY CANOE
TIME TO HAVE THE INTERNATIONAL
BOTTLED WATER ASSOCIATION -- A
JUST A COUPLE OF QUICK POINTS --
WE SUPPORT THE MINOTAUR RECYCLE
APPROACH IN THIS BILL -- THAT'S
RELATIVELY NEW FOR US THIS IS A
VERY CHALLENGING ISSUE -- AND
OUR PRIMARY OBJECTION TO THE
BILL AS IT IS JUST TOO MUCH TOO
FAST -- AND YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE
DEEP IN IT -- I I DIDN'T BRING
ANY -- OF VISUAL AIDS I WILL
MAKE THAT MISTAKE AGAIN ALL OF
BRING SOME NEXT TIME APOLOGIZE
AND WE WANT YOU TO REDUCE WASTE
OIL THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT
BUT NOW APPARENTLY THAT'S NOT
THAT'S NOT THE STORY.
BUT BUT A YOU KNOW A LOT OF THE
GOOD WORK THAT'S BEING DONE IN
INCREASING USE RECYCLING.
IS BY OUR MEMBERS AND IT'S KIND
OF IT'S IT'S BREAKING ITS PATH
BREAKING ITS ITS ITS QUALITY
WORK.
ON WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS A
STATUTORY MANDATE THAT EVERYBODY
ACHIEVE.
KIND OF OUT LIAR RESULTS AND SO
THAT'S THAT'S THE PIECE THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO NAVIGATE AND TO
TRY TO HELP WITH THIS.
WE SAT DOWN TO SOME OF THE
LARGEST PURCHASERS OF THEM
RECYCLE MATERIAL WITH THE
PROVIDERS AND CAME UP WITH A
FRAMEWORK AND THAT'S THE THAT'S
THE THING THAT WE THINK BEST
INFORMS THIS AND WE ALSO THINK
THAT.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE E. U. AND I I
HAVE.
TO I HAVE TO AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES THAT THAT THE E. YOU
LOOK AT THIS FOR A VERY VERY
LONG TIME.
AND ISN'T GOING ANYWHERE NEAR
75% THAT THAT NUMBER -- IT IN
OUR MINDS AS FOLKS THAT DO THIS
KIND OF EVERY DAY WE CAN'T WE
CAN'T UNDERSTAND HOW THAT COULD
POSSIBLY HAPPEN SO THAT'S THAT'S
REALLY OUR OUR PRIMARY CONCERNS
WE THINK THAT THE FRAMEWORK THAT
WE PUT TOGETHER -- ONE OF THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT THAT TESTIFIED
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS PART
OF THAT FRAMEWORK -- WE CAME UP
WITH -- 25% -- BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WE THINK THAT
THAT IS DOABLE WE ALSO THINK
THAT THE MARKET WOULD HAVE TO
OPERATE INKIND OF UNPRECEDENTED
LEE.
EFFICIENT AND OTHER WAYS TO EVEN
HIT THAT NUMBER AND SO -- THAT'S
WHAT WE CAME UP YOU IS OBVIOUSLY
I THINK SUPPORTS OUR FRAMEWORK.
THIS IS AN ECONOMIC APPROACH AND
AND IT SEEMS TO US TO BE HEAVILY
HEAVILY HEAVILY A YOU KNOW KIND
OF PUSHED ON THE DEMAND SIDE
WE'RE WE'RE NOT SEEING THE SAME
LEVEL OF ATTENTION.
AND AFFECT ON THE SUPPLY SIDE
NOT I WOULD SAY THAT THAT IN THE
THE LAST LITTLE WHILE WE'VE HAD
SOME SOME -- HOPEFUL
CONVERSATIONS WITH WITH THE
AUTHORS -- AND WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO KIND OF ROLLING UP
OUR SLEEVES AND REALLY REALLY
DIGGING INTO THE DETAILS THE
NUMBERS THE TIME LINES THE
PENALTIES -- AND SOME OF THE
OTHER FACTORS OF THIS KIND OF
VERY COMPLEX AND VERY INVOLVED
BILL -- AND WITH THAT WE ARE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED BUT
LOOKING FORWARD TO SOME SOME.
GOOD WORK TO BE DONE AT THAT
STILL LEFT TO BE DONE ON THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU TO MY THANK YOU.
OTHER BOOKS ONE ACT I DON'T
OPPOSITION A RAISE CONCERNS.
GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS THERE
THOMAS WITH NIAGARA BOTTLING
WE'RE OPPOSED TO AB SEVEN NINE
TWO IN ITS CURRENT FORM BUT
SUPPORT THE ALTERNATIVE
FRAMEWORK BY THE BOTTLE WATER
INDUSTRY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE TERM MEMBERS JOE ACT ON
BEHALF THE PLASTICS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION -- WERE OPPOSE
BECAUSE OF THE ANA CAN'T
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES ON THE
MARKET THAT BEEN OUTLINED
[inaudible]
AND THE ALSO BECAUSE WE DO
BELIEVE ANY IN A MORE MEASURED
APPROACH THANK YOU.
IF CHAIR MEMBERS ADAM REGULAR
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ALSO HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED BUT LOOK FOR TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR THINKS
AUTHORS.
THROUGH THE USE OF THE
CALIFORNIA THE PRODUCERS IN
OPPOSITION.
MR MEMBERS JOHN HERE ON BEHALF
GROCERY MANUFACTURERS OPPOSE FOR
THE REASON STATE.
SOME OF YOU GUYS GET YOUR
LETTERS AND HAVE ABOUT ALL THOSE.
GROUPS WERE LISTEN OPPOSITION --
THANK YOU OKAY -- OTHER FOLKS
WHEN ADAM AND OPPOSITION A RAISE
CONCERNS NOW SEEN IN ITS -- AT
THE WE BRING TO THE BACK TO
COMMITTEE.
CENTER WILL CASKEY.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO CONGRATULATE
THE AUTHORS AND BRINGING THE
MATTER FORWARD I THINK IT BILLS
ON SB ONE SIX EIGHT YOU MIGHT
REMEMBER THAT THAT WAS A SMALL
30% CONTENT BILL LAST YEAR.
IT WAS UNFORTUNATE COULDN'T GET
APPROVED OVER IN THE OTHER HOUSE
I'M WONDERING IF THE THE MIND.
SENATOR ASKING ON PAGES EIGHT
AND NINE OF OUR ANALYSIS THE
TALK ABOUT -- SOME.
AN AMENDMENT LETTUCE LANGUAGE
ABOUT TWEAKING THE TIMELINE --
CLEAR FIND THE MINIMUM CONTENT
STANDARDS I WAS WONDERING THE
AUTHORS THOUGHTS ON ON THAT --
INPUT.
WE WE WE ACCEPTED I THINK THAT
COMMITTEES IN MINNESOTA WE'RE
STILL.
ARE THESE THE ONE THAT WE ACCEPT
YES.
OKAY AS I DID I MISS THAT THEN
THE NEXUS ON THE TIME. TO JUST
CLEAR FOR TIMELINE WAS CHANGED.
YEAH MEDIUM AND IT WAS ON TIMELY
OKAY SO WE GOT ANOTHER YEAR ON
TWENTY FIVE I'M.
ON THE PENALTIES.
ON IT TALKS ABOUT COULD FIND A
MINIMUM CONTENT STANDARDS ARE
NOT MEASURED IN THE AGGREGATE
THE UNPAID SEVEN IN THE HOUSE AS
WE TALK ABOUT PENALTIES ARE.
PER BOTTLE VERSUS THE WEIGHT --
IN.
THAT THE RECOMMENDATIONS SORT OF
PUTS IT ON THE AUTHORS ABOUT
REVISING REVIVING THE WEIGHT AND
THE PER BOTTLE PENALTY.
IS THAT ALSO INCLUDED OR SAT.
STATUS QUO YEAH SENATE THIS
RECOMMENDATION.
BECAUSE IT SEEMS IT TALKS ABOUT
THE AMBITIOUS NATURE OF THE BILL --
AT LEAST THROUGH THE END OF THE
DECADE MIGHT REQUIRE SOME.
OF THE TO GET PEOPLE GOING THE
BILL ALSO GET GIVEN YOUR WORK
FROM LAST YEAR AS WELL AS WHAT
HAPPENED IN EUROPE I THINK WE
ARE STILL HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN
FIND A COMPROMISE WITH ALL THE
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
I'LL BE WILLING TO MOVE THE BILL
THANK YOU THE QUESTION FAST FROM
THE MEMBERS YES SIR SKINNER.
I'M THANK YOU I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT WE HAVE A BILL
THAT FINALLY NOT FINALLY BECAUSE
WE'VE HAD OTHERS BUT STILL THAT
THIS IS FOCUSED ON MARKETS
[inaudible]
AND OF WE'VE ALREADY HEARD FROM --
REPRESENTED FROM CALIFORNIA
WASTE ABOUT THE FACT THAT --
RECYCLING IS NOT PUTTING
SOMETHING IN A BEEN JUST ISN'T
AN UNLESS WE HAVE MARKETS SO
IT'S NOT JUST THE PURCHASE OF
THE STUFF WE SHOULD READ HER
BAIL.
IT IS THE REMANUFACTURE OF IT
INTO A PRODUCT THAT IS RECYCLING
IT'S A LOOP.
AND UNLESS THE LOOP IS CLOSED WE
DON'T HAVE ANY RECYCLING.
SO WE KNOW NOW.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE SORT OF FIXATED
BECAUSE A CHINA BUT ACTUALLY
WE'VE NOT HAD A CLOSED LOOP FOR
EVEN PRIOR TO THAT.
AND WE'VE HAD AND I THINK IT'S
UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS ARE SO DEDICATED TO
DO THE RIGHT THING IN OUR OUR
PUBLIC TAKE UP RATE.
OF WHAT THEY PERCEIVED TO BE
RECYCLING WHICH IS PUTTING IN A
BIN IS PHENOMENAL IT'S GREAT.
BUT WE HAVEN'T THEN DELIVERED ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF SENDING THE
RIGHT.
ECONOMIC SIGNALS ARE MARKET
SIGNALS TO INSURE THAT THAT
MATERIAL THAT EVERYBODY PUTS IN
THE BIN GETS RE MANUFACTURED.
NOW YEARS AGO FOR EXAMPLE WHEN
CALIFORNIA ADOPTED AB NINE
THIRTY NINE WHICH WAS EIGHTY
NINE I BELIEVE -- WE WERE VERY
FIXATED THAT WE NEEDED MARKETS
AND THERE WAS DIFFERENT EFFORTS
INCLUDING EFFORTS TO REQUIRE
WHICH PASSED REQUIRE THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
THE PAPER WE PURCHASED HAD TO
HAVE AN MINIMUM POST CONSUMER
RECYCLED CONTENT BECAUSE WE KNEW
WE HAD TO SEND THAT SIGNAL IF WE
LOOK AT OUR JURISDICTIONS.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS UP AND DOWN
THE STATE MANY OF THEM HAVE
RULES AROUND THEIR OWN PREACHER
PROCUREMENT.
THAT THEY BY MINIMUM A RECYCLED
CONTENT AND FOR IN THE DURING
THAT TIME THERE WAS.
NOT ENOUGH MANUFACTURING IN U.
S. OF THAT USED THE SECONDARY
MATERIALS BUT THERE WAS ROBUST
MANUFACTURING.
BUT LIKE SO MUCH ELSE OF THEIR
MANUFACTURING SECTOR IN U. S..
WE'VE WITH THE IT'S DIMINISH SO
IN OTHER WORDS THERE IS FAR LESS
MANUFACTURING.
IN THE U. S. THAT WILL TAKE A
SECONDARY MATERIAL AND RE
MANUFACTURE IT.
PARTLY WHY BECAUSE WE'VE NOT
SENT THE RIGHT MARKET SIGNALS
NOW WE HAPPEN TO HAVE COMPANIES
IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT DO YOU.
PURCHASE THESE PLASTICS AND WILL
RE MANUFACTURED THERE'S FEWER
THAN THERE USED TO BE BUT WE
HAVE THEM HERE.
AND WHY SHOULDN'T WE HELP
SUPPORT THEM.
AND RATHER AND SO THAT THEY CAN
COMPETE FAIRLY WITH THIS VIRGIN
RESIN -- BECAUSE WE HAVE THE
GOALS MEANING WE HAVE THE 75%
GOAL FOR QUOTE UNQUOTE RECYCLING
SO WORK COLLECTING THAT MUCH OF
THE MATERIAL SO TO CLOSE THE
LOOP WE HAVE TO MAKE THE MARKET
SIGNAL.
NOW WE HAVE SEEN AS CALIFORNIA
INCREDIBLE SUCCESS WITH GOOD
MARKET SIGNALS.
THE RENEWABLE ENERGY WAS ONE OF
THE NOTIONS THAT WAS CITED WEEK
THE PRICE FOR A KILOWATT HOUR
EVERY NEW BILLY GENERATED
ELECTRICITY COMPETES FIND WITH
EVERY OTHER GENERATION OF
ELECTRICITY.
PARTLY DUE TO THE APPROPRIATE
MARKET SIGNALS THAT CALIFORNIA
ENACTED -- EVEY IS HAVE COME
DOWN IN PRICE AGAIN PARTLY DUE
TO THE MARKET SIGNALS THAT
CALIFORNIAN ACTED.
THIS IS SOMETHING WHERE WE HAVE
GOT TO ADOPT POLICIES TO SEND
THOSE APPROPRIATE MARKET SIGNALS.
NOW WHILE I CAN'T NECESSARILY
GUARANTEE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SEE A LOT MORE.
IN COUNTRY YOU'RE IN STATE
MANUFACTURING FACILITIES -- COME
ABOARD BUT IF IT DOES ALL THE
BETTER BECAUSE THEN WE ARE
CLOSING THE LOOP RIGHT HERE AND
WE'RE EVEN REDUCING.
THE ALL THE EMISSIONS RELATED TO
SHIPPING IT OUT SOMEWHERE ELSE
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE THIS BILL
IT IS A GREAT MOVE IN EXACTLY
THE RIGHT DIRECTION SO THAT
CALIFORNIA'S.
GOALS AROUND RECYCLING ARE REAL
BECAUSE WE ARE ACTUALLY CLOSING
THE LOOP AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING IT [inaudible] THIRTY
DOLLARS.
THANK YOU CHAIR.
SO WE HAVE WE'VE HAD A LOT OF
CONVERSATION ABOUT I AGREE I
WANT I WANT TO CLOSE THE TWO I
THINK THIS GREAT I THINK
CALIFORNIA.
IS A LEADER [inaudible]
BUT IT WAS CITED IN SOME OF THE
TESTIMONY ABOUT YOU KNOW
BASICALLY WE FORCED.
RENEWABLES AND ENERGY.
BUT TOO MUCH OF A GOOD THING IS
TOO MUCH OF A GOOD THING.
WE ARE PRODUCING IT IS THE
KNOWLEDGE I WANT TO BRING SO I
CAN COME BACK TO THIS BILL.
WE'RE OVER PRODUCING SOLAR
ENERGY IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW
AND WE'RE STILL INCENTIVIZE IT
WERE STILL PUSHING THAT
[inaudible]
FORWARD.
AND SO THE OUR LEADER BUT OUR
COST OF ENERGY IS HIGHER THAN
MOST ANY PLACE IN THE NATION.
SO I THINK WE SHOULD INCENTIVIZE
BUT ALSO HEARD THE OPPOSITION
WHO JUST SAID HATE LIST THUS
THUS DO THIS THE RIGHT WAY THE
RIGHT WAY IS NOT FORED INTO A
GOAL THAT IS VERY HARD FOR THEM
TO MEET.
SO THAT WE PUSH IT OUT OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE DON'T ACTUALLY
DO WHAT WE WANT TO DO IF WE WANT
TO BE A LEADER IN THE WORLD.
WE HAVE TO BRING INDUSTRY ALONG
WITH THIS.
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN SO I HEARD
FROM THE OPPOSITION THAT THEY
WOULD DON'T WANT THAT THAT IT'S
ABOUT A PERCENTAGE SO LET'S TRY
TO GET TO THAT PERCENTAGE WHERE
THEY'RE COMFORTABLE WITH IT.
AND I WOULD BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THIS SO THAT WE ACTUALLY CAN'T
DO THE RIGHT THING AND LEAD --
AND SHOW BY EXAMPLE TO THE REST
OF YOU KNOW.
PEOPLE WHO ARE HER NOT DOING
THIS OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO IF WE CAN PUT THAT LOU AND
CLOSE THAT LOOP -- AND ACTUALLY
DO IT IN A WAY WHERE WE DON'T
PUSH BUSINESS OUT OF CALIFORNIA
ANY WE I HAVE BOTTLERS IN MY
DISTRICT THAT ARE OPPOSE THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION BECAUSE OF
THE PERCENTAGE IN THIS BILL.
SO ARE YOU WILLING -- TO LOOK AT
THAT NUMBER AND GET IT TERM
SOMEPLACE WHERE THEY CAN CAN'T
COME ON AND SAY HEY LOOK WITH US
DO THIS AND ARE SPREAD OUT OVER
TIME SO THAT WE DON'T.
PUSH THAT INDUSTRY OUT OF
CALIFORNIA OR DRIVE THE COST UP
TO WHERE IT IS COULD NOT CAN
ACTUALLY BE A PRODUCTIVE.
AND AND MEET THE GOAL.
NO I I JUST WANNA MAKE UP FIRST
I APPRECIATE -- THE SKINNER AND
ARE KIND OF HER A HISTORIC
PERSPECTIVE I JUST WANT TO MAKE
THE POINT THAT EVERYBODY THAT
WAS SITTING UP HERE WAS OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED AND WE HAVE BEEN.
HAVING VERY GOOD NEGOTIATIONS
WITH THEM THEY ARE IN FAVOR OF
THE MANDATE WE ARE JUST WORKING
WITH THE NUMBERS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN.
COME TO SOME SORT OF NUMBER THAT
PUSHES THEM A LITTLE BIT BUT
THAT THEY CAN AGREE WITH ALAN --
TO WE'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK SO
FAR AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT
WORK BECAUSE IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT THIS -- THAT WERE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THIS AND CLOSE THE LOOP.
THIRD I ACTUALLY I THINK WE WANT
TO HELP SO -- HAPPY TO WORK WITH
AND WHICH IS FOR EXAMPLE THE
INITIAL OFFER FROM THE
OPPOSITION WAS 25% BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE YOU HEARD
OPPOSITION FROM NIAGARA NIAGARA
TODAY TODAY NOT TOMORROW TODAY'S
ALREADY AT 40%.
NESTLE IS AT 37% AND THOSE ARE
THE TWO LARGEST BOTTLED WATER
COMPANIES IN THE STATE.
ALSO IN ADDITION 50% OF OUR PET
IS GOING OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA
SO WE WE ABSOLUTELY.
AGAIN THE RICHES OF ONE OF THE
OF THE PLASTICS IS OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA SO AGAIN WE WOULD
LIKE TO BE THE SINGLE WE WANT TO
KEEP IN CALIFORNIA.
WE WANT A REALISTIC PERCENTAGE
BUT IT'S ODD WHEN.
YOU AGAIN YOU HAVE THE TWO
LARGEST.
BOTTLE WATER MANUFACTURES
ALREADY WELL ABOVE THE 25%
SAYING.
HEY THE INDUSTRY CAN GET THERE
TILL TWENTY TWENTY FIVE NOW ONE
OF THE REASONS IS THERE'S A
LIMITED SUPPLY THAT'S RIGHT SO
YOU GARY GO AHEAD.
I PLEASE ALSO PART PART OF IT IS
WE HAVE TO COLLECT MORE SO WITH
TO DO BETTER COLLECTION WEEK IF
WE CAN GO HIGHER THE 75%
ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS
AS SOME OF THE RECYCLE PLASTIC
IS GOING TO OTHER USES SO IF WE
CAN LIMITED TO BEVERAGE BOTTLES
I THINK WE'RE ALL VERY VERY OPEN
TO THAT -- BUT WE ALSO BELIEVE
BY PUSHING THIS CONTENT THERE
WILL BE MORE DEMANDING PART PART
OF WHAT WHAT ALEX DIDN'T SAY IS.
THERE'S THIS COMMON OF WATER
SUPPLY HE'LL HE'LL TELL HIS
BUSINESS OF THE STRUGGLE.
SO WE HAVE MANUFACTURERS IN
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE STRUGGLING
BUSINESSES WHO WANT TO DO MORE
RECYCLED PLASTIC THERE HASN'T
BEEN AS MUCH A MARKET BECAUSE OF
THE PRICING.
BETWEEN.
VIRGIN PLASTIC AND RECYCLE
PLASTIC SO AGAIN WE WE
ABSOLUTELY WANT TO FIND A
PERCENTAGE BUT AGAIN WHEN THE
OPENING OFFER.
IS A PERCENT THAT'S SIX YEARS
EIGHT YEARS SEVEN YEARS OUT AND
THAT YOU HAVE MANY OF THE
LARGEST MANUFACTURES READY
MAKING IT.
COCA COLA JUST BY CONTRAST SAYS
IN EUROPE THE GOOD 250% BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE CALL NOW THEY
HAVE A SAID THAT IN NORTH
AMERICA CALIFORNIA.
BUT THEY'RE SAYING THAT IN
EUROPE SO SO AGAIN WE WE WANT.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE PERCENTAGE
MAKES SENSE BUT WE ALSO DON'T
WANT TO BE TAKEN.
FOR YOU ALSO CREATE A WHEN YOU
MANDATE IT SO THESE THE DO ANY
MANDATE THAT AMOUNT.
IT INCREASE IT CREATES.
THEY HAVE TO GO GET IT AND IF
THE VET SUPPLIES OUT THERE AND
IT'S DRIVES THE PRICE THAT WE
SAW THAT WHEN THE BIOMASS
INDUSTRY JUST LAST TWO YEARS AND
WE FORCED THEM TO TAKE A CERTAIN.
PERCENTAGE AND THEN THEY'RE ALL
COMPETING FOR THAT CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE WHEN THERE'S OTHERS
OF OTHER VEHICLE SO IT HAS TO BE
BALANCED AND I KNOW YOU'RE MADE
SO I I WANT THIS TO WORK.
AYE AYE AYE BUT WE'VE GOT A IT'S
GOT TO WORK SO THAT WE DON'T
DRIVE THEM OUT OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE KEEP THOSE HERE WE
ACTUALLY OUR MODEL FOR THE ORLD.
TOTALLY GREEN I THINK ONE OF THE
WAYS THAT WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT
THE OFFRAMP THAT WE DESIGNED
475% BUT WE COULD DO IT FOR FOR
THE LOWER PERCENTAGES.
IS REALLY HAVE SORT OF CAL
RECYCLE BE ABLE TO FLIP THAT
SWITCH ON AND OFF SINCE IF YOU
REALLY DO HAVE.
A SUPPLY ISSUE THAT WE'RE
MONITORING YOU KNOW SIX YEARS
OUT THANK YOU CAN HAVE CAL
RECYCLE SAY OKAY.
YOU KNOW WORKABLE GONNA FLIP IT
OFF SO I THINK THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WERE WE ARE OPEN.
TO NEGOTIATING SO THAT THE
SOMEONE IS MONITORING I THINK IT
IS.
DIFFICULT WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
BASS MAKE SIX OR YOU KNOW EIGHT
YEARS OUT. TO TO KNOW EXACTLY
THE RIGHT PERCENTAGE WHICH IS
WHY I THINK IT DOES MAKE SENSE
TO HAVE AN OFFER.
WHICH WHICH THAT OFFRAMP GOING
TO BE.
REGULATED BY.
THE WAY SUPPORT.
WHO'S GONNA DO WHAT I THINK AT
THIS POINT.
THE WAY WE HAD ENVISIONED THE
75% OFF RAMP WAS BY CAL RECYCLE
AND THAT'S WHO WE ARE PROBABLY --
OF LOOK AT AS WELL.
I DON'T KNOW I DON'T KNOW IF
WAY SPORTS ARE.
OFF THE FIELD YES AND AND AND
AND MY JOINT AUTHORS SAY AGAIN
WE'RE WE'RE ALSO CONSULTING WITH
THEM ABOUT WHAT THE OFFRAMP
SHOULD BE AS WELL.
SO WE WE HAVE THE SAME CONCERNS
IS YOUR TRYING.
TO PLAN FOR THE FUTURE AS WELL.
I WANTED -- TO WE WANT WE WOULD
LOVE TO PARTICIPATE NOT OFFRAMP
CONVERSATION AND OBVIOUSLY WE'RE
DEEPLY INVOLVED IN YOUR A CO
AUTHOR JOIN AUTHOR ON THE ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIZED VERSION OF WHAT
WE'RE DOING.
ON PLASTICS WRIT LARGE WILL BE
PRESENTING LATER TODAY -- BUT I
I THINK IT'S I I WOULD SAY THE
MOST COMPELLING ARGUMENTS AND
BROUGHT UP TO ME WITH THE REST
THIS PARTICULAR BILL FROM THE
OPPOSITION HAS JUST BEEN.
AND IF YOU IF YOU IF YOU TALK TO
COVER CYCLE AND EVERYBODY AGREES
OF THESE.
THE STANDARDS ARE AGGRESSIVE BUT
I THINK THE THOUGHT IS IS THAT --
YOU KNOW THE THE THE HOW WE'RE
GONNA BE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE STILL IN
DEVELOPMENT AND STILL GROWING.
TO A FACTUAL -- EIGHT MY TIRE
RECYCLING RATES AND AND RECYCLE
CONTENT RATES -- BUT GIVEN THE
FACT THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTIES ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY.
AND I THINK THE COUNCIL BECAUSE
OF THE RIGHT PLACE.
TO KNOW THOSE OF THOSE OF THE
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS AS THE
ONES ARE GONNA BE IMPLEMENTING
SB FIFTY FOUR A. B..
TEN EIGHTY IF THOSE PASS AND AND
THAT MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S
NOT CONFLICT IN THAT WE DON'T
ALSO CREATE.
I SERIES A BY PRODUCT IN THE
MARKETS IT MIGHT ACTUALLY BE
DISADVANTAGEOUS TO THE THE
PROPER RECYCLING WASTE REDUCTION
AGENDA AND SO.
I'D LOVE.
TO THE BILL PASSES OUT TODAY
LOVE TO WORK CLOSELY BETWEEN OUR
COMMITTEE AND IN THE TO VIEW ON
ON ON THAT ON THAT OUR FRONT
LANGUAGE.
HAPPY TO ABSOLUTE OKAY.
OKAY -- BUT THE QUESTIONS
CONCERNS.
FIVE OKAY SO IT'S REMOVED BY A
CINEMA CASKEY -- IF YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE BY THEIR AUTHORS.
JUST ASK FOR DRIVER THING.
THANK YOU ARE ABLE TO DOES A
CLOSE -- DETECTIVE IS KALRA.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN A. B. SEVEN
NINETY TWO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALLEN HI ALAN HI BATES
[inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
HILL.
SKINNER AYE SKINNER AYE STERN.
I CASKEY CASKEY I OKAY GREAT --
SO WILL HOLD OUT OPEN -- THREE
ZERO WELL THAT OPEN FOR OTHER
FOLKS THAT I THINK YOU SOME
MEMBERS.
WE SHOULD THE COMMITTEE WILL BE
RELIEVED TO HEAR THIS IS MY VERY
LAST BILL.
I LOVE THE I LOVE THE COMMITTEE
AS WELL BUT I'M SURE YOU'LL BE
HAPPY TO SEE ME.
GO AND HAVE SOME OTHER AUTHORS
AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
AB ARE TEN FORTY SIX REVIVES AN
ISSUE THAT I WORKED ON A COUPLE
YEARS AGO.
WHICH IS LOKING AT HOW WE WAS
REDESIGNED THE CLEAN VEHICLE
REBATE PROGRAM.
THE CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE%
PROGRAMS BEEN ONE OF THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAYS WE'VE HAD TO
INCENTIVIZE CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
TO GET INTO CLEAN CARS IT'S BEEN.
A WHILE THE SUCCESSFUL WE HAVE
ALMOST FIVE HUNDRED OR OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND CLEAN CARS ON
THE ROAD TODAY -- YET WE ARE
STILL VERY FAR AWAY FROM OUR ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION GOAL IN
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IN OUR FIVE
MILLION CAR GOAL IN.
TWENTY THIRTY SO WE THINK BY
HAVING A REDESIGN OF THE PROGRAM
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE A
PROGRAM THAT TAKES OUT SOME OF
THE YEAR TO YEAR VOLATILITY WITH
THIS PROGRAM WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED BECAUSE EVEN WITH THE
KERN APPROPRIATION WE JUST DID
IN THE BUDGET.
THE PROGRAM POTENTIALLY COULD
EVEN RUN OUT SOMETIME IN THE
FALL THIS YEAR -- WHICH WOULD
LEAVE CONSUMERS OUT IN A LURCH
AND WOULD REALLY -- TAKE -- BE
TAKE A HIT FOR OUR CLEAN CAR
INDUSTRY AS AS EVERYBODY AND
THIS COMMITTEE KNOWS 40% OF OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS.
ARE CREATION IS COMING FROM
TRANSPORTATION 80% OF THAT
TRANSPORTATION NUMBER COMES FROM
LIGHT DUTY VEHICLES WHICH
INCLUDES PASSENGER VEHICLE SOME
MOST OF THAT.
POLLUTION IS REALLY COMING FROM
THE CARS THAT YOU AND I DRIVE
EVERY SINGLE DOWN THE ROAD.
SO WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY ASK BY
VOTE ON A. B. TEN FORTY SIX WHAT
WE WANT TO DO IS ASK THE A. R.
B. IN COORDINATION WITH
PERMANENT FINANCING THE STATE
TREASURER. TO LOOK AT DESIGNING
THE A PROGRAM WHERE THEY COULD
SECURITIZED FUNDS IN THE SHORT
TERM. TO GIVE OUT OVER -- SAY A
TEN YEAR PERIOD POTENTIALLY
RAISE THE REBATE LEVEL UP TO
SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS BUT
HAVE THAT REBATE GO TO ZERO OVER
TIME SIMILAR TO WHAT WE DID WITH --
GO SOLAR AND SEVERAL WE THINK BY
REDESIGN THE PROGRAM IN THIS
FASHION WE CAN GET TO OUR FIVE
MILLION VEHICLE GOAL BY.
TWENTY THIRTY WITHOUT RESPECT
FAST RIGHT [inaudible]
YES SIR.
SURE MEMBERS -- DAN CHAU WITH
TESLA.
AS THE ONLY -- OUT OF AUTO
MANUFACTURER IN THE STATE AND
THE STATE'S LARGEST
MANUFACTURING EMPLOYER I'M
PLEASED -- HERE TO REPRESENT THE
TUSSLE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TEN FORTY SIX IN SHORT WE
BELIEVE -- THE BILL IS NEEDED TO
FORCE A SERIOUS CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW TO REFORM THE CVR P..
TO HELP MEET THE STATE'S
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION
AND GHG AND THEIR POLLUTION
GOALS.
AT A TIME WHEN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING TO
ROLL BACK FUEL ECONOMY AND GHG
EMISSIONS STANDARDS.
THE STATE NEEDS TO DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO ENCOURAGE CONSUMERS
TO BUY EDIE'S.
AND MAINTAIN THE EEVEE SALES
MOMENTUM THAT HAS BEEN ACHIEVED
THUS FAR -- AS OF MAY WITH --
BUT A 6% MARKET SHARE -- LAST
YEAR -- ALMOST 10% -- WITH A
COUPLE MONTHS.
AS THE THE SOME MEMBER A
MENTIONED -- WE BOTH BRING TO
THIS CONVERSATION TO THE BEST
PRACTICES OF THE CALIFORNIA
SOLAR INITIATIVE WHICH
REPRESENTS THE GOLD STANDARD IN
REBATE DESIGN.
STABLING CONTINUOUS -- REVENUE
SOURCE TRANSPARENT REBATE LEVELS
THAT STEP DOWN OVER TIME AS
PENETRATION INCREASED.
CONSUMER EDUCATION AND AWARENESS
WHILE ALSO GIVING TAXPAYERS AND
DECISION MAKERS CERTAINTY THAT
REBATES WOULD COME TO AN END.
AB TEN FORTY SIX IS INFORMED BY
THIS EXPERIENCE AND IS BEFORE
YOU AT A TIME WHEN UNFORTUNATELY
THE PROGRAM -- THIS IS RUN OUT
OF FUNDING -- AND CONSUMERS HAVE
AGAIN BEEN PLACED ON WAIT LISTS --
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU --
SOMEONE ROOTING FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP RESPECT THAT FIRST
PRIVATE.
SPONSORED.
QUESTION SUPPORT.
THIS CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKUP PRIOR WITH A
PRIME TO KELLY ON BEHALF OF
CHARGE POINT WE WANT TO THANK MR
TING FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD.
AND DRIVER.
YEAH BLUFF HAD WITH CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
WE SUPPORTED A PRIOR VERSION OF
THE BILL AND WE UNDERSTAND THERE
WILL BE AMENDMENTS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO REVIEWING THAT NEW
PERSON.
KILLER ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING SO SHE
ISN'T IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE VICE COUGH WITH NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA -- WHERE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU?
PROSECUTORS HERE ON BEHALF OF
ADVANCED -- ENERGY ECONOMY IN
SUPPORT.
HERE WE'D INTO AN SEP
REPRESENTING STANDUP RUSS ONCE
FOR THE BILL.
KATHY CARE TO REPRESENTING THREE
FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT FOLKS HONOREES
OPPOSITION CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL.
MORNING MR SHARON MEMBERS LEE IS
OVER THERE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
CAL CHAMBER AND A COALITION OF
BUSINESSES AND CLEAN TECH
ORGANIZATIONS ARE UNFORTUNATELY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
DOES THE DUPLICATE EXISTING
STUDIES ONGOING A CARBON
INTERFERES WITH TECHNOLOGICAL
DEVELOPMENT.
CAL CHAMBER ONLY OPPOSE CERTAIN
PORTIONS OF THE PRIOR VERSION OF
THE BILL WHICH SOUGHT TO STUDY
WAYS TO INCREASE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND IMPORTANT
ISSUE TO EVALUATE.
CUSTOMERS NOT OPPOSED TO
HOLISTIC STUDY TO EVALUATE WAYS
TO INCREASE PENETRATION OF LOW
OR ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES IN
CALIFORNIA.
HOWEVER THE LEGISLATURE THIS
YEAR DID JUST TO PROVE A ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
EXPENDITURE FROM THE GREENHOUSE
GAS MONEY. FOR CARD TO STUDY
THIS VERY ISSUE INCLUDING WAYS
TO TRANSITION TO A LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION ECONOMY INCLUDING
INCREASING THE USE OF LOW AND
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES IN THE
STATE.
THIS BILL UNFORTUNATELY
CIRCUMVENT THAT PROCESS AND
HAMSTRINGS A MORE HOLISTIC
APPROACH BY MANDATING THE CLEAN
VEHICLE REBATE BE SCALED WITH
THE CONTINUES APPROPRIATION TO
MEET A FIVE MILLION ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES BY TWENTY
THIRTY GOAL.
THE REALITY IS IS POINTED OUT BY
THIS COMMITTEES ANALYSIS THAT
DESPITE THE USE OF REBATES
MARKET PENETRATION OF YOUR
MICHELIN VEHICLES REMAINS AROUND
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND AND
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE MARKET
EDUCATION AND OTHER FACTORS MUST
BE ADDRESSED FIRST.
IN ADDITION THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE RECENTLY
POINTED OUT THAT THESE
EXPRESSIONS EXPENDITURES HAVE
NOT TO DATE BEEN EFFECTIVE OR
COST COMPETITIVE WHICH DOES NOT
HELP US MEET OUR STATE'S
EMISSION REDUCTION GOALS.
ANOTHER TRANSPORTATION SECTORS
MUST ALSO BE ADDRESSED WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS
SUGGESTED BY THE COMMITTEE IN
THE AUTHORS WILLINGNESS TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON OUR CONCERNS.
ABOUT FOR THESE REASONS AND
OTHERS CAL CHAMBER MEANS A
POSTED AB.
TEN FORTY SIX GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JOURNALS.
THE HARPER THAT'S LATER THAT'S
LATER SIR -- JOHN MOFFITT ON
BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE OF
AUTOMOBILE MANUFACTURERS WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL AS IT AS IT
IS IN PRINT -- WEEK COMPLIMENTS
TO THE COMMITTEE WE THINK THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS IS VERY GOOD --
WE RAISE TWO ISSUES IN OUR
OPPOSITION LETTER ONE WE THINK
MAYBE ADDRESS WOULD LIKE O SEE
LANGUAGE BUT WE THINK MAY BE
ADDRESSED BY THE AMENDMENTS THAT
THE THAT THE COMMITTEE IS
SUGGESTING.
ON THE OTHER ISSUE WE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH THE
AUTHOR YESTERDAY AND RAISE THE
ISSUE OF FEE BATES AND ARE
CONCERNED.
ABOUT THAT SORT OF PROGRAM AND
STRUCTURE AND HOW WE'VE SEEN
THOSE THOSE SYSTEMS FAIL IN IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD WHEN
THEY'VE TRIED THEM -- THE THE
AUTHOR AND I CERTAINLY DON'T
SPEAK FOR HIM BUT MADE CLEAR TO
US IN THE MEETING THAT THAT WAS
NOT THE INTENT HE EXPLAINED TO
US.
MUCH OF WHAT HE SAID IN
COMMITTEE HERE TODAY ABOUT SORT
OF FRONT LOADING -- USING A
SECURITIZATION TOOL TO FRONT
LOAD MONEY FOR C. B. R. P. AND I
THINK OUR RESPONSE WAS WELL
THAT'S SOMETHING WE'D LIKE TO
TALK ABOUT.
AND SO -- AS A SAID WE WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL AS IT IS IN
PRINT -- BUT LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD TO SEE IF WE
CAN COME UP WITH A A LONGER TERM
MORE STABLE FUNDING SOURCE FOR
C. B. R. P. WE THINK -- THE
CONCEPT IS SOMETHING WE CAN WORK
WITH BUT LOT MORE MEAT NEEDS TO
BE PUT ON THE PHONE A LOT MORE
DETAIL.
IN THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL --
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
THAT DISCUSSION OKAY PURSUE THAT
IN MANY OTHERS YOU WHAT WHAT IS
IS THERE IT WAS THE RECYCLE
CONTENT.
OF THE CARPET IN THE ZAPS.
YOU KNOW I I MEAN I'LL BE HONEST --
I YOU YOU KNOW UNDER THE HOOD OF
A CAR IS RECYCLED CARPET A LOT
OF THOSE PLASTICS ARE MADE FROM
RECYCLED CARPET.
ITSELF.
BUT THAT COULD BE UPSET BY
FUTURE BILL THAT WE'RE GOING TO
TALK ABOUT THERE YOU GO.
AND WHAT TO DO YOU HAVE OKAY ALL
RIGHT OTHER FOLKS ONE OF HIS
CONCERNS I AT YOUR ALLEN NUMBERS
THE COMEDIAN BRIAN KINNEY WITH
CLEAN ENERGY -- OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL -- ALSO OUR TRADE
ASSOCIATION OF IRONY JUST SO
SEASON CALIFORNIA'S OPPOSE MOST
AMENDED I WOULD YOU THINK THE
AUTHORS OFFICE FOR A WIN IS TO
WORK WITH OUR CONCERNS.
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT -- NOT
HAVING A CAP ON THE ON THE FEES
AND RUN AWAY -- OPPORTUNITY
COSTS THAT THE THE MONEY MIGHT
GO -- TO TOWARDS CLEAN AIR AND
IMMEDIATE REDUCTIONS IN
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
KNOCKS RATHER THAN ASPIRATIONAL
GOALS IN TWENTY THIRTY SO FOR
THOSE REASONS LOOK FOR WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE IN
TRYING TO RESOLVE OUR CONCERNS
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE CRISP OUR BEHALF OF
GLOBAL AUTOMAKERS WERE KIND OF
BETWEEN -- WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORS -- A DESIRE -- TO SEEK A
CONTINUOUS FUNDING SOURCE -- FOR
THE ADOPTION OF ELECTRIC
VEHICLES WE DO SHARE AUTO
ALLIANCES CONCERNS WITH REGARD
TO THAT DISCUSSION THAT --
MISTER MOFFETT HAS HAD WITH THE
THE AUTHOR WE LOOK FORWARD -- TO
HAVING CONTINUE -- DIALOGUE WITH
THE OFFICE LOOK -- FOR TO MA'AM
SAYS THE BILL MOVES FOR THANK
YOU.
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
MR ENTRY RESEARCHER MEMBERS
INJURY AND THREE ON BEHALF OF
THE WESTERN PROPANE GAS
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE AN OPPOSING
THIS MINUTE.
SESSION OF THIS BILL -- WE VERY
MUCH BELIEVE THAT LOW KNOCKS
ENGINES HAVE A ROLE TO PLAY HERE
AND WE VERY MUCH LIKE.
OF GREATER FOCUS ON LIFECYCLE
EMISSIONS OF OPPOSED TO TELL
HYPE.
THAT'S BEEN ONGOING POSITION
THAT THIS GROUP WAS HAD ON THIS
ISSUE AND I THINK WE KINDA.
WANT TO BE TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL
SHIFT THINGS IN THAT DIRECTION
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE FOR THOSE
REASONS.
WAS LAST MINUTE THANK YOU.
HUESO I'M SO SORRY DO WE
REPRESENTING IN THAT IN THAT.
WESTERN PROPANE GAS ASSOCIATION
OKAY.
CUT EVERY HAS SO MANY.
CLIENTS.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS REBEKAH ASKINS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BAND'S BIO
FUELS ALLIANCE IN OPPOSITION.
WHAT BEGAN YEAH NATURAL GAS --
COLLISION IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
MAJOR.
JOHN LINGER ON THE OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEELS INCONVENIENCE
ALLIANCE WITH A WIDER COMMAS
WITH CHAMBER.
YES NOW IS THE TIME FOR TWEETERS --
COOK ACOSTA ME HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NEW CAR DEALERS
ASSOCIATION.
I WE WANT TO THANK MR TING AND
HIS STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US WE
CONTINUE TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
WAYS TO PROMOTE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES WHERE THE RETAILERS.
TRYING TO GET PEOPLE IN THEM
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THE CONCERN THAT WE HAVE WITH
THIS BILL IS RELATED TO FEE
BATES AND IT'S VERY BROAD
AUTHORITY THAT IS GIVEN TO THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD TO
POTENTIALLY CREATE A PROGRAM.
A FEW BATES MEAN GET INTO IT IF
YOU'D LIKE OF WHY IT JUST
DOESN'T WORK NOW -- DOES NOT
WORK IN CALIFORNIA AND WHAT WE
THINK IT WILL NOT HAPPEN WE
BELIEVE WE'VE REACHED A
COMMITMENT TO TAKE LANGUAGE TO
RESOLVE OUR CONCERNS -- AND WITH
THAT THAT'S WHY WE'RE NOT HERE
IN OPPOSITION TODAY BUT A
TWEENER WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT
LANGUAGE IN PRINT AND WE TRY TO
SEE IF WE CAN WORK ON GETTING
THE SUPPORT POSITION FOR THE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ERIN RODRIGUEZ WITH
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
ALSO TWEENER IS ON THE BILL AND
WE APPRECIATE.
THE WORK ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING
AND HIS STAFF IS DONE TO SUPPORT
AND BOLSTER THE STATE WIDE
DEPLOYMENT OF STE -- ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES -- WE THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF IMPORTANT
DETAILS TO BE WORKED OUT
INCLUDING AND LANGUAGE ON EQUITY
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS THANKS.
GOOD MORNING CATHERINE GARCIA ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
ALSO A TWEETER AB TWO TEN FORTY
SIX HAS POTENTIAL TO IDENTIFY
AND RESOLVE.
SOME OF THE KEY STICKING POINTS
THAT PREVENT THE EEVEE
INCENTIVES ARE BEING AS
EFFECTIVE AS NEEDED I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THE BILL CONTINUE TO
DEVELOP THANK YOU.
CRIME.
ARE THE MATTERS NOW BACK BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE AND MISTER
CHAIRMAN THIS.
ALL BY CENTER SKINNER.
SO I'D LIKE TO FOCUS ON THE
SECURITIZATION OF REVENUES WE
GOT TO TREASURER AIRPORT AND
FINANCE.
FIND THESE INSTRUMENTS
SECURITIZED THEM AND CREATE.
A BUNCH OF MONEY A BUNCH OF
MONEY THEN THE AIRPORT'S GONNA
SET.
NO HIGHER THAN SEVEN THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED SORT OF A REBATE
SCHEDULE AND THERE'S GONNA BE
ANOTHER AXIS AND THIS IS GOING
TO SAY IN ORDER TO GET TO ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION.
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO HAVE OR
WE THINK WE'RE GONNA NEED THIS
REBATE.
AT THAT SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED LET
ALL THE CONSUMERS SO AS THE
STAFF REPORT PART PARTS THAT DO
A BETTER JOB A DAD.
INTO WILL SOME OTHER TRIGGER.
OCCURS THAT WE READ WE PASS
MILLION TO WHATEVER IT IS AND
THEN THAT REBATE WOULD BE
ADJUSTED.
UNTIL LATE SOME POINT IN TWENTY
THIRTY WERE IT. ONE ZERO THE
JUSTICE ZERO IS THAT IS THAT
THAT THAT THE ONLY IDEA
ABSOLUTELY.
GOOD AND THEY AN IDEA THAT YOU
NEED TO SECURITIZED AS WE SAY --
WE DON'T BELIEVE IT'S
APPROPRIATE ALSO JUST SAY HEY WE
WANT TO TAKE ALL THIS MONEY OUT
OF GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FROM
BECAUSE THAT ACTUALLY.
WOULD REDUCE ALL THE OTHER
PRIVATE SO WE THINK THIS IS A
MORE RESPONSIBLE WAY TO GO -- IN
THE IN AROUND SO THAT WE COULD
GET THE MONEY UP FRONT BUT THEN
PAY IT BACK OVER TIME SO.
ANOTHER WAY TO LOOKING AND IS
THERE IS A POP.
AN AMOUNT THAT ALLOCATED FROM
THE GREENHOUSE GAS FUND THIS
COULD BE AN AUGMENTATION.
TWO TO ONE ASSURE THE PUBLIC
THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO RUN OUT
OF REBATES AT SOMETIME IN APRIL
OR SEPTEMBER WHEREVER WHEREVER
HIS AND AND ALSO POSSIBLY.
RESTORE BECAUSE AS THE FEDERAL
LEVEL GOES DOWN THAT WOULD ALLOW
THAT BACK FILLING IS AT THE THE
THRILLS AND THAT'S WHAT THE
MAJOR CONCERNS IN MY WE WANTED
TO DO THIS.
YES WITH TESLA AND GENERAL
MOTORS THE TWO MOST POPULAR
SELLERS OF THEM IN CALIFORNIA.
THE BECAUSE OF THE THE VOLUME
THAT THEY SOLD WHICH IS A GOOD.
TO THE GOOD NEWS ON THAT THEY
HAVE NOW GONE THE CUT IN THE
FEDERAL TAX CREDIT SO NOW IF YOU
WANT TO GO BY TESLA OR CHEVY
BOLT.
YOU DON'T GET THE SAME AMOUNT OF
TAX CREDIT IF YOU WANT TO GO BUY
SOME OF THE CAR.
AND THERE WAS SOME CRITICISM
ABOUT THIS.
BEING DUPLICATIVE OF THE ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION THAT WAS HAND
MONDAYS BUDGET -- THAT IS TO CUT
ITS STYLE COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
THAT STUDY IS ABOUT A MUCH MORE
HOLISTIC STUDY ON HOW YOU COULD
TO CLEAN CARS BY.
TWENTY FORTY WHICH INCLUDES
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE A WHOLE
VARIETY OF FACTORS THIS IS VERY
VERY NARAL.
ONLY LOOKING AT THE CLEAN
VEHICLE REBATE PROGRAM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND I FORGOT TO LEAD OFF BY
SAYING WE'RE REALLY HAPPY WITH
THE COMMITMENTS AND HAPPY TO
TAKE.
OKAY -- I MEAN THE COURSE THE
BIG QUESTION IS WHERE IS THE
MONEY.
IT'S GONNA WATER BOWL.
THAT WATER UNDER THE WATER YEAH
THAT IS ALWAYS THE BIG QUESTION
IS WHERE THE MONEY'S COMING FROM
SO THAT THAT' WHY WE DIFFERENT
P. GINNY THAT'S A THAT'S A
POSSIBILITY OKAY NOT A BAD IDEA
SENATE SKINNER -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I WANT TO THANK YOU ONCE
AGAIN FOR FOCUSING ON MARKETS
AND ECONOMIC SIGNALS BECAUSE I'M
IN OUR CALIFORNIA SOME OF OUR
MOST SUCCESSFUL.
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE EITHER HELP
DESK CLEAN NEAR.
OR REDUCE WASTE OR ANY NUMBER OF
OTHER THINGS THIS BAND BECAUSE
WE GOT OUR MARKET SIGNALS RIGHT
[inaudible]
AND WE GOTTA GET OUR MARKET
SIGNALS RIGHT ON THIS ONE
BECAUSE TRANSPORTATION IS STILL
TAILPIPE EMISSIONS.
ARE THE NUMBER ONE SOURCE
[inaudible]
OF OUR EMISSIONS THAT CREATE
THAT ARE CONTRIBUTING TO CLIMATE
CHAOS.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY I THINK IN
I SEE MORE IMPORTANTLY NOT
BECAUSE THE CLIMATE CRISIS ISN'T
JUST VERY VERY REAL.
BUT PEOPLE CALIFORNIANS ARE MORE
DIRECTLY AFFECTED.
MAYBE NOT.
A DIFFERENT WAY BECAUSE FIRES
ARE PRETTY BAD BUT YOU'VE GOT
MANY MANY MORE PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA.
GETTING CHRONIC ASTHMA.
THAT IS FROM AIR POLLUTION WE
STILL HAVE OUT OF THE TEN MOST
POLLUTED CITIES IN THE US.
CALIFORNIA'S GOT SEVEN OR EIGHT
OF THEM.
AND IT'S PRIMARILY TAIL PIPE
POLLUTION SO UNTIL WE GET TO THE
TYPE OF GOALS THAT WE HAVE
ALREADY SET HERE THERE AND
EVERYWHERE AROUND ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES ARE CLEAN.
VEHICLES WE'RE NOT GOING TO
CLEAN OUR AIR AND WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DEAL WITH THE CLIMATE
CRISIS.
AND WHILE I WOULD LIKE TO SEE A
FAR GREATER AMOUNT OF OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
REDUCTION FINDER GIGI ERA FIND
TO BE.
DIRECTED TOWARDS THIS HUGE
SECTOR OF GHG EMISSIONS AND
CONTINUALLY APPROPRIATED.
I THINK YOUR APPROACH IS
APPROPRIATE BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT
TYING IT TO A PARTICULAR FUND
SOURCE SO THAT WE STILL HAVE THE
ABILITY.
TO ARGUE HERE IN THERE EVEN
THOUGH I WILL STILL MAKE THE
CASE FOR A HIGHER PERCENT OF G.
G. R. F. CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATED TO GET CLEAN
VEHICLES BUT ANYWAY.
BUT THIS BILL IS VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IN THE SAME WAY THAT WE
GOT THE PRICE OF ROOFTOP SOLAR
DOWN IN NOT JUST ROOFTOP SOLAR.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO MAY NOT
LIKE ROOFTOP SOLAR BUT THE
BRINGING OF THAT PRICE DOWN
BROUGHT DOWN THE PRICE OF ALL
SOLAR PEAVEY WHICH BROUGHT DOWN.
THE KILOWATT HOUR RENEWABLE
GENERATION PRICE WHICH IS MADE
UP WHY WE CAN HAVE -- BUT THE
AMOUNT OF RENEWABLE GENERATION
NOW IN THE STATE WITHOUT THE
HUGE PRICES.
SO WE HAVE TO DO THE SAME THING.
NOW.
YOUR BILL DOES THAT IT'S ON THE
RIGHT MODEL -- IT'S NOT BEFORE
US TODAY BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE -- MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES IN THIS ALSO BECAUSE
FROM AN AIR POLLUTION POINT OF
VIEW THERE EVEN A MORE
SIGNIFICANT.
SO IF WE'RE THAT WE SHOULD
INLUDE THAT BUT THAT'S OKAY
RIGHT NOW THIS IS AROUND THE
PASSENGER VEHICLES -- SOME POINT
WILL EXPAND IT.
I BUT I THINK IT'S REALLY THE
RIGHT DIRECTION BUT I ALSO.
DO HOPE THAT -- AND I KNOW YOU
ARE WORKING WITH THEM THAT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT BOTH ART
DEALERS CAR DEALERS AND OUR MAN
YOU ARE AUTO MANUFACTURERS.
THAT JUST LIKE THE PREVIOUS BILL
THAT WE HAVE THE RIGHT SWEET
SPOTS SO THIS REALLY DOES.
ACHIEVE WHAT WE HAVE IN MIND THE
MARKET SIGNAL THAT YOU'RE
DESIGNING HERE REALLY DOES HE
KEEP IT AND WE DON'T HAVE.
YOU KNOW AND I KNOW THE
SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO PRACTICE IT
BEFORE WE'RE GOING TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND IT BUT I APPRECIATE.
YOUR COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH THE
FOLKS WHO ARE EITHER IN
OPPOSITION OR TWO WINNERS -- AND
WITH THAT I WOULD MOVE THE BILL.
RIGHT THIS QUESTIONS BUT THE
MOVE -- TO FEW LIKE CLOSE TO
JUST THREE QUICK POINT ON ON THE
FEE BASED ISSUE ABSOLUTE THIS
THIS BILL WAS NOT INTENDED TO
USE FEE BAIT AS A FUNDING STREAM
SO I ACTUALLY HAVE COMMITTED. TO
DOWN -- TO SOME OF THE OPPONENTS
IN TERMS OF EQUITY WE DEFINITELY
WANT TO ADDRESS THE EQUITY PIECE
SO WE ARE WORKING ON AMENDMENTS.
TO ENSURE THAT THAT IS ACT
ADEQUATELY ADDRESSED MEETING
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES I THINK
WE'RE VERY OPEN. TO INCLUSION IN
THIS BILL IF THERE'S A WAY TO DO
IT WITHOUT WITHOUT UPSETTING THE
APPLE CART AND BITING OFF TOO
MUCH.
BY THE HAVE TO MUCH A WINDOW.
BUT IF WE CAN'T THEN WE'RE HAPPY
TO DO THAT -- WITHOUT RESPECT
FASTER ABOUT.
WHICH SO MUCH OKAY -- OBJECTIVE
IS COR.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN A. B. TEN
SIXTY FOUR THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
ALLEN.
ALLEN HI BATES NO BATES NO DALI.
DALI NO HILL.
SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN.
BY CASKEY MAKOWSKI I ARE YOU
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THE ERA OF TING IS
OVER -- WE WE WILL NOW MOVE.
THE U. S. SENATE RAG OCCUR HE'S
HERE TO PRESENT.
ITEM FOR IN YOUR AGENDA.
PACKETS MEMBERS IS AB.
ONE SIXTY EIGHT YOU MAY PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AB ONE SIX EIGHT AIMS TO
ENSURE THAT THE NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBAL CULTURAL RESOURCES AND
SACRED SITES WILL BE PROTECTED
UNDER NEW STREAMLINED HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT LAW.
WE ARE SEEKING TO PROVIDE A
TEMPLATE THAT CAN BE USED IN
FUTURE STREAMLINING LAWS AS WELL.
WE HAVE LOST MUCH OF OUR STATES
NATIVE HISTORY AND ONCE A
RELIGIOUS OR CULTURAL ARTIFACT
SITE OR BURIAL GROUND IS LOST IT
CANNOT BE REPLACED.
AS A SHOW OF GOOD FAITH I
ACCEPTED SENATE HOUSING
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS YESTERDAY
HOWEVER WE HAVE NOT HAD A CHANCE
TO THAT THESE AMENDMENTS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TRIBES.
WE HAVE A COMMITMENT FROM THE
SENATE HOUSING SURE THAT WE WILL
WORK WITH TRIBAL ATTORNEYS
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL AND
COMMITTEE STAFF UNTIL
CALIFORNIA'S TRIBAL COMMUNITIES
AGREED THAT WE HAVE A PRODUCT.
THAT TRULY PROTECTS TRIBAL
CULTURAL RESOURCES.
IF THAT EFFORT FAILS OVER THE
INTERIM WE WILL STAND DOWN AND
COME BACK NEXT YEAR WE'LL RETURN
UNTIL WE HAVE A TRULY PROTECTED.
CULTURAL AND RELIGIOUS PLACES
AND ARTIFACTS OF CALIFORNIA'S
SOVEREIGN TRIBE IN TRIBAL
NATIONS.
TRIBES MUST HAVE ASSURANCES THAT
ON THE ENFORCEABILITY OF THIS
LANGUAGE AND THEY NEED A
GUARANTEE THAT TRIBAL CULTURAL
RESOURCES WILL GET THE SAME
PROTECTIONS.
THAT THEY CURRENTLY RECEIVE
UNDER AB.
FIFTY TWO WITH CONSULTATION
TRIBAL CULTURE RESOURCES CAN BE
PROTECTED OR AVOIDED AND IMPACTS
CAN BE MITIGATED.
DEVELOPMENT CAN ACTUALLY MOVE
FASTER WITH CONSULTATION BECAUSE
LITIGATION IS LESS NECESSARY OF
THE MEANS OF PROTECTION OF FOUR
TRIBES.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
YOURSELVES PARTICIPATION IN
THESE CONVERSATIONS AND I HOPE
THEY'LL CONTINUE TO BE INVOLVED
IN CONVERSATIONS GOING FORWARD.
AS WE HAVE ENGAGE THE LARGER
COMMUNITY OF TRIBAL STAKEHOLDERS
I HAVE EVERY CONFIDENCE THAT
TOGETHER AND IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE TRIBES WE WILL ACCOMPLISH
THIS GOAL.
MEMBERS I S. REAR AYE AYE VOTE
AND TODAY I HAVE WITH ME
MICHELLE OPINION.
OF FRONT REVERSING VARIOUS
CALIFORNIA TRIBES.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE HI MY NAME'S MICHELLE
APPENA I'M A MEMBER OF THE RIVER
TRIBE FROM NORTHEASTERN
CALIFORNIA.
I'M AN ATTORNEY I REPRESENT MANY
TRIBES ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE BEEN PRACTICING
FEDERAL INDIAN LAW FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA TRIBES -- A BIG PART
OF MY PRACTICE.
IN CULTURAL RESOURCE PROTECTION
AND AND WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE'S OVER THE YEARS TO
A MAN STATE LAW TO ENSURE THAT
TRIBAL CULTURAL SITES ARE ARE
ARE WELL PROTECTED.
AND MANY OF OUR CULTURAL SITES
HAVE BEEN DESTROYED -- OVER THE
YEARS THROUGH -- CONSTRUCTION
AND DEVELOPMENT ACTIVITIES
BECAUSE THE LAWS WERE NOT IN
PLACE TO ALLOW FOR A
CONSULTATION WITH TRIBES TO
ENSURE THAT THE TRIBES COULD.
IDENTIFY THOSE SITES -- AS I'M
SURE SOME OF YOU KNOW.
MOST OF OUR CULTURAL SITES ARE
NOT WITHIN IN THE ARMENIAN
RESERVATIONS BECAUSE WE WERE
REMOVED FROM OUR HOMELANDS TO
AND PLACED IN SMALL AREAS THAT
DON'T NECESSARILY INCLUDE ALL OF
OUR CULTURAL SITES ARE BURIALS --
AND TRADITIONAL CULTURAL PLACES.
A SO STATE LAW IS REQUIRED IN
ORDER TO PROTECT THESE PLACES --
FROM DEVELOPMENT AND FROM
DESTRUCTION A LOT HAS BEEN LOST --
BEGINNING IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR
WE STARTED OF MENDING A STATE
LAW IN IN THE JOURNAL PLANNING
CODE SO THAT WE COULD --
PROVIDED EARLY CONSULTATION FOR
TRIBES TO BE AT THE TABLE WHEN
COUNTIES AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FOR DETERMINING WHERE THEY WERE
GOING TO PLAN FOR DEVELOPMENT.
AND THAT CREATED THE FIRST
DEFINITION OF CONSULTATION IN
THE STATE.
SINCE THEN WE'VE BEEN ADDING IN
IN AN IMPROVING TO THOSE TO THAT
LAW THAT BODY OF LAW THAT'S
THERE -- THERE'S A NATIVE
AMERICAN HERITAGE COMMISSION
HERE WITHIN THE STATE AND WE'VE
BEEN IMPROVING THE STATUTES THAT
GIVE IT AT THE READY TO ENSURE
THAT THESE SITES ARE PROTECTED --
RECENTLY.
IN THE IN THE LAST FEW YEARS AB
FIFTY TWO WAS PASSED.
AND AB FIFTY TWO DOES PROVIDE A
SEQUEL THE ON RAMP ESSENTIALLY
WERE TRIBAL CULTURAL SITES OF
THEIRS CONSULTATION IT IS
REQUIRED WHEN THEY TRIED KNOWS
THAT OTHER SITE THAT IT WOULD BE
IN THE DEVELOPMENTS PASSED.
AND WE ARE THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR CONSULTATION AND
TO ESTABLISH APPROPRIATE
MITIGATION MEASURE SO SB THIRTY
FIVE WAS PASSED A COUPLE YEARS
AGO AND ON THE HOUSING
STREAMLINING ACT.
UNFORTUNATELY DIDN'T ACKNOWLEDGE
THOSE PRIOR LAWS AND THE PROCESS
THAT HAD BEEN DEVELOPED OVER ALL
OF THOSE YEARS.
AND SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
THAT IT BRINGS IT INTO A HARMONY
WITH.
THE EXISTING CULTURE
PRESERVATION LAWS AND WE HOPE
THAT YOU CAN -- CONSIDERATE AND
HELP US IMPROVE THAT PROCESS.
OKAY -- FOLKS WANT TO VOICE
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
HELLO CHUCK APOLOGY ON BEHALF OF
THE CHIANG AND COLUSA TRIBES --
ALONG WITH MICHELLE BY THEN
WORKING ON SACRED SITES FOR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS WITH THE
TRIBES A LOT OF WORK HAS BEEN
DONE.
A LOT OF COMPROMISES WERE MADE
AND OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T WANT
ANYTHING TO TAKE AWAY FROM A
FROM AB -- FIFTY TWO I THINK
WE'LL BE ABLE TO WORK WITH CALL
GOING FORWARD TO GET THE RIGHT
LANGUAGE AND I URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
EFFORT WORKERS FOR THE DRY CREEK --
RICH REBOUND POMO INDIANS ALSO
TO RIVER TRIBE EXPRESS THE THE
SAME SENTIMENTS OF THE AUTHOR --
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS OF COURSE
SO -- WE ALSO HAVE.
SOME CONCERNS BUT WE DEFINITELY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT -- THIS
VEHICLE MOVES FORWARD THANKS
VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
FOR YES NOTHING GONZALEZ ON
BEHALF BEHALF OF BOYD GAMING AND
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY OF FOLKS WANNA RAISE
OPPOSITION CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL.
CNN OKAY DRIVES BACK.
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTION STATUS IN A CASKET. FOR
SOMEONE THANK THE AUTHOR ON THAT
I YES I VOTED YES THEY AND
HOUSING.
I FEEL ANXIOUS.
THIS TODAY ABOUT THE CONCEPT THE
MINIMUM CONSULTATION AND AYE AYE --
I BELIEVE I HEARD IN THE
AUTHOR'S PRESENTATION YOU SHARE
THAT CONCERN BECAUSE THERE'S AN
ENTHUSIASM FOR THIS MINISTERIAL
APPROVAL OF INFILL HOUSING.
AND A WE MADE A MISTAKE AND AND
SB THIRTY FOUR BY NOT INCLUDING
SPECIFICALLY CULTURAL.
INDIAN -- FAXED OVER AREAS AND
ALSO THERE'S DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
IN THE KNOWLEDGE MEANT THAT THE
SERVER DIFFICULT AREAS OR NOT
WELL KNOWN AREAS THAT ARE THAT
THE PUBLIC AND THE PUBLIC
BECAUSE WE KNOW A WETLAND WE
KNOW WHAT WE THINK WE KNOW
WETLAND WE KNOW WHAT -- IN BAR
MAINLY SENSITIVE AREA SO.
WHEN?
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
IS NOW PASSED THE CONSOLE WITH
THE THE CALIFORNIA -- TRIBE AND
THEN IT SAYS IT IN AN IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THESE ACTIONS TO
AVOID OR MINIMIZE THE IMPACTS
AND THAT MAY BE.
BUT THAT'S A DIFFERENT PROCESS
BECAUSE MINISTERIALIS BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS BRUCE IS THE SEQUEL
PROCESS WHICH WILL SAY LET'S
HAVE A HEARING ABOUT THIS AND
LET'S TALK ABOUT CLARIFYING WITH
WITH WHAT THAT IMPACT IS AND
WHAT IT MAY BE.
A TO ENTIRELY DIFFERENT PROCESS
AND I'M JUST CAUTION THE OUR
ENTHUSIASM TO TO JUMP IN EVERY
POSSIBLE INFILL SITE NEEDS TO BE
DEVELOPED AND I DIDN'T SUPPORT.
SB THIRTY FIVE IN THIS COMMITTEE
LAST YEAR JUST PUT THAT OUT
THERE SO I'M.
I VOTED FOR AND I'M GOING TO
VOTE FOR IT TODAY IN ON A MOVIE
BUT I'M EXTREMELY CAUTIOUS --
CONCERNED ABOUT THESE INTO CS
STICK.
CITY ADMINISTRATOR.
THANK ALL CONSULT WHAT YOU TRIBE
HAD THE MEETING WE'RE MOVING
FORWARD OR WILL GET THEIR THEIR
IDEA OF MINIMIZING IS DIFFERENT
THEN WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IN A
SEQUEL.
OPEN.
AND I WOULD BE INTERESTED IN THE
AUTHORS.
COMMENTS THEY MIGHT.
JUST A SCAREDY CAT IN READING
TOO MUCH INTO THEIR OR DO YOU
SHARE SOME OF THESE CONCERNS --
I DO SHOW SOME OF THE CONCERNS
ABOUT I'M GOING TO HAVE MY
WITNESS BECAUSE SHE WAS HERE
WHEN THEY DID AB FIFTY TWO IN
OTHERS AND THEY HAD COVER THAT
DURING THE HOUSE OR DO YOU
PREFER.
TO TO YET THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION I MEAN YOUR TOUCH ON ON
MOVE THE BILL I HAVE TO STEP OUT
FOR IN IT SO I JUST WANT TO MOVE
THE BILL.
ARE YOU TOUCHED UPON YOU KNOW
THAT'S REALLY THE THE NOT THEY
WERE TRYING TO CRACK HERE
BECAUSE THE THE SB THIRTY FIVE
PROCESS DID DELINEATE CERTAIN
EXEMPTIONS FROM STREAMLINING.
AND THE ORIGINAL VERSION OF THIS
BILL INCLUDED TRAVEL CUTS
CULTURAL RESOURCES AS DEFINED IN --
THE PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE IN THE
LIST OF EXCLUSIONS SO THAT IT
WOULD NOT BE UNDER THE
MINISTERIAL PROCESS -- THERE WAS
CONCERN ABOUT THAT BY THE SB
THIRTY FIVES AUTHOR -- AND SO
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO SORT
THROUGH -- THE HOW THE MECHANICS
OF THIS WILL WORK -- BECAUSE AB
FIFTY TWO IS IN A SECRET PROCESS
AND THAT IS NOT MINISTERIAL SO
IT IS A DISCRETIONARY PROCESS
THAT DOES TRIGGER YOU KNOW A LOT
OF REMEDIES AND SO.
WITH THE CULTURAL RESOURCE
COMPONENT YOU'RE RIGHT THAT IS
THE MECHANICAL PIECE THAT WE'RE
WORKING THROUGH AND OF COURSE WE
DO.
WE MEANING THE TRIBES THAT THEN
THE TRIBAL REPRESENTATIVES THAT
I'VE BEEN IN CONTACT WITH WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT WE WOULD
CALL AN AB FIFTY TWO LIGHT.
PROCESS THAT DOESN'T ADEQUATELY
CONSIDER THE RESOURCE AT HAND --
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THE AB
FIFTY TWO PROTECTIONS ARE BUILT
INTO THIS LEGISLATION.
AND HOW THE WORDING OF THAT
LOOKS THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO RESOLVE WHEN AN MISTER CHAIR
I THINK THE STAFF ANALYSIS IS
SPOT ON ABOUT TALKING ABOUT THE
LACK OF LANGUAGE.
IN THE IN THE SB THIRTY FIVE THE
MINISTERIAL -- CONTEXT WHICH IS
IT'S IT'S YOU GO INTO THIS
CONSULTATION WITH THE JUST A BIG
HOPE THAT -- THAT THE THE THE
CITY MANAGER THAT YOU'RE DEALING
WITH IS IS GOING TO BE SENSITIVE
TO THE THE THE CONCERNS THAT THE
TRIBES SPRING WHICH IS DIFFERENT
FROM THE C. FOR PROCESS WHICH IS.
FUNDAMENTALLY -- SPELLED OUT
RIGHT AND WE YOU KNOW WE'VE
SPENT MANY YEARS DEVELOPING V.
SICKLE GUIDELINES AS THE
HANDBOOK.
THE P. R. OVER THE YEARS AB SO
THERE'S A VERY WELL THE BOTTOM
OF DEVELOPED BODY OF RULES
REGULATIONS AND THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF TRAINING -- DONE TO FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT SO THAT THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT THESE
PROVISIONS AND SO HAVING A ED
MINISTERIAL PROCESS THAT DOES
NOT INCLUDE ALL OF THAT BUNDLE
OF PROCESS.
WOULD BE VERY CONFUSING AND I AM
ONE OF MY MY CONCERNS IS THAT
BECAUSE YOU'RE SEEING MORE AND
MORE STREAMLINING BILLS THAT.
THE LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL IS
GOING TO BE PROBABLY REPLICATED
ANOTHER STREAMLINING BILLS AND
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE GET
IT RIGHT BUT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE GET IT DONE IN THIS
SESSION BECAUSE WE WILL MISS
TIME IN SITES COULD BE.
IMPACTED IN THE INTERIM SO WE
WOULD MEAN A WE DO FEEL A LOT OF
PRESSURE TO GET THIS DONE RIGHT.
THIS SESSION.
BEFORE THE END OF THE SESSION
MISTER CHAIR I WOULD JUST ONCE
AGAIN I I MENTIONED ALREADY BUT
POINT OUT THAT MANY THE SACRED
SITES.
DON'T WANNA WELL PUBLICIZED THAT
THEY EXIST THERE'S THERE'S JUST
SAID A SENSITIVE I'M NOT SEEING
THEIR TUCKED INTO THE COMMUNITY
BUT THEY ARE TUCKED IN THE
COMMUNITY AND THIS WHOLE --
MINISTERIAL PROCESSES ANTITHESIS
THAT THAT THAT AT LEAST WHAT IT
WHAT IS LEFT OF THAT HAS BEEN
PRESERVED AND I I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT IT BUT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE CHAIR'S
RECOMMENDATION.
AND THE AND THE AND THE AUTHOR
TODAY.
THANK YOU IF I COULD JUST ADD
THIS ROUTE ONE WHAT REAL QUICK
POINT THAT --YOU KNOW THIS IS A
BILL THAT IS FOCUSED AND
TARGETED I THINK TOWARDS URBAN
SETTINGS -- BUT URBAN SETTINGS
DO INCLUDE TRIBAL CULTURAL SITES --
I DRIVE BY THEM AND I TAKE MY
DAUGHTER TO SCHOOL AT RIO
AMERICANO HIGH SCHOOL OF THEIR
LANDS THAT ARE SET ASIDE.
THEIR SHELL MOUNDS IN THE BAY
AREA THERE YOU HAVE BEEN BUILT
AROUND AND SO THEY'RE THEY'RE
THEY'VE BEEN PROTECTED THEY'VE
BEEN CAP THEY MAY BE A PARKING
LOT.
ABOUT THEIR THEIR IN THEIR
UNDERNEATH THAT AND SO THIS BILL --
SB THIRTY FIVE COULD POTENTIALLY
YOU KNOW RESULT IN THE
DESTRUCTION OF THOSE REMAINING
SITES THAT HAVE BEEN SORT OF
HELD AND PROTECTED ALL THIS TIME.
BUT IT ALSO IS A BILL OBVIOUSLY
THE PLACE ACROSS THE STATE SO IT
WILL APPLY IN RURAL AREAS AS
WELL AND ONE OF THE AREAS THAT
I'M CONCERNED WITH IS THAT THE
THE CAR AREA.
FOR THE CAMPFIRE -- YOU KNOW THE
CITY A PARADISE BURNED DOWN AND
ALL THESE OTHER AREAS -- YOU
KNOW WE'RE OBLITERATED AND
TRAVEL CULTURAL SITES HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED IN SO TRIBES HAVE BEEN
IN THERE IDENTIFYING THOSE SITES
AND WORKING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE IDENTIFIED BECAUSE THEY
WERE COVERED WITH DEVELOPMENT.
BUT NOW THAT WE KNOW THAT THEIR
THEIR YOU KNOW HOW THEY COULD BE
AFFECTED BY -- YOU KNOW
STREAMLINED PROJECTS TICKET
HOUSING UP AND IT'S NOT THAT WE
OPPOSE LOW INCOME HOUSING
BECAUSE OUR COMMUNITIES ALSO A
LIVE THERE IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
AND THEY NEED LOW INCOME HOUSING.
BUT WE JUST WANT TO BALANCE THE
INTERESTS HERE AND MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE SITES THAT WHERE THEY
SHOULDN'T BE BUILT -- THAT WE
AVOID THEM.
AND IF WE KNOW WHERE THEY ARE
AND WE HAVE A PROCESS THAT WE
CAN AVOID HIM AND PUT HIM SOME
PLACE BETTER YEAH.
YEAH MY GRAMMY BECAUSE THE VERY
THOUGHTFUL CORRECTIVE -- WITH
REGISTRY THIRTY FIVE TIMES
HAPPENED SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU --
OTHER THOUGHTS ARE QUESTIONS
LIKE IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
SKINNER -- MY WILL TO CLOSE US
OF THE S. THREE I WROTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE KEEP THE
SERVICE CORPS.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB ONE SIXTY
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASSED
THE SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE.
ALLEN HI ALLEN HI BATES.
BATES HI DOLLY.
DOLLY AYE HILL [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
BY CASKEY CASKEY I'VE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OKAY I WILL ANSWER FROM SOBRE
COOLEY WHO'S HERE TO PRESENT AB
THREE NINETY SIX THIS IS ITEM
FIVE IN YOUR PACKETS
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING -- MR MEMBERS I'M
HERE TODAY PERCENT AB.
TWO NINETY SIX AND I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE THERE ARE SOME
AMENDMENTS WHICH I AM TAKING.
AN OBJECT WE WANT TO SAY.
I THINK THIS IS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT NOTABLE BILL.
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
THOUGHT THAT YOUR CONSULTANT HAS
DONE ON HY TAKE A GOOD IDEA AND
KIND OF IMPROVE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF IT
[inaudible]
BECAUSE THERE'S NO THAT THAT'S
ACTUALLY WHERE YOU THE RIVER
BEACH ROAD YOU HAVE TO HAVE
IDEAS THAT WORK SO I'M VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THAT.
AND ONE OF KNOWLEDGE THAT WORK
BY YOUR STAFF -- AB TWO NINE SIX
ESTABLISHES THE CLAIM INNOVATION
GRANT PROGRAM WITHIN THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL. TO
ACCELERATE AND SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT NEW INNOVATIONS.
IMPROVE ADAPTABILITY AND
RESILIENCE TO THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE -- RECORDED
RECENT YOU AN INTERGOVERNMENTAL
PANEL ON CLIMATE CHANGE THE I.
P. P. C. STUDIES SURF REPORT.
AS WELL AS A NATIONAL CLAMOR
ASSISTANT ASSESSMENT.
IMPACTS OF GLOBALWARMING OF
COURSE ARE ALREADY BEING RESERVE
ACROSS THE NATION THE WORLD.
IN THE TIME TO ACT IS NOW.
IN OUR MOST RECENT SESSION OF
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE POLICIES
THE LA -- SPECIFICALLY
RECOMMENDED AT THIS STATE
SUPPORT INNOVATION.
AND ADDRESS OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
POLLUTION.
THAT.
THE BILL INTENDS TO ROCKET UP TO
BOOST THE BEST IDEAS THAT CAN
HELP ADDRESSED CARBON.
DOES ALREADY BEEN RELEASED.
AND ADDRESSED ENVIRONMENTAL
POLLUTION IN THE AIR WATER AND
SOIL.
THIS BILL WOULD UTILIZE A
COMPETITIVE PROCESS TO AWARD
MATCHING GRANT FUNDS. FOR
INNOVATIONS IMPROVE ADAPTABILITY
RESILIENT TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
THE PROGRAM WE FUNDED TO A
DIFFERENT ECONOMIC TOOL THAN
MOST THE STATE'S OTHER CLIMATE
POLICIES.
AND THAT BECOMES IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT BECOMES A FUNDING
SOURCE [inaudible]
OF THAT IS A NEW ONE IN THE MIX
AND DOESN'T PULL FOR EXISTING
DOLLARS FOR EXAMPLE.
THE ELECTRIC PROGRAM INVESTMENT
CHARGE OR EPIC FUND OR THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND.
AND I HAVE WITH PRIMEROS SELECT
THE RIBS IN THE LARK TO
INSTITUTE HERE IN SUPPORT SO
MERRY.
HELLO THERE.
MY NAME'S MERRY SO LUCKY I JOIN
YOU TODAY AS A REPRESENTATIVE OF
OUR TO INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT OF
AB T..
NINETY SIX LARA IS A LOS ANGELES
BASED NGO THAT TRANSFORMS IDEAS
AND RESEARCH INTO MARKET READY
PRODUCTS.
ARTIST SUPPORTIVE OF AB TWO
NINETY SIX BECAUSE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WE SEE THE ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC DOLLARS INVESTED IN
RESEARCH YIELDS POSITIVE
ECONOMIC OUTCOMES.
WE RECOGNIZE THE BILL AUTHORS
INTENTIONS TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE BY ALLOCATING RESOURCES
FOR CLIMATE RELATED RESEARCH.
WE ARE PARTICULARLY EXCITED TO
BE WORKING WITH AUTHORS OFFICES
ON THE OPPORTUNITY TO BRIDGE THE
GAP.
FROM RESEARCH TO MARKET READY
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES.
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE CLIMATE
INNOVATION GRANT PROGRAM WOULD
NOT ONLY ADVANCE CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE GOALS BUT WILL BRING
POSITIVE ECONOMIC GROWTH TO THE
STATE. TO FUNDAMENTAL ELEMENTS
THE PARALLEL LARGE HIS CORE
MISSION.
THIS GRANT PROGRAM UTILIZES THE
SUCCESSFUL MODEL THAT WE SEE
ELSEWHERE IN THE UNITED STATES
WHICH IS LEVERAGING MATCHING
FUNDS AND THUS COMBINING MANY
FUNDING SOURCES FOR APPLIED
RESEARCH.
WITH THE HELP OF FEDERAL AND
STATE FUNDING PROGRAMS AN
ACCELERATOR SUCH AS LARGER
COMPANIES LIKE MANGO MATERIALS
CAN TURN THE RESEARCH INTO
pMARKET READY PRODUCTS.
MAKER MATERIALS BASED IN
BERKELEY PRODUCES A BIO POLYMER
FROM RECYCLED METHANE AND
CREATES BIOPLASTICS.
**** MATERIALS WAS STARTED BY
THREE WOMEN ENGINEERS AND WAS
AWARDED RESEARCH FUNDING BUT
UTILIZED LARGE HAS SERVICES TO
HELP PROPEL THEIR PRODUCT INTO
THE MARKET.
WHERE TO WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE SIMILAR SERVICES FOR
ANY STATE FUNDED RESEARCH IN
CALIFORNIA?
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY AS WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON AB.
TWO NINETY SIX THANK YOU.
OUR FOLKS ONE OF THREE SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL FOR SUPPORT.
RYAN A JACK IN THE REGIONAL
WATER AUTHORITY -- REALLY
SUPPORT THAT GRANT PROGRAM AND
INCLUSION IN WATER AS AN
ELIGIBLE -- ENTITY OR CATEGORY
IN.
THANK YOU.
KILLER ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA TRIAL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
AMERICA'S SOME BEHALF AS MUCH IN
SUPPORT.
LARA COMMISSAIRE CLUB
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE IS OPPOSITION I
DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY RUSSIA
POSITION THE BILL BUT CONCERNS
OKAY THAT IS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS THOUGHTS.
A CENTER CASKEY I GUESS IS THE
IS THE ANTICIPATION THAT THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL WILL BE
SOLICITING DONATIONS FOR THE FUN
I MEAN I I GOT THE PEACE WITH
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD THE
PERSONAL.
INCOME AND THE MINIMUM AMOUNT OF
FUNDS BUT IS IS THAT HOW YOU
ENVISION THIS WORKING.
WELL IT'LL BE THERE WILL BE THAT
CHANNEL AND ERRORS -- EVENTUALLY
A TAX TACKLE -- Và FENNEL
LEVELING EIGHT THOUSAND BUT WE
NEED LIKE A CUP RIGHT MILLION
YEAH IT'S GOING.
I MEAN I JUST I DON'T KNOW IF
THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCILS
EVER ACCEPTED A DONATION.
I MEAN I DON'T EVEN KNOW OF ANY
STATE AGENCY IF SOMEBODY JUST
WALKED IN WITH A CHECK WILL THEY
KNOW WHAT TO DO NOW.
I JUST DON'T KNOW HOW THAT WOULD
WORK.
YES ON ONE OF THE AMENDMENTS IF
YOU LOOK AT PAGE.
TEN THE FIRST ONE IT WOULD ALLOW
THEM.
TO TERM WHETHER ANOTHER ENTITY
IS MORE APPROPRIATE FOR ME OUT.
THE CCSD THE STEM.
CELL THERAPY HAS ACTUALLY HIRED
STAFF AND RELIES ON FLAT TO BE
SO THERE IS PRECEDENT FOR THIS
APPROACH THANK GOD FOR THE
INITIATIVE PROCESS IT PASSES ALL
THESE INNOVATION.
YEAH.
WHEN STUCK OKAY ALL RIGHT?
OUR THAT'S THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION I APOLOGIZE WAS ON TOP
OF IT.
ACTUALLY COMES.
NO ACTUALLY THE SOME QUESTIONS
THOUGHTS.
DO YOU WANT.
TO MOVE THE BELL CENTRE CASKET
CAM AB YOU MAY CLOSE.
INNOVATION IS THE WORD I THINK
WE FACE.
TREMENDOUS CHALLENGES.
AND I ACTUALLY HAVE A POEM FOR
YOU FROM BEEN FRANK THAN YOU
KNOW THE OLD. ONE FOR WANT OF A
NAIL THE HORSE WAS LOST FOR WANT
OF THE HORSE TO RIDE WAS LOSS
FOR ONE OF THE WRITER.
THE BATTLE WAS LOST FOR ONE OF
THE BALLOT CAME TO WAS LOST ON
ALL FOR THE WONDERFUL HORSESHOE
NAIL.
I THINK WE ARE IN A TIME.
IN THAT IN WHICH WE CAN ACTUALLY
DISDAIN ANY GOOD IDEA.
THAT MAY LEAD TO SOLUTIONS TO
DEAL WITH SORT OF THIS
EXISTENTIAL THREAT OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
AND I THINK TO FIND A WAY HERE
INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA.
IN OUR DEMOCRACY. TO START A BE
LOOKING FOR A GROWING AGE FOR
GOOD IDEAS THAT WE CAN BRING TO
BEAR ON THIS PROBLEM.
IS TREMENDOUS.
AND SO THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS IT LETS US DEVELOP.
ADDITIONAL GROWING AGES FOR
RESEARCH THE COMPLETE KEY ROLE
AND TRY.
I'M DELIGHTED TO HAVE MR STERN
IS MICHAEL WATER HE'S BEEN A
GREAT CHAMPION WITH ME.
HI HE HE IS PRESENT AND IN
SPIRIT HERE RIGHT NOW.
QUESTION I BILL.
OKAY I CENTER PLEASE CALL.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWO NINETY
SIX THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE.
ALAN AYE ALLEN AYE BATES RIGHT
BATES HI DOLLY.
DOLLY AYE HILL [inaudible]
SKINNER.
STERN MIKE OWSKI CASKEY I OKAY.
THAT'S FOUR ZERO WILL LEAVE THAT
OPEN FOR OTHER FOLKS DOWN THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALRIGHT
WE'LL NEXT CALL OF US IN THE
QUIRK.
WHO'S YOUR PRESENT AB.
FOUR OH TWO THIS ITEM SIX IN
YOUR AGENDAS.
HAVING BEEN HERE SINCE EIGHT
THIRTY I NOW HAVE RENEWED
RESPECT. FOR THE LOBBYISTS WHO
HAVE TO BE HERE NEVER KNOWING
WHEN THEIR BILL WILL COME UP.
FOR HOURS ON END.
ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU CHAIR
ALAN AND SENATORS.
IT'S GREAT TO HEAR SEE MY FORMER
SAMPLING COLLEAGUE NOW MY SENATE
COLLEAGUE MISTER DALI HERE.
HE WAS -- COURSE VICE CHAIR OF
THE COMMITTEE WHEN I STARTED TO
CHERISH AND ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE
YOU.
SO AB FORO TWO WOULD SAVE MONEY
FOR WATER AGENCIES BY REDUCING
THE COST OF OVERSIGHT.
AND WOULD KEEP REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT LOCAL SO THAT'S THE
MAIN POINT I'M GONNA REPEAT IT.
AB FOUR OH TWO WOULD SAVE MONEY
FOR ALL WATER AGENCIES BY
REDUCING THE COST OF OVERSIGHT.
AND WOULD KEEP REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT LOCAL.
AB FORO TO AUTHORIZES THE STATE
WATER BOARD TO ESTABLISH A
FUNDING PROGRAM TO SUPPORT.
LOCAL LONGER OVERSIGHT OF SMALL
DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS LOCAL
HEALTH OF FISH OFFICERS.
REGULATE SMALL DRINKING WATER
SYSTEMS AND THIRTY CALLIN.
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA.
REGULATION OF DRINKING WATER IS
FUNDED ENTIRELY BY FEES CHARGED
TO PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS.
BECAUSE FEES VARY BASED ON
SYSTEM SMALLER SIZE SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS DO NOT GENERATE
SUFFICIENT FEE REVENUE. TO COVER
THE COST OF OVERSIGHT.
AS A RESULT SIX COUNTY SHOULD
RETURN DRINKING WATER OVERSIGHT
AUTHORITY BACK TO THE STATE
WATER BOARD.
THE FEES FOR THIS OVERSIGHT ARE
THEN ASSESSED ON WATER SYSTEM
STATE WHY.
SO THE OVERSIGHT.
THAT THE WATER BOARD DOES IS
ALREADY PAID FOR BY ALL THE
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS IN THE
STATE.
SMALL WATER SYSTEMS NEED THE
MOST OVERSIGHT BECAUSE THEY ARE
THE MOST LIKELY. TO VIOLATE
DRINKING WATER STANDARDS BECAUSE
THEY HAVE SO FEW RESOURCES. 90%
OF ALL NON COMPLIANT WATER
SYSTEMS ARE SMALL SYSTEMS.
AB FOR OH TWO MAINTAINS LOCAL
OVERSIGHT OF THESE SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS.
AND USES THE ALREADY EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND NETWORK OF
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS.
WITHOUT AB -- FOR TO SEVERAL
COUNTIES WILL RETURN OVERSIGHT
AUTHORITY BACK TO THE STATE
WATER BOARD WHICH RESULT IN LESS
LOCAL CONTROL AND HIGHER COSTS
FOR THE STATE.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE ARE -- JUST IN MILAN
WHO IS SPONSORED -- WHO IS THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE SPONSOR
OF THE BILL THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION?
OF ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS AND DANIELLE
HOLMAN FROM PLASTER COUNTY
[inaudible]
PROCEED [inaudible]
MADAM CHAIR.
JUST ALONG WITH THE LOCAL
ENVIRONMENT HEALTH DIRECTORS
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF DISCUSSIONS
WITH YOU'LL START FROM THIS BILL --
AS THE OLDEST SAID WE REPRESENT
THIRTY OF THE JURISDICTIONS THAT
PROVIDE THIS CRITICAL OF THE
SITE.
AND I JUST WANT TO STRESS THIS
IS AN OPT IN PROGRAM AND IT'S
NOT A NEW FEE AUTHORITY.
THE FUNDING IS ANOTHER ISSUE
WHERE THAT COMES FROM AS YOU'VE
HAD PLENTY DISCUSSION ABOUT SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
WHERE WE GET THE FUNDING OF THE
STATE BOARD GETS THE FUNDING IS
AN ISSUE FOR ANOTHER DAY.
WE WANT TO ESTABLISH THIS POLICY
IN THE POLICY IS THAT.
THE STATE AND ITS FUNDING
MECHANISMS WHATEVER THAT IS
SHOULD BE SUPPORTING THESE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO RETAIN THIS
AUTHORITY.
BECAUSE THIS AUTHORITY HELPS THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS STAY
CONNECTED PARTICULARLY IN THESE
DIFFICULT TIMES WHEN YOU HAVE SO
MANY OF THESE DRINKING WATER
SYSTEMS UNDER STRESS.
SO WE ARE LOSING WE'VE LOST FIVE
WE OFF PLACE TO LOSE ANOTHER
HALF A DOZEN OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THEY SIMPLY CANNOT
AFFORD TO KEEP THIS PROGRAM
GOING.
AND WE BELIEVE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH BEFORE THE STATE
WATER BOARD WE WORK FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
THERE WAS A SIMILAR BILL
INTRODUCED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
THREE AND NOW IT'S BECOMING A
PRESSING MATTERS SO.
WONDER THANK AN EXCELLENT
ANALYSIS IT'S A KIND OF A GEEKY
ISSUE IT'S A DIFFICULT ISUE.
THANK YOU FOR PUTTING IT OUT IN
THE TABLE WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE WATER AGENCIES TO FIGURE OUT
THE FUNDING SOURCE BUT WITH
URGELL COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT US
TO RETAIN WHERE THOSE
JURISDICTIONS WHICH THIS IS AN
OPT IN.
WHERE THEY WISH TO RETAIN THE
PROGRAM WE BELIEVE THIS IS GOOD
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH?
GOOD GOVERNMENT EFFICIENCY AND
IT'S GOING TO HELP BALANCE THE
INEQUITY WITH THOSE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
DANIEL CAN EXPLAIN BETTER WHY
THIS IS CRITICAL FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO KEEP THE
PROGRAM.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU
JUSTIN ONCE AGAIN MY NAME IS
DANIELLE PULLMAN AND I'M A
REGISTERED ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
SPECIALIST WITH PLASTER COUNTY.
AND FORCING THE STATE
REGULATIONS FOR SMALL PUBLIC
WATER SYSTEMS -- I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE
OF DIRECTORS OF ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH IN SUPPORT OF AB -- FOUR
OH TO A I THINK IT'S CRITICAL
THAT THIS PROGRAM REMAINS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL OVER THE LAST DECADE
DRINKING WATER REGULATIONS HAVE
BECOME INCREASINGLY STRINGENT
FOR EXAMPLE ADDITIONAL LEADING
COPPER TESTING AND ALL OF OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS FOLLOWING THE
DEVASTATING EVENTS IN FLINT
MICHIGAN.
SMALL PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS ARE
OFTEN OPERATED BY A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS.
IT COULD BE A SMALL COMMUNITY
THAT'S MUTUALLY OWNED WHERE IT'S
JUST A GROUP OF VOLUNTEERS WHO
ARE.
ARE MAINTAINING THE WATER SYSTEM
INFRASTRUCTURE AND MANY CASES
THESE INDIVIDUALS THEY DON'T
HAVE ENGINEERING BACKGROUNDS --
PRIOR EXPERIENCE IN DEALING WITH
UTILITIES THEY SIMPLY JUST DO
NOT HAVE THE TECHNICAL AND
MANAGERIAL CAPACITY OF LARGER
WATER SUPPLIERS AND THEREFORE.
THE REALLY RELY ON THE LOCAL
COUNTY REGULATORS FOR THAT FACE
TO FACE TIME IN GETTING OUR
BOOTS ON THE GROUND AND GOING TO
THESE WATER SYSTEMS AND
PROVIDING THEM.
ASSISTANCE IN ENSURING THAT
THEY'RE PROVIDING SAFE DRINKING
WATER.
IF THIS PROGRAM REVERTS BACK TO
THE STATE THE STATE REGULATORS
OFFICE COULD BE FOUR TO FIVE
HOURS AWAY AND THEY JUST WON'T
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THE SAME TYPE
OF ASSISTANCE THAT THE COUNTIES
CAN.
COUNTY ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS WE WE TRULY KNOW THE
INS AND OUTS OF OUR COUNTIES WE
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
BUILDING OF PLANNING DEPARTMENTS
AND UNDERSTAND THE DIRECTION OF
THE DEVELOPMENT IN OUR COUNTIES.
WE ALSO MAINTAIN GREAT
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE LARGE
PUBLIC WATER SUPPLIERS AND
THEREFORE WE ARE THAT PERFECT
MIDDLE MAN.
IN DODD COORDINATING ASSISTANCE
BETWEEN THE LARGE MUNICIPAL
WATER SUPPLIER AND THAT SMALL
WORLD WATER SYSTEMS WE CAN ALSO
COORDINATE AND WE DO COORDINATE
A CONSOLIDATION OF THESE SMALL
UTILITIES WHEN IT'S POSSIBLE.
ON ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
FACTORS IS THAT COUNTY
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
WE PROVIDE ASSISTANCE DURING
EMERGENCIES AND EVENTS LIKE WILD
FIRES AND FLOODS WHERE.
OUR ON A SMALL WORLD WATER
SYSTEMS CAN BECOME COMPROMISED
I'M JUST QUESTIONING WHAT WILL
HAPPEN WHEN THE NEXT DEVASTATING
WILDFIRE STRIKES CALIFORNIA.
AND THE INSPECTOR FOR THE RURAL
COMMUNITY IS FOUR TO FIVE HOURS
AWAY AND THEIR FOCUS IS GOING TO
BE ON CITY OF SACRAMENTO AND LOS
ANGELES AND THESE LARGE WATER
SUPPLIERS.
THEREFORE I AM IN SUPPORT AND I
FEEL THAT THIS PROGRAM.
CAN AND SHOULD REMAIN AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL WITH COUNTY
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
THANK YOU.
RIGHT NOW FOLKS ONE ADAM SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS MY NAME IS
MERION WARMER I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE RURAL COUNTIES WITH THE
CHAIRS INDULGENCE I'D LIKE TO
MAKE TWO QUICK POINTS. ONE OF
MOST OF OUR COUNTIES ARE NOT WE
ARE RELUCTANT TO INVITE THE
STATE IN. TO HELP THEM MANAGE
THEIR SYSTEMS BUT THIS IS A
FRAMEWORK THAT'S EXISTING AND
ALLOWS FOR OPTING IN AS JUSTIN
MENTIONED AND WE THINK IT'S AN
IT'S AN OPTION THAT THE COUNTIES.
SHOULD BE ABLE TO AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF SECONDLY MOST OF
THESE COMMUNITIES ARE IN OUR
COUNTIES AND ARE DISADVANTAGED
AND THIS AGAIN WILL GIVE US AN
OPTION THAT WILL HELP US PROVIDE
SAFE CLEAN DRINKING WATER FOR
OUR CONSTITUENTS THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
CARE MARTIN ST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
CAN'T DO BURKE WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ANDREW EVAN TURNER WITH CLEAN
WATER ACTION IN SUPPORT.
MEGAN FLOYD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE OF
DIRECTORS ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
AND ALSO THE LOCAL REGULATOR IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOR A TWO THANK
YOU.
OKAY FOLKS WINERIES OPPOSITION
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL.
PLEASE STAY HERE.
CAN YOU SPELL [inaudible]
YEAH.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CHRIS ANDERSON ON BEHALF
OF ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES I WANT TO BEGIN
BY THANKING YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IN
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR TAKING THE
TIME AND ATTENTION. FOR THE TIME
AND ATTENTION THAT THEY'VE GIVEN
TO THIS BILL ADDITIONALLY I LIKE
TO THINK THE AUTHOR HIS STAFF
AND THE SPONSOR FOR CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH US TO TRY TO FIND A
SOLUTION THAT WOULD SATISFY
EVERYBODY INVOLVED.
LP'S DO IMPORTANT WORK.
AN AQUA KNOWS AT SOME COUNTIES
CURRENTLY DO NOT HAVE THE FEE
BASED TO COVER THE REGULATORY
COSTS THAT'S WHY WE SUPPORT THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL AND DON'T
OPPOSE THE CREATION A NEW
REGULATORY PROGRAM.
RATHER AQUA IN THE MORE THAN
SIXTY ORGANIZATIONS OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED TO THIS BILL ARE
POSED TO THE POSSIBLE FUNDING
SOURCE FOR THIS PROGRAM.
THIS BILL DOES NOT SEEK FUNDING
FROM THE BUDGET IN FACT THE BILL
IS SILENT ON A FUNDING SOURCE
HOWEVER SINCE THE PROGRAM TO BE
PLACED IN A SAFE DRINKING WATER
ACT.
THE STATE WATER BOARD CAN FIND
THIS PROGRAM USING FUNDS FROM
THE SAFE DRINKING WATER ACCOUNT
WHICH IS LARGELY COMPRISED OF
DRINKING WATER FEES.
PAID BY ALL PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS.
AQUA OBJECTS TO THIS FUNDING
SOURCE FOR A COUPLE OF REASONS.
FIRST MANY OF THE FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY PUBLICWATER SYSTEMS THAT
ARE REPRESENTS ALREADY PAY
DISPROPORTIONATELY MORE IN
DRINKING WATER FEES THAN SMALLER
WATER SYSTEMS.
SO IF THE STATE WATER BOARD
INCREASING INCREASES RATES
WITHOUT BRIEF PROVIDING
RECIPROCAL BENEFIT IT BECOMES
HARDER FOR OUR MEMBERS TO MEET
THEIR MISSION OF PROVIDING SAFE
AND RELIABLE DRINKING WATER.
SECOND THIS PROGRAM WOULD COST
THE STATE WATER BOARD ROUGHLY
FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY IF EVERY COUNTY IN THE
STATE DECIDED TO PARTICIPATE.
LAST FISCAL YEAR THE WATER BOARD
COLLECTED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AND DRINKING WATER FEES.
THIS MEANS THE WATER BOARD COULD
BE REQUIRED TO COLLECTS 5260%
AND ADDITIONAL REVENUE TO
ADEQUATELY FUND THIS PROGRAM.
AKA QUESTIONS HOW THE WATER
BOARD COULD ACTUALLY FROM THIS
PROGRAM AND REMAIN IN COMPLIANCE
WITH PROPOSITION TWENTY SIX AN
ARTICLE THIRTEEN A THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION.
THESE CONSTITUTIONAL MANDATES
THE MAN THAT REGULATORY FEES
IMPOSED ON A LOCAL AGENCY DO NOT
EXCEED THE RESULT IN
PROPORTIONAL COST OF THE SERVICE
PROVIDED BY THE STATE.
OUR MEMBERS ARE NOT REGULATED BY
L. P. A.'S THAT MEANS THE WATER
BOARD COULD SUBSTANTIALLY
INCREASE RATES ON PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEMS WITHOUT RE PROVIDING ANY
ADDITIONAL SERVICE.
ESSENTIALLY REQUIRING ONE PUBLIC
ENTITY TO SUBSIDIZE ANOTHER.
WE'VE REQUESTED THAT THE AUTHOR
MAKE THIS A TO YOUR BILL AND GO
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS TO
IDENTIFY A FUNDING SOURCE
UNFORTUNATELY PROPONENTS HAVE
REJECTED THIS REQUEST THEREFORE
UNTIL THE PROPONENTS IDENTIFYING
ALTERNATIVE FUNDING SOURCE WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A NO VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
GOOD MORNING PRECIADO YOU GIVE
ME A LITTLE BIT OF TIME I'M RYAN
THAT JACKIE WITH THE REGIONAL
WATER AUTHORITY.
RW A IS A JOINT POWERS
ASSOCIATION COMPRISED OF TWENTY
pTHAT PROVIDE DRINKING WATER TO
TWO MILLION PEOPLE IN THE
GREATER SACRAMENTO AREA.
I PREFERRED TO BE HERE TO TALK
TO YOU ABOUT THE GOOD WORK THAT
WE DO WHICH IS OUR MISSION IS TO
RELIABLY PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY
AFFORDABLE WATER -- TO ACHIEVE
THAT MISSION OUR PER TOP
PRIORITIES ARE TO ADAPT TO
CLIMATE CHANGE.
BOB.
ADDRESS WATER EFFICIENCY AND TO
MEET THE HUMAN RIGHTS WATER IN
OUR SERVICE AREA.
OFTEN TIMES THIS MEANS THAT
WE'RE WORKING HAND IN HAND WITH
THE HELP HE IS. ONE OF OUR
MEMBER AGENCIES PLASTER COUNTY
WATER AGENCY JUST HEARD FROM
DANIELLE ODD PLASTER COUNTY
WATER AGENCY AND DANIELLE HAVE A
GREAT WORKING RELATIONSHIP.
DANIELLE MENTIONED THAT --
THEY'VE COLLABORATED ON SEVERAL
CONSOLIDATION OPPORTUNITIES --
AND I DON'T MEAN TO STEAL
DANIELLE'S FUNDER BUT THEY ALSO
HAVE AN AWARD WINNING PROGRAM
THAT PROVIDES INFORMATION TO ALL
THE SMALL DRINKING WATER
SUPPLIERS AROUND THE STATE. TO
HELP ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT SHE MENTIONED
THAT'S AN ANNUAL PROGRAM HOSTED
IN THE SUMMER AND SQUAW VALLEY
SO FOR ALL OF YOUR DISTRICTS ALL
OF YOUR SMALL WATER SUPPLIERS
YOU SHOULD YOU SHOULD LOOK THEM
UP BECAUSE IT'S A VERY VALUABLE
SERVICE.
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
COLLABORATIVE RELATIONSHIP OUR
CHALLENGE WITH THE BILL IS THE
SHIFT IN IN FUNDING -- THAT THE
FUNDING COMES OUT OF ESSENTIALLY
EYES WHICH IMPEDES OUR ABILITY
TO DO ARE GOOD WORK.
WHAT WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS A
SOLUTION THAT ALLOWS FOR L. P.
A.'S TO DO THEIR GOOD WORK AND
FOR US TO DO OUR COULD WORK WE
THINK THAT THAT SOLUTION IS?
IS AVAILABLE OUT THERE IF WE
LOOK AT OTHER SOURCES OF OF
FUNDING AS CHRIS MENTIONED THE
BIG CHALLENGE IS.
THIS IS GONNA COME OUT OF
DRINKING WATER FEE IS.
THE IT'S AS JUSTIN MENTIONED
IT'S A BIT WONKY.
AND THAT IS A BIT WONKY BUT IT
CREATES AN EXTREME COST PRESSURE
OUT OF THE EXISTING -- REVENUES
THEY'RE AVAILABLE AND DRINKING
WATER FEES AND SO WITH THAT.
I FAILED TO MENTION THAT IS WITH --
REGRET THAT I'M HERE IN
OPPOSITION BECAUSE WE WE DO
SINCERELY APPRECIATE THE WORK
THIS ONLY AMERICORPS DOES AND
AGAIN THE WORK THAT LP IS
[inaudible]
TO THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH.
ABOUT THE FUNDING.
BUT NO BUDGET HAD WITH
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION AS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
ALTHOUGH IT'S NOT SPECIFIED IN
THE BILL.
THIS WOULD RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
FEE INCREASES ON OUR SYSTEMS.
HOWEVER WE BELIEVE THAT THE
AMENDMENT TO THE SPONSOR AND
AUTHOR HAVE COMMITTED TO REALLY
MAKE PROGRESS AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS TRYING TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS.
WE WILL BE TAKING THIS BILL BACK
TO OUR LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE
NEXT WEEK FOR FURTHER
CONSIDERATION AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING ON WAYS THAT WE CAN
FIND RESURCES.
APART FROM THE INCREASED FEES TO
SUPPORT THE IMPORTANT WORK OF
LOCAL PRIVACY AGENCIES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BOB
READ WITH READ GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS ON BEHALF OF DESERT
WATER AGENCY IN ELDORADO
IRRIGATION DISTRICT OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED.
FIRST DIVERSE FOR THE LOS
VIRGINIS MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT THE MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT OF ORANGE COUNTY
ELSINORE VALLEY MISSILE WATER
DISTRICT. FOR THE REASONS STATED
WE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED AND IN
ADDITION TO THAT IT'S THE
CONCEPT THAT IF YOU LEGITIMIZE
THIS USE OF THE SAFE DRINKING
WATER THANK YOU CAN USE THAT
ELSEWHERE TO AND THAT'S REALLY
WHAT.
IT SAYS ARE NERVOUS THANK YOU.
SURE MEMBERS IN THREE MILLION ON
BEHALF OF MESA WATER DISTRICT
AND US INCLUDED VALLEY WATER
AGENCY WE ECHO THE SAME COMMENTS
AS OUR COLLEAGUE FROM AQUA THANK
YOU.
CHRIS CON REPRESENT THE
COACHELLA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU.
OKAY -- OTHER FOLKS WORRIES
CONCERNS RAIMESBEFORE THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS THAN A DOLLY.
WELL.
I HAVE WINNERS AND LOSERS ON
BOTH SIDES OF THIS ISSUE AND SO.
PERSONALIZED APPRECIATE AUTHOR
TRYING TO AT LEAST HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT I LAID OFF
THIS BILL AND OTHER HOUSE.
AND YOU KNOW I I REPRESENT
MILLIE HUNDREDS OF LITTLE.
SMALL WATER DISTRICTS THAT ARE
STRUGGLING TO MEET ALL THE
STANDARDS THAT ARE PLACED ON
THEM.
AND HAVE NO ABILITY BILL EVEN
RAISE RATES BECAUSE THEY'RE
UNDER PROP TWO EIGHTEEN AND
PEOPLE ARE GONNA RAISE RATES ARE
HAVING A HARD TIME STAYING IN
THEIR HOME.
THEY'RE IN SOME OF THESE
COMMUNITIES.
THE RATE WOULD BE HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS PER HALL PER HOUSEHOLD
BECAUSE THERE'S JUST NOT ENOUGH
VOLUME IN THESE SMALL TOWNS IN.
THE TOWN THAT.
WHEN MY KIDS GO TO SCHOOL IS
FACED WITH THIS EXACT PROBLEM?
IT'S BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN
REGULATED IN WHERE WE WE HAVE
HIGHER STANDARDS.
THAT WERE PUT ON THEM IN THE
WHEN THEY FIRST DEVELOP THEIR
WATER SYSTEMS [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
IS.
AT IT AT THE SAME POINT.
THEY HAVE TO PERFORM.
THE REGULATIONS AND THEY END UP.
GOING BANKRUPT IT OR NOT THEY
CAN'T GET WHERE THEY WILL WE
WHEN THEY'RE FORCED TO GO
[inaudible]
SO -- I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO SAY I
MEAN AT THE END OF THE DAY IT'S
THIS BILL IS BASICALLY SAYING
YOU CAN OFTEN BUT I ON THE OTHER
HAND I HAVE ALL OF MY LARGE
PURVEYORS THAT ARE.
WORRIED THAT THEY'RE GONNA BE
THAT THIS FIGHT IS GOING TO GET
USED. TO OFFSET THE COST AND YOU
KNOW AS I'VE OFTEN SAID IN
CALIFORNIA IS A VERY DIVERSE
STATE AND ONE SIZE FITS ALL
REGULATIONS.
DON'T ALWAYS WORK IN CALIFORNIA
[inaudible] FOR EXAMPLE.
THESE COMMUNITIES CAN'T.
COMPLY THERE'S JUST NO WAY THEY
CAN COMPLY AND THAT'S WHY YOU'RE
SEEING THEM.
OPT OUT.
SO AS A STATEMENT MORE THAN IT
IS OF IT I WOULD [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
WE JUST BAILED OUT IN MY OPINION.
YOU KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
WITH.
CAP AND TRADE MONIES. TO DO
WATER WHICH IS.
AND IT'S LIKE THE TRAIN IT
DOESN'T REALLY REDUCE CARBON IS
THE WRONG AND I'M I'M A THROW IT
OUT THERE BECAUSE IT JUST TICKS
ME OFF THAT WE ARE.
TAXIS ALMOND DIVERTING IT TO
TAKE CARE OF THINGS THAT JUST
AREN'T RIGHT.
SO WE DO THAT KIND OF STUFF ALL
THEIR IS WRONG.
SO BUT TO FORCE REGULATIONS ON A
COMMUNITY THAT CAN'T AFFORD IT
AND THESE IT WE TALK ABOUT
HELPING POOR PEOPLE ALL DAY LONG
HERE.
AND WE REALLY DON'T WE HURT THEM
BY FORCING THEM AND SO WE NEED
TO LET THEM KNOW WHAT'S IN THE
WATER AND THEY HAVE TO TAKE THE
RISK OF WHETHER THEY'RE GOING TO
BE ABLE.
TO YOU KNOW THE AT PARTS PER
BILLION.
GREAT THAT WATER NOT SO.
I'M A LOSS FOR HOW WE ACTUALLY
GO FOR BECAUSE I HAVE LITERALLY
HUNDREDS OF COMMUNITIES THAT I
REPRESENT A EVEN MORE NOW THAT
I'M IN THE SENATE.
THAT ARE FACED WITH THESE
REGULATIONS AND CAN'T MAKE IT
WORK [inaudible]
SO -- I'M.
I DON'T KNOW IF THIS BILLS AND
GET OUT HERE NOT I DON'T KNOW
BUT I'M INCLINED TO WANT.
pAND NOT ON THE BACKS OF SOMEBODY
ELSE WE NEED TO HAVE EXEMPTIONS
FOR THESE PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
EXEMPT OUT OF SOME OF THESE
CRAZY.
REGULATIONS THAT THEY'RE IN.
OKAY WELL OF COURSE THE BILL
THIS BILL DOESN'T GO DID CRAZY
REGULATIONS AND BUT WHAT IT DOES
DO IS IT SAYS IF YOU WELL FIRST
OF ALL.
YOU CAN OPT OUT AND GO TO STATE
WATER BOARD RIGHT NOW.
AND MY EXPERT HERE WILL TALK
ABOUT WEIGHT SO IF YOU'RE COUNTY.
AND YOU DON'T WANT TO DO LOCAL
OVERSIGHT COULD YOU CAN AFFORD
IT BECAUSE OF FEES DON'T PAY FOR
IT GOES TO THE STATE WATER BOARD.
AND OUR LAST MY EXPERT HERE
WHERE DID THOSE FEES COMES FROM
WHEN PEOPLE OPT OUT.
THANK YOU AUTHORED -- THROUGH
THE CHAIR.
THIS IS THE ISSUE THIS IS THE
ISSUE WE FACING IN THE AND THE
ISSUE WE FACE IS.
LET ME ADDRESS PARTY PROP TWENTY
SIX BECAUSE HIS AN ALLEYWAY
SECOND OKAY WHERE ALL RIGHT WHO
IS WHO HAS TO PAY THE FEES RIGHT
NOW PLEASE ANSWER BACK RIGHT AND
NOW THE LOCAL PRIMACY AGENCY.
GETS FEES FROM THOSE
JURISDICTION THOSE WATER SYSTEMS
THAT THEY REGULATE.
IF THEY GIVE THE FEEDBACK TO THE
STATE.
THE STATE WILL GET IT FROM THE
BROUGHT A POT.
SO THAT IS WHERE YOU'LL SEE THE
EFFICIENCY OF THIS BILL.
RIGHT NOW THE STATE USES.
I'M THAT MUCH BROADER FUND THAT
HAS MULTIPLE FUNDING SOURCES THE
LOCALS ERNIE HAVE.
THAT ONE SOURCE WHICH IS THEIR
SMALL DRINKING WATER SYSTEM AND
SINCE WE WHEN WE SUPPORTED THE
POLICY FOR THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
JOURNEY PAY A HUNDRED DOLLARS
SINCE THAT WAS ADOPTED BY THE
WATER BOARD WE PUT AN EVEN
BIGGER SQUEEZE WE SUPPORT THAT
THE DISADVANTAGED.
SHOULD GET SUPPORT BUT NOW WE
HAVE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THAT
CAN ONLY CHARGE A HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR A FOR A SERVICE THAT
COSTS YOU KNOW FIVE HUNDRED SIX
HUNDRED SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS IN
THAT COMMUNITY.
SO WE DO SEE THIS AS A WAY OF
BASICALLY USING THE SAME FUNDING
MECHANISM THE STATE.
IT'S CURRENTLY USING AND WOULD
BE USING ON THE SELF SAME
SYSTEMS IF WE HAD TO GIVE THEM
BACK.
SO THERE'S NO CHANGE IN THE
FIELD.
THIRTY THIS ISN'T A NEW TAX THIS
ISN'T A NEW PROGRAM IT'S SIMPLY
ALLOWING THE LOCALS TO KEEP THE
PROGRAM RATHER THAN THE STATE
TAKING THE PROGRAM BACK.
AND I CAN TELL YOU WE HAVE DONE
SOME PRELIMINARY NUMBERS AND I
HAVEN'T COMPLETELY DRUNK LOCAL
KOOL-AID NOT SAYING EVERY LOCAL
JURISDICTION IS BETTER OR MORE
EFFICIENT.
BUT WE CAN SEE WE CAN SHOW A
FIFTEEN OR 20% REDUCTION IN COST
OVERRULED IF THE LOCALS KEEP THE
PROGRAM FOR ALL THOSE REASONS AT
YOUR LOCAL LBJ'S EXPLAINED.
SO LET ME SAY THAT IF THE LOCALS.
FEEL THAT THEY CAN'T DO THIS
PROGRAM.
THEY WILL THEY CAN ALL OPT OUT
ALL GO TO THE STATE AND THE FEES
YOU WILL PAY.
WITH THE SAME WE'RE TALKING ON
TALKING ABOUT RIGHT NOW THERE
WILL BE NO CHANGE IN FEES IF
EVERY AGENCY GAVE UP.
COMPARED TO THIS PROGRAM HERE.
THE ONLY CHANGE THIS MAKES IS TO
SAY THAT THE LOCALS CONTINUE TO
DO THE WORK THE FEES WILL NOT
CHANGE [inaudible]
ASSUMING.
THAT PEOPLE WOULD HAVE OPTED OUT
ANYWAY BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD
IT.
SO IF THE COURT THE PRESS CAN
HEAR IS.
DO THEY OPT OUT WE NO LONGER
HAVE LOCAL CONTROL AND OF COURSE
THEN THE FEES ARE PAID BY THESE
OTHER WATER PRODUCERS OR DO WE
ALLOW WORD.
LOCALS TO DO THE INSPECTION AND
THE FEES ARE PAID POINT IS FEES
WON'T CHANGE WHETHER THEY OPT
OUT OR THEY GO INTO THIS PROGRAM
[inaudible]
END.
SINCE THE FEES WON'T CHANGE.
YOU KNOW I DON'T REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHY THEY'RE OBJECTING.
I REALLY DOUBT.
ALL THIS DOES IS ENSURE LOCAL
CONTROL THANK YOU.
YES YES OKAY.
SO THERE ARE ABSOLUTELY NO
GUARDRAILS ON THIS PROGRAM SO
WHAT ONE OF OUR CONCERNS IS IS
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO CREATE A%
SITUATION WHERE EVEN COUNTIES
THAT ARE OTHERWISE SELF
SUSTAINABLE WILL OPT INTO THIS
PROGRAM BECAUSE WHITE WHY WOULD
THEY NOT YOU EITHER THEY HAVE.
TO RE ASSESS THE RATES AND
COLLECT THE REVENUE WILL.
OR THEY CAN HAVE THE STATE WATER
BOARD DO THAT WITH A GIANT
SUBSIDY FROM OUR MEMBERS. ONE OF
OUR WORK CONCERNED THAT THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY NO NEXUS BETWEEN THE
FUNDING SOURCE AND WHO BENEFITS
FROM THIS PROGRAM ONE OF THE
REASONS AS JUSTIN EXPLAINED THAT
THIS PAIN DELEGATES THIS PROGRAM.
IS BECAUSE IT SAVES THE STATE
MONEY BUT THE STATE HAS NO SKIN
IN THE GAME UNDERNEATH THIS
PROGRAM AGAIN THEY'VE GONE TO
DRINKING WATER FEES.
WITHOUT.
EXAMINING ANY ALTERNATIVE
FUNDING SOURCES AS ONE OF THE
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION SAID NOT
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT AND WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT HOW THIS BILL WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED WE KNOW THAT NOT
EVERY.
COUNTY IS GOING TO BE RETURNING
THERE AT THE READY TO THE STATE
WITH WITHOUT THIS PROGRAM BUT
EVERY COUNTY WOULD HAVE A
TREMENDOUS INCENTIVE TO OPT INTO
THIS PROGRAM AND THE LATEST
AMENDMENTS.
ALLOW THE STATE WATER BOARD TO
REACH OUT TO ALL TWENTY EIGHT
COUNTIES THAT ARE NOT IN -- PA
OFFER THEM THE ABILITY TO BECOME
ONE AND PARTICIPATE IN THIS
PROGRAM THAT IT IS EXTREMELY
CONCERNING TO US -- MISTER CHAIR.
BOB I'LL JUST POINT OUT THAT.
IF IF THEY ARE SELF SUSTAINING.
ALL THAT MONEY UNDER THIS BILL
WOULD GO IN AND THE STATE.
IT WOULD MAKE NO DIFFERENCE TO
THEM THEY WOULDN'T HAVE TO IF
THERE ARE SELF SUSTAINING NOW.
THAN THE STATE WATER BOARD ISN'T
GOING TO HAVE TO ADD NEW FEES.
SO THE ONLY WAY THIS IS AFFECTED
HIS IF YOU HAVE A COUNTY WITH
MANY SMALL SYSTEMS.
AND THEY CAN'T MAKE IT ON THEIR
OWN.
THEN THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO GO
TO THE STATE.
AND THE AND THE CHOICE IS EITHER
IT'S DONE BY THE LOCALS.
AND PAID FOR BY THROUGH THE THIS
SYSTEM OR IT'S PAID THROUGH THE
SYSTEM AND THE STATE DOES IT.
SO THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS IS IT
LOCAL CONTROL OR STATE CONTROL
THERE'S NO DIFFERENCE IN THE WAY
THE MONEY IS ALLOCATED PERIOD.
BUT I'M A NUMBERS GUY -- I KNOW
DAVID WOLF -- WANTED.
TO QUICKLY -- VOICES OPPOSITION
YEAH MISTER CHAIRMAN THANKS FOR
SQUEEZING ME AND DAVID WILL FOR
THE HARRY JACK HARRY JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BECAUSE WE
DO HAVE PROPOSITION TWENTY SIX
CONCERNS.
MEMBERS NOT BECAUSE OF THE TAX
PROP TWENTY SIX MAKES VERY CLEAR
THAT THE REGULATORY FEE
EXEMPTIONS NEEDS TO GO TO THE
COST OF PROVIDING THE SERVICE
AND I FIND IT VERY DIFFICULT TO
BELIEVE.
THAT THE COST OF PROVIDING THE
SERVICE.
QUALITY IS MET IF LARGER LOCAL
PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES ARE
SUBSIDIZING SMALLER ONES I DO
BELIEVE THAT'S WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
WITH THIS BILL AND THAT'S WHY
WE'RE OPPOSED THANK YOU.
CANCEL ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL I CAN RESPOND PLEDGE COUNCIL
HAS AND FOUND THE PROBLEM WITH
WITH.
WITH THAT TWENTY SIX NOR DID
THEY THINK THIS IS THIS IS
NOTHING MORE THAN WHAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY DOING THAT BECAUSE
THERE'S THIS BILL IS SILENT ON A
FUNDING SOURCE THAT HASN'T BEEN
IMPLEMENTED YET IT'S GOING TO BE
IF THIS BILL BECAME LAW IT WOULD
BE UP TO THE STATE.
WATER BOARD TO DETERMINE HOW.
TO AT SS THE FEES TO FUND THIS
PROGRAM SO IT'S AN IMP IT'S A
QUESTION OF IMPLEMENTATION HOW
ARE THEY GOING TO IMPLEMENT IT.
MISTER CHAIR SORRY MATT MATT
JUST TRYING TO ADDRESS THIS.
AS YOU CLEARLY UNDERSTAND.
WE CANNOT SLICE AND DICE
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS DOWN TO THE
MINUTIA WE PUT AND KEEP DRINKING
WATER FUNDS.
AND DRINKING WATER COSTS IN THE
SAME PART WE DON'T TAKE MONEY
FOR MY FOOD PROGRAM.
AND PUT IT INTO THE WATER
PROGRAM THAT IS A PROBABLY A
PROP TWENTY SIX VIOLATION.
BUT WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
ALL THAT MONEY GOES INTO ONE
PRODUCT WITH THE STATE WATER
BOARD.
AND IT'S DISTRIBUTED ACCORDINGLY
SAME WITH AYE ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS.
OUR DRINKING WATER PROGRAM FUNDS
FIND ALL THE ACTIVITIES WE
REQUIRED AND DRINKING WATER SO.
THERE MAY BE SOME
DISPROPORTIONATE ALLERGY BUT
IT'S DEFINITELY A LITTLE
LEGITIMATE EXPENSE BECAUSE
WHETHER YOU ARE A FIFTEEN
CONNECTION A THIRTY CONNECTION --
HUNDRED NINETY NINE CONNECTION
THE MONEY'S ALL COMING IN FOR
THE SAME PURPOSE AND THAT'S TO
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT FOR DRINKING
WATER SO WE DISPEL AND SO IT IS
LEAD COUNSEL THIS BILL THE
TWENTY SIX ARGUMENT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY -- LARA.
DIFFERENCES OF INTERPRETATION
HERE.
OKAY JANSSON CASKEY.
I KNOW THAT WE PRIORITIZE
CONSOLIDATION.
AND WORDS FEASIBLE WORDS
FEASIBLE.
THIS HAVE -- CURTAILING AFFECT
ON THAT.
GOAL THAT WE SET UP TO OTHERS IS
THERE ARE THERE MANY SEPARATE
BILLS DEALING WITH CONSOLIDATION
SEPARATE PROGRAMS THIS FAR AS
I'M CONCERNED HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH IT WE JUST PASSED OUT OF
ASSEMBLY -- ENVIRONMENTAL --
QUALITY -- A BILL BY SENATOR
CAMPBELL GYRO CALLING FOR MORE
CONSOLIDATION THIS BILL HAS.
AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED NOTHING
TO DO WITH THAT.
SENATOR WORKERS WHO THROUGH THE
CHAIR IF I MAY RESPOND WE DID
OFFERED TO THE WATER AGENCIES A
PROPOSED AMENDMENT WHICH THE
AUTHORS COMFORTABLE WITH.
AND THAT IS FOR THE L. P. A.'S
TO REPORT TO THE STATE WATER
BOARD IN THEIR JURISDICTIONS ON
WHICH SMALL WATER SYSTEMS ARE
ELIGIBLE OR WOULD BE ADVISABLE
TO EIGHT TO LOOK AT
CONSOLIDATION FOR THE SAME
REASONS THAT WE'VE HAD THIS
DISCUSSION AND WE UNDERSTAND THE
VALUE OF THAT.
AND I THINK SENATE TO A BATES IS
OFFICE RAISE THAT ISSUE WITH US
AND WE CAN COPE WITH THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO BRING THE COST
DOWN. FOR THOSE UNSUSTAINABLE
SYSTEMS AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT
AND I THINK THE LPA PROGRAM HAS
NOT HAD THAT MANDATE ALTHOUGH
THEY DO DO IT CLASSIC COUNTY
DOES DO IT ROUTINELY.
AND OTHERS DO BUT WE WOULD
ACCEPT THAT AMENDMENT WILLINGLY.
TO ENSURE THAT L. P. A.'S REPORT
ON THE VIABILITY OF THESE
SYSTEMS TO REDUCE THE COST TO
EVERYBODY.
NOT JUST OF THIS MOST WATER
SYSTEM FUND.
FONG SIR ALL OPTING IN.
MY NIGHT [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY.
I MEAN I AM [inaudible]
THE BILL [inaudible]
OKAY.
YEAH I REALLY THINK CAN.
THE FRONT IS THE BOARD ALREADY
HAS.
YOU KNOW THE ABILITY.
TO REYES FEES UNDER EXISTING
AUTHORITY CAN'T RAISE RATES
WITHOUT GOING TO THE BUDGET
PROCESS -- RIGHT.
SO I I MEAN I I THINK THIS IS I
I I HEAR THE ARGUMENTS THE
OPPOSITION AYE AYE IS ONE OF
THOSE.
COST BENEFIT WAIT I JUST THINK
THAT -- YOU KNOW WITH OR WITHOUT
THE BILL RATES YOU KNOW.
VERY WILL GO UP YEAH IF AND WHEN
THE LOCALS GIVE BACK A THIRD OF
THE STATE BECAUSE LOCALS CAN
AFFORD. TO PROVIDE THE OVERSIGHT
OF I'M GONNA SUPPORT THE BILL --
BUT TO DO CLEARLY.
THE VALUE TO THIS -- YEAH I SO.
TERM CASKEY S. AS MOVE.
IF YOU LIKE TO CLOSE -- SO I'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OPPOSITION
I WOULD LOVE IT IF THERE WERE
SOME OTHER WAY TO FUND THIS AND
AGAIN IT IS SILENT BUT WE DO
EXPECT THE WATER BOARD TO DO
EXACTLY WHAT THEY'VE BEEN DOING.
IT'S BEEN LEGAL FOR A LONG TIME.
THERE WILL BE NO NET INCREASE IN
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT SENT
HIM TO THE SYSTEM.
OTHER THAN FOR A FEW STE FOR A
FEW COUNTIES WHICH CANNOT AFFORD
TO DO THIS WHERE THE FEES ARE
NOT ADEQUATE THEN THAT WILL BE
SPREAD ACROSS.
HE WOULD ALSO BE SPREAD ACROSS
IF THEY SIMPLY.
DIDN'T TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
AND SIMPLY GAVE THE OVERSIGHT TO
FOR FINANCIAL REASONS TO THE
STATE.
THE ONLY THING THIS REALLY DOES
IS ALLOW LOCAL OVERSIGHT.
WHEN THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO DO IT
THAT'S REALLY WHAT IT COMES DOWN?
TO OKAY CURRENT MOOD BY SEVERAL
CASKEY CENTERPIECE KALRA.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB FOR OH TWO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS. TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
ALLEN HI ALLEN HI BATES
[inaudible]
DOLLY [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
I CASKEY.
CASKEY I'VE OKAY WELL THE ROLL
UP AND THAT'S A TWO ZERO THANK
YOU.
GOOD LUCK WITH FUTURE
NEGOTIATIONS.
OKAY WILL NEXT CALL UP -- SOMBER
GLORIA WHO'S YOUR TO PRESENT A
BEFORE TWENTY THREE THIS HAS TO
DO WITH -- THOUGH YEAH THAT'S
CONTROL DISTRICT IN SAN DIEGO.
THIS ITEM SEVEN IN YOUR PACKETS
MEMBERS.
GOOD ACTORS CHEN AFTERNOON FOR
MORNING WHAT WELL WHATEVER EACH
BACK ON SCHEDULE WAS CHAIRMAN --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- TO YOU
SIR AND TO YOUR STAFF FOR THE
EXCELLENT WORK ON THIS BILL A
BIG STEP IN THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT -- A BEFORE TWENTY
THREE WOULD BE STRUCTURE SAN
DIEGO'S POLLUTION AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT BOARD A DIRECT
THEM TO INCREASE THEIR PROGRAM
TRANSPARENCY -- YOU HAD BECAUSE
OF FIGHTING IN THE BILL GALLON
RESPECT YOUR TIME I KNOW FOLKS
ATTORNEY GOT TO HOLIDAY WEEKEND
I DO HAVE -- TO I DO HAVE A
WITNESS I'D LIKE TO HAVE A
TESTIFIED SUPPORTED THE BILL AS
DIATONIC -- WITH ENVIRONMENT
HEALTH COALITION THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
THANK YOU -- MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- I'M DIANE TECH FOR AN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THANK YOU
THE ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
COALITION AND I ALSO SERVE ON
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD AS THE FIRST
REPRESENTATIVE OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE TO THE BOARD.
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH COALITION
IS SPONSORING AB FOR TO THREE
BECAUSE SAN DIEGO HAS A SERIOUS
AIR POLLUTION PROBLEM THAT HAS
BEEN NEGLECTED FOR DECADES.
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES HAVE A LONG
HISTORY OF WORKING TO IMPROVE
AIR QUALITY BUT THE CURRENT
BOARD HAS BEEN UNRESPONSIVE.
AIR MONITORS IN SOME AREAS
INDICATE A HUMAN CANCER RISK OF
OVER THREE HUNDRED CANCER FROM
MILLION ASTHMA HOSPITALIZATIONS
ARE THREE TIMES HIGHER IN
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES THAN THEY
ARE IN OTHER COMMUNITIES.
THESE CONDITIONS ARE ARE
UNACCEPTABLE AND DEMONSTRATE THE
NEED FOR NEW LEADERSHIP SAN
DIEGO NEEDS A PRO ACTIVE BOARD
THAT WILL ADOPT POLICIES TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS AND IMPROVE
PUBLIC HEALTH ESPECIALLY IF.
HE'S ME IN THE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE MOST IMPACTED.
THE NEED FOR CHANGE AND
REPRESENTATION IS CLEAR THE SAN
DIEGO AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
BOARD IS AN ANOMALY AMONG THE
LARGE AIR DISTRICTS IN THE STATE
IN THE PRODUCT OF A TWENTY FIVE
YEAR OLD PROVISIONS SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNED. TO EXAM SAN DIEGO
COUNTY FROM HAVING A DIVERSE AND
REPRESENTATIVE BOARD.
THE NEED FOR DIRECTED ACTION IS
ALSO QUITE CLEAR FOR EXAMPLE
TRANSPARENCY IS COMPLETELY
MISSING -- ON THE WEBSITE FOR
INSTANCE THERE ARE NO PENDING
PERMITS ARE CURRENT PERMITS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE WHEN DATA IS
REQUESTED WHERE THERE IS A
PROVISION FOR THAT THERE IS A
RESPONSE OF NO DATA AVAILABLE.
MONITORING DATA FROM EXISTING
MONITORS TAKES YEARS TO BE
PROCESSED TWENTY SIXTEEN DATA
WAS JUST RECENTLY -- RELEASE
OTHER LARGE DISTRICTS HAVE
ROBUST PUBLIC INFORMATION
AUTHENTIC COMMUNITY
PARTICIPATION AND AMBITIOUS K. --
REDUCTION PROGRAMS OBSCENE DIEGO
DESERVES AN AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT THAT ENCOURAGES
AND SUPPORTS ITS CAPABLE AND
COMMITTED STAFF TO TAKE BOLD AND
EFFECTIVE ACTION.
TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND OUR
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES WE
WE VERY MUCH ALIVE BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW [inaudible]
NUMBER.
OKAY WE APPRECIATE YOUR ANALYSIS
AND WE ALSO SUPPORT THE CHANGES
THAT THE GOVERNANCE COMMITTEE --
HAS MADE -- AND ALSO THE
AMENDMENT TO PUSH THE CAR
BROUGHT IT TO THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IS A HAVE REQUESTED
SO WE WOULD REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL THANK YOU.
JONATHAN CLAY HERE REPRESENTED
COUNTY SAN DIEGO WE HAVE
PREVIOUSLY HAD CONCERNS AT THIS
MEASURE BUT THROUGH THE HARD
WORK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA
HIS STAFF AND THE SPONSORS WE'VE
ADDRESSED ALL OF OUR CONCERNS --
WITH THE MEASURE. FOR TO GET --
ANYONE ELSE ONE SERVE VOICE
SUPPORT FOR THE DOCTOR.
HI GOOD MORNING -- UNIVERSITIES
WITH CALIFORNIA ROOM TO
CIVILIANS INSTRUCTS AFFORDABLE.
THANK YOU.
FOREIGN COMMISSAIRE CALL
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
VICTORIA ROOM WITH NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE OF MY
WITH THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION AND IN SUPPORT.
OKAY THEY WANT TO RAISE
OPPOSITION CONCERNS.
OKAY THAT IS A FOR THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS.
FIVE IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
CASKEY OF THE SEMESTER VERY
QUICKLY -- I REPRESENT THE NORTH
COUNTY ARE CITIES IN SAN DIEGO
AND I'M CONCERNED THAT THE
WAITING ON THE BILL BASICALLY
PUTS THEM AT A DISADVANTAGE
WITHOUT ANY -- REGULATIONS THAT
ARE GOING TO COME THROUGH SO I
MEAN OPPOSE IT TODAY I KNOW THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA YEAH HE
IS REALLY.
A ONE OF THE VERY SPECIAL
MEMBERS THAT REALLY WORKS FINE
ADDRESSING THINGS THAT ARE HAVE
TO DO WITHOUT.
YOU KNOW THE BALANCE HE THERE
AND FAN DIEGO WE HAVE A LOT OF
FEELINGS IN NORTH COUNTY TO FEAR
CONSTANTLY AND NO WORK I THINK
THE TRANSPORTATION ISSUES A HUGE.
ONE AND SO IN THESE ARE THINGS
THAT CONCERN ME ON JUST WANT TO
GET THAT ON THE RECORD BUT YOU
KNOW IF I CAN BE OF SERVICE AND
HELP IN TERMS OF GOING FORWARD.
CERTAINLY WOULD WOULD DO THAT.
BECAUSE THERE ARE I WOULD HAVE
NOT COULD DISAGREE WITH THAT THE
SENATOR I WOULD JUST POINT OUT
THAT THE CURRENT BOARD HAS NO
SEATS FOR ANY NORTH COUNTY CITY --
THIS BILL WOULD ACTUALLY PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITY FOR NORTH COUNTY
CITIES TO HAVE A VOTING SEAT ON
THIS BOARD.
ALL RIGHT BY I AGREE WITH YOU
ONE SPECIAL MEMBERS I WILL TAKE
THAT AS YOUR CLOTHES THAT'S THE
MOVE BY CINEMA CASKEY -- THIRTY
PLEASE CALL.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB FOR TWENTY
THREE THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE BATES.
BATES NO DOLLY [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
SKINNER.
STERN I CASKEY LIVE LIKE OWSKI I
OKAY WILL -- LEAVE IT OPEN AT
THE TWO TO ONE VOTE -- LET OTHER
PEOPLE THANK YOU OKAY WHEN I
CALLED CUSTOMER GALLAGHER -- 2%
ITEM EIGHT THIS IS
[inaudible]
EIGHTY FOUR THIRTY CHRISSY READY.
DO YOU WANT [inaudible] ONE WAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
SENATORS AND AND I I WANT TO
START BY THANKING THE CHAIRMAN --
AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
EXTENSIVE DISCUSSIONS THAT WE'VE
HAD ON THIS BILL AND AND
THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSIONS.
AND I AM WILLING TO ACCEPT THE
PROPOSED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS --
DE THROUGH F. THERE ON PAGE.
SEVENTEEN AND THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS -- I WANTED TO DISCUSS
ON THE OTHER ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED.
AND WE'VE CONTINUED TO HAVE I
THINK.
SOME PRODUCTIVE DISCUSSIONS --
THERE BUT I CAN'T COMMIT TO THE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THIS TIME --
THE MOST NOTABLY BECAUSE THEY
WOULD LARGELY PRECLUDE THE
BUILDING OF SINGLE FAMILY HOMES
WHICH REPRESENTS THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF OF THE
HOUSING AND THAT WAS BURNED --
YOU KNOW IN THE CAMPFIRE -- SO
MY DISTRICT IS A MANY OF YOU
KNOW STILL IN THE MIDST OF
RECOVERING.
FROM THE DEADLY ESTAMOS
DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRE.
IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY NOW WHICH
DEVASTATED NOT.
IN YANKEE HILL.
A SECOND DISASTER IS CURRENTLY --
UNFOLDING AS THE AREA STRUGGLES
TO ABSORB.
THOUSANDS OF FIRE VICTIMS.
THE PROBLEM IS IS QUITE SIMPLY
THAT THERE ISN'T HOUSING
AVAILABLE THE CAMP FIRE
DESTROYED 14%.
A BEAT COUNTIES HOUSING STOCK
ALMOST FIFTEEN THOUSAND HOMES --
THE COUNTY FELL SEVENTEEN PLACES
MORE THAN ANY OTHER COUNTY IN
THE STATE.
ON THE AFFORDABILITY INDEX IN
THE AFTERMATH OF THE FIRE -- THE
RENTAL MARKET VACANCY RATE ALSO
FELL TO NEARLY 0%.
AFTER THE FIRE IN ALL OF THIS IS
MAKING IT VERY EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT. FOR CAN'T FIRE
VICTIMS AND OTHERS AS THEY
STRUGGLE TO FIND HOUSING EVEN
HAD PEOPLE THAT WERE -- YOU VIC
DID OUT OF THEIR RENTALS -- TO
MAKE ROOM.
FOR REMOVING AND FIRE VICTIMS SO --
AND EVEN THOUGH MANY WANT TO
STAY IN THIS AREA WHERE THEY
HAVE JOBS AND FAMILY AND AND
COMMUNITY CONNECTIONS.
THIS IS ALL MAKING IT VERY HARD
I WAS JUST RECENTLY AT THE THE
GRADUATION THAT WE HAVE PREPARED
ICE HIGH SCHOOL WHO ARE ABLE TO
HAVE THAT GRADUATION BACK UP ON
THE CAMPUSES OF WONDERFUL DAY.
AND THE PRINCIPLE OF THAT HIGH
SCHOOL IS A GUY NAMED LORELEI
HALL AND THE THE THE KIDS THERE
WERE CHANT LILY CHANTING HIS
NAME.
HE HAD A GREAT RELATIONSHIP WITH
THOSE KIDS.
JULY HALL IS MOVIE BECAUSE HE
CANNOT FIND.
ADEQUATE HOUSING AREA MOVE INTO
THE CENTRAL VALLEY -- AND THIS
IS JUST ONE HIGH PROFILE STORY
OF OF WHAT IS GOING ON
THROUGHOUT THE REGION.
THEY WILL TAKE YEARS FOR THE
COMMUNITY DESTROYED BY THE FIRE
TO REBUILD IN THE MEAN TIME.
EVACUEES NEED TO FIND STABLE
HOUSING.
MOREOVER NOT EVERYONE WILL WANT
TO REBUILD.
MANY WILL WANT TO FIND PERMANENT
HOUSING AND IN THE SURROUNDING
AREAS.
THEY MAY NOT WANT TO GO BACK UP
ON THE RIDGE.
WE ALSO HAVE FEMA SITES.
IN SEVERAL OF THE CITIES.
IN YUBA CITY AND TWO OF THEM IN
OR A BILL -- IN ORLAND.
WE HAVE A FOUR HUNDRED UNIT FEMA
SITE THAT'S GOING INTO GRIDLEY --
THIS WEEK BUT ALL THAT IS
TEMPORARY HOUSING EIGHTEEN
MONTHS.
MAX IN THOSE FEMA CAMPS.
THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO GET
HOUSING ONLINE AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
MANY PEOPLE ARE STILL
PRECARIOUSLY HOUSE AT BEST
LIVING WITH FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
OR MAYBE IN AN RV OR TRAILER --
AT WORST LIVING IN A TENT --
NHà LIVING ON THE STREETS.
OTHERS HAVE AND WILL BE FORCED
TO LEAVE THE AREA OR EVEN THE
STATE WE RISK LOSING TEACHERS
POLICE OFFICERS AND VITAL WORK
FORCE THAT WE NEED -- IN OUR
REGION LARGE EMPLOYERS HAVE EVEN
TALKED ABOUT LEAVING IF THEY
CANNOT FIND HOUSING FOR THEIR
EMPLOYEES.
SO ALL THIS IS IS IT IS AN
UNPRECEDENTED ISSUE FOR US AB
FOR THIRTY THE CAMPFIRE HOUSING
ASSISTANCE ACT WILL HELP CREATE
HOUSING IN THE REGION.
BUT CREATE A NARROWLY APPLIED
STREAMLINED MINISTERIAL APPROVAL
PROCESS FOR BUILDING HOMES IN
THAT REGION IMPACTED BY THIS
FIRE.
THE BILL ONLY APPLIES TO
SELECCIONAR ACTED REGION.
AND I WANT TO GO THROUGH THIS
QUICKLY SO THAT EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS.
THERE ARE MANY LIMITS ON THE
STREAMLINED APPROVAL IT HAS TO
BE WITHIN THE CITY LIMITS.
OF THE SELECT CITIES -- SO NO
SPRAWL INTO THE UNINCORPORATED
PARTS OF THE COUNTY -- IT
INCLUDES PROTECTIONS IN HERE.
THAT IT CANNOT BE BUILT IN A
FLOOD PLAIN CAN BE BUILT IN A
WILD FIRE HAZARD ZONE.
BUT I COULD NOT BE ON
ENVIRONMENTALLY SENSITIVE AREAS
INC INCLUDING AREAS THAT HAVE
BEEN PROTECTED.
BY CONSERVATION OR THAT ARE THEN
INCLUDE ENDANGERED HABITAT --
THAT OUR WETLANDS.
ALL WOULD BE PROHIBITED
ADDITIONALLY ANY BENNY
DEVELOPMENT UNDER THIS BILL
WOULD HAVE TO BE BUILT ACCORDING
TO LEED GOLD.
STANDARDS.
AT THE DEVELOPMENT AGAIN HAS TO
BE CONSISTENT IT WOULD HAVE TO
BE IN AN AREA THAT IS ZONED IN
THAT CITY. FOR RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENT -- IN A COULD NOT IN
A FOR INSTANCE BEES ON ON COULD
NOT BE BUILT ON SOMETHING THAT
IS NOT ZONED.
CURRENTLY IN THE GENERAL PLAN.
EVERY EVERY JURISDICTION
INCLUDING THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTIVE AND I AM COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS.
AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD --
SIERRA CLUB IS NEUTRAL ON THIS
BILL -- AND AS I SAID I WANT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK -- AS YOU MOVE
THIS BEFORE BUT IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE GET THIS TOOL IN PLACE.
I IN AN AREA THAT DESPERATELY
NEEDS IT AND SO I WOULD I WOULD
JUST ASK THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY -- WITH ME TO
TESTIFY HAVE ANGELA COUNSELOR.
VICTIM OF THE CAMPFIRE AND ALSO
OWNER OF SUSTAINABILITY
MANAGEMENT CONSULTING.
AND ORVILLE CITY MANAGER TOM
LANDAU -- SO THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE THOUGH.
THANK YOU MY NAME'S ANGELA
KESSLER I ACTUALLY HAVE THREE
JOB SAVE TWO HOME BASED
BUSINESSES THAT I LOST.
I AM THE CEO PRESIDENT OF
SUSTAINABILITY MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION WERE A GROUP OF
PROFESSIONALS TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED AROUND THE WORLD THAT --
MANAGE STING ABILITY AND THEN I
DO AS A PRINCIPAL CONSULTANT
SUSTAINABILITY STRATEGY IS MY
CAREER AND I'M ALSO A FULL TIME
LECTURER CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY CHICO.
I LIVED IN PARADISE FOR TEN
YEARS AND I WAS VERY LUCKY TO
LIVE IN THIS WONDERFUL PLACE.
AND ON THAT DAY DID LOSE MY HOME
LOSS TO VEHICLES AND ANOTHER
PROPERTY THAT I OWN TO TWENTY
THREE ACRES OF FORESTED LAND.
THE FIREFIGHTERS TO SAVE OUR
BARN IN OUR RV.
SO I ACTUALLY HAVE SEVEN
INSURANCE CLAIMS AND RECOVERING
FROM THE CAMPFIRE HAS ACTUALLY
BEEN A FULL TIME JOB AND I DO
TURN JOHN JOBS RIGHT NOW FROM MY
REGULAR WORK.
IN ORDER JUST TO WORK ON OUR OWN
INSURANCE CLAIMS FOR OUR FAMILY
TRYING TO PUT OUR LIVES BACK
TOGETHER.
BUT IF I MAY SHARE WITH YOU --
THESE ARE SOME ARTIFACTS ABOUT
WHAT'S LEFT OF OUR LIVES THESE
ARE SOME GIFTS THAT I DUG
THROUGH FROM FOUR DAYS OF SLUDGE
AFTER THE RAINS HIT AFTER FIVE
WEEKS WE WEREN'T ALLOWED TO
RETURN HOME.
I DON'T KNOW IF I MAY PASS THEM
AROUND IF THAT'S THE CASE BUT I
LIVED IN EUROPE FOR TEN YEARS
AND THESE ARE THE MILITARY COINS
COMMANDERS GAVE TO ME FOR
PHILANTHROPIC WORKS AS AN
INTERNATIONAL BAKER.
HELPING OUR EX PATS AND OUR
MILITARY OVERSEAS.
THIS IS WHAT'S LEFT OF OUR LIFE
IF YOU'D LIKE FREE.
AFTER FOUR DAYS OF TAKING TWENTY
HOURS OF CLEANING THOSE THOSE
ARE AND HOW THEY LOOK TODAY --
MY CAMPFIRE STORIES START AT
SEVEN FORTY ONE ON THE NEWS I
HEARD IT THAT THERE IS A FIRE
AND PULL GO TWELVE MILES AWAY.
I CALLED MY FATHER IN LAW IS
NINETY ONE YEARS OLD TOLD AND
START PACKING CALL HIS NINETY
YEAR OLD GIRLFRIEND.
TELL HER START PACKING IN COME
ON OVER AT TEN AM HE ARRIVED AND
THEY WERE SMOKING THE CANYON AND
WE'RE THE FIRST THE STREET WHERE
THE LAST STREET LEAVING PARADISE.
ON A MAJOR CORDER CALLED SKY WAY
AND WE HAD SMOKE COMING OUT OF
THE CANYON SO I WAS THE FURTHEST
AREA FROM THE ORIGIN OF THE FIRE
TO SO SURPRISED.
THE WE DIDN'T RECEIVE ANY CODE
RED ALERTS THERE WERE NO SIRENS
BLARING THERE WERE NO TELEPHONE
CALLSFROM CODE RED.
AND THERE WAS SILENCE AND SO --
WHEN HE DID COME OVER I STAND ON
THE CASH SAID HE DâN WHEN YOU
SEE FIRE CHRIS THAT HILL YOU
HOLLER AT ME BECAUSE THEN I KNEW
WAS GAME ON I WAS GRABBING ALL
MY LOOK?
MIGHT BUSINESS DOCUMENTS AS MANY
AS I COULD GRAB.
SO TEN TWENTY RUN BACK IN THE
LIVING ROOM AND THEY'RE MY HOUSE
AT THE HOUSE ACROSS THE STREET
IS ON FIRE WE GO OUTSIDE TO TRY
TO EVACUATE PUT HIM IN HIS CAR
IT GET IN MY TRUCK.
AND THE WIND IS FULL ON BLOWING
STRAIGHT OUT ME.
FROM MY NEIGHBOR'S HOUSE ON FIRE
ACROSS THE STREET BUT ALL THE
EMBERS JUST BLOWING INTO MY
OTHER NEIGHBORS HOUSE STRANGEST
THING YOU COULD IMAGINE.
SO IF YOU VISITED PARADISE YOU
WONDERED WHY USER ONE HOUSE
STANDING THE WHOLE REST OF THE
NEIGHBORHOOD IS GONE IT JUST
CREATE ITS OWN WHEN IT WAS SO
BIZARRE AND VERY SURREAL.
AND FROM THERE WE EVACUATED TO
CORNING ENDED UP IN A HOTEL WITH
EIGHTY SIX OTHER FAMILIES FROM
PARADISE.
AND FRIDAY WE STARTED REALIZING
THAT THE WHOLE TOWN WAS ACTUALLY
GONE IN JUST THE SORROW AND NOT
REALLY HEARTBREAK OF IT ALL.
AND AFTER I STARTED FEELING
REALLY BAD FOR MYSELF I AM
HELPED GOT A LOT OF HELP FROM
FRIENDS AND FAMILY WHO JUST
STARTED SENDING MONEY IN CLOSE
AND I SPENT THE ENTIRE WEEKEND
JUST CLOTHING AND FEEDING PEOPLE.
FROM THEIR RETURN TO HOUSING
WHERE WHAT WE GOING TO DO AND SO
I WAS ABLE TO SECURE A HOUSE FOR
A FAMILY THAT'S VERY TEMPORARY
THIS NICE GENTLEMAN JUST LIKE
STAY AS LONG AS YOU WANT.
BUT I DON'T THINK ANYONE
REALIZED IT WAS TWO THREE YEARS
AND I CAROL IN POSITION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SO WE REALLY DO
NEED HOUSING WE ARE OF ALL
SOCIOECONOMIC CLASSES -- FOR ALL
PROFESSIONALS WE DON'T WE REALLY
DO WANT TO STAY IN OUR AREA WE
DON'T HAVE ANY CHOICES EVERY DAY
I SPENT HOURS AND HOURS ON
ZILLOW LOOKING.
FOR OPPORTUNITIES AND WHETHER
IT'S RENTALS WHETHER IT'S GOING
TO BE MULTI FAMILY SINGLE FAMILY
MANY CURVATURE OF SPACE OUR
EMPLOYERS ALL HAD EMPLOYEES
AFFECTED FROM PARADISE THAT HOW
TO EITHER LEAVE THE AREA.
SO NOW WE NEED TO RECRUIT OUR
WORK FORCE BACK TO THE AREA AND
WE CAN ONLY DO THAT IF WE HAVE
HOUSING SO I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME TODAY AND
HAVING ME BE ABLE TO JOIN YOU
[inaudible]
YES SIR.
HELLO NONTON LANDAU I AM THE
INTERIM CITY ADMINISTRATOR FOR
THE CITY FOR A BILL I AM HERE
REPRESENTING THE CITY COUNCIL --
STRONGLY SUPPORTS ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR THIRTY IN HOPE JEWEL PASSED
OUT OF COMMITTEE IN ITS CURRENT
FORM.
YOU'VE HEARD THIS ALREADY BUT
APPROXIMATELY FOURTEEN THOUSAND
HOMES WERE LOST WHICH HOUSED A
VERY LARGE PERCENTAGE OF WORKERS
IN THE AREA.
MOST LIVED IN AND STILL DESIRE
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES.
OUR REGION A CON REGION'S
ECONOMIES AT SERIOUS RISK.
THEY'RE NOT LONG TERM HOUSING
ALTERNATIVES WE ARE RURAL AREA
WITHOUT AN ADEQUATE HOUSING
STOCK.
DESPORTIVA AN INFLUX OF
SURVIVORS THIS IS A THOUSAND
PIECE PUZZLE OF WHICH THIS BILL
IS A PART.
AS NOTED IN THE STAFF REPORT
SUDDEN AND SUBSTANTIAL GROWTH
HAS ALREADY OCCURRED IT'S NOT
GOING TO KERR BECAUSE THIS BILL.
IN ORVILLE -- THE THE STATE
DEPARTMENT FINANCES ARE
POPULATION GREW BY TWENTY POINT
4% AND THAT'S NOT INCLUDING THE
DEBRIS WORKERS.
OF WHOM THERE ARE ABOUT FIFTEEN
HUNDRED TWO THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
FOLKS IN OUR COMMUNITY.
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S NOT
SUSTAINABLE PEOPLE LIVING WITH
FRIENDS ARE CROWDED IN SMALL
APARTMENTS WITH LARGE FAMILIES.
WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMMODATE
THESE PEOPLE WE'VE ALREADY
EXPEDITED SOME HOUSING AND HAVE
BUILT SEVERAL -- SUBDIVISIONS
90% OF THOSE HOMES HAVE BEEN
SOLD CAMPFIRE SURVIVORS. TO ME
IS CRITICAL EMPHASIZES BILL
DOESN'T ELIMINATE PLANNING FOR
THE PLANNING PROCESS IF YOU'RE
GOING TO SUBDIVIDE.
YOU STILL HAVE TO GO THROUGH
PLANNING STAFF YOU STILL HAVE TO
HAVE PUBLIC HEARING.
THE CITY SPENT YEARS CRAFTING OR
GENERAL PLAN AND PREPARE THE
RIVER ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENTS
RELATED TO THAT.
UNDER ASSEMBLY BILL FOR THIRTY
DEFAULT MUST STILL CONFORM TO
THAT PLAN.
AGAIN OUR ECONOMY IS AT RISK
ALREADY HUNDREDS IF NOT
THOUSANDS OF EMPLOYEES HAVE LEFT
THE AREA.
IN MOST CASES OF LEFT CALIFORNIA.
BUSINESSES WILL UNDOUBTEDLY
FOLLOW.
OUR HOSPITAL UP THE HILL HAS
CLOSED I LOST THIRTEEN HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES RIGHT THERE.
PLEASE PASS THIS LEGISLATION WE
NEED YOUR HELP THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS POLIO --
SHUDDER INTO AND WE HAVE THE YOU
CAN THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THE THE
COUNTY THE AREA NEEDS THE MOST
USABLE BILL NECESSARY.
I WOULD JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU NOT INSIST ON ALL THE
AMENDMENTS -- AND LET THE LET A
BILL OUT THE WITH ALL THE
SAFEGUARDS THAT ARE ALREADY IN
IT CAN BE THE MOST USABLE BILL
POSSIBLE THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY -- WHERE THE SAFEGUARDS YOU
THINK REPLACE SYKORA?
I THINK THE ASSEMBLY MAN I I
DON'T SPEAK FOR THE SELLING OF
BUT I THINK HE DID A WONDERFUL
JOB LAYING OUT WHERE HOUSING
COULDN'T BE BUILT.
I MEAN THERE'S MULTIPLE THINGS
TO BE LISTED -- WAREHOUSING
COULDN'T BE BUILT THAT DOESN'T
REPLACE SEQUEL BUT I THINK THOSE
ARE THE SAFEGUARDS THE YOU WOULD
WANT IN THE BILL THAT ARE
ALREADY IN THE BILL.
REVENUE SO AS AN ADDRESS LIKE
TRAFFIC OR OR YOU KNOW SPRAWL OR
OR WATER QUALITY OR THOSE KINDS
IMPACTS.
OKAY LET'S HEAR FROM THAT LET'S
HEAR FROM AND OTHER FOLKS WENT
OUT ON SUPPORT.
MEMBER ADAM RIGHT ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
JUST TO ANSWER QUESTION I THINK
THE GENERAL PLAN WICH DOES
DISCUSS SPRAWL WHEN THEY RECEIVE
A PROCESS THAT HAS EXTENSIVE THE
AYE ARE.
THOUGHT TO CONFORM TO THANKS YET
MUCH LESSEXPENSIVE THAN A
INDIVIDUAL PROJECT WHEN SHE
HOSTED A CALIFORNIA -- BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE CIVIL JUST
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA HERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JOHN KENNEDY WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
IN A CONDO WITH THE SACRAMENTO
REGIONAL BUILDERS EXCHANGE AND
IT SAYS STATEWIDE AFFILIATES IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOODMORNING MANY CARDOZA VICE
MAYOR CITY OF CITY THE CITY VIEW
THE CITY A STRONGLY SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING GRACE ESPANOLA YUBA
CITY YUBA CITY AND I FULLY
SUPPORT THIS.
AB FOR THIRTY INNER URGE YOU TO
PLEASE PASS SAY YOU'RE ON YOUR
OWN CITY COUNCIL I AM ON THE
CITY COMMITTEE QUESTION RECESS
BECAUSE IT.
ON YOU KNOW UNDER UNDER CURRENT
LAW YOU AS A CITY CAN DESIGNATE
PORTIONS INTERESTED ACTUALLY
GENERAL PLAN NOT RIGHT HERE --
PORTIONS OF YOUR CITY AS FOR IT
YOU CAN ZONE IT -- OF BY RIGHT
DEVELOPMENT.
AND THUS BYPASS THE WALL
TOGETHER.
HOW COME YOU HAVEN'T TAKEN THAT
PATH?
AND SAID YOU'RE COMING TO THE
STATE NOW ASKING FOR A A BLANKET
SECRET EXEMPTION.
THAT IS A REALLY GOOD QUESTION
AND I APPRECIATE YOU ASKING ME
THIS AND I WAS -- ELECTED ON
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO
I'M STILL LEARNING ALL THOSE
AREAS THAT YOU'RE ASKING -- BUT
AT THIS MOMENT I THINK THAT THE
FOCUS ON THIS PARTICULAR BILL
WOULD BE VERY MUCH SUPPORTED.
I WOULD HOPE THAT WE CAN MOVE
THAT FORWARD.
VIEW THE MERIT VICE MAYOR DOUBLE
THE THE GENTLEMAN OVER HERE YES
DID YOU CAN YOU MAYBE ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
CAN YOU REPEAT IT PLEASE
BASICALLY YOU COULD ZONE A LOT
OF THIS LAND -- FOR BY RIGHT
DEVELOPMENT.
AND THUS BYPASS SEQUEL BECAUSE
IT BE MINISTERIAL DECISION AS
OPPOSED TO WHICH AT A AT IS
DISCRETIONARY DECISION BY THE
CITY [inaudible]
AND SO I HOW COME YOU'RE NOT
TAKING THAT PATH.
WE'RE WORKING TOGETHER -- WITH
THE COMMUNITY AT THIS TIME WE
WERE IN THE PROCESS BUT THERE IS
BEEN NO DECISIONS MADE AT THIS
TIME.
WERE WERE WERE WORK WE'RE WE'RE
WORKING TOGETHER WE HAVE MADE
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS BUT NO
DECISIONS HAVE MADE A STOP WE'RE
STRONGLY SUPPORTED.
OF AB.
FOR THIRTY THIS IF I COULD
MISTER CHAIRMAN IF OKAY YES SIR
IT JUST REALLY QUICKLY I MEAN --
AS WE DISCUSSED A LITTLE BIT IN
ORDER TO CHANGE THE BUYER RIGHT
YOU DO HAVE TO GO THROUGH A
PUBLIC PROCESS HAVE A STAR HEAVY
ENGAGE IN THAT KIND OF PROCESS.
I CAN'T SPEAK FOR WHAT PROCESS
THEY KNOW WE HAD A MISTER LANDAU
I THINK IT HAD BEEN A LONG TIME
CITY ADMINISTRATOR COULD SPEAK
TO THAT ISSUE TO IF IF IF IT'S
APPROPRIATE WOULD APPRECIATE
THAT YEAH.
I WOULD SAY THAT WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IS TRUE IF I'M BUILDING
APARTMENT COMPLEX A JONES I BY
RIGHT GET TO BUILD.
BUT IF I'M SUBDIVIDING PROPERTY
MAYBE TO PUT A SINGLE FAMILY
DEVELOPMENT IN AN APARTMENT
COMPLEX.
I STILL HAVE TO GO THROUGH AN
APPROVAL PROCESS I CAN'T DO THAT
BYE BYE RIGHT I HAVE TO GO
THROUGH A SUBDIVISION PROCESS.
AND THAT TAKES EQUAL.
SO IT'S E. IT IS REQUIRED IF I'M
GOING TO DO ANYTHING BUT BUILD.
A SINGLE UNIT ON A SINGLE LIFE.
BUT YOU COULD MAKE A DECISION TO
ZONE.
FOR SINGLE FAMILY HOUSING -- AND
AND ALLOW FOR THE PERMITTING
PROCESS TO BE DONE BY RIGHT.
NO I STILL WOULD HAVE TO GO
THROUGH A SUBDIVISION PROCESS.
TO SUBDIVIDE THAT PROPERTY WHICH
THEN TAKES THE SEQUEL PROCESS.
HELLO AGAIN I'D Y. MODERATE
SUBDIVIDE THE PROPERTY SO I HAVE
A FIVE ACRE PARCEL HONEST PUT IT
INTO.
A FIVE ACRE FOR ACRE APARTMENT
COMPLEX AND PUT SIX SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES.
I HAVE TO GO THROUGH A STATE
PROCESS AND ITS STATE MAP ACT TO
SUBDIVIDE INTO SIX LOTS.
AND THAT TAKES A PROCESS THROUGH
SEEK WORK.
IT'S STILL UNDER THIS BILL WOULD
TAKE A PROCESS AND THROUGH
PLANNING COMMISSION PUBLIC
HEARING COUNCIL PUBLIC HEARING.
BUT I CAN'T JUST DO IT BY RIGHT.
YEAH I THINK THERE'S ANOTHER
PATH YOU COULD TAKE I'M I'LL GET
IN TOUCH WITH THE PROFESSOR TALK
ABOUT THAT -- BUT OKAY I'M SORRY
KEY LET'S LET'S KEEP HEARING
FROM A POSITION.
DEPUTY CITY MANAGER FOR THE CITY
OF YUBA CITY WE SUPPORT THE BILL
AND AGREE WITH MR LAND ELSE
OPINION AS RLATES -- TO A BY
RIGHTS WE'D LOVE TO KNOW IF
THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE BUT WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL WOULD HELP US
RIGHT NOW TODAY -- BRING HOUSING
TO THE MARKET FOR THESE FOURTEEN
THOUSAND UNITS OR LOST.
YET IS A PROFESSOR AT CHAPMAN
LAW SCHOOL I THINK WOULD BE
HAPPY.
TO TALK YOUR CITIES ABOUT THIS.
MY NAME IS KATIE TELL MY MED THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE CHICO
CHAMBER AND EVEN THOUGH THE CITY
OF CHICO -- COUNSEL REQUESTED TO
BE REMOVED FROM MAYBE FOUR
THIRTY THE CHAMBER STILL
CONTINUES TO SUPPORT AB.
43010215% OF THE WORK FORCE.
OF CHICO EMPLOYERS LIVED IN
PARADISE SO WE'RE LOOKING.
AT REGIONAL HOUSING TO SOLVE --
ARE ARE CONCERNED FOR LABOR
RETENTION AND LABOR RECRUITMENT
SO WE IMPLORE YOU TO SUPPORT AB
FOR THIRTY AS PRESENTED.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING KATE LADEN WITH
CHICO BUILDERS ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR GARY
HANSEN MAYOR CITY WILLOWS THE
CITY WILLOWS FULLY SUPPORTS THIS
BILL AND WE DESPERATELY NEED
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MARTY LETTERMAN'S
HERE NORTH VALLEY BOARD OF
REALTORS -- WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THE MORNING NOT ADAM FINELLI
ALSO IS HERE NORTH VALLEY
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
HE ZERO NOT A BUSINESS OWNER AND
SHE GO AS WELL AS SPEAKING FOR
MYSELF PERSONALLY AS A CHECK A
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER AND STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BRADBURY FOUNDER CHECK A FIRST
REPRESENTING THIRTY THREE
HUNDRED CITIZENS -- WE SUPPORT
A. B. FOUR THIRTY AS A RE TRIALS
AND APPROACH THANK YOU.
OKAY.
THANK YOU YOU KNOW WE STILL HAVE
THE CITY OF CHICO IS ON IN
OPPOSITION -- SPEAKING CHAMBER
AND PHONE NUMBER [inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY ALL RIGHT OKAY.
FOLKS WANT TO RAISE OPPOSITION
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I WITH THEM HI MATTHEW BAKER
WITH PLANNING CONSERVATION THEY
AT FIRST LIKE TO APOLOGIZE TO
THE AUTHOR HAD TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR STEPPING IN SO LATE ON THIS
BILL.
WE KNEW THERE WERE PEOPLE
WORKING ON IT WE HAD CONFIDENCE
THAT WAS HEADED IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT WE FIND -- THAT IS
NOT NEARLY AS FAR AS IT.
WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE TO BE
PASSING THIS COMMITTEE AND AFTER
MULTIPLE PLEASE FROM LOCAL
RESIDENTS FOR PC ON A STEP IN
AND DO SOMETHING I FIND MYSELF
IN THE UNFORTUNATE POSITION OF
BEING HERE? TO TO VOICE OUR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PCL IS
EXTREMELY CONCERNED.
AND HAS THE UTMOST SYMPATHY FOR
THE VICTIMS OF THIS CAMPFIRE AS
WE DO FOR ALL THE COULDN'T
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
THAT HAVE BEEN STRUCK BY THESE
INCREASINGLY DEVASTATING FIRES
IN RECENT YEARS.
DETAILS ARE VERY INTERESTED IN
DEVELOPING AYE IDENTIFYING THE
APPROPRIATE STREAMLINING
MECHANISM FOR THE RECOVERY OF
THESE COMMUNITIES.
WE JUST DON'T THINK THAT THIS
APPROACH PRESENTED BY FOUR
THIRTY IS THAT APPROPRIATE
MECHANISM.
AS RECENTLY AS LAST YEAR WE
WORKED DILIGENTLY IN SUPPORT OF
THE SANTA ROSA RECOVERY BILL --
TWO TWO SIX SEVEN THAT BILL BY
COMPARISON OFFERED EXPLODED
JUDICIAL REVIEW IS NOT A FULL
SEQUENCE EMPTION.
IT HAD STRICT INFILL
REQUIREMENTS IT HAD STRICT
TRANSPORTATION EFFICIENCY
REQUIREMENTS FOR V. M. T. NGH G..
A HAD -- STRICT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING REQUIREMENTS AND
STRONGER ANTI DISPLACEMENT
CRITERIA THEN FOUR THIRTY DOES.
EITHER THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT
THAT SHOULD BE REQUIRED FOR SUCH
A BROAD TO QUICKLY ACTION OR FOR
ANY KIND OF RECOVERY PLAN AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY THERE SHOULD BE
A RECOVERY PLAN.
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT -- THE
CENTER IS A BILL THE COUNTY AND
THE CITY WERE WORKING TOGETHER
WITH THE LEGISLATOR TO TO HAVE A
VERY SPECIFIC DEVELOPMENT PLAN
PRESENTED AS PART OF THE BILL.
AND AND IT WAS.
ALMOST ENTIRELY CONSISTENT WITH
AN ALREADY ADOPTED COMMUNITY
THAT IT MASTER PLAN FOR FOR THE
DOWNTOWN AREA.
AND IT WAS.
THE AREAS THAT WERE NOT PART OF
THAT ADOPTED PLAN THAT THAT
BECAME MOST DIVISIVE INSTALLED
THE BILL [inaudible]
THIS.
YOU KNOW THAT THIS AND SAID THIS
IS OUR OUR PRIMARY
RECOMMENDATION TO THE AUTHOR TO
HOLD THIS BILL AND TO DEVELOP
SUCH A PLAN OFFERING SUCH A
BROAD.
THE QUICK REACTION JUST BASED ON
GENERAL PLAN CONSISTENCY WOULD
BE UNPRECEDENTED AND AND A BAD
PRECEDENT FEDERAL PLANS JUST
SIMPLY DID NOT HAVE THE KIND OF
SPECIFIC SPECIFICITY. TO
IDENTIFY PARCEL PACIFIC IMPACTS
OR OR REGIONALLY CUMULATIVE
IMPACTS -- YOU KNOW AND WE'RE
TALKING A ABOUT NEW DEVELOPMENT
THERE IS ALREADY A FULL SEQUEL
EXEMPTION IN PLACE FOR
REBUILDING.
A PROPERTY THAT IS LOST IN A
FIRE THIS IS ABOUT NEW
CONSTRUCTION AND REGIONAL REGION
WIDE RECOVERY THAT THERE SHOULD
AND THAT KIND OF THAT THAT TO
REQUIRE.
A PLAN -- CROSS JURISDICTIONAL
COOPERATIVE.
PLAN WITH ROBUST COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT ON BUT THAT
REBUILDING AND RECOVERY LOOKS
LIKE -- AND BECAUSE OF THE LACK
OF THAT PLAN THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT LOCAL OPPOSITION AND
THERE HAVE.
BEEN JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE
OPTED TO BE EXCLUDED FROM THIS
BILL THAT HAVE BEEN MOST
DIRECTLY AFFECTED FROM THIS FIRE --
YOU KNOW WE WE URGE.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO GO BACK
TO THIS COMMUNITY HOLD THE BILL
TODAY GO BACK TO THE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPED.
ACROSS JURISDICTIONAL PLAN.
WITH ROBUST COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
THAT YOU KNOW IS TARGETED AT
ECONOMIC RECOVERY FOR THE REGION
ADDRESSES OTHER STATE.
ENVIRONMENTAL INEQUITY MANDATE.
AND AND ALSO REALLY INSURERS
THAT THESE COMMUNITIES INTO THAT
WE DON'T REBUILD AND REPLICATE
THE MISTAKES AND RISKS OF THE
PACK -- WITH WITHOUT A PLAN IN
PLACE.
WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT THE
APPROPRIATE THREE MONEY
MECHANISM.
YEAH BUT WITHOUT SUCH A PLAN B.
PURCHASE A NO VOTE RESPECTFULLY.
THANK YOU -- MY NAME IS SUSAN
JUDY THANK YOU FOR HAVING US
HERE TODAY.
THE ANALYSIS PROVIDED BY THE
COMMITTEE.
I LIVE IN YANKEE HILL CALIFORNIA
BOTH MY SONS LOST THEIR HOMES.
MY YOUNGEST SON LOST IN ADDITION
HIS FARM.
ON THAT HE'S SPENT HIS WHOLE
ADULT LIFE BUILDING.
I'M.
BUT NONETHELESS I OPPOSE -- AB.
FOUR THIRTY I THINK THAT IF.
IT'S UNDERSTANDABLE THAT PEOPLE
WOULD WANT TO REACH OUT AND
PROVIDE AS MUCH HELP AS THEY CAN
FOR PEOPLE WHO LOST THEIR HOMES
BUT IT'S NOT THE BILL THAT WILL
DO THAT.
I'M I THINK THAT IT IS AN END
RUN AROUND SYKORA.
AM I THINK THAT EXEMPTING
BUILDERS FROM ENVIRONMENTAL.
OF REGULATIONS THAT SUCH.
A VERY BAD PRECEDENT -- AND AS
HE JUST SAID I DON'T KNOW HIM --
IT IT IT IT SETS A PRECEDENT AND
IT'S SO BROAD THAT IT TAKES AN
WAY -- WAY TOO MUCH SO IT SETS
ONCE ESTABLISHED THIS PRESIDENT
CAN ALLOW DEVELOPERS TO MAKE
CLAIMS ABOUT NEED AND WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE INCREASING.
DISASTERS INCREASING WILDFIRES
WE CAN SAY WE NEED THIS AND THEN
JUST FOR A SEQUEL OUT AND SAY
LET'S LET'S GET AROUND THIS.
AB POOR THIRTY WAS EXPANDED IN
THE VERY BEGINNING FROM ITS
ORIGINAL STATE AND GOAL WHEN REP
REPRESENTATIVE GALLAGHER
INTRODUCED IT HE FOCUSED ON
PRIMARILY ON CHICO AND OR AVAIL.
BUT HE HAS SINCE ADDED IN IN THE
AMENDMENTS THERE ARE THREE
COUNTIES NOW SO NOW WE HAVE --
HOUSING SPREAD OUT IN THREE
COUNTIES IN EIGHT CITIES OR
AVAIL BAGS GREATLY WILLOWS
ORLAND YUBA CITY CORNING IN LINE
VOTE.
THIS EXPANDING ASSAULT ON SEA
QUEST.
ANNA IS -- UNNECESSARY I THINK
AND WE'VE TALKED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT INFILL TODAY THERE ARE
MANY POSSIBILITIES AND CHECKOUT
FOR THAT.
WE WE DON'T NEED TO IMMEDIATELY
ABANDON SEQUOIA AND ALLOW THIS
ENVIRONMENTAL DISASTER TO GO ON
THANK YOU.
IF IT AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN.
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS RICHARD HERMAN I'M AN
ATTORNEY ON GENERAL COUNSEL FOR
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA VERMELHA
DEFENSE CENTER.
BY WAY OF INTRODUCTION I
PREVIOUSLY WORKED AS A
CONSULTANT. FOR THE SENATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SUBCOMMITTEE.
ON LONG RANGE LAND USE PLAN A
THE BACK IN THE SEVENTIES I'VE
STUDIED GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT
THROUGH THE VALLEY FOR THE LAST
THIRTY FIVE YEARS.
AND I'VE LITIGATED UNDER SYKORA
GENERAL PLAN SUBDIVISION AND ALL
THE LAND USE PLANNING AREAS.
IT'S MY PERCEPTION THAT YOUR
STAFF ANALYSIS ADDRESSES ALL OF
THE ISSUES WHICH SERVE SHOULD
SUPPORT A NO PASS AT THIS POINT.
WE HEAR SUPPORT THE PCL
RECOMMENDATION I BELIEVE YOU'VE
HAD OTHER LOVE LETTERS COME IN
FROM THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY.
WHAT THIS REALLY IS IS IT SAY?
FREE PASS FOR LARGE SCALE
DEVELOPMENT AND THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL'S OWN TESTIMONY AND
STATEMENTS SAID HOWEVER.
MOST LARGE HOUSING PROJECTS SUCH
AS WHAT IS NEEDED IN BUTTE
COUNTY.
SO WHAT HE'S TALKING ABOUT IS
LARGE SCALE SUBDIVISION
DEVELOPMENT.
IT'S NOT REALLY FOCUSED ON
INFILL DEVELOPMENT IN FACT THE
STAFF.
ANALYSIS FOR BOTH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE OF THE
ASSEMBLY AND ALSO THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE LISTED ALL OF THE
EMISSIONS THAT YOUR CONSULTANT
ALSO RAISED SO. TO KEEP IT SHORT
SINCE IT'S NEW áP NEW OUR OF
OUR POSITION WOULD BE.
THAT AT THIS POINT.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO DO SOMETHING
WITH THIS BILL OTHER THAN
COMPLETE NO AT THIS POINT.
IT NEEDS TO PROBABLY BE A TO
YOUR BILL IT NEEDS TO GO TO
STUDY IT NEEDS TO TAKE SOME OF
THE IT A DEN OF FIGHT
INFORMATION.
THAT YOU'RE CONSULTANT PRESENTED
IN HER AND ALICE'S AND THAT
NEEDS TO BE FLESHED OUT SO WE
REALLY NEED TO KNOW HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE THERE REALLY THAT ARE
GOING TO BE NEEDING THIS NEW
HOUSING.
WHERE ARE THEY GOING TO NEED TO
BE OR THEY'RE GOING TO
SACRAMENTO OR THEY COME TO CHECK
ON THE OTHER REGIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AREA?
IN THE ARE FOR COUNTY AREA.
OR HAVE THEY ALREADY LEFT.
THE ECONOMIC DISASTER THE DEL
DISASTER ECONOMIC EXPERTS OF
PRESENTED AT CHICO ON MAY NINTH
SAID THAT IN THE FIRST YEAR 50%
OF THEM ARE ALREADY GONE.
IF I WORK FOR A LOOP THE
PLAINTIFFS AGAINST P. JEANNIE I
INTERVIEW THE DISASTER VICTIMS
FROM PARADISE REGULATE.
MANY OF THEM ARE ALREADY GONE
THERE REALLY GOING TO BE GONE
THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE HERE THE
NUMBER THAT IS NEEDED.
TO PROVIDE HOUSING.
FOR AS YOUR ANALYSTS SAID IS
VERY VERY MUCH SMALLER THAN THE
NUMBERS THAT HAVE BEEN PUT ON
THE BOARD BY THE OF THE AUTHOR.
FINALLY I JUST LIKE TO SAY.
ON A PERSONAL LEVEL I WORKED
CLOSELY WITH MR GALLAGHER ON THE
ORVILLE CASE TONIGHT.
HIGHLY RESPECT HIS ABILITY AND
HIS REPRESENTATION OF OUR
DISTRICT OUR OF IN THIS POINT WE
DISAGREE.
THIS IS NOT NEEDED AND AS YOUR
STAFF WARRANT REPORT SHOWS
THERE'S VERY VERY LITTLE SEQUEL
A LITIGATION THAT'S COME OUT OF
THIS IN OUR PARTICULAR AREA.
THERE'S BEEN VERY LITTLE ON A
LARGE SCALE.
OF HOUSING THE ONLY HOUSING
THAT'S BEEN CHALLENGING CHICO
RECENTLY WAS CHALLENGED ON
ISSUES OTHER THAN SEEK WHAT.
AND I ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH THE
POINT THAT WAS MADE THAT THE
GENERAL PLAN PROCESS DOES NOT
ADEQUATELY PROTECT.
THE KIND OF ANALYSIS NEEDS TO BE
DONE PARTICULARLY ON CUMULATIVE.
REGIONAL DEVELOPMENT IMPACTS
SPECIFICALLY AS WELL FROM CARBON
EMISSIONS THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
HAS TRIED REALLY REALLY HARD TO
AVOID IN ORDER TO SAVE.
AN ECO CATASTROPHE.
THANK YOU THINK THE ARGUMENT
THAT IS MADE BY THE SUPPORTERS
OF THE BILL IS THAT -- EVEN IF
SEE WHAT HASN'T BEEN USED TO
CHALLENGE PROJECTS.
IT.
SLOWS DOWN [inaudible]
THE CONSTRUCTION BECAUSE PEOPLE
ARE WORRIED ABOUT PERMITTING AND
AND AND LIABILITY IN THEM AND
PREDICTABILITY AND ALL THE REST.
ACTUALLY WHAT THE EXPERTS SAY --
ON THE SANTA ROSA AND THE OTHER
DISASTER RECOVERY IS IT'S NOT
THE SEQUEL LIMITATION.
IN FACT THE COUNTY EXECUTIVE FOR
BUTTE COUNTY SAID IT THE PRIMARY
PROBLEM IS LACK OF CONSTRUCTION
LABOR.
AND THE HIGH COST OF MATERIALS
THAT'S WHAT'S SLOWING THINGS
DOWN.
IF THIS BILL HAD SOME OF IT
ADDITIONS TO IT THAT SAID WE
WANT TO SUPPORT MORE
CONSTRUCTION TRAINING IT BUTTE
COLLEGE OR AT YUBA COLLEGE OR
SOMETHING ELSE LIKE THAT THEN IT
MIGHT BRING SOMETHING.
WORTHWHILE TO THE TABLE BUT
RIGHT NOW IT'S OVER BROAD.
IT'S EXTREME AND IT SHOULD NOT
BE APPROVED THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT OKAY LET'S
HEAR FROM OTHER FOLKS WHO WANT
TO RAISE OPPOSITION -- CONCERNS
WITH THE BILL.
YES PLEASE I'M GRACE MARVIN I'M
REPRESENT FIFTEEN HUNDRED
MEMBERS OF THIS YEAR CLUB YA HE
GROUP IN VIEW GLAND COLUSA TAME
AND PART OF LASSEN COUNTY.
AND WE FEEL AS WE UNDERSTAND
THIS IS SIERRA CLUB NATIONAL
POSITION.
THAT WE WILL NOT WE DO NOT WANT
TO ACCEPT THIS BILL UNLESS IT IS
SERIOUSLY AMENDED.
WE FEEL THAT FOR THIRTY DOESN'T
GIVE ATTENTION TO THE CUMULATIVE
IMPACTS IN INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
OF HOUSING PROJECTS INCLUDING
EMERGENCY EVACUATION ROUTES.
SEWERS WATER AND ROAD NEDS
WALKWAYS ARE THE EVER GROWING
DANGERS FROM G. AT G. H. G.
EMISSIONS.
THIS COMMITTEE IS ADDRESSING
CLIMATE CHANGES CONSTRUCTIVELY
AS POSSIBLE FOUR THIRTY DOES NOT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME STEVEN
MARK WERE VISITING CENTER AS
MOVEMENT.
AND MANY OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE AND
YOU COUNTY WHO ARE SCARED FOR
OUR FUTURE.
WE KNOW THAT WE'RE FACING
EXISTENTIAL CRISIS IN CLIMATE
CHANGE AND WE NEED SOLUTIONS
THAT ARE GOING TO ADDRESS THAT.
AND DEVELOPMENT IS A KEY PART IN
THAT.
AN INFILL DEVELOPMENT BRING
PEOPLE CLOSER TOGETHER REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS VEHICLE
EMISSIONS.
AND WOOD CONSIDERATE PROTEST
ADDUCTION AND WASTED RESOURCES
IS REALLY KEY AND THIS BILL.
DOES NOT DO THAT WE ARE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF AB.
FOUR THIRTY AND WE BELIEVE THAT.
THIS DOES NOT ADDRESS THE NEED
THAT IT STATES IN THE BILL SAYS
IS HOUSING ASSISTANCE FOR CAMP
ARE REFUGEES.
THE FOLKS THAT NEED HOUSING IT
AFFORDABLE.
LOW AND A HOUSING THIS IS NOT
THAT SOLUTION THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SAM PONZIO AND ON
BEHALF OF BUTTE COUNTY THREE
FIFTY WE STRONGLY OPPOSE A
MINUTE JUST LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
PER MINUTE BUT ISSUE REGARDING
THE PRECEDENT THAT COULD BE.
SEVEN FIVE THE FOR COULD BE SET
REGARDING SEEK WELL BECAUSE
THERE WILL BE MORE CLIMATE
DISASTERS WITHOUT.
A DOUBT THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY ARM.
YES MA'AM YEP.
MORE OF A NEUTRAL TRAINER BUT
MORE COMMON SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA'S HERE CLUB WORKED
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE STAFF
PROTECTIONS ADDED TO THE BILL
AND LIKE SOME A MEMBER GALLAGHER
SAID WE ARE CURRENTLY NEW TROT
THIS TIME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT LOTS HERE THERE'S A
LOT HERE LET ME LET ME -- FIRST
ASK THE AUTHOR -- I HEARD YOU
ACCEPT.
THE A MAN'S D. E. N. F. NOW IT
WAS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT --
YOUR STAFF FOR WAS IN TOUCH WITH
OUR OFFICE -- AND THE THE CHEAP
EXPRESS YOUR AGREEMENT. TO SIX
UNITS IN ACRE AND THEN FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON V. M. T..
IS THAT NOT THE CASE -- WE'VE
BEEN HAVING DISCUSSIONS THIS
MORNING RIGHT KIND OF GOING BACK
AND FORTH A LOT OF THAT WAS
ABOUT TRYING TO REACH KIND OF A
GLOBAL.
ON THESE THREE AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE NOT AGREEING -- TO WE'RE NOT
THERE YET I'M CERTAINLY
COMMITTEE KEEP TALKING IF WE CAN
MOVE THIS BILL FOR TODAY -- BUT
YOU KNOW THAT.
WHAT WAS BEING REQUESTED WAS?
OF THE ANTI REQUIREMENT AND THE
AND THE SIX BILLION PER ACRE
DENSITY.
A REQUIREMENT AND AS I CAN GET
INTO V. AN T. IN MY AREA RIGHT
NOW THERE IS NO DATA.
AVAILABLE FOR SOMEONE TO COMPARE
TO WHAT THE VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED FRIG FRANCES AND I HAVE
EMAILS.
YOU KNOW FROM ALL THE COUNTIES
THAT I CHECKED IN WITH -- FROM
BUTTE AND TAME AND SUTTER --
STARTERS COVER BY SAY BECAUSE
THEY DO HAVE SOME DATA -- BUT
BUTTE AND TO HIM -- WOULD NOT
KNOW HOW TO COMPLY WITH.
THE V. AN T. REQUIREMENT AS AS
AND I WOULD FURTHER NOTE THAT
UNDER THE NEW SEQUEL RULES FOR
ANY SECRET DOCUMENTS GOING FOR
THAT THAT'S NOT A REQUIREMENT
TILL TWENTY TWENTY SO THIS IS
JUST A VERY NEW.
REQUIREMENT THAT YOU KNOW THESE
RURAL AREAS WOULD HAVE A VERY
HARD TIME.
THE OMMITTEE SOMETHING THAT WE
DON'T HAVE DATA FOR AND THAT WE
WOULD KNOW HOW TO REPLY WITH
RIGHT YEAH -- BUT ARE YOU ALSO I
THINK -- MEETING WITH YOU YOU
AGREE -- TO LIKE A PERCENTAGE
CAP I THINK WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
MAX OF 10% [inaudible]
PER CITY.
IN GROWTH THAT WOULD THEY WOULD.
IN UNITS RIGHT -- I'M OPEN TO
DISCUSSION ABOUT A CAP YOU KNOW
WE'D WE YOU AND I BOTH TALKED
ABOUT THAT -- I DON'T KNOW THAT
WE'VE COME TO AN EXACT NUMBER.
YET -- AND THAT'S WHY I'M SAYINGI I HAVE A THING I WANT TO
CONTINUE TO TO TALK ABOUT THAT --
INTEREST BECAUSE THAT THAT
DISCUSSION WAS PART OF CAN A A
GLOBAL AGREEMENT ON THESE THREE
AMENDMENTS THAT THAT I'M NOT
AGREEING TO THEIR IN THAT
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS RIGHT NOW
RIGHT -- OKAY AND I DON'T KNOW
WITHOUT HAVING LIKE ALL THOSE
DETAILS IT'S HARD FOR ME TO SAY
[inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
I GUESS WHAT I AM AT WHAT ASK
YOU ARE YOU SAYING THAT ALL
THOSE THINGS THAT HAVE TO BE
PART OF THIS.
LET ME LET ME INCLUDES A LET ME
JUST SERVICE ARE JUST THE I MEAN
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE ROOM --
WE'VE BEEN ENGAGED IN IN PRETTY
INTENSE DISCUSSIONS ON THIS I
MEAN I THINK.
I THINK THE COMMITTEE'S
PERSPECTIVE IS ALWAYS BAND --
OBVIOUSLY VERY SYMPATHETIC FOR
THE BROADER A CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED WITH.
DISPLACEMENT FROM THE PARADISE
FIRE -- ONE OF THE CHALLENGES OF
COURSE IS.
I WITH SO MANY DIFFERENT CITIES
IN THE MIXERS ALSO QUESTION
ABOUT THE EXTENT TO WHICH ANY
INDIVIDUAL CITY HAS A DIRECT
NEXUS.
I OR OR OR MORE DIRECT NEXUS TO
THE FIRE THE MOST.
DIRECTOR OF ALL THE CITIES IS TO
GO THAT'S WHERE THIS GRAND THE
GREATEST DISPLACEMENT FROM THE
FIRING OF COURSE IS THE ONE CITY
THAT'S ASKED TO BE.
KEPT OUT OF THE BILL BECAUSE
THEY ASKED TO RIGHT I UNDERSTAND
THAT I UNDERSTAND THAT AND I AND
YOU KNOW WE HEARD FROM VOICES
FROM FOLKS FROM CHICO HERE TODAY
ON BOTH SIDES YOU KNOW -- I I
UNDERSTAND THAT [inaudible]
I THAT'S ONE ISSUE OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S THE YOU KNOW THE KIND OF
THE BROADER CHALLENGE OF THIS
COMMITTEE ANYTHING SEEN AS A
GUARDINO SYKORA -- WE DID HAVE A
JOINT HEARING -- WITH THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IT SEVERAL
OF YOU ATTENDED -- YEAH AND AND
THE CARD THE GIST OF THAT
HEARING.
AND THERE'S ALWAYS A LOT OF
ARGUMENT ON BOTH SIDES IS THAT --
YEAH THAT SECRET BEING USED AS A
YOU KNOW AS A JUSTIFICATION --
FOR BASICALLY THE ARE THE
ARGUMENT THE CORE ARGUMENT ABOUT
HEARING AS YOU ALL RECALL WAS
THAT -- WAS THAT.
IT'S IT'S IT'S MISPLACED TO PUT
THE BLAME FOR THE HOUSING CRISIS
ON SEAQUEST [inaudible]
I'M.
NOW YEAH THEY'RE DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES ON THAT -- THERE
ALSO YOU KNOW LOTS OF HOUSING
CHALLENGES UP AND DOWN THE STATE
AND WE GOT ALMOST AS CRISIS AND
ARE ALL OVER THE STATE CERTAINLY
IN OUR CITIES WE HAD A BIG FIRE
IN SANTA ROSA.
CAME UP BY UNDERSTAND AS A
DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCE BUT BUT
CERTAINLY -- EQUALLY SYMPATHETIC
AND DIFFICULT -- AND SO I THINK
PART OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN
GRAPPLING WITH IS -- AND AND AND
AND AND YOU KNOW I'M VERY
COGNIZANT OF THE FACT THAT YOU
KNOW THE BILL FLEW OUT OF THE
ASSEMBLY -- DID NOT HAVE THE
OPPOSITION IS SIERRA CLUB AND
OTHER GROUPS TO HAVE TYPICALLY
OPPOSE MANY ATTEMPTS TO MAKE ANY
CHANGES EQUAL I MEAN THERE IS A
BILL.
THAT -- YOU KNOW WHAT IF.
BASICALLY PUT A A BAD FAITH.
STAND ONE OF YOUR COLLEAGUES --
ON THE SENATE SIDE AND YOU KNOW
AND THERE'S A BILL THE BASICALLY.
I'M CAUGHT A FILE EXISTING
LANGUAGE -- TO TO DISSUADE BAD
FAITH FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS AND AND
SIERRA CLUB POSE THAT.
ASSOCIATED WITH THE C<c.cyan> AND</c>
YET HERE WE HAVE AN EXAMPLE OF A
BLANKET EXEMPTION FOR ALL OF THE
CITY'S -- THAT SEE C<c.cyan> THAT</c>
THAT SIERRA CLUB STILL CV AND A
LOT OF THE OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
OF TYPICALLY OPPOSE ANY CHANGES
THE SEA QUEST -- ARE HAVE NOT
TAKEN A POSITION ON SO THAT CAN
YOU KNOW I I GET THAT AND I
THINK IT'S I THINK IT IS I THINK
IT DOES SPEAK TO THE UNIQUE.
SYMPATHETIC CASE OF THE THE AND
PRACTICE ON THE GROUND ASSOCIATE
WITH THE FIRE I I UNDERSTAND
THAT -- SO I THINK WHAT WE'RE
GRAPPLING WITH HERE IS.
HOW DO WE?
YOU KNOW I'M HOW DO WE YOU TAKE
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE FIRE
WHICH WAS WHICH WAS A HORRIFIC
AND AND AND WE'RE ALL PRAYING AT
THIS IS NOT GOING TO BECOME THE
NEW NORMAL BUT I I I KNOW BUT
BUT WE CERTAINLY NOT TERRIBLE
FIRES IN THE PAST THOUGH.
NEVER WE HAD AN ENTIRE CITY JUST
BURN TO THE GROUND IN THE WAY WE
SAW WITH PARADISE.
AND WE'RE VERY CONCERNED AND
SYMPATHETIC TO TO THE WORK
YOU'RE DOING WITH ALL OF YOUR
LOCAL FOLKS ON TRYING.
TO ADDRESS THE DISPLACEMENT
ISSUES THERE [inaudible]
I WE'VE ENGAGE AS YOU KNOW AND
I'M IN AND LOST HIM TRIED OUT
DISCUSSION ABOUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT OUGHT TO BE DONE
SO THE QUESTION IS YOU KNOW IF
WE'RE GOING TO GRANT AN
EXEMPTION SO CITY SECRET HOW DO
WE MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT --
YOU KNOW HOW.
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
NOT -- HELPING TO PROMULGATE OR
ENCOURAGE.
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT
APPROACHES THAT -- YOU KNOW THAT
THAT ARE THAT ARE NOT IN LINE
WITH A LOT OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
BEST PRACTICES THAT ARE BEING
EMPLOYED UP AND DOWN THE STATE.
AND THAT'S I THINK AT THE HEART
OF A LOT OF THE THE ASKS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE HERE HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT SIMPLY.
CONTRIBUTING TO SPRAWL.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT WE HAVE
TYPICALLY DONE IF YOU LOOK AT
THE BILLS THAT HAVE COME BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE.
THAT HAVE BEEN OPPOSED AS I SAY
BY ALL THESE ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS THAT WE STILL PASSED OUT
OF THE COMMITTEE THAT'S BECAUSE
WE DEMANDED A WHOLE SLEW OF OF
OF MITIGATING ENVIRONMENTAL
FACTORS.
ON THINGS LIKE LEGAL WHICH IS
NOW IN THIS BILL THAT'S AND
THAT'S AN EXCELLENT THING I'LL
BUT ALSO THINGS LIKE.
YOU KNOW -- ZERO NET ENERGY --
VMT REQUIREMENTS -- YOU KNOW
OTHER SORTS OF REQUIREMENTS THAT
DIRECTLY RELATE TO A KIND OF
REALLY ENVIRONMENTAL BEST
PRACTICES IN ALL OF THOSE BILLS
RELATED DIRECTLY -- TO TO
ASPECTS OF THE HOUSING CRISIS
AND AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ISSUES THAT.
AND BY THE WAY THOSE BY THE WAY
WERE OWN WE'RE WE'RE ONLY
JUDICIAL EXPEDITED REVIEW AS
OPPOSED TO A STRAIGHT UP
EXEMPTION ALTOGETHER -- SO
THAT'S THE CHALLENGE HERE I
THINK I THINK THAT'S WHAT WORK
WERE KIND OF GRAPPLING WITH I
GUESS -- YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW
YOU MAY VERY WELL HAVE -- THE
VOTES TO GET THIS OUT JUST AS IT
IS -- I THINK FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW ON I AM.
YOU KNOW I I I I IE IF YOU WELL.
I SUPPOSE.
WHAT WOULD BE IMPORTANT ME?
IN ADDITION TO D. E. AND F.
WHICH YOU AGREE TO FOR NOT GOING
TO GO WITH A B. AND C.
[inaudible]
I AM.
I WOULD WANT TO KIND OF GO BACK
TO WHAT I AT LEAST THOUGHT WAS
SOME OF THE CORE PRINCIPLES THAT
WE AGREED ON IN ARE CLOSED OR
CONVERSATIONS. SIXTEEN IT'S AN
ACRE.
I'M AND THEN [inaudible]
A CAP.
RIGHT TO THE THAT WE WE MAKE
SURE THIS DOESN'T JUST BECOME AN
ABSOLUTE RAMPANT -- GROWTH.
BEYOND BEYOND THE SCOPE THAT I
THINK ANY OF US THINK IS LIKELY
TO HAPPEN.
AND I REAL ROBUST FOR THE
DISCUSSION AND YET BE ANTI AND
WITH WITH US FOR A WHOLE WITH
HOLDING A RITE.
OF BRINGING THIS BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE IF WE'RE NOT ABLE.
TO ADDRESS THE V. M. T. ISSUES --
THAT THE THERE WE HAVE.
AND YOU KNOW WITH OUR COMMITTEE
COMMITTING TO A GOOD FAITH
DISCUSSION -- WITH TRYING TO GET
TO YES ON ON SOMETHING IT'S
MEANINGFUL I THINK.
THEREFORE GONNA GRANT A SECRET
ACTION ON THIS THE ANTI ISSUE I
THINK IS VERY IMPORTANT US
BECAUSE IT REALLY SPEAKS TO YOU --%
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
DOUBLING DOWN ON BAD PLANNING
PRACTICES.
NOW AS I SAY IF IF THE VOTES ARE
THERE FOR YOU TO GET THIS OUT OF
COMMITTEE.
ARE WITHOUT HAVING TO MAKE THOSE
KINDS OF COMMITMENTS.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE VERY WELCOME.
TO ODD TO TO TO GO THAT
DIRECTION AND I'M I CERTAINLY
WON'T BE OFFENDED I MEAN I I I
THAT WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
AND AND I THINK YOU GET WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO AND IT'S A
TOUGH BALANCE THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO STRIKE HERE -- BUT IF NOT ARE
YOU KNOW I CERTAINLY CAN
COMMITTEE YOU.
TO A REALLY GOOD FAITH
DISCUSSION ABOUT ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT WE JUST THAT I JUST
OUTLINED.
AND TRYING TO GET TO A PLACE
WHERE WE REALLY CAN ALL FEEL
COMFORTABLE -- AND AND I THINK
WE DON'T HAVE TO OF COURSE BRING
ALL THE OTHER NUMBERS INTO THAT
DISCUSSION BASED ON WHERE
EVERYONE IS TODAY.
SO AS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE WOULD.
WHATEVERWE WERE ALLOWED TO MOVE
FOR IT WOULD REALLY BE IN ACCORD
WITH AT LEAST A MAJORITY OF THE
COMMITTEE'S WISHES.
SO THAT'S WHERE I AM.
BUT I CERTAINLY WANT TO HEAR
FROM MY OTHER COLLEAGUES -- THIS
IS A TOUGH TOUGH BILL A TOUGH
ISSUE TOUGH YEAH CHALLENGE
YOU'RE FACING IN YOUR REGION --
I THINK IT I WILL SAY TO ALL THE
ADVOCATES HERE ON BOTH SIDES OF
THIS ISSUE THE YOU REALLY DO
HAVE A DOG -- AND COMMITTED
ADVOCATE IN IN IN THE IN THE
CELL NUMBER I MEAN REALLY DOES
CARE A GREAT DEAL ABOUT.
ABOUT HIS DISTRICT ABOUT THESE
COMMUNITIES IN ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES THAT THEY FACE AND
YOU KNOW I ADMIRE YOUR TENACITY
IN SPIRIT.
AND A COMMITMENT TO TO TO DOING
RIGHT BY YOUR BY YOUR
CONSTITUENTS WHICH WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
YOU REALLY ARE DOING RIGHT.
BY THESE TOWNS -- AND AND THAT
IF WE ARE GOING TO BE DOING.
pTHERE REALLY ARE THERE THERE
REALLY IS AN ENVIRONMENTAL
MITIGATION IT REALLY IS AN
OFFSET.
AT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE WE'RE
DOING RIGHT BY -- THESE
COMMUNITIES ON THE ENVIRONMENTAL
SIDE SO I WITHOUT A LOVE TO OPEN
THE FLOOR TO DISCUSSION AND
CENTER HEALTH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND AND
THANKS FOR THE DISCUSSION I
APOLOGIZE IT DID NOT HEAR THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OPENING
COMMENTS BUT I DID HEAR A LOT OF
THE TESTIMONY I A OF AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AND
DIRECTIONS AYE AYE WILLING
FRANKLY TO MOVE THE BILL.
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS.
THE AMENDMENTS THAT HE'S TAKEN
BUT I DO UNDERSTAND YOUR CONCERN
AND THE ISSUE AND I DID HEAR
FROM THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT
HE'S WILLING.
TO CONTINUE A CONVERSATION WITH
YOU WHAT IT WHAT IS IT WILL GO
FROM HERE.
ELEMENTS FINANCE OF INCH WELL
OKAY SO I MEAN THERE IS TIME TO
DO THAT THERE IS TO IT HEARD AND
THAT I FREE AND I THINK THAT'S
AN IMPORTANT.
ASPECT OF IT BECAUSE YOU KNOW IS
I'VE READ THROUGH THIS IN AS I
VISITED PARADISE AND I WENT
THROUGH THOSE TOWNS THE IN THE
AREA AND SAW THEM I I I GUESS
I'M KIND OF STRUCK WITH THE
DEVASTATION THAT I SAW THE
CHALLENGES THAT THE RESIDENTS
ARE FACING NOW.
LIVING IN CHICO AND THE OTHER
CITIES.
IN IN CONDITIONS THAT ARE -- ARE
CHALLENGING HAVE NOTHING ELSE I
MEAN THEY'RE THEY'RE VERY
DESPERATE.
AND AS I HEARD THE OPPOSITION
TALK ABOUT THE UNPRECEDENTED
NATURE OF THIS WELL AS THE
AMPLIFIERS WERE UNPRECEDENTED.
AND THEY LEFT COMMUNITIES YEAH
I'M IN THE TOWN OF PARADISE
COMPLETELY DESTROYED.
AND HOW CAN WE NOT LOOK AT
TRYING TO FIND A SOLUTION WHEN.
IT.
THE ISSUE OF TAKING.
SAY GOING TO GRIDLEY OR BIGGER
SUMMIT OR ORVILLE.
AND ALLOWING THIS I'VE
UNDERSTAND IN THE FEMA.
TRAILERS ARE GOING TO BE BUILT
IN WHICH CITY OF MASTIC.
GRIDLEY AND HOW MANY OF THEM DO
WE HAVE. FOR FOUR HUNDRED UNIT
HUNDRED UNITS ARE BEING BUILDING
GREATLY RIGHT NOW OF TRAILERS
THAT WILL BE THERE FOR A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME.
AND WHEN THOSE EXPIRE AND AND
WHEN THEY'RE GONE THEY'RE GONE
THOSE PEOPLE WILL BE WITHOUT
HOME.
AND I THINK IT'S INCUMBENT UPON
US TO DO SOMETHING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT THEY'RE NOT LEFT
HOMELESS AGAIN -- AND IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO DO IS THE
FEAR OF SPRAWL TO ME I THINK IS.
IS -- I MEAN THIS SIX DISC
SUNSET IN TWENTY TWENTY SIX HOW
MANY HOMES ARE WE GOING TO BUILD
IN THAT LENGTH OF TIME.
YOUR QUESTION IS NOT ENOUGH THAT
WILL MAKE YOU KNOW CREATE THIS
FOR ALL THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THIS I SEE IT -- THE A LARGE
SCALE DEVELOPMENTS THESE ARE
PEOPLE WHO LIVED IN SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES WITH A LOT OF A
CREATURE AROUND THEM YEAH THE
IDEA OF THEM MOVING INTO TRACK
HOMES IS THIS NOT SOMETHING THAT
I CAN SEE.
AS A POSSIBILITY AND I LOOK AT
THE CONDITIONS THAT ARE THAT ARE
ON HERE AND AND TO ME.
THE MOST VALUED ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATION.
IN CALIFORNIA IS A SIERRA CLUB.
AND THEY'VE TAKEN A NEUTRAL
POSITION BECAUSE THEY RESPECT
THE WORK THAT THE AUTHOR HAS
DONE IN IN IDENTIFYING IN LAYING
OUT THOSE CONDITIONS OF WHERE
THIS BILL COULD WORK YEAH.
SO I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL
AND SUPPORTED TO THAT THAT
CONVERSATION CAN CONTINUE NOW
CAN GET TO A COMFORT SPOT FOR
YOU IN THE COMMITTEE THAT YOU
SHARE -- BUT I DO THINK THAT BY
NOT MOVING THIS BILL FORWARD
WE'RE LEAVING AND DESERT IN A
COMMUNITY THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN.
BEEN.
DEVASTATED BY WHAT IS HAPPENING
I WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR IF IF.
YOU KNOW WITHOUT INITIAL EVEN
YOU KNOW IF IF IF IF IT TURNS
OUT A MAJORITY THE COMMITTEE IS
COMFORTABLE WITH.
THE BILL AS IT IS AND AND YOU
KNOW A WITH WITH YOU KNOW WITH
IMMENSELY HE'S AGREED.
TO AND I'M NOT GONNA BUT IF I
COULD JUST ADD O THAT I AGREE
WITH YOU MISTER MISTER CHAIR BUT
I THINK.
KNOWING THE AUTHORS I DO HE'D
WANT TO WORK WITH YOU AFTER THE
FACT ANYHOW IT BECAUSE THIS BILL
WILL GO TO THE FLOOR.
AND AND HE WANTS TO DO THE RIGHT
THING ABSOLUTELY THE THE
CHALLENGES BàN [inaudible]
OUR I DON'T THINK IT'S ANY AS AS
ANY TO DO WITH THE WITH THE THE
GOOD FAITH OF THE AUTHOR I THINK
THE CHALLENGES SPEND JUST --
SOME DISAGREE JUST KIND OF CORE
DISAGREEMENTS ABOUT -- ABOUT.
THE ROLE OF SEA QUEST I AM NINE
NINE AND AND AND I THINK WE
SHARE THOSE VALUES YEAH YEAH.
OKAY -- YES I REQUEST YOU KNOW I
GOT THAT.
OKAY -- TO LET ME LET ME ASK YOU
ONE OTHER QUESTION BY THE WAY
YEAH.
YOU MENTIONED THE DOLLARS HAS TO
BE DONE WITHIN CITY LIMITS
IMMEDIATE.
I'VE I'VE GOTTEN REALLY INTO THE
GENERAL PLANS OF ALL THE CITY'S
INVOLVED A WONDERFUL.
I ALSO ENVY THE COLOR PRINTING
WHICH WE DON'T GET IN OUR
OFFICES -- I PROVIDED TO THE AYE
FOR YOU THAT I'M A GREAT FAN
YEAH PROBABLY REPORTABLE GIFT --
NOW LET ME ASK YOU YOU YOU WERE
SAYING THAT EVERY HAS TO BE
WITHIN THIS THAT THE CITY LIMITS.
THERE AT LEAST IN PLACES LIKE
YUBA CITY BUT ALSO ELSEWHERE
THERE'S AN INTERESTING IDEA OF A
SPHERE OF INFLUENCE I LOVE TO
HAVE IN THE SPHERE OF INFLUENCE.
OVER ON THE COMMITTEE YOU KNOW
BUT BUT WHAT WHAT IS THAT WE'RE
DECIDED TO PLAY WITH THE BILL
AND CITY LIMITS VERSUS SPHERE OF
INFLUENCE.
SO BUSTER OF INFLUENCES COMMON
YOU KNOW CITIES WILL HAVE A
SPHERE OF INFLUENCE IS KIND OF
LIKE WHERE THEY WOULD LIKE. TO
POSSIBLY GO IN THE FUTURE BUT IT
HASN'T BEEN ANNEXED.
INTO THE CITY LIMITS OKAY SO
UNDER THIS BILL IT DOESN'T ALLOW
YOU TO BUILD.
CARTE BLANCHE IN THE SPHERE OF
INFLUENCE IT EITHER HAS TO BE IN
THE CITY LIMITS.
OR IT HAS TO BE A SPECIALLY
PLANNED RESIDENTIAL AREA THAT
CONTAINED IN THE CITY'S GENERAL
PLAN.
NOW CAN YOU BE IN THE SPHERE OF
INFLUENCE AND IN THE GENERAL
PLAN.
YES YOU CAN BE HOW DOES THAT
WORK IN IN INTERACTION WITH THE
THE COUNTY GOVERNMENT.
WELL YOU HAVE TO GO TO A LAUGH
CO PROCESS TO ANNEX THAT
PROPERTY INTO THE CITY LIMITS.
OKAY SO AT THAT POINT.
IT WOULD HAVE TO BE ADDED TO THE
CITY LIMITS TO BE ABLE TO
ULTIMATELY ENJOY THE RIGHT WELL
I MEAN IF THEY'VE HAD IF THEY'VE
PLANTED IN THEIR GENERAL PLAN AS
A SPECIALIZED RESIDENTIAL ZONE.
THAT'S WHAT THE LANGUAGE SAYS
THEN THAT WOULD BE ELIGIBLE
RIGHT -- BUT I MEAN YOU CAN LOOK
THROUGH ALL THOSE DIFFERENT
GENERAL PLANS FOR EXAMPLE FOR
EXAMPLE BIGGS.
HAS.
WE OWE IT SPHERE OF INFLUENCE
RIGHT BUT MUCH OF THAT LAND IS
ZONED AGRICULTURAL.
IN THE GENERAL PLAN AND THEN IT
HAS.
AN AREA WHERE THAT IS SORT OF
HAS AN AG BUFFER IF YOU WILL AND
A LOT OF CITIES HAVE THIS -- IN
MY AREA ANYWAY.
WHICH UP WHEN I WAS BUT WE WERE
95% AGRICULTURE LAND USE.
WHAT ARE YOUR LIKE THE POSTER
CHILD FOR NOT SPRAWLING AND IN
MY AREA BUT IN BUT -- NO IN
THESE GENERAL PLANS LIKE THEY
OFTEN WILL HAVE THAT AG BUFFER
SO THEY DON'T TAKE UP THEY DON'T
GO ALL THE WAY OUT TO THE
POTENTIAL SPHERE OF INFLUENCE
THEY JUST PLAN CERTAIN AREAS
THAT MAKES SENSE.
YEAH -- NEXT TO IT EXISTING
DEVELOPMENT OF THIS IS THIS IS
WHY I LOVE THIS JOB BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE.
AG BUFFERS IN TORRANCE IN SANTA
MONICA SO -- YEAH I'M LEARNING A
LOT HERE SO -- THE SENATE DOLLY.
MR CARED.
THANK YOU.
FOR DOING THE GOOD WORK YOU'RE
DOING AYE.
I'M A CO AUTHOR ON THE BILL.
I'D LIKE TO COMMITTEE TO KNOW
THAT I LOST. ELEVEN THOUSAND MY
CONSTITUENTS IN MIGUEL YEAH.
WERE AFFECTED BY THIS FIRE AND
SO.
THIS IS NEAR AND DEAR TO MY
HEART AND I ALSO SERVE MANY
YEARS JUST LIKE A SIMILAR
GALLAGHER YOU'RE DEAD ON THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
AND DID DEALT WITH -- LAUGHTER
CQ A LAUGH GO OPEN SPACE.
ALL THE THINGS THAT ALMOST ONE
AM DROP HECKSCHER FOR YOU FOR
THOSE MEMBERS WHO DON'T HAVE
VAST AMOUNTS OF OPEN SPACE IN
YOUR COUNTIES OR CITIES.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE NUMBER IS
IN BUTTE COUNTY BUT I CAN TELL
YOU IN MY COUNTY WHERE I COME
FROM. 65% OF THE COUNTY IS OWNED
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
WILL NEVER BE DEVELOPED AND I
WILL GUARANTEE THAT THERE'S A
GOOD PART OF BUTTE.
AND THESE OTHER COUNTIES THAT
ARE ZONED ACT WHICH ARE.
LOTS HAVE CONSERVATION IS ON
WILL NEVER BE DEVELOPED AND SO
WE TALK ABOUT SPRAWL YOU TALK
ABOUT VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED.
IN THESE ARE RULE COMMUNITIES
WERE.
THIS IS NOT THE SAME AS WHAT.
MOST PEOPLE THINK OF WHEN WE GO
TO DO DEVELOPMENT IN.
URBAN AREAS AND SO I ALSO WANT.
TO CURRENTLY THAT OUT HERE.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS A CARP
LAUNCH SEQUEL EXEMPTION HE'S
TAKEN ALL KINDS OF AMENDMENTS TO
NARROW THIS THING DOWN.
TO TAKE CARE OF THE FIFTEEN
THOUSAND FIFTEEN THOUSAND HOMES.
THAT.
WERE DESTROYED IN ONE DAY.
SO.
AND I HAVE I'VE MET WITH THESE
PEOPLE AND YOU KNOW YEAH THEY
MIGHT NOT BE THERE YOUR NUMBERS
MIGHT NOT HAPPEN BECAUSE THERE'S
NO PLACE TO GO.
DOES THAT MEAN THAT THEY DON'T
WANT TO COME BACK THERE DOES
THAT MEAN THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
ROOTS IN THAT COMMUNITY I BEG TO
DIFFER I'VE I HAVE A LOT OF MY
CONSTITUENTS WHO.
ARE IN REDDING I I REPRESENT
READING AND HAD A LOT OF MY
CONSTITUENTS WHO WERE MIGUEL YOU
ARE IN READING RIGHT NOW.
SO WE'VE TOGETHER THE TWO OF US
HAVE TRIED TO DIVIDE UP THE
PIECES LEGISLATION.
I WORKED ON A SOLAR EXEMPTION.
FOR AND WHICH WAS IN FRONT OF
THIS -- ENERGY COMMITTEE SORRY.
AND WE'VE NARROWED THESE THINGS
DOWN I HAVE OPPOSITION FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS ON MOST.
OF MY LEGISLATION I WORK ON WHEN
IT COMES TO NATURAL RESOURCES.
WE WERE MY POINT IS IS THAT I
THINK THAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HAS DONE A GREAT JOB OF BEING
REALISTIC HERE AND COMMONSENSE
APPROACH TO THIS.
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
AND ALSO LIKE.
TO POINT OUT THAT [inaudible]
SOME.
THE NEED TO VISIT THE COMMUNITY
IF YOU HAVE AND I KNOW MANY OF
YOU HAVE BEEN THERE AND SO WE DO
WE DO TO SEE WHAT EXEMPTIONS.
WE DON'T FOR THE KINGS ARENA WE
DO IT.
FOR DAYS ARENA WHEN THERE'S A
LOTTA.
WEALTH IN LOT OF POLITICAL JUICE
THAT COMES IN AND TESTIFIES IT.
AND THE SEEMS TO GET DONE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A COMMUNITY
OF REALLY POOR PEOPLE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT OTHER
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED BY ORVILLE WE'VE HAD A
LOT OF DAMAGE IN OUR AREA AND SO
I THINK THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
APPROACH.
TO GETTING TO WHERE WE WERE
TRYING TO GO.
THE SPHERES OF INFLUENCE ARE
GOING TO BE BUILT IN UNLESS
THERE IS A PLAN DEVELOPMENT AT
ARI'S BEEN.
RATIFIED BY THE LOCAL BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OR THE CITY.
HAS BEEN THROUGH A GENERAL PLAN.
IT'S YOUR PARTY OR GENERAL PLAN
SO -- I'M GLAD THAT WE I THINK
THIS BILL WILL GET OUT HERE
TODAY WITHOUT TAKING MEMBERS I
AND I'VE BEEN HERE WHERE YOU'RE
AT ASSEMBLYMEMBER WHERE YEAR.
IF YOU TAKE ALL THE MINUTES
YOU'RE NOT GONNA GET WHERE YOU
WANT TO GO SO WHAT'S THAT WHAT
THE HECK YOU YOU LOSE EITHER WAY
AND I AND I THINK THERE IS MAYBE
SOME ROOM VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
IS.
IT'S NOT THE SAME AS WHERE YOU
HAVE MASS TRANSIT WHERE YOU CAN
ACTUALLY DO THESE KIND OF THINGS.
THIS IS NOT THERE SENATE LIVING
PLEASE CAR FIVE TWO THINGS FIRST
OF ALL ON THE ARENA'S DID NOT
GET AN EXEMPTION RIGHT THEY GOT
EXPEDITED REVIEW SO THEY STILL
HAD TO PART OF THIS CONVERSATION
AND IT WAS REJECTED BY THE
AUTHOR.
ON THE VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED ME
CLARIFY THAT AS WELL.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT --
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED -- ET IN
IT IN COMPARISON WITH URBAN
AREAS OR SUBURBAN AREAS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE SO THE WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT HOW IT HOW THE
VEHICLE MUST TRAVEL IN A RELEASE
WITH THIS AREA.
SO THAT COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE -- SO
CITY WE DID DID THE THE PROJECTS
WOULD ONLY BE COMPARED TO THE TO
TO TO THE TO THE EXISTING.
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED PATTERNS.
OF THAT COUNTY OF THAT REGION.
SO THAT.
GOES TO MAKE IT TO TOAST TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT HIS ROUGHLY RIGHT RURAL
AREAS HAVE HIGHER VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED THERE LONGER COMMUTES
NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
SO I JUST A I I HEAR YOU AND I I
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THOSE TWO
THINGS ARE CLARIFIED WELL THE
MINUTE WAS TO REQUIRED TO BE 15%
BELOW THE REGIONAL AVERAGE WHICH
IF YOU'RE REGIONAL AVERAGE NOT
CITY RIGHT BUT IF YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE REGION ADDRESS.
AVERAGES AND WHEN WE DO
[inaudible]
WE DO.
I ONLY TRANSPORTATION AGENCY
THAT HAS DONE -- IS SAY COX'S
SAY CAUGHT DOES ENCOMPASS SUTTER
COUNTY WHICH WOULD INCLUDE BE
THE CITY IN LIVE OAK -- BE CAG
WHICH IS A PLAN AGES THE COVERS
BUTTE COUNTY WHERE MOST OF THE
CITIES ARE AND TO HIM A COUNTY
WERE CORNING IS.
DOES NOT.
HAVE THAT DATA YET SO THERE'D.
EACH COULD DO AN ANALYSIS
PERHAPS ON WHAT YOUR VEHICLE
MILES ARE GOING TO BE BUT YOU
HAVE NOTHING TO COMPARE IT TO
CAUSE A REGIONAL THE ANTI HAS
NOT BEEN ESTABLISHED YET.
IN.
YEAH I KNOW THAT'S NOT CAR
BELONG SEEK WAS.
YOURS DURING THE SEASON THERE'S
A THERE'S A LOT OF THIS BUILDING
NOW DOWN A LOT OF THE TIME TO
GET. TO THE PLACE WHERE HE'S OUT
WHERE WE HAVE.
MAJOR ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS GOING
NEUTRAL AND I THINK I CAN I
COMMEND YOU FOR THAT I THINK
THIS IS A GREAT BILL.
AND I THINK YOU KNOW WE HAVE A
HOUSING CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA AND
I'M NOT GONNA SAY IT'S ALL
SEQUEL.
THERE ARE A LOT OF REASONS WHY
WE HAVE.
PROBLEMS WITH HOUSING CALIFORNIA
AND I THINK SEEK WORK IN IS A
PIECE OF IT BUT THERE ARE MANY
OTHER THINGS WHICH WE WE KNOW.
WE ADDRESS THAT BUT WE HAVE
HOUSING PRICES WE HAVE DISPLACED
PEOPLE.
THAT ARE WANTING TO COME BACK TO
THEIR COMMUNITY AND IT IS WAS A
DEVASTATING.
THE FIRE AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN
GET THIS BILL PASSED AND SIGNED
BY THE GOVERNOR ND WE CAN BUILD
SOME HOMES FOR THOSE FOLKS.
AND LITTLE IN LEGAL THIS YOU SAY
IS VERY SIGNIFICANT AS ONE ONE
OF THE ARGUMENTS WE MADE OVER
AND OVER AGAIN WITH THE BILLS
THAT WE LET -- THIS COMMITTEE --
SO I AM NOT A MASTER.
A VERY QUICKLY -- AS TIME GOES I
THINK WE'VE AID MOST EXCEPT I
JUST WANNA MAKE UP.
A COMPARISON MY CONCERN IS
CERTAINLY SPRAWL BUT IT'S
CERTAINLY DENSIFICATION AND THEY
AMENDMENT THAT WAS SUGGESTING
HERE IS A HUGE DENSIFICATION OF
AREAS THAT ARE VERY RURAL IN
NATURE.
SO I THINK WE HAVE TO BE SEEKING
BALANCE BETWEEN THOSE TWO THINGS
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER DID WHEN HE PUT.
FORTH TAUGHT WHAT HE WOULDLIKE
TO SEE IN TERMS OF THE MINIMUM
AND MAXIMUM NUMBER OF ACRE SAND
THE MINIMUM NUMBER OF UNITS PER
ACRE.
WHAT'S IN HERE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT -- TWO HUNDRED UNITS ON A
TEN ACRE PLOT I MEAN THAT GIVES
YOU OUT ONE TAMPA NACRE THESE
ARE THESE OF THE STAFF IS
STACKED FLAT SMALL TOLD FAMILY.
AND I THINK YOU HAVE TO PROVIDE
SOME SORT OF A VERY OFTEN I
THINK THAT'S WHAT HE'S LOOKING.
FOR A IN THE MANNER IN WHICH
HE'S APPROACH THERE SO I THINK
THAT WE SHOULD PASS ADELPHIA'S
AND HAVE HIM CONTINUE TO WORK
THROUGH THAT FILL.
YOUR RELATING YOU'RE RELIEVING
THE CONCERNS ABOUT SPRAWL BUT AT
THE SAME TIME YOU'RE PROVIDING
THE KIND A HABITAT.
THAT REALLY FOSTERS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN AS COMPARED TO OUR WORK
FORCE AND THAT'S REALLY GOOD
PLANNING AND I THINK HE'S BUILT
FROM.
WHICH SEEK WHICH TRIES TO DO AND
I THINK IN A RATHER ARCHAIC WAY
FRANKLY A WE SHOULD LET THE
PLANNER SANDY AND THE CITY.
AND THERE'S OWNING AND THEIR SUB
THERE -- SUBDIVISION MAP TRACKS
ALL OF THAT HAS BEEN PUT IN
PLACE FOR EONS TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE YOU KNOW GREAT COMMUNITIES
DOES NEED TO BE AMENDED I AS
TIMES CHANGE BUT NOT TO THE
DRAMATIC THE THAT'S BEING
PRESENTED HERE IN THE MEMO SO I
THINK YOU GUYS ARE WORKING.
ON IT HI I'M TOTALLY SUPPORTIVE.
OF WHAT TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER IS DOING AND CERTAINLY
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS CHAIRMAN TO
TRY.
TO YOU KNOW KIND OF TIGHT END UP
FOR BOTH SIDES OF THE ISSUE SO.
I'LL LET.
CALL THE QUESTION OKAY.
OKAY.
SEE THAT MAN OF AYE SIR -- DOES
IT FROM MARKHAM JUST FOR FOLKS
TO KNOW FROM OUR CONVERSATIONS
LOW PR.
I'M ON THIS UNITY ISSUE YOU KNOW
ULTIMATELY THEY JUST NEED TO
HAVE A A MODEL RUN THE CAR CAN
DO IT A TRANSPORTATION
CONSULTING CAN DO IS GUIDE AS
MAP SHOWING EXISTING.
LOCATIONS A QUALIFY NOT BASED ON
THE PROJECT AND THEY DON'T HAVE
A MAP AND THEY CAN RUN A MODEL
SO THERE ARE WAYS TO DO IT AND
WE CAN WE CAN HAVE A
CONVERSATION.
ON THE OTHER THING BY THE WAY --
THIS PROFESSOR THAT I WAS
REFERRING -- TO YOU COULD YOU
CAN IF ANY OF I KNOW A LOT OF
CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS HERE -- YOU
CAN WALK YOU THROUGH YOUR
OPTIONS IN TERMS OF ZONING AND
BY RIGHT IN.
THE CENTER PLAY WAS HE WAS A
GENTLEMAN NAMED KENNETH STALL AS
T. . H. L. HE'S PROFESSOR
CHAPMAN LAW SCHOOL AND YOU CAN
LOOK THEM UP ONLINE.
AND HIS NUMBERS THERE YET SHE
PICKS UP THE CLIP THE CALLS AND
BUT IS IT IS AN INTERESTING
PERSON TO TALK TO YOU IF YOU'RE
RUNNING INTO -- IF YOU WANT TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE THE
INTERESTING INTERPLAY BETWEEN
ZONING IN AND BY RIGHT IN SECRET
EXEMPTIONS -- OR OR JUST
AVOIDING SEAQUEST THROUGH -- FOR
FOR FOR FOR PROJECTS AND IN
DOING IT WITHIN THE THE CURRENT
LEGAL STRUCTURE -- CENTER CASKET.
I COULDN'T CONTROL MYSELF MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
THIS IS REALLY HARD IS THERE
ANYTHING IN THIS BILL THAT WOULD
ENCOURAGE SUGGEST.
THE MAN REQUIRE TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT [inaudible]
ANYTHING [inaudible]
OF NO.
IS THERE ANYTHING IN THIS BILL
THAT WOULD REQUIRE DENSER
DEVELOPMENT IN ANY OF THE SIX
CITIES ARE EIGHT CITIES THAT YOU
HAVE.
IT WOULD REQUIRED.
DENSER DEVELOPMENT ALTHOUGH IT
DOES HAVE A MINIMUM DENSITY
AFFORDABLE AND UNITS PER ACRE.
AND IT HAS A MAXIMUM ACREAGE OF
FIFTY ACRES [inaudible]
NOTWITHSTANDING THE LEAVES
CERTIFICATION WHICH WOULD
PRECLUDE THE CITY FROM APPROVING
BY MINISTERIAL APPROVAL.
MORE DENSER DEVELOPMENTS IN THAT
AT ALL.
AND THAT WOULD HAPPEN THAT WOULD
HAPPEN AT THE ONE PUBLIC HEARING
THAT IS NOW REQUIRED THE IMAGE
THAT AMENDMENT DE THAT YOU'RE
TAKING -- WELL THAT'S ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT I'M TAKING TODAY
YES -- BUT THAT THAT
CONSIDERATION WOULD BE AT THAT
ONE HEARING NO THAT WOULD I MEAN
IT'S IN THE BILL.
THERE HAS TO BE A AT LEAST FOR
DWELLING UNITS PER ACRE
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
I'M.
OTHER THAN THE LEAN
CERTIFICATION IS THERE ANYTHING
IN THE BILL THAT REQUIRES BETTER
HOUSING.
WHAT'S NEW BUT IS THERE ANYTHING
REQUIRES BETTER HOUSING BECAUSE
WE HAVE ALL KINDS OF CRITERIA --
WELL EVERYTHING THAT WOULD BE
BUILT UNDER THIS BILL IS BEING
BUILT TO THE MODERN -- CODE
WHICH INCLUDES A GREEN BUILDING
CODES -- EVERYTHING IN THAT
WOULD BE APPROVED UNDER THIS --
COULD NOT BE BILL TOM ON
WETLANDS -- IT COULD NOT BE
BUILT ON ANYTHING THAT AFFECTED
HABITAT -- COULD NOT BE BUILT A
IN IN AREAS THAT WOULD BE.
CONSIDERED.
THERE ARE DANGERS POSED BY
FLOODING OR WILD FIRE HAZARD --
SO.
I WOULD SAY IN ALL AS RESPECTS
IT IT.
IT INCENTIVIZE IS.
GOOD AND RESPONSIBLE HOUSING
GROWTH NOW IT HAS TO BE IN THE
CITY LIMITS LIKE SO IT CAN'T GO
UNDER THE UNINCORPORATED PARTS.
OF THE COUNTY.
YEAH I THINK WE HAD TALKED ABOUT --
YOU KNOW I THINK THEIR TESTS
FIND AT THE CITY'S HADN'T DONE
ANYTHING TO START WORKING ON
AMENDMENTS SITTERS SPECIFIC PLAN
TO GENERAL PLANS OR ANY OF THESE
OTHER TOOLS WELL THEY ALL HAVE
GENERAL PLANS BY AND THEY HAD
AND SOME OF THEM HAVE SPECIFIC
PLANS.
FOR HOUSING PROJECTS WE WE HAD
WE HAD LAST YEAR WE HAD MISTER
AT SOME NUMBER WOULD HAD A BILL
FROM SANTA ROSA THAT.
TALKED ABOUT -- X. EXPEDITED
JUDICIAL REVIEW BUT THEY HAD A
YOU KNOW THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT
AMENDMENTS TO THEIR DOWNTOWN
STATION AREA PLAN THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT AMENDMENTS TO THE
RED ZONE AREA THAT THEY HAD THEY
HAD SPECIFIC PLANS.
IN THIS WITHIN THE CITY ALREADY
THAT THEY WANTED.
TO EXPEDITE DE ARE PLANNING
PROCESS IN THE END IN ORDER TO
CREATE MORE DENSITY TO CREATE
MORE HOUSING IS THERE ANYTHING
IN THIS BILL THAT HAS ANYTHING
SIMILAR TO THAT.
SO WE'VE DONE THE SAME THING IN
A DIFFERENT WAY OKAY.
SENATOR DOLLY CENTER NIELSEN AND
I SINCE DAY ONE HAVE BEEN
TALKING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
I'VE BEEN TALKING TO
STAKEHOLDERS COMMUNITY GROUPS
NON PROFITS -- AND WE HAVE A
PACKAGE THE LEGISLATION OF WHICH
THIS IS ONE BILL.
I HAVE WORKED WITH THAT'S WHY
EVERY LOCAL GOVERNMENT THAT'S
AFFECTED BY THIS BILL SUPPORTS
THIS BILL THAT.
AND WE'VE WE'VE LOOKED AT THEIR
GENERAL PLANS AS WELL I PROVIDED --
THE CHAIRMAN WITH.
EVERY SINGLE GENERAL PLANETS
AFFECTED BY THESE -- BECAUSE
WE'VE LOOKED AT THIS AND SAID
HEY HERE'S WHERE WE'VE PLAN FOR
GROWTH.
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF WHERE WE
HAVE ALREADY PLAN FOR GROWTH IN
TRYING TO EXPEDITE HOUSING.
IN AREAS THAT WE HAVE ALREADY
APPROVED -- IN ALL THESE LOW AND
THAT'S WHY ALL THESE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FOLKS GOT UP HERE I
HAVE I HAVE WORK SO CLOSELY.
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS THAT I'VE TAKEN A
CITY OUT THEY SAID THEY DIDN'T
WANT TO PARTICIPATE.
THAT'S HOW COOPERATIVE I'VE BEEN
FROM DAY -- ONE SO TO ANYBODY'S
POINT THAT I HAVEN'T BEEN
WORKING COOPERATIVELY WITH THE
LOCALS AND TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THIS IS COORDINATED AND PLANNED
OUT.
IT'S JUST NOT TRUE I MEAN THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN.
MORE OF ALL OF US HAVE BEEN
THESE LAST EIGHT MONTHS.
AND I WOULDN'T BE HERE THIS IF I
HADN'T IF I DIDN'T HAVE THAT RAY
AND I DON'T THINK I'D THIS BILL
PROBABLY WOULDN'T BE AT THIS
STAGE -- IN IN THIS HOUSE IF I
HADN'T DONE THAT RAY AND SO.
I THINK ALL THAT SPEAKS TO THIS
IS A VERY COMPREHENSIVE
COLLABORATIVE COOPERATIVE EFFORT
CAN YOU CLARIFY FOR ME UNDER
AMENDMENT HE IT REQUIRES YOU TO
TALK -- TO GROUPS THAT IN THE
TRIBAL COMMUNITY THAT MAY BE.
ADVERSELY AFFECTED OR THAT
THEY'RE NOT ADVERSELY AFFECTED.
YEAH THAT WAS A COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT -- THAT PROPOSE THAT
WE ARE ACCEPTING.
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE TRAVEL GROUPS
IN OUR REGION THAT.
MEAL.
MAY HAVE SOME ISSUE WITH THE
PACIFIC BUT SPECIFIC SITE THAT
IS BEING USED SO I MEAN WE'RE
OKAY WITH THAT.
HOW WOULD YOU AFFECT YOUR
EFFECTUATE THAT WHAT WOULD BE?
I DON'T KNOW MAYBE THERE IS A
CULTURAL SIDE OR THERE'S SOME
ISSUE BEYOND THAT'S COMMON THAT
YOU IT IT WELL AS A COMMON THING
THAT YOU WOULD HAVE TO DO IN A
SEQUEL PROCESS RED.
RIGHT YOU HAVE TO IDENTIFY IT WE
HAVE A BILL EARLIER THAT TODAY
THAT WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
ADVERSE EFFECTS THAT THEY MAY
HAVE ON THE MINISTERIAL.
MOM.
I AM TO WERE AGREEING TO DO THAT
BECAUSE I AM BAD THINK GETS A
THOUGHTFUL AMENDMENT AND LET'S
SO WE'RE GOING TO DO THAT TODAY
I JUST ONE I'M LOOKING FOR
CLARIFICATION BECAUSE THE WHAT
WHAT'S IN OUR PACKAGES THAT YOU
JUST KIND OF WORK.
TALK WITH THEM AND WORK WITH
THEM TO THAT THEY'RE NOT ADVERSE
EFFECT BUT I WANT.
TO GET SOME SPECIFICS OF HOW YOU
HOPE TO ACHIEVE THAT.
NOT MY BALL I THINK IT WOULD
JUST BE A CONSOLE LIKE YOU WOULD
NORMALLY DO A TRAVEL
GOVERNMENT'S WHEN YOU HAVE A
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT.
YEAH BECAUSE UNDER SEEK BUT YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE A HEARING AND
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PEOPLE TO WEIGH IN ON WHAT THE
AT AFFECT IS UNDER MEREST
MINISTERIAL.
APPROVAL YOU DON'T HAVE THAT I
READ SOME CONCERNS AND THE LAST
BILL OF THAT THE DEFICIENCIES ON
THESE CALLS ARE CULTURAL SITES
[inaudible]
SOME.
SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A PUBLIC
HEARING AS FOR THAT'S ANOTHER
AMENDMENT THAT WE'VE AGREED TO
THERE WILL ALSO BE OTHER PUBLIC
HEARINGS AS THE CITY MANAGER FOR
MORE BILL TALKED ABOUT ANY TEN
THE U. DO A SUBDIVISION -- BEEN
A A DEVELOPMENT THERE'S GOING TO
BE.
PLANNING COMMISSION OTHER
HEARINGS IT IS A MINISTERIAL
APPROVAL PROCESS WHICH I WOULD
POINT OUT THIS COMMITTEE HAS
PASSED IT SB.
THIRTY FIVE MEN AND SB -- THIRTY
FIVE YELLOW.
WAS LARGELY MORE FOCUSED ON AN
URBAN AREA AND PROVIDE A
MINISTERIAL APPROVAL -- AND I
THINK THAT'S THAT'S FINE THIS IS
MODELED AFTER SB.
THIRTY FIVE THE AUTHOR OF THAT
BILL SUPPORTS THIS LEGISLATION
AS WELL -- AND IS MODELED OFF A
THIRTY FIVE AND IS FOCUSED ON A
RURAL AREA THAT'S BEEN AFFECTED
BY DISASTERS VERY LIMITED. TO
THIS REGION AND HAS A LOT OF THE
SAME PROTECTIONS.
YEAH I DON'T REMEMBER THAT SB
THIRTY FIVE COMING THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE BUT BUT SO I WEBSITE
INSIDE INCOME BUT I WAS IN NO
ONE SB THIRTY FIVE ANYWAY.
AND I'LL BE A NO ON THIS -- BILL
BECAUSE I BELIEVE WITH THE
OPPOSITION THIS IS THIS IS A
WHOLESALE -- DISREGARD FOR THE
PUBLIC PROCESS THAT'S REQUIRED
BY SEEK.
AND I KNOW I KNOW PEOPLE MISS
TAXI CLUB OF WHAT YOU DO IS YOU
BRING IN THE PUBLIC SO THAT THEY
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON AND NOBODY
IN ALL THESE COMMUNITIES IS
GONNA KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON STUFF
JUST IS GOING TO GET BUILT.
AND IF THERE'S A SLOWDOWN
THERE'S WAYS THAT THAT CITIES
CAN -- ASSIST IF THEY ARE REALLY.
INTERESTED IN BUILDING THESE NEW
CITIES AND IT'S REALLY A PART OF
THEIR GENERAL PLAN SO.
MISTER CHAIR I AM A NO ONE THIS
I WAS IN NO YESTERDAY AND
HOUSING -- I THINK IT'S A
HORRIBLE PRECEDENT TO BE TO BE
SETTING AND I AM DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THE OTHER AMENDMENTS ARE
SUGGESTED IN OUR ANALYSIS.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW IF I WOULD GET
TO YES WITH THEM BUT I CERTAINLY
CAN'T GET THE S. WITHOUT ALL THE
ALL THE MEMBERS.
THIRDLY IS FOUR POINT OUT THAT
THIS IS A SON SENATE BILL AND IN
ESSENCE NOT FOREVER.
AND THAT EVERYONE OF THESE
COMMUNITIES HAS DONE A GENERAL
PLAN.
AND IF YOU'VE EVER DONE A
GENERAL PLAN IS NOT GOING TO
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO CHANGE YOUR
ZONING AND SIXTY WELL HOWEVER
LONG IT IS TELL THAT.
IT TAKES IN MOST CASES TEN TO
TWELVE YEARS TO GET A GENERAL
PLAN.
THROUGH THE PROCESS EVEN TO
GENERAL PLANTS SO I DON'T THINK
YOU'RE GONNA SEE WHOLESALE BLOW
OUTS OF THESE COMMUNITIES AS HE
IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN IS YOU'RE
GONNA SEE WORK DEVELOPMENTS ARE
EVEN PLAN TO GO.
GO IN THESE COMMUNITIES
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
SO.
WHAT DO YOU WHAT YOU WANT TO DO
I MEAN I GUESS WHAT I -- WHAT
WHAT WHAT I WHAT I WOULD SAY?
BY THE WAY WE JUST GOT THE VMT
NUMBERS FROM YOU COUNTY SO THEY
ARE AVAILABLE.
BUT OKAY SO SO IT'S SO YOU HAVE
A CHOICE IF YOU HAVE A CHOICE I
MEAN WE I APPRECIATE THE FACT
YOU'VE ACCEPTED A MEN'S D. E.
ENOUGH.
I UNDERSTAND WE'RE STILL HAVING
TROUBLE WITH A B. AND C..
AND EVEN WITH THOSE YOU KNOW
WE'RE NOT SURE THAT SOME OF OUR
MEMBERS WOULD VOTE FOR IT -- SO
YOU HAVE A CHOICE AND IT KIND OF
DEPENDS ON YOUR READ OF THE
COMMITTEE AND WHERE YOU WANT TO
GO WITH THIS -- I WOULD BE
WILLING TO VOTE FOR THE BILL
TODAY.
I WITH -- WITH WITH A COUPLE KEY
AREAS OF CLARITY ONE WOULD BE AT
A 10% PER YOU UNIT CAP PER CITY
SO AS TO MAKE SURE THAT JUST TO
ENSURE THERE'S NOT A BLOW OUT.
OF A REAL ROBUST DISCUSSION
ABOUT V. AN T. WITH THAT.
YOU KNOW AND AND IF AND IF WE'RE
NOT ABLE TO TO GET IT RESOLVED I
WOULD RESERVE THE RIGHT TO BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE IF.
A MAJORITY OF THE COMMITTEE
WASN'T YOU KNOW WHAT WASN'T
WILLING TO KEEP GOING FOR WITH
THE WITH YOUR FOR YOUR VERSION.
I AND SIX UNITS PER ACRE -- SO
WITH THAT WITH THAT.
WITH WITH THOSE -- PROVIDES AS I
WOULD BE ONE OF THE FOR TODAY
NOW AS I SAY IF YOU'RE NOT.
IF YOU FEEL LIKE YOU YOU KNOW
YOU GOT THE VOTES -- WITHOUT ME.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO TAKE THOSE --
BUT THAT'S A DECISION IN A
MINUTE LEAVE TO YOU.
AND A AND I'M I'M I'M I'M
CERTAINLY NOT OFFENDED WHETHER
WAY WE YOU KNOW WE BOTH WORKED
HARD ON THIS AND AND I I THINK
NO MATTER WHAT I FEEL LIKE.
THE BILL AT LEAST IN A BETTER
PLACE FOR MY PERSPECTIVE THAN IT
WAS BEFORE CAME TO US
[inaudible]
SO.
I WANT TO BE REALLY CLEAR LIKE I
BY EXCEPT THE THREE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE'VE ALREADY AGREED ON D.
TWO F. -- SO THAT'S VERY CLEAR
ON THE RECORD PROJECT I'M TAKING
THOSE.
AB AND C. AT THINKER WHERE WE'VE
BEEN HAVING DISCUSSION RIGHT --
I THINK THE L. ONE I CAN WHAT I
WANT TO COMMIT TO US THE CAP
ISSUE IS WHAT I WANT TO COMMIT
TO YOU YET IS A IS A CONTINUE
GOOD FAITH.
DISCUSSION AS WE'VE ALREADY BEEN
HAVING [inaudible]
GOING FORWARD -- BECAUSE I THINK
THAT WE ACTUALLY IT SEEMS LIKE
WE'RE GETTING CLOSE ON A ON A
POTENTIAL DWELLING UNIT -- MAYES
SAID SIX YEAH I THINK AND I
THINK.
THAT IF AND I'M AND I'M NOT
OPPOSED TO A CAP I JUST NEED TO
UNDERSTAND.
WHAT THE TOLD WHAT THAT CAN BE
WE LOST FOURTEEN THOUSAND
HOUSING UNITS RIGHT SO I'M
REALLY TRYING TO REPLACE?
WHAT'S BEEN LOST RIGHT FOURTEEN
THOUSAND AND I THINK WE'LL MEET
A LOT OF OUR DISCUSSION IS
CENTERING AROUND.
NOBODY HERE.
I DON'T DISAGREE WITH HAVING
INFILL MULTI FAMILY AND ALL THAT
LIKE.
THIS BILL WILL DO THAT.
THIS BILL WILL DO THAT RIGHT --
BUT YOU KNOW I HAVE THE STATS
AND WE HAD NINE THOUSAND SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES LOST IN THIS FIRE
SO.
WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO BUILD.
IN KIND WHAT HAS BEEN LOST AND
SO.
IF YOU HAVE TO DANCE
REQUIREMENTS OR IF.
WERE OF THE V. M. T. IS SUCH
THAT IS GOING TO PRECLUDE YOU
FROM.
YOU KNOW BEING ABLE TO BUILD
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES THAT IS
WHAT'S NOT WORKABLE AND I NEED
TO UNDERSTAND.
HOW IT'S GONNA HOW THAT'S GONNA
WORK GOING FORWARD SORRY?
HI WILL IN GOOD FAITH CONTINUE
TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT BOTH THAT.
THE THE DWELLING UNIT PER ACRE --
AND THE AND THE CAP.
BECAUSE I THINK WE CAN GET THERE
ON SOME ON BOTH OF THOSE ITEMS.
WHICH REFERRED ME AND PETE VMT I
JUST I MEAN.
EVERYTHING THAT I'M HERE A MAN
IS LIKE THAT.
THIS COMPLEX AND NONE OF MY
JURISDICTIONS WOULD KNOW HOW TO
COMPLY WITH THAT AND THAT IS
THAT THAT'S SO BECAUSE HE'S
REALLY IF WE'RE IF WE'RE GONNA
FOUR IN A ROW FOR THE LOW
DENSITY THE BEAUTIES REALLY
IMPORTANT MEDIUM AND I SAY THIS
IS NOT.
IS NOT COMPARING THE ANTI
BETWEEN YOUR COMMUNITY AND A
CITY IT'S NOT IT'S ABOUT IT'S
IT'S CONTEXTUALIZING WITHIN THE
REGION.
TELL YOU WHAT WHEN WE DO THIS
ONE WE ACCEPT THE MOTION.
I SEE WHERE THE VOTES ARE NOW
YOU CAN GO REACH OUT TO CENTER
SKINNER CENTER STERN AS WELL.
ARE WE STILL HAVE SQUARE FOR
SITTING HERE FOR AWHILE AGO
EITHER BILLS ALL LAY OFF FOR NOW.
I IF YOU FEEL AS THOUGH YOU NEED
MY VOTE LET'S CIRCLE BCK AND
AND AND AND HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT THESE OTHER ITEMS -- BUT
IF YOU GOT THE VOTES YOU KNOW
WITH WITH THE OTHER MEMBERS WE
CAN YOU KNOW WE MIGHT AS WELL
KEEP MOVING.
NO MATTER WHAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO HAVE A GOOD.
GOOD FAITH DISCUSSION REALLY NO
MATTER WHEN YOU NO MATTER WHERE
YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT ON THAT I
APPRECIATE THAT ABOUT YOU KNOW
OKAY.
SO -- LET'S ENTERTAIN A MOTION
SONY TO VOTE ON THE FLOOR IF I
DON'T GET TODAY RIGHT YEAH YEAH
YEAH YEAH.
RIGHT CENTER HILLS MOVE THE BILL --
SO I'M LAID OFF FOR NOW AND
LET'S LET'S CIRCLE BACK BY THE
END OFTHE DAY.
HI -- THANK YOU.
THEN THANK YOU THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
IT TOUGH BILL OF INTERESTING
ISSUES LOTS OF TOUGH ISSUES --
BUT DO APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
ROBUST.
DISCUSSION FOR THE BOTH REMOVED
EFFECTIVELY COLOR.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB FOR THIRTY
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE.
ALAN.
BATES.
BATES HI DELI.
DELI AYE HILL.
HILL AYE SKINNER.
STERN MY CAL SKI.
MY FESCUE NOW.
OKAY THANK YOU TAKE CARE BYE
OKAY ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- BUT OKAY
ALL RIGHT LET'S -- LET'S NOW GO.
TO HER TO HAVE BEEN PATIENTLY
WAITING.
THANK YOU.
AND HE'S HERE TO PRESENT ITEM
NINE IN YOUR GENESIS AB.
FIVE OH EIGHT MAC REALLY DO --
DOMESTIC WELLS AND DRINKING
WATER.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR.
THERE ARE SOME MORNINGS
AFTERNOONS AFTERNOON SENATORS
AFTERNOON NOW.
I WON THE FIRST SO THANK THE
CHAIR IN YOUR SOUTH FLORIDA.
WORK ON THIS BILL WITH MY STAFF
AND A VERY HAPPY TO THIS AFTER
YOU COMMITTEE -- AMENDMENT.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB FIVE ZERO
EIGHT WHICH IMPROVE ON EXISTING
WATER BOARD PROCESSES. TO
DELIVER SAFE DRINKING WATER TO
SMALL COMMUNITIES.
WHO RELY ON DOMESTIC WELLS AND
SMALL WATER SYSTEMS?
WAS FOR COMEY KEY US UP
AMENDMENT THIS BILL REQUIRES TO
WATER BEFORE LET RATE PAYERS.
THE RENTERS AND THE LEVEL OWNERS.
INDEED.
COMMUNITY NOTE ABOUT THE WATER
QUALITY CONCERN IN THAT AREA.
INFORMATION OF ALL THE HEALTH
EFFECTS OF TWO CONTAMINANT AND
INFORMATION OF ALL WOULD BE
OPPORTUNITY FULL CONSOLIDATION
OR EXTENSION OF SERVICES.
THIS BILL ALSO CLARIFY THAT AS
THE STATE OLD ORDERED
CONSOLIDATION AND EXTENSION
BEGINNINGS.
IT IS A VIOLATION OF THE LAW FOR
A RECEIVING WATER SYSTEMS TO
OVER CHARGE TO STAY BEYOND THE
REASONABLE COST. TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO DE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
WISHED ME HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT.
IS -- A MICHAEL CARE BORN FROM
THE LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND SHE SHASHA HARD HARDEN DOES
BROWN DO WESTERN CENTER OF LAW
AND PROPERTY.
OKAY YEAH WE WOULD APPRECIATE
EXPEDITED REVIEW -- NO
EXEMPTIONS BUT EXPEDITOR YOU.
YES SIR I WILL TRY TO BE FAST
[inaudible]
CAPTION HERE.
MY NAME IS LIKELY ONE I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AND I WANTED TO START BY QUICKLY
THINKING THE AUTHOR FOR
CONTINUING THIS CHAMPION
DRINKING WATER SOLUTIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- THIS IS
A BILL LIKE THE AUTHOR JUST
MENTION THAT HAS NO OPPOSITION
AND SIGNIFICANT SUPPORT.
THE IDEA OF THE BILL IS TO
ENSURE THAT DRINKING WATER
SOLUTIONS MOVE FORWARD AND AN
EFFICIENT AND TRANSPARENT MANNER --
AND THE THE THE IMPETUS FOR THE
BILL WAS A COMMUNITY CALLED
TOMBSTONE IN FRESNO COUNTY --
THAT'S LOOKING TO EXTEND OUR
HABIT AN EXTENSION OF DRINKING
WATER SERVICE PROJECT MOVE
FORWARD.
AND THE WAY THE PROCESS WORKS
NOW THE THE PROCESS THE PROCESS
DOESN'T MOVE FORWARD UNTIL YOU
HAVE MAJORITY CONSENT IN THE
COMMUNITY -- AND THAT POSTPONES
A FEASIBILITY ANALYSIS THIS
WOULD CHANGE THAT SO THAT THE
FEASIBILITY ANALYSIS COULD MOVE
FORWARD WITH OUT FIRST HAVING
MAJORITY CONSENT SO YOU PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO PEOPLE --
BEFOREHAND WHEN THEY'RE DECIDING
WHETHER TO CONSENT OR NOT -- WE
DEFINITELY URGENT I VOTE FOR THE
BILL AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
[inaudible]
YES SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON SASHA HARLEM WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY I'M A HOUSING POLICY
ADVOCATE. FOR OUR LOW INCOME
CLIENTS -- BUT WATER QUALITY
ISSUES ARE VERY MUCH HOUSING
ISSUES AS WELL WE HOUSING
CLIENTS DISPLACED FROM THEIR
HOMES AND COMMUNITIES TO A LACK
OF ACCESS TO CLEAN DRINKING
WATER -- AS WELL AS STRUGGLE
WITH A LACK OF INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT WATER QUALITY CONCERNS MAY
BE PRESENT -- FOR THEM AND THEIR
FAMILIES -- SO THE INFORMATION
THAT THOSE FAMILIES WOULD
RECEIVE UNDER THIS BILL --
REGARDING LOCAL WATER QUALITY
WILL BETTER EQUIP THEM TO MAKE
APPROPRIATE DECISIONS IN THESE
SITUATIONS AND INFORMATION ABOUT
THEIR RIGHTS AND OPTIONS WITH
RESPECT TO CONSOLIDATION -- WILL --
HIGHER THAN TO ADVOCATE FOR
SOLUTIONS FOR THEM AND THEIR
FAMILIES WE ARE NOT PRO AND CON
THANK YOU.
OKAY -- OTHER FOLKS WHO WANT TO
WIN SUPPORT.
ANDREA MENTOR WITH CLEAN WATER
ACTION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CHRIS ANDERSON ON BEHALF
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT AND JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR HIS
STAFF AND LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
WORKING WITH US THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS THANK YOU.
MELISSA ROMERO AT THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
SUPPORT AND I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED
TO PASS ALONG THE SUPPORT OF
SPHERICAL CALIFORNIA.
IN THE CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ALLIANCE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MATTHEW BAKER PLAYING
CONSERVATION LEAGUE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY OPPOSITION CONCERNS
FRIENDS ARE THE FRIENDS THINK.
THEY'RE GOOD OKAY ALL RIGHT --
AND GET OKAY I KNOW POSITION --
QUESTIONS THOUGHTS NOW OKAY --
CLOSE PROCURATORATE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE OKAY THANK
YOU MOVED BY CENTER WITH CASKEY --
SIX IT WAS KALRA.
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB FIVE EIGHT
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE ALLEN HI ALAN I BATES.
THAT DALY HILL SKINNER.
STERN AYE CASKEY CASKEY ACT OKAY
ALL RIGHT GREAT LET'S TALK
CARPET THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAVE
A STOCK CARPET ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO ITEM TEN THIS IS
AB -- SEVEN TWENTY NINE REALLY
THE CARPETS TUITION AND
RECYCLING.
THIS IS.
A VERY REAL.
RESEARCHERS AND THEIR SENATORS
AGAIN SECTION A YOUR EFFORT AND
YOUR STAFF.
FOR A PHONE THE WORKING ON THIS
BILL AND I WILL BE A SEVENTEEN
D. COMING HE AMENDMENT.
DOES THE SCHOOL THIS BILL IS
REALLY SIMPLE WE WANT TO GIFT
CAL RECYCLED THE TOOLS. TO
OVERSEE THIS PROGRAM WHICH WAS
ENACTED IN TWENTY TEN BY TENS OF
ASSEMBLY SPEAKER OF PROGRESS. TO
MEET THE STATE RECYCLING GOAL.
AB TWO TWENTIES.
SEVEN IT IS A BILL THAT WOULD
PROVIDE THE STATE THE TOOL TO
ADDRESS THE DEFICIENCY IN THIS
CARPET THE STEWARDSHIP PROGRAM.
AND THIS BILL WILL ALSO A
PROVIDE INCENTIVE FOR CONSUMERS
TO BUY EASIER TO RECYCLE CARPET.
AND GIVEN THE ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
THE TOOLS NEEDED TO OVERSEE THE
PROGRAM.
PERSONS WILL ALLOW FOR A BRIDGE
PROGRAM IN THE CASE OFFICE TO
WORSHIP ORGANIZATION CEASE
OPERATIONS.
OR A PLAN IS DISAPPROVED. TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS FEET AND
CONTINUE RECYCLING TO SPILL
REQUIRE THE TRANSFER OF TO AN
EXPANDED CONSUMER FEES. TO BE
DEPOSITED INTO TRUST OR ASK TOOL
TO CONTINUE THE PROGRAM.
DUE TO THE HISTORY OF NON
COMPLIANCE WAS A STATUE MARIE
REQUIREMENT THE DEPARTMENT OF
RESOURCE RE RESOURCE RECYCLE AND
RECOVERY OR CAL RECYCLED.
NEED TO LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY TO
PROVIDE INCENTIVES AND
APPROPRIATE.
THE OVERS OVERSIGHT TO MEET CALL
CALIFORNIA'S RECYCLING GOAL. TO
DO THIS A. B. SEVEN TWENTY NINE
INCREASED TO CEILING FOR A CIVIL
PENALTY FROM ONE THOUSAND PER
DAY TWO FIVE THOUSAND PER DAY.
TO ALLOW CAL RECYCLE -- DETERRED
FUTURE VIOLATIONS.
IN A IN ADDITION DUE TO THE
SIGNIFICANT CAL RECYCLE STAFF
TIME AND RESOURCES UTILIZED.
TO HELP BRING DOES PROGRAMMING
INTO COMPLIANCE.
DURING THE LAST THREE ALTHOUGH
FOR THE LAST SEVEN YEARS THINGS
TO CREATION OF THIS PROGRAM.
THE CALLS HOWEVER EXCEED THE
STATUTORY 5% CAP ON
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES.
SO THIS RESULT TO CAL RECYCLE
SHIFTING SOME RESOURCES TO
SUBSIDIZE THE CARPET RECYCLING
PROGRAM.
AND DOES WHAT DOES BILL REMOVED
A CAB.
ALLOW KILL RECYCLE TO LEVY A
QUARTERLY FEET THAT MEANS TO OF
FULL MS ADMINISTRATIVE AND
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF THIS
PROGRAM.
FINALLY THIS BILL DIRECT THIS TO
OR SHOULD ORGANIZATION TO
IMPLEMENT A DIFFERENT ASSESSMENT
THAT WERE INCENTIVE SITES
CUSTOMERS TO BUY EASIER TO
RECYCLE COPPERED AND MADE OF
RECYCLED.
MATERIALS IN THE MARKETPLACE.
AGAIN -- WAS MEETING HERE TODAY
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OUR JOHNSON
ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
STEWARDSHIP ACTION COUNCIL.
AND GREAT CAMPBELL ON BEHALF OF
THE INTERFACE WHICH IS THE
CARPET THE MANUFACTURE
[inaudible]
MISTER SCHMEISER.
BASED ON MISTER WHAT COUNTIES.
I WILL BE ABLE TO THAT -- I JUST
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE.
AT A FEW POINTS VERY QUICKLY --
FIRST I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
SPONSOR THE NATIONAL SECURITY
BACKS AND ACTION COUNCIL I ALSO
ALAMEDA STOP WASTE AND WESTERN
PLASTER WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY.
I DO WANT TO SPEAK TO ONE POINT
IN THE OPPOSITION LETTER THE
COALITION LETTER FROM C. B. I IN
THE CHAMBER AROUND HOUSING
PRICES -- WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY A
VERY SIGNIFICANT ISSUE IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT LAST NIGHT.
JUST REALLY QUICKLY THE AVERAGE --
SQUARE FOOTAGE OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
SQUARE FEET THAT'S TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE SQUARE YARDS EVEN
IF CARE DECIDED ON THEIR OWN TO
DOUBLE THE FEE FOR THIS LESS
EXPENSIVE CARPET -- THIS.
CARPET THAT ISN'T AS RECYCLABLE --
THAT WOULD ADD EIGHTY ONE
DOLLARS TO THE PROCESS THE PRICE
OF HOUSING -- THE AVERAGE HOUSE
AND STATE OF CALIFORNIA
LITERALLY EIGHTY ONE DOLLARS SO
I THINK HOPEFULLY -- THE
COMMITTEE CAN SET ASIDE THIS
pTHIS BILL ON HOUSING PRICES I
THINK IT'S A NON ISSUE -- AT
EIGHTY ONE DOLLARS -- AND WITH
THAT I'LL JUST BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS BASED ON THE
MOTION THANK YOU.
SHERMAN MEMBERS GREG CAMPBELL
MAP INTERFACE INTERFACE IS A
LARGE CARPET MANUFACTURER AND
RECYCLER BASED IN GEORGIA WE ARE
MEMBERS OF CAREHAD BEEN SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND TO BE VERY HAPPY
WITH YOU YES THE WHERE WHERE THE
FATE WHERE THE FAVORITE CHILD --
AND HONESTLY WE DON'T WANT TO BE
HERE CONSIDERED HAVE LEGISLATION --
TO TRY TO MAKE THIS PROGRAM WORK
BETTER BUT THE CONTINUAL NON
COMPLIANCE OF CARE HAS KIND OF
LEFT US NO CHOICE BUT TO SUPPORT
A LEGISLATION LIKE A. B..
SEVEN TO NINE EVERYBODY'S HEAD
ON MOST THE POINTS.
THE IMPORTANCE OF A BRIDGE PLAN
GIVEN THE FACT THAT FROM TWENTY
THIRTEEN TO TWENTY SIXTEEN THEY
WERE OUT OF COMPLIANCE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THEY CAN EVEN GET A
PLAN APPROVED.
AND IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHILE
GETTING SOMETHING APPROVED THE
DIRECTOR HAS SAID VERY
SPECIFICALLY IF THEY DON'T DO A
NUMBER OF THINGS.
THERE WE RELOCATION AND RIGHT
NOW ONE OF THE BIG REASONS WHY
THAT PROBABLY WILL NOT HAPPEN IS
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN THE
SIXTEEN AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS AND WHAT HAPPENS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
OF THE RECYCLING --
INFRASTRUCTURE IN CALIFORNIA IF --
THE STEWARDSHIP ORGANIZATION
GOES AWAY WE DON'T WANT THEM TO
GO AWAY EVEN THOUGH THEY DON'T
LIKE US ON THE BOARD HOW WE LIKE
FOR CARE TO CONTINUE BUT WE JUST
THINK THEY SHOULD MOVE FORWARD
THE GOALS.
THE SECOND THING.
THE FEE SHOULD BE REFLECTIVE OF
WHAT THE INCENTIVE PROGRAM IS
THE PROGRAM IS DESIGNED TO GET
CARPET OUT OF LANDFILLS.
AND IN TO RECYCLE OR REUSE -- TO
HAVE A FEW STRUCTURE A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL ASSUMES AN ARC OF
CARPET IS THE SAME ALL CORPORATE
IS NOT.
SOME CARPET IS MORE RECYCLABLE
THAN OTHERS THIS BILL SIMPLY
MOVES THE BALL TOWARDS HAVING A
HIGHER FEE FOR CARPET THAT IS
HARDER TO RECYCLE AND A LOWER
FEE FOR CARPET THAT IS EASIER
RECYCLE.
WE DON'T THINK THAT'S CONSISTENT
AND WILL ALLOW FOR A BETTER AND
MORE PRODUCTIVE PROGRAM AND FOR
THAT WE ASK FOR MY BILL.
OKAY OUR FOLKS WANT TO ADD THEIR
SUPPORT VOICE SUPPORT
[inaudible]
EVERY SINGLE.
HELLO I AM ANDREW MENTOR WITH
CLEAN WATER ACTION WE ABSOLUTELY
SUPPORT THIS BILL IN THIS MODEL
ALSO THE DIFFERENTIATION OF FEES.
BECAUSE THERE ARE TOXIC
MATERIALS IN SOME CARPETS THAT
WE ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
GETTING BACK INTO THE RECYCLING
MODE.
AND WE THINK THAT WILL HELP
DRIVE THE REDUCTION OF THOSE
TOXIC MATERIALS SO JUST WANT TO
BRING THAT TO YOUR ATTENTION
THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JULIE
LIEBERMAN HERE WITH CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
THANK YOU.
HERE TOO SO ON BEHALF OF THE
CLEAN SEIZE LOBBYING COALITION
IN SUPPORT.
NATALIE MAX ON BEHALF OF RETHINK
WASTE IN SUPPORT.
SELECT US HERE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA PRODUCTS -- CHIEF
COUNCIL AND US ALWAYS
ASSOCIATION OF NORTH AMERICA IN
SUPPORT.
OR FRONT TABLE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA REFUSE RECYCLING
COUNCIL NORTHERN DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
OKAY -- OTHER FOLKS VOICE IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
WELL ENOUGH.
YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN IT'S BEEN A
LONG MORNING.
OKAY -- LE FOLKS MY POSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN ALLOW PHYSICIANS.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RAINY POLLOCK ON
BEHALF OF THE CARPET AND RUG
INSTITUTE OUR MEMBERS ARE
MANUFACTURES OF CARPET THEY'RE
ALSO MEMBERS OF CARE THAT'S A
STEWARDSHIP.
ORGANIZATION -- WE'RE HERE TODAY --
YOU KNOW AGAIN ANOTHER YEAR
ANOTHER CARPET DALE -- AND YOU
KNOW I THINK A LOT OF US ARE
SAYING JUST WHAT THE PROGRAM
WORK I YEAH I THINK YOU'LL SEE
THAT OVER THE YEARS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN PROVING THE
RECYCLING RATE WHEN WE SEE THE
OVERALL STATE RECYCLING RIGHT
CONTINUE TO DROP
THERE HAS BEEN IMPROVEMENT A
SERVER YOU HAVE BEEN OUT TO SOME
OF THESE FACILITIES AND SEEN THE
RECYCLING OF CARPET HAPPENING.
WHERE WE HAVE CONCERNS IS
DEALING WITH THE DIFFERENTIAL?
BACK IN FEBRUARY CAL RECYCLE
APPROVED THE PLAN.
THAT WAS SUPPORTED BY THICK
CARPET ADVISORY COUNCIL.
THAT CARE WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE
WITHIN A ONE YEAR TIME FRAME TO
LOOK AT THE POTENTIAL
DIFFERENTIAL.
DURING THAT TIME THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS THERE'S SUPPOSED TO
LOOK AT DIFFERENT WAYS A
DIFFERENTIAL COULD BE SET UP
SHOULD BE BASED UPON COSTS
SHOULD BE BASED UPON FIBER TYPE
SHOULD BE BASED UPON.
A RECYCLING SO WHAT WE'RE HERE
IS WE BELIEVE THAT THAT THAT THE
CARDS BEFORE THE HORSE HERE.
MANY TIMES THE COMMITTEE ALWAYS
WANT TO SEE INFORMATION I THINK
CENTER STERN SAID EARLIER NOW
LET'S HAVE INFORMATION BE GIVEN
TWICE BEFORE BEFORE WE MAKE A
DECISION.
SO ARE REQUEST TODAY IS WHY ARE
WE RUSHING AND MANDATING
SOMETHING THAT MAYBE MAY NOT
WORK AFTER INVESTIGATIONAFTER
ANALYSIS IS BEING DONE WITH CAL
RECYCLE AND ALSO WITH -- THE
ADVISORY BOARD WHAT IS THE
DIFFERENCE IF WE MADE SIX AWAIT
SIX MONTHS INTO NEXT YEAR UNTIL
THIS COMMITTEE GETS ALL THE
INFORMATION.
LOOKS AT IT AND THEN MAKES A
DETERMINATION.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT IS A PROCESS
THAT SHOULD BE MAINTAIN HERE
THIS IS THE PROCESS THAT WE WE
WOULD BE FAIR TO ALL THE PARTIES
BECAUSE THAT AT THAT TIME YOU
HAVE ALL THE INFORMATION
NECESSARY. TO MAKE WE BELIEVE A
CREDIBLE A DETERMINATION I WOULD
ALSO SAY THAT I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT IN THE DRAFTING OF THIS
AMENDMENT.
THAT I DON'T THINK THAT THERE
WERE ANY MEETINGS HELD WAS
STAKEHOLDERS LIKE THE RETAILERS
WHO WILL BE VERY AFFECTED BY
THIS I DON'T THINK THAT THERE'S
ANY CONSIDERATION OF OTHER.
WAY SIX SET UP THE DIFFERENTIAL
I DON'T THINK THERE IS A
DISCUSSION WITH CAL RECYCLE OR
THE CORPORATE VICE REPORT ABOUT
WHAT DIFFERENTIAL SHOULD BE IN
PLACE.
THEREFORE WE WOULD LIKE TO DEFER
THIS THE LAST POINT I WOULD MAKE
IS THAT IS CONCERNED A BRIDGE
PLAN WE UNDERSTAND A BRIDGE PLAN
SHOULD BE -- SHOULD BE SET UP
HOWEVER WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
WHERE YOU HAVE A PROGRAM AFTER
ONE YEAR IF CAL RECYCLE CANNOT
IDENTIFY ANOTHER ENTITY THAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO TAKE OVER THE
PROGRAM AND RUN IT.
THAT GIVES US CONCERNED AND FOR
THE REMAINING CONCERNS OUT TURN
IT OVER THE MICROBES THANK YOU.
HI HAT MICROBES IN HERE ON
BEHALF OF MOHAWK INDUSTRIES --
IT AND AND WE WE'VE TALKED A LOT
OF YOU OVER THE LAST WEEK OR SO
ABOUT THIS IS ALL TRY TO BE
QUICK.
AND NOW I HAVE THE BENEFIT OF AN
EXCELLENT ANALYSIS TO TALK ABOUT
SO JUST RATHER THAN WHAT I'VE
TALKED ABOUT BEFORE JUST.
SOME SOME SOME POINTS TO IT JUST
KIND OF FURTHER WERE WET WITH
MISTER POLLOCK JUST SAID ABOUT
YOU MEET MAYBE YOU KNOW HOLDING
THE BILL.
HAPPENS MORE OVERSIGHT JUST YOU
KNOW THE SONG POINTS OUT SOME
SOME ITEMS ON IN HER COMIC
NUMBER TWO ON PAGE. THIRTY EIGHT
PAGE EIGHT I'M.
SHE ASKED THE QUESTION -- YOU
KNOW WHO WOULD BE COULD BE THE
STORED IN THE EVENT THAT CARE IS
NOT THE STORED IN MAYBE CARE
ISN'T THE RIGHT STORE GIVEN THE
CONTENTIOUS HISTORY WITH --
CALORIE CYCLE OVER THE YEARS
EXCELLENT QUESTION -- IT'S AN
EXCELLENT QUESTION I MEAN WHAT
IF YOU KNOW WHERE WE WERE
PLANNING THE DEMISE OF CARE WITH
THIS BILL THAT WE'RE WE'RE JUST
ASSUMING CARE IS NOT GONNA EXIST
IN THAT CAR SECONDS GOING TO GET
RID OF CARE.
WE WOULD YOU KNOW CARES ON ON ON
A TRAJECTORY TO MEET THE
RECYCLING GOALS IF IF THEY MEET
THE RECYCLING LOST OR IF THEY'RE
JUST LIKE A PERCENT OR TWO OFF
IS IS IS THAT WERE THE OF
GETTING RID OF CARE.
AND MAYBE THE COMMITTEE OUGHT TO
JUST.
HOLD THE BILL AND HAVE A HAVE A
FULL INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
WHO SHOULD BE THE STEWARD IT
SHOULD BE CARE SHOULD BE CARRY
CYCLE IS ANOTHER ENTITY.
GOOD GOOD GOOD QUESTION ACTUALLY
QUESTION BROUGHT UP ANNOUNCES --
THERE AND SHE'S DEAD THE THERE'S
THE COMMENT NUMBER THREE TALKING
ABOUT -- THE THE ADMINISTRATIVE
FEE CAP THE THAT THAT WAS ADDED
TO THE BILL IN JUNE ON JUNE
TWENTIETH SO THAT THAT THE THIS
REMOVAL OF THE CAP WAS NEVER
DISCUSSED IN THE ASSEMBLY IT'S A
NEW PART OF THE BILL.
IT'S REALLY THAT THAT ALONE.
REMOVING CARRY CYCLES ABILITY TO
IT YOU KNOW COVER CYCLES
ADMINISTRATIVE FEE CAP 5% THAT'S
WORTHY OF A BILL ON ITS OWN AND
NOT NOT JUST THROWN INTO THIS
BILL.
THE EVENING OF THE THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE IN THIS COMMITTEE
MAYBE YOU KNOW.
SHE CHASSIS EXCELLENT QUESTION
YOU KNOW WITH THE THREE OUT OF
SEVEN YEARS -- THEY'RE CAUGHT
THE COSTS OF IMPLEMENTING THIS
PROGRAM HAVE HAVE EXCEEDED THEIR
5% CAP.
WHY IS THAT YOU JUST WE JUST
ACCEPT THE FACT THAT?
WELL THE MEET THE MOST NEED MORE
MONEY WE SHOULD REMOVE THE CAP
WELL MAYBE MAYBE THEY SHOULD ASK
WHY WHY WHY DID THE X. EITHER
FEE CAPPING THE THE THREE OF
THOSE YEARS AS TO CONFORM POINT
OUT.
THEY WERE SUING CARE WHEN THE
MISSION THE BEEN SOON CARE THEY
THEY WOULD YOU KNOW THE THE
RUNNING UP THEIR COSTS TO SUE
CARE THEY WERE SEEKING ONE POINT
EIGHT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AT A
CARE.
IN THE MINISTRY OF LODGES
WHACKED HIM DOWN TO TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS OR SOMETHING THAT I MEAN
I THINK THEY WERE BANKING ON
THAT MONEY AND THEY RAN UP LEGAL
BILL.
AND NOW USE AND FEEDING GET IT
AND FINANCING WILL REMOVE A FEW
CAPEN GOOD GOOD GOOD GOOD POLICY
QUESTION COULD BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE OVERSIGHT QUESTION.
MAYBE HOLD THE BILL FOR THAT --
AND FINALLY A TOTALLY HEAR YOU
BUT I GUESS THE QUESTION IS YOU
KNOW REGARDLESS OF WHATTHE BILL
PASSES.
IN CAL RECYCLE COULD DOES
DISAPPROVE CARES PLANTS ITEM --
AND THEN YOU KNOW THEN WHAT RATE
WELL AND THEN DIDN'T THIS BILL
SITTING IN THIS COMMITTEE I MEAN
IF THE IF THEY DISAPPROVE COUNT
CALORIES I THINK WOULD
DISAPPROVE CARE IN DECEMBER
NOVEMBER WHENEVER THEY COULD DO
THAT ANY TIME AND AND AND YOU
KNOW THE MONEY'S GONNA CONTINUE
TO PHONE.
THE FUND THE THEY'LL THEY'LL
MINISTER THE PROGRAMMING ME
CAN'T YOU CAN'T SELL CARPET INTO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITHOUT
CONTINUE TO PUSH MONEY INTO THE
PROGRAM THE INFRASTRUCTURE
EXISTS.
I MEAN YOU WHEN YOU WENT OUT AND
SAW THE RECYCLER IN IN IN IN
LINCOLN YOU KNOW WE'D BE FURTHER
ALONG THIS PROCESS OF CARE AND
IF CARRY CYCLES A LITTLE QUICKER
IN IN IN IN IN APPROVING THE
PLAN THAT THEY DID FINALLY
APPROVED -- IT YOU KNOW IT'S
GOOD QUESTION.
RIGHT NOW -- MR MAGISTER RESPOND
THAT AND CURRENT STATUTE ALLOWS
MANUFACTURERS TO CONTINUE SELL
CARPET IN THE CALIFORNIA FOR ONE
YEAR AFTER IF THE PLAN IS SORT
OF TERMINATOR RESULT SONGS IT'S
COMPLYING WITH THE CURRENT PLAN.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT THAT WILL
STILL BE ON GOING MY LAST ONE
JUST SINCE I COULDN'T FIND IT'S
JUST YOU KNOW ON THE
RECYCLABILITY OF CARPET YES JUST
YOU KNOW IT'S A IT'S EASY YOU
KNOW WHAT'S WHAT'S THE HIGHEST
RECYCLABLE MOST RECYCLABLE TODAY
MAY NOT BE THE HIGHEST RECYCLE.
MOST RECYCLED TOMORROW I MEAN
TECHNOLOGY IS EVOLVING I MEAN
YOU YOU I JUST HEARD AB SEVEN
NINETY TWO BY TEAM EARLIER YOU
KNOW THE THE THE PLASTIC RESIN
MARKET IS IS.
QUICKLY MOVING TECH TIP TO TO TO
DO TINGS AND YOU KNOW PT CARPET
WHICH YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW IS WERE
ALL PLASTIC BOTTLES ARE GOING AS
PT CARPET ANY AND AND PT CARPET
IS 1100%.
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S IT'S IT'S A
LOT OF P. T. AND AND A LOT OF
RECYCLED PTM PT CARPET.
THE THE ALLEGATION HERE IS THAT
IT'S HARD TO RECYCLE IT WELL YOU
YOU THOUGHT BEING RECYCLED IS
BEING CART THAT CARPET IS BEING
RECYCLED AND IN THE AND IT'S AND
IT'S PROGRESSING ANNEKE AND IT
COULD BE THE EASIEST RECYCLED
CARPET IN A YEAR OR TWO SO.
YOU KNOW WE DON'T WALKING INTO A
WAY TO DO AN ASSESSMENT WE HAS
THE ABILITY AS THE ADMINISTRATOR.
TO DO THINGS.
OKAY ALL RIGHT I'M I'M IN A PATH.
TO DETERMINE A SIGN AND I'LL BE
RIGHT.
BUT WE WANT TO HEAR FROM OTHER
FOLKS ONE OUT ABOUT.
IS THERE ARE OTHER OPPOSITION TO
AB.
SEVEN TWENTY NINE I RECOMMEND
AFTER THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE WANNA LINER COMES
WITH THE OPPOSITION AND THEN
JUST TO RESPOND -- WE DO THINK
ANY AGGREGATE COSTS TO HOUSING.
FOR SOME IT MAY BE DE MINIMUS
FOR OTHERS I THINK THE AVERAGE
COST ILL -- EXACERBATES OUR
HOUSING CRISIS THANK.
HI INJURED BECAUSE IT OVER THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION CAN I HAVE JUST A
MOMENT TO RESPOND TO THE
COMMENTS ARE MADE ABOUT THE
SPONSOR BY IT BUT MY LETTER THAT
I WROTE.
OKAY THANK YOU.
I JUST MOSTLY WANT TO EMPHASIZE
EXACTLY IS I'M FROM COAL CHAMBER
STATED THAT WERE IN THE MIDST OF
IT HOUSING CRISIS RIGHT NOW THAT
EVERY DOLLAR MATTERS -- AND
LOOKING AT THIS ONE PARTICULAR
BILL IN A SILO FAILS IN OR
TAKING CONSIDERATION THE WHOLE
PICTURE.
HOUSES GET BILL WITH ALL SORTS
OF THINGS EVERYTHING FROM
EARTHQUAKES TO FLOOD STONE FIRES
ALL THESE DIFFERENT TYPES
LEGISLATION IN EVERY LITTLE
PIECE ADDS UP.
A RECENT STUDY BY ANY H. B.
FOUNDER THOUSAND DOLLAR INCREASE
IN THE MEDIAN PRICE HOME RESULTS
IN NEARLY TEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIAN HOUSEHOLDS BEING
PRICED OUT OF THAT HOME.
SO SMALL INCREASE.
HE'S NUMBER PEOPLE ARE UNABLE TO
AFFORD TO BUY A HOUSE SO WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT I'M NOT GONNA
DEBATE SPECULATIVE NUMBERS
BECAUSE THOSE WERE SPECULATIVE
THAT WERE PUT FORTH A FURNACE
COMMITTEE.
BUT I WILL SAY THIS IS THIS BILL
IS POTENTIALLY A MARKET THE
STABILIZER AND CAN HAVE SOME.
PATIENCE THAN JUST THE
ASSESSMENT SELF. FOR THOSE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
OKAY WILL CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING SEEING THE QUESTIONS YOU
MAY CLOSE [inaudible]
MR.
TO AGAIN TO THE BILL IS TO GIVE
A CAL RECYCLE TOOL -- TO TO
OVERSEE THE PROGRAM AND TO TO
MEET OUR STATE RECYCLING GOALS --
NOT TO REALLY -- WHAT WINNER
STAND AT THEM A MONEY KEEP
COMING IN?
BUT GOOD THURS AND URGENCY AND
IN THAT BECAUSE THE CODE IS --
CARE WAS ACTUALLY STARTED BACK
IN.
TWENTY TEN BY DâN ON DECEMBER
SPEAKER.
OF PARALYSIS SO I THINK THIS IS
THE TIME -- TO AND YOU KNOW A IN
A NOT SHOW UP.
A LEVEL THANK YOU ARE THE WRIST
FULLY OFFER YOUR LAW ASSISTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THERE IS MOTION.
HE NEVER ACCEPTED THE MOTION
THAT.
OKAY SO WE ASK MATTER THERE IS
NO MOTION ON THE FLOOR THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND WE'LL WAIT
UNTIL WE HAVE OTHER MEMBERS ALL
RIGHT MISTER RIVAS IS HERE'S
SOCIAL WORK ON A SIMILAR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- RIVAS THIS IS
AB.
NINETY LET'S TALK ABOUT -- THE
OFFICE OF SPILL PREVENTION AND
RESPONSE.
SPECIFICALLY NON FLOATING OIL.
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
COMMITTEE STAFF IT.
SHOULD THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE -- LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE WORK IN
PREPARING THE ANALYSIS IT ALSO
LIKE TO THANK ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS STAKEHOLDERS TO
ENGAGE THIS ON THIS BILL.
I'M HAPPY TO HAVE REMOVED NEARLY
ALL OPPOSITION -- ON THIS BILL
WHICH IS IN THE BILL.
NINE THREE SIX THE ON THIS
LEGISLATION -- A PROPOSES TO
ENHANCE OIL TRANSPORTATION
SAFETY IN OUR STATE BY FIRST
MAKING SURE THAT WE DEFINE NON
FLOATING OIL AND STATUTE.
I AND SECOND TO ENSURE THAT
SAFETY STANDARDS ARE REGULARLY
UPDATED TO INCORPORATE THE BEST
POSSIBLE TOOLS FOR CLEANUP.
OF NON FLOATING OIL AND SO LOOK
OUR STATE IS BLESSED WITH
INCREDIBLE NATURAL RESOURCES AND
WE HAVE A LONG HISTORY AS A
STATE -- OF A MAKING SURE THAT
WE PROTECT OUR NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT OF THE PROTECTING
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH OR SAFETY AND
WITH THAT MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT
IT MORE AND MORE HEAVY CRUDES.
LIKE THE CANADIAN TAR SANDS OIL
ARE BE TRANSPORTED TO OUR STATE
AND TRANSFER.
HI PLAN TANKER.
AND BECAUSE OF OUR LOCATION
SPECIALIZED REFINING CAPACITY.
OUR STATE IS A DESTINATION FOR
NEW SUPPLIES OF THIS NON
FLOATING OIL.
AND UNFORTUNATELY OUR CURRENT
STATE LAW WE DO NOT SUFFICIENTLY
ACCOUNT FOR SPILLS OF NON FOR AN
OIL.
AND THIS GREAT SIGNIFICANT RISK
FOR OUR STATE AND IN PARTICULAR
IT CREATES A RISK FOR OUR
COASTAL AREAS.
I SAFETY PREPAREDNESS IS
IMPORTANT WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
ISSUE.
I AND AS PREVIOUSLY AS A
PREVIOUS -- A COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
HIGHLIGHTED WE CAN LEARN FROM
THE STATE OF MICHIGAN WHEN IN
TWO THOUSAND AND TEN A RUPTURED
PIPELINE.
RESULTED IN A SPILL INTO THE
KALAMAZOO RIVER A SPILL OF MORE
THAN A HUNDRED AND FORTY
THOUSAND THE GALLONS OF NON
VOTING CANADIAN TAR SANDS OIL.
IT WAS CITED AS THE LARGEST OIL
SPILL YOU'VE NEVER HEARD OF THE
REMEDIATION OF THIS BILL TOOK
FIVE YEARS COST OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS.
AND ACCORDING TO US AGENCIES
TOTAL CLEANUP PROVED IMPOSSIBLE
AND CONTAMINATION REMAINS TO
THIS DAY.
THIS BILL ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
THREE SIX IS ABOUT SAFETY AND
PREPAREDNESS.
AGAIN THIS LEGISLATION MANDATES
AN UPDATE OF CALIFORNIA'S -- THE
CONTINGENCY PLANNING TO SURE
THAT THE OFFICE OF SPILL
PREVENTION AND RUDE AND AND
RESPONSE OSCAR IS ADEQUATELY
PREPARED TO DEAL WITH SPILLS OF
THESE NON FORTY OILS.
OUR OILS MOST LIKELY TO CAUSE
LASTING -- THE DAMAGE TO OUR
MARINE ENVIRONMENT WATER REYES
AND PUBLIC HEALTH AND WITH THAT --
LET'S HEAR FROM.
HER WE HAVE THE SPONSORS AND WE
HAVE -- SO FOLKS DOES WELL ALL
OF THEM TO DO SOMETHING.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
JOHN ROSENFIELD SENIOR SCIENTIST
FOR SAN FRANCISCO BAY KEEPER
HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
NINE THIRTY SIX SAN FRANCISCO
BAY IS AT RISK FROM PLANS TO
PRODUCE MORE NON FLOATING OIL.
NOT ALL OIL IS THE SAME AND WE
NEED TO PREPARE DIFFERENTLY FOR
DIFFERENT TYPES OF SPILLS.
THE NATIONAL ACADEMY OF SCIENCES
FOUND THAT CURRENT OIL SPILL
RESPONSES BASED ON EXPERIENCE
WITH FLOATING OILS FOR NOT
ADEQUATE FIRST BILL OF NON
POLLUTING WHILE.
CALIFORNIA'S COASTAL ECONOMY.
LOCAL AN OFTEN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND OUR FRAGILE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY ECOSYSTEM WOULD BE
SEVERELY DAMAGED BY A SPELL OF
NON FLOODING OIL.
WHAT DOES THAT DO NOT FLOAT ARE
PARTICULARLY DAMAGING TO BOTTOM
DWELLING ORGANISMS AND THEIR
HABITATS?
IN SAN FRANCISCO BAY SUCH AS
BILL WOULD BE CATASTROPHIC TO
COMMERCIAL AND RECREATIONAL
FISHERIES FOR HALIBUT.
TENSION IS CRAB STURGEON JUST TO
NAME A FEW.
SPILLS NON FLOATING OIL ARE
NOTORIOUSLY DIFFICULT TO DETECT
TRACKING REMEDIATE BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT VISIBLE FROM THE
SURFACE.
SOME WOMEN RIVAS MENTIONED --
KALAMAZOO RIVER SPILL.
THAT CLEAN UP EFFORT HAS BECOME
THE MOST COSTLY SPELL IN.
STILL NOT COMPLETED.
CLEANING THIS BILL ON THE BAY
WOULD BE FAR MORE CHALLENGING
THAN ONE CONFINED TO A RIVER BED
BECAUSE IN THE DAY THIS MATERIAL
CAN SPREAD IN ALL DIRECTIONS.
AND A GREATER DEPTHS.
NON FLOATING OIL SPILLS IN PORT
WOULD IMPACT THE HEALTH OF
RESIDENTS IN SOME OF THE BAY
AREA'S MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
COMMUNITIES NEAR THE BASE PORTS
AND REFINERIES ALREADY
EXPERIENCED DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACTS TO THE SHORELINE AIR
QUALITY AND HEALTH.
THIS BILL OF NON FLOODING ALSO
WOULD BE YET ANOTHER IMPACT FOR
THESE COMMUNITIES TO BEAR.
AB NINE THIRTY SIX WOULD BEGIN
TO ADDRESS THESE RISKS BY
REQUIRING GREATER PREPARATION
FOR SPILLS OF NON FLOODING
LYLE'S.
TRANSPORTED THROUGH THE BAY AREA.
IT'S TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO TAKE
THE KIND OF REASONABLE
PRECAUTIONS THAT WASHINGTON AND
STATE HAS ALREADY TAKEN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
YOUR NEXT WITNESS I WOULD ALSO
ADD TO YOUR TESTIMONY THAT.
HE SOUTH BAY WHICH GETS STUCK
WITH THE SLOW CURRENTS WOULD
ACTUALLY EVENTUALLY GET ALL THE
NON FLOATING OIL SETTLING THERE
AS ALL THE OTHER.
TOXINS SETTLE IN THE SOUTH BAY
THE NEXT IN ARE YOU SEE WITH
YOUR FROM YOUR YES -- GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M AN ALEXANDER A
SENIOR ATTORNEY WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL ALSO
HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
NINE THIRTY SIX THIS LEGISLATION
TAKES SOME STRAIGHT FORWARD VERY
COMMON SENSE STEPS TOWARD
ADDRESSING THE THREAT OF NON
POLLUTING OIL THAT ARE CO
SPONSORS ARTICULATED.
OF FIRST OF ALL IT DEFINES NON
FLOATING WHILE BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
SOLVE A PROBLEM UNTIL YOU'VE
NAMED AT THE U. S. COAST GUARD
HAS RECOGNIZED SPECIFICALLY IN
ITS GUIDANCE.
THAT NON FLOATING OIL IS A
DISTINCT CATEGORY OF THREAT AND
NOW CALIFORNIA CAN DO THE SAME.
AND SECOND OF ALL IT STUDIES NON
FLOATING OIL AB NINE THIRTY SIX
CALLS ON OSCAR TO HOLD THE
TECHNOLOGY WORKSHOP.
EXCLUSIVELY DEVOTED TO NON
FLOATING OIL AND ALSO TO
COMPLETE A COME A LITERATURE
REVIEW.
OF LITERATURE CONCERNING A NON
POLLUTING OIL CLEANUP TO ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S DEPLOYING THE
BEST METHODS THERE ARE OUT THERE.
FOR CLEANING UP THIS TYPE OF OIL
BEFORE IT SINKS TO THE BOTTOM
AND WEEKS THAT KIND OF HAVOC.
THATHAS BEEN DESCRIBED IN OUR
WATERS.
AND FINALLY AB NINE THIRTY SIX
PREPARES FOR THE WORST PREPARES
FOR A SPELL OF NON FLOATING OIL --
IT REQUIRES THAT CALIFORNIA'S
STILL CONTINGENCY PLANNING BE
UPDATED TO ADDRESS SPECIFICALLY
NON POLLUTING OIL.
IT REQUIRES THAT OSCAR CREATE A
SPECIAL RATING CATEGORY FOR THE
OIL SPEED AT THE OIL SPILL
CLEANUP ORGANIZATIONS OR OFFICE
ROSE -- TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
QUALIFIED TO ADDRESS
SPECIFICALLY NON FLOATING OIL.
I AND IT REQUIRES THAT ANY
TANKER THAT'S COMING INTO THE
STATE WITH NON FLOATING OIL
IDENTIFY AN AUSTRO THAT IS
SPECIFICALLY QUALIFIED TO
ADDRESS THAT TYPE OF OIL.
SO CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT WAIT
UNTIL THE WORST BANDS BEFORE IT
TAKES PRECAUTIONS AB NINE THIRTY
SIX TAKES THOSE PRECAUTIONS NOW
I THEREFORE RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE.
IF ANYONE WANT TO ADD ON SUPPORT.
WE WANT ACTION.
YES.
SURPRISE SURPRISE -- BUT ONE OF
THE REASONS I WANT TO ADD TO
THIS IS THAT.
PART OF MY SPECIFIC WORK -- IS
TO WORK WITH THE ISSUE OF
SUBSISTENCE FISHING IN SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AND YOU KNOW THE
EFFECTS THAT YOU HEARD ABOUT.
THE FISSION AND THE LOW DWELLING.
ANIMALS THERE -- AFFECT HUMAN
HEALTH AND SAFETY BECAUSE THAT
IS A SIGNIFICANT PART OF OUR
POPULATION IN THE BAY AREA.
THE BILL.
OKAY THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON VICTORIA AROUND
WITHIN OUR DC BUT ASKED TO
REGISTER SUPPORT FOR SURFRIDER
TODAY THANK YOU.
MELISSA ROMERO AT THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
SUPPORT.
HERE TOO SO ON BEHALF OF HEAL
THE BAY IN SUPPORT.
BRENNAN DAWSON BENEFITS HERE
CUPS HOW CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
KATHY CARRIAGE IN BEHALF OF
THREE FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION IN
SUPPORT.
MARSILLI PERCENT THE ON BEHALF
[inaudible]
IN SUPPORT.
CAROL WE'D WITH SUSTAINABLE
PRESS MORE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT TO
RAISE CONCERNS WITH THE BILL
OPPOSITION. TWO NINE THE ITEMS
BACK WITH ME I DON'T THINK THERE
IS ANY RESTAURANT POSITION MOVE
BY.
TIMBER CASKEY ANY QUESTION.
ARE YOU MAY CALL.
I REALLY -- APPRECIATE UP TO BE
HERE AND RESPECT LAST NIGHT BUT
I WANT TO CLARIFY OKAY I'VE
THERE THERE'S YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
GO.
YEAH I IN AND SO ARE WITH THAT
THEY HAD REMOVED IT AT THE LAST --
THE COMMITTEE HEARING AND SO --
THEY REMOVE IT OKAY [inaudible]
THAT [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
GREAT.
OKAY YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE PRETTY.
SURE THAT HAVEN'T SO AT OUR
PREVIOUS -- A COMMITTEE HEARING
I BELIEVE IT WAS LAST WEEK THEY
DURING THE HEARING -- THEY THEY
CAME UP AND AND ESSENTIALLY SAID
THAT THEY WERE GONNA REMOVE
OPPOSITION BUT IT STILL SHOWS IN
THE ANALYSIS -- WHY THAT IS I
DON'T I KNOW I CAN TELL YOU IS
JUST THE INFORMATION THAT THAT
THAT THEY HAD RECEIVED?
IN THE ARM AT A PREVIOUS
AMENDMENT WE MADE.
PRIOR TO OUR LAST COMMITTEE
HEARING -- LAST WEEK IN NATURAL
RESOURCES THAT'S WHY THEY REMOVE
THEIR OPPOSITION.
THE BILL HASN'T CHANGED SINCE
THEN OKAY ALL RIGHT.
OKAY I THERE ARE.
I DIDN'T SAY WHAT THE MEMO ONCE
I'M JUST GONNA LAY OFF NOT TO
DELAY OUT.
YEAH I MEAN MAYBE I'M.
YOU KNOW IF BY THE END OF THE
HEARING CAN GET THAT ADDITIONAL
PERMISSIONS YOU CAN ADD ON LATER
ON YEAH THAT'S FINE SURE OKAY.
TALK TO PLEASE CALL.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN A. B. NINE
THIRTY SIX THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BATES.
DELI [inaudible]
TELL [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
I CASKEY.
ASKING.
IS THE AMERICAN -- IS GONNA HE'S
GONNA GET ON THIS REAL FAST.
IF THIS.
ISSUE.
CLARIFIED SO WE CAN GET CENTER
BATES IS BUILT VOTE BY THE END
OF THE DAY.
LET'S MAKE THAT HAPPEN OKAY.
SEE WORKING FOR YOU WORKING FOR
YOU MAN ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATE ALL
RIGHT NOW WE'RE ACTUALLY HERE
FOR FROM OBSERVERS SALAS WHO'S
HERE TO PRESENT A. B..
NINE SEVENTY AS HAS TO DO WITH
TRANSPORTATION GRANTS TURN AGING.
I AM SIXTEEN YOUR PACKETS
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU RICHARD READY MEMBERS
I KNOW YOU HAVE A LONG HEARING
SO KEEP THIS VERY SHORT.
I BELIEVE WE DO HAVE SUPPORT ON
THIS ISSUE AB NINE SEVENTY WOULD
PROVIDE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION FOR
SENIORS AND THE DISABLED.
AT TO GET TO THEIR HEALTH CARE.
I'LL CARE APPOINTMENTS WE WILL
BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
IMMENSELY THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON THAT AND WE
DO HAVE -- MISS WARREN HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M IN WARREN I AM THE CHAIR OF
THE LEDGE COMMITTEE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE.
AND WE'RE HERE.
TO I ASK YOU [inaudible] TWO
GIVE THE SENIORS.
AND MAKE.
GET RID OF THE DISPARITY.
AMONG OF THE SENIORS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THOSE IN ISOLATED IN RURAL AREAS.
HAVE LITTLE OR NO TRANSPORTATION.
WE'RE ASKING YOU TO PROVIDE.
THAT'S RETALIATION.
OBVIOUSLY. ZERO OR NEAR ZERO
EMISSION TRANSPORTATION.
IN THE FORM OF A SHUTTLE. FOR
SENIORS AND THE DISABLED WE NEED
TO GET TO NON EMERGENCY MEDICAL
APPOINTMENTS.
AND WE'RE ASKING YOU TO APPROVE.
OF GRANTS TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING.
US SO THAT THOSE.
OR LEASE MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATIONS.
OF SEVEN OR FIFTEEN ADJUST TWO
FIFTEEN PASSENGER SHUTTLE -- I
THINK THE LEGISLATURE HAS DONE A
GOOD JOB IN PROVIDING.
AND SEEING THAT SENIORS HAVE
[inaudible]
HEALTHCARE.
NOW WE NEED TO GET THEM TO THE
HEALTH CARE.
AND THAT THE NON EMERGENCY
HEALTHCARE IS EQUALLY AS
IMPORTANT AS THE EMERGENCY
HEALTH CARE.
AND SO WE'RE ASKING THEM.
THEN FOR APPROVAL.
THAT WE CAN GET THE FUNDS OUT OF
THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FINE. TO OF PURCHASE THESE
VEHICLES.
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT THE
SENIORS IN THOSE RURAL AREAS AND
I WAS THINKING.
WHILE.
STATE.
WELL SENATOR AT DALY WAS HERE
THAT HIS PEOPLE WOULD DEFINITELY
BENEFIT FROM THAT AS WELL AS
OTHER.
SENIORS LIVING IN THE ROLE IN
ISOLATED AREAS.
WE ASK FOR YOUR VOTE THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE TO ENSURE MEMBERS
CYPRESS SHADE YOUR PATIENCE I
KNOW IT'S BEEN A LONG HEARING
THANK YOU SO MUCH MY NAME IS
STILL FULL BORE HOW AND I'M WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION WE STAND HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE SEVENTY AND
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE AND THE
AUTHOR'S WORK.
BILL THE COMMISSION SUPPORTS
TRANSPORTATION POLICIES THAT
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LIFE
SAFETY.
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC GOALS
OF CALIFORNIA THIS BILL COULD
IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH ACCESS
LIKE MISS WARREN SAID BY
PROVIDING.
ACCESS TO THOSE OF THE ARE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND ALSO
TRUST AIR QUALITY AND GREENHOUSE
REDUCTION GOALS BY PER TYSON THE
PURCHASE OF THE STAFF AND AND
SOME VEHICLES.
ON THE COMMISSION COMMENCE ARMS
OR SALAS AND ITS LEADERSHIP AND
FINDING NEW WAYS TO ENSURE ACT
IT'S TRANSPORTATION WHILE ALSO
ADVANCING AND MEETING THE
STATE'S.
GREENHOUSE AN ENVIRONMENTAL
GOALS HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE BUT WE'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT AND WE ASK YOUR SUPPORT
THIS BILLS WELL THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT FOLKS WANT TO ADD ON
SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARC WATTS
REPRESENTING THE CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
THE POLICY THIS BILL IS ALIGNED
WITH THE POLICIES OF THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND ENCOURAGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
LAUREN RALPH CALIFORNIA SENIOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I REPRESENT NAPA
AND SOLANO WHO HAVE A RURAL
PORTIONS IN THERE IN THE
COUNTIES.
AND DOES SOMETIMES A GETTING A
RIDE TO A REGULAR MEDICAL
FACILITY FROM RE OF THIS STORE
DIXON CAN TAKE A COUPLE OF HOURS
ONE WAY. TO WORK ON WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
NOW HOW HOW DO YOU GET ELECTED
TO BE IS THE SENIOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER -- I'M A MEMBER
OF THE ADVISORY COUNCIL THE
DEPARTMENT ON AGING FOR SAN
FRANCISCO COUNTY.
AND A US SOLICIT FROM THE
COMMUNITY THOSE PEOPLE WHO MIGHT
WANT TO SERVE AS A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE.
THERE IS AN ELECTION
[inaudible]
WHO WORKS [inaudible]
THE NOW THE PART IN THE ADVISORY
COUNCIL. TO THE DEPARTMENT ON
AGING VOTED FOR COUNTY.
WELL SAN FRANCISCO IS CITY AND
COUNTY BUT PUBLIC SERVICE
AGENCIES PSA OTHER SENSE THERE
ARE THIRTY THREE OF THEM IN THE
STATE.
SO THEY MIGHT BE MULTI COUNTIES
MULTI CITY LOS ANGELES COUNTY OF
COURSE LOS ANGELES HAS NOT ONLY
THE CITY AND COUNTY BUT ALSO THE
EXTENDED.
NORTHERN LOS ANGELES COUNTY AREA.
IN THEIR PSAS.
YOUR SENIOR SENATORS.
YES YES I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
WE HAVE SENIOR SENATORS ALSO AND
WE MIRROR THE LEGISLATURE THE
FUTURE FOR YOU.
WE'LL BE GLAD TO HAVE YOU SIR.
IDEA THAT SOMEBODY SMEARING AS
FRIGHTENING BUT THE GOOD THE
GOOD PARTS WE'RE NEARING THE
GOOD PART.
OKAY ALL RIGHT.
OKAY -- IF ANYONE WAS THE RESULT
POSITION OR CONCERNS OR TWEETERS.
IT ALSO IS HERE.
THE BRAND ALSO SEE A CALIFORNIA --
WE'VE SEEN THE AMENDMENT AND SO
WE WE WILL WE WILL BE REMOVING
OPPOSITION.
I THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN
THE COMMITTEE PUTTING WORK.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR OKAY ALL
RIGHT.
AS ITEM IS NOW BEFORE THE THE
OKAY SO CAN YOUR SENATOR CASKEY
ANY QUESTIONS.
YEAH RIVER BY CENTER DOLLY I'M
GONNA BE OF STAINING NOTHING
AGAINST THE PROGRAM I APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR.
COMING TO THE TABLE AND
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS FUND
GLAD TO SEE YOU'RE AN
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORTER NOW AND
FOR THE USE OF THESE BONDS BUT
I'LL JUST BE ABSTAINING.
OKAY MAYBE YOU WON'T BE AS
WELCOME IN THE SENIOR
LEGISLATURE YEAH.
YEAH YOU RETHINK THAT ONE OKAY
ALL RIGHT APPRECIATE THAT -- AS
MOVE I CENTER DOLLY AND YES NO
MAYBE NOT.
YEAH IF YOU DID OKAY ALL RIGHT
TECHNICALLY.
YEAH OKAY CENTER PLEASE CALLER.
THE RESPECTFULLY ASK AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN A. B. NINE
SEVENTY THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ALLEN.
ALLEN HI BATES DAILY.
I TELL.
SKINNER STERN AYE CASKEY
[inaudible]
OKAY.
I BELIEVE THAT OPEN FOR BOTH
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU BOTH ASSEMBLYMEMBERS.
SENIOR OTHERWISE.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL NOW HEAR FROM --
SO MEMBER CALDERON. TO PRESENT
ITEM SEVENTEEN IS AB.
NINE SEVENTY FIVE YOU ARE
WELCOME TO PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
CENTERS A. B. NINE SEVEN FIVE
WILL ESTABLISH A CALIFORNIA
CULTURE ALLIANCE.
AN ADAPTATION LEADERSHIP
COORDINATION ACT TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THE ACT THIS ACT
REQUIRES THE SECRETARY NOW TO
RESOURCES AGENCY TO COLLABORATE
WITH OUTSIDE NATIONS ON HOW TO
SUPPORT AND PROMOTE THE GOALS
POLICIES.
AND BEST MANAGEMENT PRACTICES
RELATED TO A GLOBALLY SHARED
OCEAN.
RESPECTFULLY THE SECRETARY OF
NATURAL RESOURCES CURRENTLY
OVERSEES PROTECTION OF THE OCEAN
AND COAST BUT THE HEALTH OF THE
STATE AGENCIES AND OUTSIDE
PARTNERS THESE COLLABORATION
EFFORTS ARE STRICTLY WITHIN
CALIFORNIA'S COAST AND OCEAN.
THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT STATURE
FOR THE SECRETARY TO COLLABORATE
OR COMMUNICATE WITH OUTSIDE
NATIONS TO ADDRESS THE MOST.
PERTINENT ISSUES THREATENING OUR
SHARED OCEAN.
IT'S REALLY SIMPLE BILL REALLY
EASY JUST ASKING THE SECRETARY
OF NATURAL RESOURCES TO WORK
WITH OTHER STATES AND OTHER.
NATIONAL SUBNATIONAL GOVERNMENTS
TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE.
THAT KIND OF A HIVE OF
INFORMATION WHEN IT COMES TO HOW
WE CAN.
PASS IN AND DEVELOP LAWLESS IS
TO PROTECT THE OCEAN IF
SOMETHING IS IMPORTANT -- EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF US -- AND WE'RE
JUST NOT GOING TO GET. TOO FAR
ALONG DOWN THE LINE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE PROTECTING OUR OCEAN
IF WE HAVE A BUNCH OF A BUNCH OF
DIFFERENT POLICIES IN DIFFERENT
LOCATIONS WITHOUT SOME TYPE OF A
CONVERSATION HAPPENING BACK AND
FORTH AND WE THINK THAT THE
SECRETARY OF NATURAL RESOURCES.
IS THE ONE BEST SUITED TO CARRY
OUT THIS PLAN AND THIS GOAL
CONSIDERING THAT THEY ARE HE IS
ALREADY DOING THIS AND IS
AGENCIES ALREADY OVERSEEING THIS
ISSUES AND SO WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON THE SUPPORT MEASURE.
CRAFT THANK YOU YES WE HAVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON NATALIE MAX ON
BEHALF OF OCEAN CONSERVANCY.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS HERE IN FULL
FORCE BOTH ON LAND AND IN THE
OCEAN YOU MUST EXPAND OUR
EFFORTS TO ADAPT TO THE CHANGES
THAT ARE ALREADY UPON US AND ARE
CERTAIN TO WORSEN IN THE NEAR
FUTURE.
THAT IS WHY I AM PLEASED TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT TODAY FOR
AB NINE SEVEN FIVE THE
CALIFORNIA COAST RESILIENCE AN
ADAPTATION LEADERSHIP AND
COORDINATION ACT.
I DON'T YOU CONSERVANCY WE HAVE
LONG SUPPORTED EFFORTS TO
ENHANCE KNOWLEDGE DEVELOPMENT
AND EXCHANGE AMONG OTHERWISE
INDEPENDENT BODIES ESPECIALLY
AROUND OCEAN CLIMATE CHANGE.
WE ARE ONE OF THE FOUNDING
MEMBERS OF THE INTERNATIONAL
LIGHTS TO COMBAT OCEAN
ACIDIFICATION WE HAVE ACTIVELY
SUPPORTED THIS INTERNATIONAL
EFFORT EVER SENSE.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A MAJOR
CONTRIBUTOR TO THIS EFFORT AND
AS A RESULT THE ALLIANCE'S
EXCEPT IS ACCELERATING ACTION
AMONG GOVERNMENTS AND OTHER
ENTITIES.
AS CLIMATE CHANGE CONTINUES TO
ACCELERATE CALIFORNIA'S CONTENT
MUST CONTINUE TO BE A CRITICAL
VOICE AN ADAPTATION POLICY
RESEARCH BRING NOBLE ENERGY
DEVELOPMENT.
THE WORLD HAS A LOT TO LEARN
FROM OUR EFFORTS AND SIMILARLY
BE CAN BENEFIT FROM THE
EXPERIENCE OF OTHERS THIS IS BY
WE ASK YOUR SUPPORT TODAY ON
EIGHTY NINE SEVEN FIVE IT WILL
HELP INSURE CALIFORNIA IS
PREPARED. FOR WHAT IS TO COME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SIR.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS READ OUT
THAT EXCUSE ME READ ADDISON
BEHALF TO SEE THE REDWOODS
LEAGUE HERE IN SUPPORT TODAY WE
APPRECIATE THE LAND SIDE OF THIS
EQUATION AS WELL THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF ACTIVITIES TO OUR RATHER
IN UP NORTH AND SOUTH WE ARE
THERE'S COORDINATION AND ACTIONS.
AROUND CLIMATE CHANGE THAT DON'T
JUST STOP AT THE BORDER IT'S FOR
THAT REASON WE'RE IN SUPPORT
TODAY.
HISTORICALLY THE RESOURCES
SECRETARY AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE HAVE ENGAGE IN ACTIVITIES
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT THE LEGISLATURE HAS NEVER
REALLY PUT ANYTHING IN THE CODE
HASN'T COULD A STAT IT HASN'T
CREATED A STATUE TO PUT.
PARAMETERS CRITERIA AROUND THAT
WE THINK THIS BILL.
GOES ALONG WITH SETTING THE
STAGE FOR THOSE ACTIVITIES IN
THERE FOR SUPPORT.
I WOULD ALSO BE REMISS IF I
DIDN'T MENTION IT SENATOR Y.
CASKET HAS A NUMBER POLICY IDEAS.
AROUND HOW THE STATE SHOULD BE
DOING ACTIVITIES AS WELL AND
WHILE WE KNOW WE'VE WORKED
THROUGH BOTH.
A COMMITTEE TO DIFFERENT POLICY
COMMITTEES HERE IN THE SENATE.
I'M ASSUMING IF THE SENATOR WILL
RAISE QUESTIONS ABOUT -- PR.
AT SOME POINT WE PRIDE BE VERY
OPEN TO HAVING THAT CONVERSATION
AS WELL BUT I BELIEVE WE'RE
WAITING TO HEAR FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WHETHER THEY
THINK ANOTHER.
ENTITY OTHER THAN THE RESOURCES
SECTOR SHOULD BE THE PERSON SO
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
I'M OTHER FOLKS ONE OUT ON IN
SUPPORT. ONE REYES OPPOSITION
CONCERNS.
OKAY BANDS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS BUT THEN WILL COST.
MY SCHOOL CHAMPION.
I THINK THE STAFF REPORT DOES A
GOOD JOB OF DISCUSSING DE I
GUESS THE DIFFERENCE OF OPINION
WE HAVE I THINK THE IDEA OF
HAVING AN INTERNATIONAL
SPOKESPERSON.
IS IS APPROPRIATE -- S. O. P. R.
HAS -- CHOIR CERTAIN
JURISDICTION OVER STATE POLICY
FOR ROUTE ALL THE AGENT
THROUGHOUT ALL THE AGENCIES NOT
JUST WITH RESOURCES BUT WITH
PUBLIC CAL WITH AGRICULTURE
WHICH TRANSPORTATION.
SO I'M.
YOU TO YOUR BILL YOUR BILL I AM
I I BELIEVE THAT I'M MOVING
FORWARD WITH BED RESILIENCY
OFFICER THAT WOULD CODIFY WITHIN.
R. AS IN STATUTE.
THE EXISTENCE OF WERE I KNOW IF
PEOPLE HISTORICALLY BEEN CONCERT
OKAY ARE GIVEN WHAT GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER DID THING JUST
SORT OF CHANGE CHANGE OF BODY
ELSE WITH THE CONVOCATION.
I WANT LIKE YOUR COMMENTS ON
THAT HOW THAT WOULD CHANGE THE
DIFFERENCE FOR THE APPARATUS OF
THE STATE GOVERNMENT.
WITH WITH THE RESILIENT OFFICER
WITHIN THE OAK BAR.
OPPOSITION AND THEN HAVING THAT.
THIS FUNCTION IN OPR MEMBER I'M
ARGUING FOR OKAY ARE AND NOT
NECESSARILY A CANCER RESOURCE
AGENCY BUT FOR OKAY ARE FOR
THESE.
ADAPTATION AND LONG TERM
PLANNING.
I MEAN I'M NOT HERE TO MAKE AN
ARGUMENT TO SAY THAT YOUR IDEA
IS.
NOT AS GOOD AS OUR IDEA AND I
MEAN I MEAN I THINK.
YOU KNOW THE WAY I LOOK AT THIS
IS.
YOU KNOW WE'VE NEVER GIVEN THE
AUTHORITY TO THE SECRETARY OF
NATURAL RESOURCES TO CLOSE TO
CARRY THIS OUT THE SECRETARY OF
NATURAL RESOURCES ALREADY WORKS
WITH -- P. R. TO TRY TO WORK ON
THESE THESE DIFFERENT ISSUES
SECRETARY NATURAL RESOURCES
ALREADY WORKING ON A GLOBAL
LEVEL WHEN IT COMES TO DIFFERENT
ISSUES JUST NOT THIS SPECIFIC
ISSUE.
AND SO I MEAN MY ARGUMENT WOULD
BE WHY NOT GIVE THE SECRETARY OF
NATURAL RESOURCES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CARRY OUT THESE
THESE DUTIES BEFORE WE'VE WE
DECIDE TO CREATE AOTHER
POSITION I DON'T HAVE AN OPINION.
THAT OPR WE SHOULD WE SHOULD IN
CREATING A POSITION WITHIN.
UNDER OPR OR OR ANYTHING ELSE I
JUST THINK THAT WHEN IT COMES TO
THIS SPECIFIC ISSUE WE HAVE AN
ENTITYWE HAVE AN AGENCY IS
ALREADY WORKING WITH THE P. R. --
SECRETARY MATCH RESOURCES I
SECRETARY LAIRD WELL CABLE
EQUIPPED TO HANDLE THESE TYPES
OF ISSUES ALREADY DEALING WITH
THESE TYPES OF ISSUES WE GIVEN
THE AUTHORITY I THINK THAT THIS
WOULD BE.
A VERY GOOD OPTION FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN -- YOU KNOW WE HAVEN'T
HEARD.
IN NECESSARILY ANYTHING EITHER
WAY FROM THE ADMINISTRATION IN
TERMS WHAT THEY WOULD.
LIKE TO SEE.
BUT I DON'T SEE WHY ARE AT LEAST
AT THIS POINT BOTH BILL
SHOULDN'T BE MOVING FORWARD.
UNLESS THAT ADMINISTRATION
DECIDES TO PUT THE FINGER ON A
SCALE IN SOME WAY THAT OR
ANOTHERI JUST WOULDN'T.
YOU KNOW THE THE CHALLENGES THAT
THAT THE SECRETARY AND WHILE.
FORMER SECRETARY LARRY WAS.
ACTIVE IN THE IN THE ADAPTATION
IS ALSO ACTIVE IN THE CAT YOU
KNOW EVEN THOUGH IT GIVES THE
JURISDICTION.
TO THE EPA DIRECTOR HE SORT OF
HIS PERSONALITY AND THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION WAS SUCH THE THE
CONCERN THAT I HAVE ARTISTIC.
THE CAUTION THAT I HAVE IS THAT
THE P. R. HAS THAT CROSS AGENCY.
WHAT IF THEY GET IN A THE
POLLING FROM PUBLIC COUNTY
PULLING FROM TRANSPORTATION THE
POLAND FROM AGRICULTURE TO BE
PULLING FROM?
AND APPARATUS FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE THOUGH I KNOW THE REPORT
IS WRITTEN BY THE RESOURCES
AGENCY IN THAT AND THAT'S WHERE
HOW WE GOT IT SET UP.
THAT'S THE NO I LOOK FORWARD TO
DISCUSSIONS I'M.
N. PARTICULARLY GIVEN YOU KNOW
THE OTHER WORK I CARP IN THE D.
V. ADAPTATION.
ACTIVITY THAT'S GOING ON WITH
THAT OKAY ARE.
I'M GOING TO STAY OFF THE BILL
TODAY [inaudible]
YES.
THE THEME FOR THE DAY OKAY.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
CATCHES SO I THINK WHAT WE'LL DO
I'M ILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION
LATER NO PROBLEM -- AND IF YOU
HAVE ANY FINAL THOUGHTS ON I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THE SENATOR TO TRY TO RESOLVE.
THE ISSUE.
WHEN IT HAD TO DO SO BUT AT THIS
TIME I THINK?
YOU KNOW THE SECRETARY NATURI
SOURCES MORE THAN A CABLE
EQUIPPED -- SECRETARY RESOURCES
IS PROHIBITED WORKING WITH ANY
OTHER AGENCY -- IF THEY IF THEY
CHOOSE TO WORK WITH THAT AGENCY
SUBJECT.
DOUBLE TO GET ALL THE
INFORMATION -- P. R. HAS ALREADY
WORKING DIRECTLY WITH A P. ARE
WE THINK IT'S AN APPROPRIATE --
SELF FOR WHEN IT COMES TO OCEAN
RESILIENCY AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ON TIMES APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU MUCH I APPRECIATE I
WOULD HEAR FROM CYBER CHU.
IS HERE TO PRESENT AB.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE GOOD
AFTERNOON.
SENATORS MISTER CHAIR LIKE TO
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS.
AND THANK THE CONSULTANT FOR
WORKING CLOSELY WITH OUR OFFICE.
TO WORK OUT LANGUAGE.
THIS IS A COMMITTEE THAT ONE
KNOWS HOW IT UNACCEPTABLE IT IS
THAT IN CALIFORNIA IN TWO
pMILLION CALIFORNIANS WHO LACK
ACCESS TO CLEAN WATER.
AND THAT THERE ARE WATER
DISTRICTS WITH SO MUCH DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE THAT THEY'RE ON THE
VERGE OF CONTAMINATED DRINKING
WATER.
MANY OF THE SYSTEMS CAN AFFORD
TO MAKE THE IMPROVEMENTS I NEED.
SECOND A COMEDY CONSOLIDATION.
CONSOLIDATION CAN ENSURE.
THAT OUR CONSTITUENTS RECEIVE
CLEAN WATER BUT THE APPROVAL
PROCESS CAN OFTEN BE VERY TIME
CONSUMING.
IT'S A PC'S OBLIGATION TO REVIEW
PROPOSED CONSOLIDATIONS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY.
THEY HAVE TAKEN A LONG TIME AND
THE LONGER REVIEW TAKES WE NO
LONGER ARE CONSTITUENTS ARE LEFT
WITH WATER THAT'S NOT DRINKABLE.
WE NEED TO BOTH PROTECT EXISTING
REPAIRS AND DELIVER CLEAN WATER
OUR BILL WOULD IMPOSE FLEXIBLE
DEADLINES ON THE CPUC FOR
CONSOLIDATION APPROVAL.
AND ENSURE THAT THE CPC HELP
IMPLEMENT OUR STATE'S POLICY TO
PROVIDE CLEAN DRINKING WATER
WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
OUR WITNESSES.
JENNIFER COMPUTER ON BEHALF OF
THE WATER ASSOCIATION WHERE THEY
SI PC REGULATED WATER UTILITY IS.
I AM JUST BRIEFLY WE HOPE THIS
BILL WILL HELP YOU SEE AND HELP
OUR WATER UTILITIES -- MEET THE
STATE SCHOOLS TO HELP
CONSOLIDATE SMALL DRINKING WATER
SYSTEMS BUT DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
SAFE.
WATER.
EVAN JACOBS CALIFORNIA AMERICAN
WATER IN FIRST PLACE PRESIDENCY
W. AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS BUT IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME I WON'T.
READ MY PREPARED REMARKS
[inaudible]
APPRECIATE THAT -- I'M SURE THEY
WERE BRILLIANT.
OKAY ANYONE WAS OUT ON IN
SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION CONCERNS I DON'T
THINK IT'S ANY RESTAURANT
POSITION BILL QUESTIONS THOUGHTS
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THE MOVE ICE CASKEY.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
A CONSIDERATION OKAY YOU HAVE TO
KEEP ITS COLOR.
I AM NUMBER TWENTY OR AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ALLEN.
ALLEN HI BATES DELI.
DELI AYE HILL SKINNER.
STERN AYE CASKEY [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- I WILL HOLD OPEN
FOR THE FOLKS THAT ON OKAY WELL
NEXT YEAR FROM SOME OF OUR
CARILLO WITH YOUR PRESENT A. B..
FIFTEEN HUNDRED AND ACTUALLY
HOUSES SENTENCES YOU ME.
A PERSON DOESN'T.
EVEN READING.
THEM TWENTY TWO IN YOUR PACKETS
MEMBERS.
YES PLEASE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I'M HERE PERCENT A. B..
FIFTEEN HUNDRED WHICH WOULD
STRAIGHTEN LOCAL AUTHORITY TO
TAKE IMMEDIATE ACTION AGAINST
LOCAL THREATS TO THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY INCLUDING THE
ABILITY. FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO DIRECT THE FACILITY OR A
PORTION OF THE FACILITY TO
TEMPORARILY DISCONTINUE THE
OPERATIONS THAT COST AND
EXPOSURE.
IN CALIFORNIA MULTIPLE
REGULATORY AUTHORITIES HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER BUSINESSES
THAT HANDLE OR GENERATE
HAZARDOUS WASTE.
AND MATERIALS THAT POSE A RISK
TO PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
LOCALLY A CERTIFIED UNIFIED
PROGRAM AGENCY IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR IMPLEMENTING AND ENFORCING.
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS AND WASTE
LAWS AND THE LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICER HAS GENERALLY GENERAL AT
THE READY TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC'S HEALTH.
AN EXPANDED AUTHORITY ONLY AFTER
A COUNTY WIDE EMERGENCY IS
DECLARED.
CURRENTLY SOME FACILITIES THAT
EMIT HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCES
CONTINUE TO OPERATE BECAUSE THEY
DO NOT MEET.
REGULATORY REGULATORY MINIMUM
STANDARDS TO CEASE OPERATIONS
IMMEDIATELY.
A PRIME EXAMPLE OF THIS TYPE OF
ATROCITY IMPACTING OUR
COMMUNITIES IS THE EXIDE BATTERY
RECYCLING FACILITY IN VERNON
CALIFORNIA WHICH CONTINUOUSLY
EXPOSED FAMILIES AND RESIDENTS
OF MY ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY
ONE ANOTHER SURROUNDING
DISTRICTS AND COMMUNITY STUDENT
DANGEROUS LEVELS OF TOXIC LEAD.
THE DELAY TO SHUT THIS FACILITY
DOWN LED TO THE EMISSIONS FROM
THE PLANT.
CONTAMINATING MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND OF A RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES ACROSS A NUMBER OF
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING BOYLE
HEIGHTS.
AND HE'S LOS ANGELES.
ABOUT FIFTY AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED
IS A RESPONSE TO THE CONCERNS
AND FRUSTRATIONS EXPRESSED BY
OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
THIS BILL IS IMPERATIVE TO
ASSURE THAT LOCAL AUTHORITIES
CLOSEST TO THE COMMUNITIES
IMPACTED BY TOXIC POLLUTION.
CAN EXPEDITIOUSLY.
PUBLIC HEALTH AND PUBLIC SAFETY.
AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED WILL ENABLE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TUTOR DIRECT
A FACILITY OR A PORTION OF THE
FACILITY TO TEMPORARILY
DISCONTINUE THE OPERATIONS THAT
HAVE EXPOSE OUR COMMUNITIES. TO
HARMFUL TOXIC MATERIALS UNTIL
THAT ISSUE.
IS CORRECTED.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE ON THIS BILL AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE WORK
WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
INVOLVED AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD.
WITH.
WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY IS
CHARLENE COUNT THAT AS WITH THE
LA COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH.
RANDY SAWYER WITH CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AND JUSTIN MILAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH.
WE WE TYPICALLY HEARING FROM TO
WHEN THIS IS OF AND I KNOW
THERE'S NO RUSH OPPOSITION BUT
HAPPY TO HEAR FROM EVERYBODY BUT
PLEASE RESPECT.
GOOD MORNING I'LL BE BRIEF MY
NAME IS CHARLENE CONTRAST
DIRECTOR OF TOXICOLOGY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ASSESSMENT AND A
DEPUTY HEALTH OFFICER WITH LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED IS ABOUT
BUILDING ON EXISTING LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICER AUTHORITIES TO
TAKE IMMEDIATE ACTION AGAINST
LOCAL THREATS TO PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY. TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS
HAVE THE CURRENT LONGSTANDING
AUTHORITY TO IMMEDIATELY ORDER
THE TEMPORARY CLOSURE OF A
CONTAMINATED BEACH. TO ORDER THE
CLOSURE OF A RESTAURANT FOR
UNSANITARY CONDITIONS OR TO TAKE
ANY NECESSARY ACTION IN RESPONSE
TO FOOD OR WATER BORNE ILLNESS
OR COMMUNICABLE DISEASE.
THE LOCAL HEALTH OFFICER
AUTHORITY OVER THESE ENTITIES IS
BASED ON THE ESTABLISHED
UNDERSTANDING THAT PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS MUST PREVENT THE
SPREAD OF THE DISEASE.
HOWEVER WHEN A CHEMICAL THREAT
ENDANGERS PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS
LACK STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO TAKE
SIMILAR IMMEDIATE ACTION.
AGAINST THE RESPONSIBLE PARTY.
A LOS SANDERS COUNTY HAS TO FACE
NUMEROUS CRISES WHEN WHICH
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES RELEASE
CHEMICALS INTO THE ENVIRONMENT
PRESENTING SUBSTANTIAL
ENDANGERMENT TO LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
I THIS BILL SEEKS TO ALIGN THE
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICER AT THE
ALREADY OVER CHEMICAL THREATS
WITH ITS ESTABLISHED AUTHORITY
TO STOP BIOLOGICAL THREATS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO EXPRESS LOS ERRORES COUNTY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RANDY
SO WHERE MY JOB TITLES AND THE
CHIEF AN ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
AND HAS THIS MATERIALS OFFICER
FOR CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
IT DID THE BILL WOULD NOT ONLY
STRENGTHEN THE LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICERS ABILITY.
BUT ALSO WOULD GIVE THE COOPER
SERVICE CERTIFIED UNIFIED
PROGRAM AGENCIES WHO REGULATE A
NUMBER OF A HAZARD MATERIALS
PROGRAMS.
THE THIRTY THEY ARE YOU OVERSEE
THESE FACILITIES AND IS IN A
COMMITTEE.
IF THERE IS A ANY IMMINENT.
ENDANGERMENT TO THE COMMUNITY TO
BE ABLE TO SHUT THIS BACILLUS
DOWN.
IT ALSO REAR GIVES ABILITY FOR
THE IT'S TO TAKE ACTION AGAINST
FACILITIES OR REQUIRE FACILITIES
TO PAY THAT THE SICK CAN BE
ASSESSED AGAINST THEM -- IN IF
THEY DO NOT DO THAT IN ITS WE
CAN TAKE SOME FORCE CHIN AGAINST
ISRAELIS.
ARE NOT PAYING THEIR PLEASE
[inaudible]
I'M.
WHEN IF AND WHEN THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT'S
HAPPENING CONTRA COSTA COUNTY?
OF COURSE IF THEY HAD WE HAD A
FACILITY THAT READ THE RESULT IN
A SOFT DRINK AS A CLOUD WITH
THIS BILL FROM ESPECIALLY.
WE'RE TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
SOUGHT MEDICAL ATTENTION THIS
RELEASED.
AFTER HIS RELEASE OCCURRED THERE
WERE A SERIES OF SMALLER
RELEASES FROM THE SAME FACILITY
THE IMPACT OF THE COMMUNITY.
WE LACK THE ABILITY REQUIRED
THAT SALINAS SHOP STOP THEIR
OPERATIONS THE SAFETY EVALUATION
COULD BE PERFORMED.
AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED WOULD GRANT
US AT THE READY TO DIRECT SUCH
FACILITIES CEASE OPERATIONS.
AND DISSECT THE CITY OF AB
VALUATION IS PERFORMED.
I THESE BUSINESS.
WE HAVE THE NUMBER SIZE BUSINESS
FROM A SMALL.
MOM AND POP SHOPS LIKE ON A
REPAIR SHOPS ARE HAVE TO
REFINERIES WITHIN OUR
JURISDICTION.
AND SO WE WOULD TAKE DIFFERENT
ACTIONS BASED ON WHAT HAPPENS
WITH THOSE DIFFERENT FACILITIES --
EXCELLENT.
THAT'S THANK YOU FOR YOUR THANK
GOODNESS MY NEXT.
YEAH IT DOES SAY THAT WE'VE MADE
NUMEROUS TIMES WITH THE INDUSTRY
YOU MAY HEAR SOME CONCERNS FROM
INDUSTRY -- WE HAVE ADDRESSED A
COUPLE OF THEIR CONCERNS
INCLUDING ADDING SPECIFICITY ON
THE CONDITIONS IN WHICH WOULD
TAKE THIS ACTION SO WE BELIEVE
WE'VE ACTED IN GOOD FAITH TO
TRYING.
TO ENSURE THAT THIS ISN'T AN
ARBITRARY AND CAPRICIOUS ACTION
BY EITHER THE HEALTH OFFICERS OF
THE COOPERS WE TRY ABOUT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF A B.
[inaudible] FIFTEEN HUNDRED
FIFTEEN HUNDRED CAT THE WORK
WITH THE HEALTH OFFICER'S
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON JACK ANDERSON
WITH THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THEY COME WITH THE LA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WERE PROUD
TO SPONSOR.
JAKE FUEL ON BEHALF OF SOUTH
COAST AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS I'M
MARGOT PARKS WITH THE WESTERN
STATES.
ASIAN I'M THE APOLOGIZE WE DO
NOT HAVE A FORMAL POSITION
LETTER INTO THE COMMITTEE ON THE
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH AUTHOR.
AND THE SPONSORS OF THE BELLAS
MISTER MILAN AND AB REFERRED TO
AND WE HAVE MADE I THINK
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS ON SOME OF
THAT.
THAT INITIAL CONCERNS WITH THE
BELL AND WE HAVE ONE OUTSTANDING
ISSUE LAUGHED -- AS YOUR
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS OTES AND
SOME OF THE PROVISIONS FOR THE
COOPER AUTHORITIES HAVE SOME
REALLY IMPORTANT DUE PROCESS
PIECES BAKED INTO IT.
WE'RE LOOKING TO SEE THAT.
BEARD IN SOME CAPACITY FOR THE
AUTHORITY GRANTED TO THE LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS IN THE ABSENCE
OF DECLARING A LOCAL EMERGENCY.
SO I THINK THAT WERE WERE
CONTINUING TO HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AND AGAIN WANTING
AUTHOR.
I. AND THE SPONSORS FOR ENGAGE
IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS SO WE'RE
HOPING TO GET THAT.
AT LEAST THOUGH AND AT THIS
POINT WE UNFORTUNATELY HAS LOST
MENTORED BY THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR WORK [inaudible]
NEXT.
YOU DON KHAKI MCCUE CAP CAN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR AND ONE
ECONOMIC BALANCE EVEN AS HE
DOESN'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL OPPOSE
POSITION -- BUT WOULD ECHO THE
COMMENTS ARE ABOUT THE WESTERN
STATES PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTATIVE.
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS ARE WORKING
WITH US ON AT THE MOMENT THAT'S
FAR I'M A JUST A LINER COMMENTS
ARE RELATIVE TO THAT ONE
OUTSTANDING ISSUE AROUND LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS -- CRITERIA FOR
ARE THESE TYPES OF SCENARIOS A
DECISION SASS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS ON GOING THANK YOU.
JOHN JACOB WITH THE CHEMICAL
INDUSTRY COUNCIL CALIFORNIA.
A SIMILAR POSITION -- WE'VE BEEN
WATCHING THIS BILL IN THE
BACKGROUND VERY PLEASED WITH THE
PROGRESS THE THAT'S BEEN MADE
THUS FAR.
AND THE ATMOSPHERE AROUND IT --
BUT WE TO HAVE THE CONCERNWITH
THAT ONE REMAINING ISSUE -- WERE
BOTH WILL BE ABLE.
TO RECONCILE IT TO MUTUAL
SATISFACTION.
ALL RIGHT LET'S CLOSE PUBLIC
HEARING BRING IT BACK.
TO MEMBERS QUESTIONS.
WHERE IS THE FINE MONEY GO?
WE TYPICALLY S. SPLIT THE FIND
MANY IN IN NOT COOPER PROGRAM I
DON'T ANTICIPATE THERE WILL BE
ACTUALLY FINDS IT LEVY BY THE
HEALTH OFFICES.
THEY CAN ON SO THAT WITH THE
COOPER PROGRAM LONG STANDING
SPLIT FOR THE FIND LIVE IS HERE
THIS ISN'T A BOUNTY PROGRAM BY
ANY MEANS WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT ISSUING FINESAND
PENALTIES.
WE REALLY TALKING ABOUT THE
CLOSURE IF THESE AN IMMINENT
PUBLIC HEALTH RATE.
AND JUST REMEMBER THE THAT
AUTHORITIES ALREADY THERE FOR
THE HEALTH OFFICES WE JUST
ENSURING THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO
GO THROUGH A PROCESS.
OF REQUIRING THIS.
TO THE HEALTH CLUBS TO DECLARE A
STATE OF EMERGENCY IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTY JUST IT IS THIS ONE ISSUE.
I GUESS THE QUESTION WOULD BE
FOLLOW UP IS IS IS THEIR
DISAGREEMENT ABOUT WHEN.
THE EMERGENCY IS IMMINENT AND
WHEN IT'S NOT EMANATE IT SEEMS
LIKE THAT LAW HAS BEEN MORE OR
LESS [inaudible]
ESTABLISH.
RIGHT THAT IS ESTABLISHED AT THE
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICER THAT
DETERMINATION IS MADE DEPENDING
ON A VARIETY OF FACTORS AND SO
CURRENTLY OUT OF AN EXAMPLE
WOULD BE IF WE HAD HUNDREDS OF
CASES.
OF LOU WE DON'T NECESSARILY
DECLARE A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY ON THAT BUT IF WE AD
A SINGLE CASE.
OF SMALL POX WE WOULD DECLARE A
NATIONAL YOU KNOW WORLD WIDE
EMERGENCY SO CRITERIA
ESTABLISHED DEPENDING ON OF THE
A VARIETY OF FACTORS IN SO --
CURRENTLY YOU KNOW OUR
BIOLOGICAL AND I KNOW THE CLOSES
THE GAPS THAT THE COUPONS HAVE
WITH EXISTING LAW WITH THE TSC
THAT IS JUST.
HELPFUL I GUESS.
NO SAID EVERYBODY'S ON THE SAME
PAGE WHEN IT COMES TO THESE.
INCIDENCES [inaudible]
OKAY.
THE ACTING CHAIR WILL ENTERTAIN
A MOTION [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
NO.
CAN I CAN.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL WAIT FOR THE
RETURN OF OTHER MEMBERS TO MOVE
YOU HAVE ANYTHING THIS SAYING
CLOSE.
YES OF MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I WAS JUST SAY AB FIFTEEN
HUNDRED AS A RESULT OF A HEARING.
HELD IN THE EAST SIDE OF LOS
ANGELES.
WITH SPEAKER RENDON ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MIGUEL SANTIAGO AND
MYSELF INCLUDED.
WITH HUNDREDS OF COMMUNITY
MEMBERS THAT HAVE BEEN SEVERELY
IMPACTED BY THE EXITE
CONTAMINATION ON THE EAST SIDE.
THE FACT THAT EXCITED WAS
ALLOWED TO CONTINUE TO OPERATE
WHILE EMITTING SUCH.
TOXINS TO THE COMMUNITIES AND
THE FACT THAT IN CORRELATION TO
THAT YOU CAN LOOK AT HEALTH
RECORDS OF OF KIDS WITH
DISABILITIES MOTHERS WHO ARE
PREGNANT AND WHO ARE EXPOSED THE
FACT THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXINS IN SUCH AS CONTROL HAS
TAKEN YEARS TO ACTUALLY.
IMPLEMENT ANY CHANGE THE FACT
THAT OVER TEN THOUSAND HOMES
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED.
OVER AND ONLY ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY HAVE BEEN CLEANED UP
WHILE THE STATE HAS ALLOCATED
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS STORE. FOR
CLEAN UP IS JUST.
INCREDIBLY ATROCIOUS AND YOU'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND SO THIS BILL AB
FIFTEEN HUNDRED IS AN EFFORT TO
ADDRESS COMMUNITY NEEDS FIRST.
WE CAN DO A LOT OF WORK HERE IN
SACRAMENTO BUT THE REALITY IS
THAT WE'RE NOT ON THE GROUND AND
WE HAVE TO ALLOW FOLKS TO DO THE
WORK ON THE GROUND AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST UNABLE TO
MOVE THIS BOAT.
OKAY AT APPROPRIATE TIME WE'LL
DO THAT THANK YOU WE'RE NOT
GONNA TURN TO ITEM NUMBER ONE ON
OUR CALENDAR THE BASIL
CONVENTION THIS IS SENATE
RESOLUTION. FORTY SEVEN ACTING
SURE DOLLY I WILL.
GOOD EVENING MEMBERS.
THE GLOBAL TRANS BOUNDARY WASTE
TRADE IS A MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
INDUSTRY INCLUDES TOXIC WASTE.
MANUFACTURING WASTE ELECTRONIC
WASTE AND WELL AS RECOVERABLE
MATERIALS FROM FINAL THE SPOILS.
OR RECYCLING.
AS THE INDUSTRY GREW IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES AND THE
EIGHTIES THERE WERE SEVERAL HIGH
PROFILE INCIDENTS OF WASTE
DUMPING AND INCIDENCE OF AT C.
AS WELL AS STORIES OF WEALTHY
NATIONS DUMPING THEIR WASTE.
I'M POOR NATIONS THE BASAL
CONVENTION CONVENE IN. NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE AMIR THIRTY YEARS
AGO TO PLACE PROTOCOLS ON
INTERNATIONAL WAY STRAIGHT
REQUIRING PRIVATE CONCERT.
PRIOR CONSENT FROM THE RECEIVING
CAMP.
COUNTRY TO ACCEPT WASTE AND
RECYCLED MATERIALS.
WELL THE UNITED STATES SIGNED
THE CONVENTION AND THESENATE
APPROVED IT NINETEEN NINETY TWO
CONGRESS THAT THE STATE HAS
FAILED TO AMEND THE FEDERAL LAW
TO CONFORM WITH THE CONVENTION.
WHICH IS PREVENTING RATIFICATION
AND PARTICIPATION IN THE
CONFERENCE OF THE PARTIES OR WAS
NGUYEN.
OFTEN HEAR COP IDENTIFICA SPEND
AT THE CONVENTIONS PROTOCOL.
BECAUSE WE HAVE FAILED TO RATIFY
THE CONVENTION THE UNITED STATES
IS HAD TO NEGOTIATE COSTLY
AGREEMENTS WITH INDIVIDUAL
COUNTRIES TO SEND AND RECEIVE
OUR WASTE.
MOST RECENT CONFERENCE OF THE
PARTIES HELD JUST. TWO MONTHS
AGO IN MAY OF TWENTY NINETEEN
ADDED CONTAMINATED IN MIXED
PLASTIC WASTE TO THE CONVENTION
PROTOCOLS.
THIS RESOLUTION SR FORTY SEVEN
STATES.
PORT FOR THE BILL BASEL
CONVENTION AND CALLS ON CONGRESS
TO AMEND THE FEDERAL LAW TO
ALLOW THE UNITED STATES TO FULLY
RATIFY THE CONVENTION AND TAKE
PART.
IN THE CONFERENCE OF PARTIES.
SENATE RESOLUTION FORTY SEVEN
POINTS OUT THAT THE FAILURE TO
RATIFY THE BASEL CONVENTION
AFFECTS MANY CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES AS THEY OFTEN DO
BUSINESS IN AND WITH COUNTRIES
THAT ARE BOUND BY THE
CONVENTIONS WASTE PROTOCOLS.
MANY CANNOT RE IMPORT PRECIOUS
METALS MATERIALS FOR RECYCLING
INTO NEW PRODUCTS.
THEIR VOICE GOES ON HEARD IN THE
NEGOTIATIONS WITHOUT THE UNITED
STATES AT THE TABLE.
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRESS IN WASTE
REDUCTION AND RECYCLING HAS BEEN
HINDERED BY CHINA AS A TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BàN WHICH
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT PREVIOUSLY ON
THE ON SOME PLASTICS AND OTHER
RECYCLABLES.
AND OUR PROGRESS WILL CONTINUE
TO HIT NEW BARRIERS AS LONG AS
THE UNITED STATES STAYS OUT OF
THE ENVIRONMENTAL TREATY.
SENATE RESOLUTION FORTY SEVEN
ADS CALIFORNIA'S VOICE TO THIS
IMPORTANT ENVIRONMENTAL TREATY.
THERE ARE SUPPORTERS.
WE WANT ONE MORE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK MARIE
WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE IN
SUPPORT OF THE RESOLUTION.
JUST REALLY TWO POINTS REALLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE CENTER
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
NUMBER.
ONE THE THE THE POINT THAT THIS
WHAT THE REST OF THE WORLD HAS.
ACTIVELY AGREED TO WITH THIS IN.
PLASTIC MIXED PLASTIC PLASTIC
WASTE TO THIS IS THAT WE SHOULD
NOT BE EXPORTING.
ON PROCESS MIXED PLASTIC WASTE
TO DEVELOPING COUNTRIES BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE.
THE CAPABILITY OF ACTUALLY AS WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT EARLIER.
REMANUFACTURING THIS MATERIAL.
THEY'RE USING LOW WAVE OF LOW
WAGE LABOR. TO SORT THROUGH IT
AND THEY'RE TAKING THE RESIDUAL
PLASTIC AND THAT STUFF BUT THERE
IS NO MARKET.
FOR THEIR SIMPLY THROWING AWAY
WHERE THEY'RE BURNING IT IN
THEIR COUNTRIES AND WE ARE
COUNTING IT AS RECYCLING CELL I
APPRECIATE CAN BRING FORWARD
THIS RESOLUTION IN ORDER TO KIND
OF AGAIN.
UNDERSCORE THAT POINT AND
IDEALLY WE HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE.
CALIFORNIA COULD.
SET ITS OWN COURSE WITH REGARD
TO TRADE AGREEMENTS AS A CALM AS
RICH AS RELATES TO THE
ENVIRONMENT WE CAN'T DO THAT.
WE'RE DEPENDENT ON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THIS IS A
RESOLUTION THAT WOULD.
HAVE CALIFORNIA AT LEAST CALL
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO TAKE
THIS ACTION VIRGIN AYE.
MISTER ACTING CHAIR IS THE STAFF
REPORT ABLY POINTS OUT.
ALL THE THE COMMUNITY OF NATIONS
EVERYBODY HAS SIGNED ON TO THIS
CONVENTION EXCEPT FOR THE UNITED
STATES AND HAITI.
AND I THINK THAT IT'S TIME FOR
US TO STOP BEING OUT LIARS.
AND TWENTY THE WORLD.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
STAFF.
THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
AND I WILL BRING IT BACK
[inaudible]
YEAH.
IF THERE WERE MOTION I WOULD
URGE AND I'VE.
SO I CAN ADD LIVE MISTER CHAIR
IF YOU WANT ME TO ALONG CLOSE.
I CAN RE READ THAT STATEMENT --
WITH THAT GO AHEAD IF YOU LIKE
NOW NOW I'M DONE I'M DONE.
I'M JUST WAITING FOR MOTION
.
YOU'RE THE CHAIR NOW.
THE SERGEANTS AT THEY CAN CALL
THE REMAINING MEMBERS WE HAVE
ONE MORE BILL LEFT ON OUR AGENDA
AND THEN WE WILL BE DONE SO WE
CAN CALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WHO ARE NOT HERE.
AND IF THE OFFER [inaudible]
CAN [inaudible]
HE I'VE JUST BEEN INFORMED THAT
THE CHAIR WILL BE PRESENTING THE
FINAL BILL.
SO WE ARE ALL WAITING FOR THE
CHAIR. FOR I WILL PRESENT THE
BILL HOW.
WE'LL WAY FOR THE CHAIR.
WITH THE CHAIR I AM A CO AUTHOR
BUT WILL WAIT FOR THE CHAIR.
ALL RIGHT -- WE'LL TAKE POTS
TWENTY THIS IS A. B. TEN EIGHTY
WITH THE OUR CHAIR OF EQ.
SENATOR -- ALLEN PLEASE YOU SEE
WELL THANK YOU I KNOW THIS IS A
LITTLE OUT OF ORDER I AND I I
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S -- I
PATIENTS I WAS JUST PRESENTING
OVER -- ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE I'M
I AS YOU ME AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
I AM A AUTHOR OF AN IDENTICAL --
BILL ON THE SENATE SIDE SEVERAL
WE OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE HAS
HEARD THIS BILL.
IN THE PAST THAT IS SB FIFTY
FOUR ON THE PRINCIPLE CO AUTHOR
OF ASSEMBLY SIZED VERSION AB TEN
EIGHTY AND I AS A FAVOR TO THE
THE PRINCIPAL AUTHOR -- DECEMBER
GONZALEZ I PRESENT THE BILL TO
YOU TODAY.
AS SHE'S ALREADY DONE SEATED US
SO I JUST WANNA.
FIRST EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE
MEMBER AND SEND AND TAKE THIS
EXTRAORDINARY COMMITTEE AND A
HUMBLE CHAIR. FOR FOR ALL OF ITS
WORK ON THIS ON THIS -- ON THIS
ISSUE HI THIS IS AN AREA THAT WE
IS AN ISSUE WE SPENT SOMETIME
LOOKING AT MEMBERS WE HAD ALL
HEARING ON THIS -- LOOKING AT
THE CHALLENGES OF WASTE OF
LITTER OF THE FACT THAT -- THAT
OUR CITIES ARE NOW SPENDING
CLOSE TO A BILLION CLOSE TO HALF
LITTER CLEAN UP ALONE.
THERE IS A HUGE PROBLEM ON OUR
HANDS OF THE GUARDS TO WASTE
REDUCTION AND WASTE MANAGEMENT.
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT THE
FOLKS IN CHINA WITH NATIONAL
SORT POLICY DECIDED NOT TO TAKE
ARE.
RECYCLED MATERIALS ANYMORE AND
SO SO MUCH OF WHAT WE WHAT WHAT
WE WHAT WHAT WHAT I TO BE
RECYCLED IS NOT GETTING RECYCLED
IT'S AN INFRASTRUCTURAL
CHALLENGE IT'S A MARKET
CHALLENGE.
AND I WHAT WE'RE TRULY DO
ACTUALLY UNLIKE SOME OF FOR OUR
COLLEAGUES ATTEMPTS WERE REALLY
IT YOU WHICH ARE WHAT YOUR ONE
OFFICER VERY PRESCRIPTIVE WE'RE
NOT TRYING TO BE TOO
PRESCRIPTIVE WE'RE ACTUALLY.
WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO TELL.
OUR AGENCY CAL RESPECT. TO WORK
VERY CLOSELY WITH INDUSTRY WITH
A CITIES WITH WASTE MANAGEMENT
FOLKS.
AND HOLLERS TO FIGURE OUT A
STRATEGY. TO TO REFER TO REDUCE
SINGLE USE PLASTIC WASTE THAT
DOESN'T MEAN WE'RE GETTING RID
OF SINGLE USE PLASTIC.
WE'RE JUST HELPING TO PROVIDE
OLD OF A NUDGE SO THAT.
THE THE PACKAGING THAT WE DO
HAVE WILL BECOME MORE
SUSTAINABLE -- TRULY RECYCLABLE
AND WHEN I SAY RECYCLE BUT ONLY
TECHNICALLY RECYCLING ALLOWED
BUT RECYCLABLE AND RECYCLED IN
REAL LIFE.
YOU KNOW WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
LOTS OF ASPECTS OF INDUSTRY THAT
WILL WILL BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY
MEET THESE GOALS PRETTY EASILY --
BASICALLY WITH THE GUARDS THE
FOLKS WHO WORK IN A PLASTIC
WATER BOTTLE INDUSTRY BECAUSE
THE ONES INTO USING THE PLASTICS.
AREA ARE ACTUALLY HIGHLY
RECYCLABLE -- BUT WE NEED TO
KEEP PUSHING IN THIS AREA I
THINK ONE OF THE REASONS WHY YOU
HAVE SO MUCH PASSION SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL.
FROM OUR CITIES AND FROM OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THEY'RE REALLY DROWNING
RIGHT NOW -- IN WASTE WE USED TO
BE ABLE TO WE WERE USED TO GET
PAID FOR THE WASTE THAT WE WOULD
GIVE AWAY AND NOW WE'RE ACTUALLY
HAVING TO PAY. TO GO TO TO TO TO
SEND OFFER CYCLE MATERIALS SO
YOU WANT LET'S HEAR SOME FROM
SOME OF THE ATTENTION IS OUR
SUPPORTERS.
WHO ARE HERE?
PLEASE.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN ALAN MY NAME
IS AMY WILL FROM I'M CALIFORNIA
OCEAN POLICY MANAGER FOR THE
MONTEREY BAY AQUARIUM AND I'M
HERE TO EXPRESS THE AQUARIUM
STRONG SUPPORT BABY.
TEN EIGHTY THIS BILL ESTABLISHES
A MEANINGFUL GOAL AND
COMPREHENSIVE BRING MY DRESSING
THE GROWING PROBLEM OF PLASTIC
POLLUTION ARE OCEAN AND
WATERWAYS.
AN INCREASING BODY OF RESEARCH
IS SHOWING THAT MORE AND MORE
PLASTIC IS MAKING ITS WAY FROM
LAND TO SEE.
IMPACTING THE HEALTH OF OUR
OCEAN WILDLIFE.
THAT'S BECAUSE IN ALMOST EVERY
MARINE HABITAT ON EARTH EVEN ARE
PROTECTED CALIFORNIA WATERS ARE
NOT IMMUNE.
RECENT GALLUP RECENT AQUARIAN
RESEARCH FOUND PLASTIC PARTICLES.
THE WATER COLUMN MONTEREY BAY.
IN THE OCEAN SURFACE TO THE SEA
FLOOR.
I RESEARCH ALSO SHOWS THAT THE
MAJORITY OF THESE PARTICLES ARE
MADE OF THE SAME TYPES OF
PLASTIC IN SINGLE USE CONSUMER.
CONSUMER PRODUCTS.
IN FACT THE MOST ABUNDANT TYPE
OF PLASTIC WAS B. E. T. NUMBER
ONE WHICH IS COMMONLY USED IN
WATER BOTTLES.
TAKE OUT CONTAINERS AND PRODUCT
PACKAGING.
IT IS CLEAR THAT ARE DISPOSABLE
SINGLE USE PLASTIC SOCIETY IS A
MAJOR CONTRIBUTOR TO THE PROBLEM
OF OCEAN PLASTICS SOLUTION.
POLLUTION SOLUTIONS HERE WE
ADOPT SOLUTIONS WE HAD UP HERE
TO COME MODELS FOR THE REST OF
THE WORLD AND NO OTHER STATE IS
BETTER POSITIONED TO LEAD IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL IS A MAJOR STEP
TOWARDS A SUSTAINABLE FUTURE
PRIOR STATE AND FOR A PLANET.
IT WILL HELP ACCELERATE
INNOVATION AND REDUCE THE AMOUNT
OF WASTE GENERATED IN SINGLE USE
PLASTIC.
PACKAGING AND PRODUCTS AND
NOTABLY THIS IS THE FIRST
LEGISLATION ON THE ISSUE THAT
ADDRESSES THE SCALE OF THE
PROBLEM.
AT THE AQUARIUM WE BELIEVE
CONSUMERS INDUSTRY AND
GOVERNMENT ALL HAVE IMPORTANT
ROLES TO PLAY.
THROUGHOUT OUR LONG HISTORY OF
WORKING WITH INDUSTRY ON OCEAN
CONSERVATION ISSUES WE'VE
LEARNED THAT COLLECTIVE ACTION.
TAKEN BY PLAYERS THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE SUPPLY CHAIN IS CRUCIAL
TO LASTING SUCCESS.
THIS BILL WOULD HELP SET THE
CONDITIONS NEEDED TO ACHIEVE
TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE.
IF THERE'S ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD
THAT CAN DO THIS THAT CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
IN THE WORLD AND THE HEALTH OF
OUR OCEAN COAST IS A MAJOR PART
OF OUR SUCCESS.
WE MUST MAKE SURE EACH ASSISTANT
I DON'T BALLOT.
THANK YOU NEXT.
THE BRIEF HERE SO I WILL BE
BRIEF -- WITH MARKETS TRYING UP
COMMODITY PRICES IN THE TANK AN
INCREASE IN PROCESSING COSTS.
A RECYCLING PARADIGMS IN
SHAMBLES AB TEN EIGHTY IS A VERY
STRONG STARTING POINT HELPING
CHANGE RECYCLING PARADIGM.
BY REDUCING PRODUCTION.
AND THE USE OF NON RECYCLABLE
SINGLE USE PACKAGING CONTAINERS.
WE BELIEVE THAT BY DEVELOPING A
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY FOR
IDENTIFYING SINGLE USE PAT
PLASTIC PACKAGING.
WAS UNIQUE CHALLENGES AND BY
REQUIRING A FACE DOWN IN THE USE
OF NON RECYCLABLE NON.
YOU RE USABLE AND NON
COMPOSTABLE SINGLE USE PACKAGING
BY THE TEN TWENTY THIRTY THAT AB
TEN EIGHTY WILL REDUCE RECYCLING
CONTAMINATION.
HELP IMPROVE THE VALUE OF THE
MARK OF MARKET.
AND OF TRULY RECYCLABLE
COMMODITIES AND SPREAD SOME
RESPONSIBILITY TO PACKAGING
MANUFACTURES AND THUS HELP
REDUCE RECYCLING COSTS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND RATEPAYERS.
WE'RE JUST SUPPORT.
EXXON OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF AB
TEN EIGHTY PLEASE COME FORWARD
TO IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND SHARE
US SHARE YOUR PASSION.
WAS THERE A MERRILL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
BRENT ALSO SEE A CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT.
THEIR GOLFING HAVE LEAVING
CALIFORNIA CITIZEN SUPPORT WHEN
I THINK THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN AND
THE THE CHAIR FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
KATHY CARRIAGE THREE FIFTY BAY
AREA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
KELLY WAS SUSTAINABLE ROSS MORE
STRONG SUPPORT. EIGHTEEN A GAL
YOUR AND ROSALIE ROTH FIRST
FIFTY SACRAMENTO IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MARSHALL THE PERSON OF THIS
SPEED FOR THREE FIFTY SAN DIEGO
AND THREE FIFTY SILICON VALLEY
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
YOUR MESSAGE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF ALAMEDA AND SUPPORT.
COMMUNIQUES ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN TO SEE NUMBERS
SUSTAINABLE BUSINESS COUNCIL IN
STOCKS. THREE SEPARATE ON BEHALF
OF THE LOCAL ADMINISTRATORS OF
THE MIRE MENTAL HEALTH IN
SUPPORT I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED
REGISTER SUPPORT FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP.
HERE TOO SO ON BEHALF OF HERE
THE BAND THE CALIFORNIA COMPOST
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
GENEVIEVE EVAN ON BEHALF OF THE
THINGS HE'S LOVING COALITION AND
STRONG SUPPORT AND I'VE ALSO
BEEN ASKED TO REGISTER FOR
OCEANIC.
THANK YOU TO CREDIT WITH A NOT
TO RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
DEMI ON BEHALF OF A COLLEGE IN
NATALIE NEXT ON BEHALF OF
RETHINK WASTE OCEAN CONSERVANCY
FANS OF THE LA RIVER IN BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS IN
SUPPORT.
PARENTS AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
THESE IN SUPPORT.
BENJAMIN PORTER ON BEHALF OF
TELFORD IN SUPPORT.
HE WENT CHEN ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
EATING OUT ON BEHALF OF
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE IN SUPPORT.
ICAL HE'S WITH CALPERS STUDENTS
AT EIGHT AT THE UC'S IN SUPPORT.
NOTHING IN HOUSE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
JIM WHEN BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
THAT CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
BRONTE ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA REP
IS RECYCLING COUNCIL NORTHERN
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU JUST HERE ON BEHALF OF
STOP WASTE NATIONAL.
ACTION COUNCIL CALIFORNIA
PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL.
THE OF LOS ANGELES AND THREE OF
SANTA MONICA IN SUPPORT.
ANDREA VENTURE WITH CLEAN WATER
ACT IN SUPPORT.
OFFICE OF CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE IN SUPPORT.
YES HELLO AND SALAS WITH THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT I'M LET'S BRING UP THE
OPPOSITION I UNDERSTAND IT'S A
SPECIAL.
TRIFECTA OF OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
THE SLEEVE [inaudible]
AGREED [inaudible]
LET'S HEAR.
I GET AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TIM
JUST A WITH THE AMERICAN
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL -- LET ME
FIRST OFF BY SAYING.
WE HAVE MADE SOME PUBLIC
STATEMENTS.
THE INDUSTRY'S COMMITMENT TO
ACHIEVING.
VERY AGGRESSIVE -- STANDARDS FOR
RECYCLABILITY COULD POSSIBILITY
OF OF PLASTIC PACKAGING SO WE
ARE IN ALIGNMENT -- WITH CENTER
ALLEN SOMETHING AMERICANS
OFFICES.
LONG TERM VISION I THINK WHERE
WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS.
IS HOW THE BILL AS CURRENTLY
DRAFTED AND SOME OF THE ELEMENTS
THAT ARE THERE IN THE BILL.
IN A COUPLE OF AREAS I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT ONE IS.
THE BILL'S.
IN OUR READ A COMPLETE
DELEGATION OF AUTHORITY TAKE OUR
CYCLE TO DEVELOP IMPLEMENTING
REGULATIONS -- TO REACH THESE
GOALS AND THAT MAKES US FRANKLY
A LITTLE NERVOUS AS TO THE POWER
THEY CAL RECYCLE HAVE.
OVER THE PACKAGING INDUSTRY
WHETHER OR NOT THE BILL WOULD
ALLOW THEM TO ARBITRARILY PICK
AND CHOOSE WINNERS AND LOSERS IN
THE MARKET PLACE SAID -- RECYCLE
CONTENT STANDARDS IN ALL THIS
AUTHORITIES DELEGATED.
OVER THE COUNTER CYCLE SO THAT.
IS CERTAINLY.
AN AREA WHERE WE HAVE SOME
CONCERNS.
THE SECOND POINT I WANT TO RAISE
IS THAT WE HAVE SUGGESTED THAT
BEFORE THE BILL OR SET
ESTABLISHES SOME INTERIM
BENCHMARKS.
FOR PACKAGING RECYCLING RATES IN
COMPOSTING RATES THAT MUCH MORE
INFORMATION IS NEEDED FROM CAL
RECYCLE IN TERMS OF A VERY
DETAILED SCOPING PLAN OF THE
STATE'S EXISTING WASTE
COLLECTION INFRASTRUCTURE.
PROCESSING CAPABILITIES WHAT MAY
BE NECESSARY.
TO BUT MAYBE NEEDED IN TERMS OF
UPGRADES TO THOSE TO THOSE TO
THE STATE'S INFRASTRUCTURE TO
GET TO THESE TO THESE. TO THESE.
BENCHMARKS THAT THE BILL
ESTABLISHES SO WE THINK MUCH
MORE INFORMATION IS NEEDED TO
HELP INFORM WHAT THOSE.
INTERIM GOALS MAY BE TO GET TO
TO GET TO THE 75% THRESHOLD.
AND WE ALSO THINK THERE NEEDS TO
BE SOME FLEXIBILITY IN THOSE
STANDARDS.
BETWEEN NOW AND TWENTY THIRTY
BASED ON MARKET CONDITIONS.
NEW TECHNOLOGIES THAT CAME MAY
COME ON THE MARKET PLACE IN
TERMS OF PROCESSING THIS
MATERIAL.
SO. FOR INSTANCE ESTABLISHING A
20% RECYCLING RATE BY TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR AND A A PACKAGING
MATERIAL MAY GET 219% BUT AS THE
WAY THE BILL'S CURRENTLY DRAFTED
THERE'S A CONDITION OF SALE IF
YOU DON'T REACH 20% OF YOUR ME
THE OFF THE MARKET PLACE.
WHY I THINK WE NEED TO HAVE SOME
SOME FLEXIBILITY?
IN THAT WE ALSO THINK THAT.
THE BILL NEEDS TO LOOK AT HOW TO
DEAL WITH SOME OF THE REGULATORY
DUPLICATION THAT WE SEE COMING
DOWN BECAUSE THERE'S CURRENTLY
THE BOTTLE BILLS COMMITTEE KNOWS
THERE'S CAL RECYCLING COMMENCE
THE RIGID PLASTIC PACKAGING
CONTAINER LAW.
SO I THINK WE NEED TO HAVE SINCE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW WE AVOID
UNNECESSARY.
REGULATORY DUPLICATION.
WE'VE PUT TOGETHER SOME.
COMPREHENSIVE AMENDMENTS OF
SHARED WAS SENT ROUNDS FOLKS AND
AND AND MACHINES ALSO SPOKE TO
TO TRY TO ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
ISSUES.
AND WE THINK IT'S A GOOD WAY TO
GET. TO THE OBJECTIVE THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE AND AT THE END
OF REASONABLE AND REALISTIC
FASHION.
I WILL TOUCH ON ONE ONE ASPECT
OF THE PROVISIONS THAT WE'VE
SUGGESTED THAT I I CAN'T SPEAK
FOR ANY OF THE OTHER FOLKS AND
THE COALITION SUPPOSING THE BILL
BUT WE HAVE SUGGESTED.
A AN ADVANCE RECYCLING FEE.
FOR SOME OF OUR PACKAGING
PRODUCERS THOSE THAT ARE
PREDOMINANTLY IN THE TAKE OUT
FOOD SERVICE PACKAGING ARENA.
THAT ARE TRADITIONALLY.
HELD UP AS EXAMPLES OF MARINE
DEBRIS AND LITTER WHICH WE THINK
WOULD BE A SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTOR TOWARD HELPING.
FINANCE SOME OF THE NECESSARY
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS.
IMPROVEMENTS TO LITTER ABATEMENT.
PUBLIC EDUCATED ASSISTANCE TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SO THAT'S A
THAT'S A A PROPOSAL TO BE PUT ON
THE TABLE.
I KNOW SENATOR ALLEN AND SOME
AMERICANS ALSO PUTTING TOGETHER
A PROCESS TO TALK THROUGH JUST
SOME OF THESE ISSUES OVER THE
SUMMER RECESS [inaudible]
I THANK.
IT'S A TAD CONCERNING THAT WE
ARE AT THE LAST.
POLICY COMMITTEE MEETING.
SURROUNDS BILL WILL BE HEARD
MONDAY IN THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE.
AND WE STILL THINK THERE'S A
WHOLE LOT OF ISSUES THAT NEED TO
BE WORKED OUT BETWEEN NOW AND
THE IN THE SESSION WHAT'S THE
WEATHER NOT WE CAN DO THAT I
DON'T KNOW BUT WE'RE COMMITTED
TO DOING IT.
WE'VE LIKE I SAID SET SAT DOWN
AND AND PROPOSED SOME SOME
DETAIL AMENDMENTS.
HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET THERE WERE
IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE OVERALL
OBJECTIVE BUT AS THE BILL'S
CURRENTLY DRAFTED.
WE STILL HAVE SOME VERY SERIOUS
CONCERNS WITH WITH THE
PROVISIONS OF AND MORE WORK
NEEDS TO BE DONE SO THANK YOU
SIR THANK YOU NEXT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS IN
THREE MILLION ON BEHALF OF THE
GROCERY MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION CONSUMER PACKAGED
GOOD PRODUCERS ALWAYS SUPPORT
THE INTENT OF AB TEN EIGHTY AS
LONG AS IT ALIGNS WTH THE
CONSUMER PACKAGING.
GOODS -- UNIFIED GOALS OF
ENHANCING.
TAXI TO STAY ABILITY WE ARE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED AS OF
TODAY -- EVERYONE OF THE LARGEST
TWENTY FIVE C. P. G.COMPANIES
AS COMMITTED TO PRODUCING MORE
RECYCLABLE COMPOSTABLE PACKAGING
AND 80% HAVE ALREADY SET.
A TWENTY THIRTY DEADLINE FOR THE
PACKING TO BE FULLY RECYCLABLE
OR COMPOSTABLE.
HOWEVER THIS BILL IS CURRENTLY
DRAFTED THE BILL CREATES A
SYSTEM BY CONDITION OF SALE AS
MENTIONED BY TIM. FOR THE
MANUFACTURE WILL BEAR ALL THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE PRODUCT
WITHOUT ANY ABILITY TO IMPROVE
THE SYSTEM WHAT PROMOTE COST
EFFECTIVE SOLUTIONS.
ARE MANUFACTURERS CAN DESIGN FOR
RECYCLABILITY IN COMPOSED
ABILITY.
CAN NOT DESIGNED FOR THE MORE
THAN FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY WASTE
JURISDICTIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THEIR INDIVIDUAL
REQUIREMENTS. TO MAKE THIS WORK
WE BELIEVE A LONG TERM WE NEED
TO WORK ON THE DEFINITIONS IN
THE BILL EXPLORE OFF RAMPS
INVESTIGATE THE NEEDS OF THE WAY
SYSTEM AND RECYCLING SYSTEM
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND EXPLORE POSSIBLE TOOLS SUCH
AS WASTE GENERATOR FEES WE
REMAIN COMMITTED TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS IN
CONVERSATIONS ON THE PROCESS OF
THIS BILL -- BUT AS OF TODAY WE
REMAIN OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED
THANK YOU.
X..
AFTER THE CALVIN GROCERS
ASSOCIATION -- ECHOING THE
COMMENTS OF THE PREVIOUS TO SEE.
ALSO EMPHASIZE AND AND THANK THE
SENATOR AND AS A MEMBER GONZALEZ
BOTH AS WELL AS OUR STAFF -- FOR
FOR ENGAGING IN REALLY GOOD
DISCUSSIONS -- SPECIFICALLY --
ARE ISSUE THAT WANT TO KIND OF
POINT OUT TO THE COMMITTEE AND
AND TO FOLKS IS AS GROCERS --
YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN SUBJECT TO A
NUMBER OF LOCAL ORDINANCES ON
THIS ISSUE AND AND IN OUR
INDUSTRY IS IS ON THE CUTTING
EDGE OF A LOT OF SUSTAINABILITY
EFFORTS BECAUSE IT MAKES SENSE
FOR A BOTTOM LINE TO OUR
CUSTOMERS APPRECIATE IT.
THAT BEING SAID IF WE'RE LOOKING
AT A STATEWIDE A REGIME FOR FOR
THIS SORT OF OF OF OF THE
PACKAGING AND RECYCLING IN AND
WASTE.
REDUCTION I'M IT'S SO IMPORTANT
TO HAVE THE LEGIT YOU KEEP IN
MIND THAT WE WOULD ASK FOR SOME
SORT OF PRE EMPTION FOR LOCALS
BECAUSE YOU KNOW OUR COMMITMENT
TO TO THIS PROJECT IS WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT.
MUCH LIKE WE DID WITH PLASTIC
BAGS OF YEARS AGO TO PROVIDE A
STATEWIDE BILL -- TO TO PREVENT --
THE SORT OF PATCHWORK QUILT OF
OF ORDINANCES THAT WE FACE WHICH
IS WHY THE GROWTH SUPPORTED THE
THE SINGER'S PLASTIC BAG WE
WOULD SIMPLY ASK FOR THE SAME
SORT OF POLICY CONSIDERATION TO
SAY THAT -- IF WE COMMIT TO THIS
AND AND BUY INTO THIS.
YOU KNOW WE DON'T COME BACK
AFTER WORKING WITH THE SENATOR
AND AND IS A MEMBER TO HAVE
LOCALS COME IN AND AND YOU KNOW
AN ACTOR BUT TOWARDS IS THAT
THAT.
OUR UNACHIEVABLE -- INST SOME
INSTANCES SO THAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND THAT'S ABOUT IT MARIN.
ALL RIGHT OTHERS IN.
IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
TEN EIGHTY THANK YOU -- TIME
JACOB ON BEHALF OF THE CHEMICAL
INDUSTRY COUNCIL CALIFORNIA --
CHAIR THE PERSPECTIVES -- JUST
VOICED THANK YOU.
AND YOU HAVE BEEN ON BEHALF OF
AMERICA AND WE REPRESENT THE
TAXI MANUFACTURES CONSUMER GOOD
COMPANIES AND SOME OF THE
HOLLERS.
OPPOSE FOR THE REASONS ALREADY
STATED WANT TO STRESS THAT WE
HOPE THAT THE STAKEHOLDERS
PROCESS DOES RESULT IN SOME
SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS IN THE
SHORT TIME THAT WE HAVE LEFT.
I WANT TO STRESS THAT WE ALSO
HAVE OFFERED A PROPOSAL AND AND
SUGGESTIONS IN TERMS OF GETTING
TO SOME GOALS WOULD LIKE TO SEE
HIM SEE SOME ALIGNMENT WITH SOME
OF THE EUROPEAN.
ACTING DIRECTOR OF GOALS AND AND
USING THAT AS A BEGINNING STEP I
JUST APPRECIATE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE PROCESS.
WHEN ENCOURAGED -- TO THAT THAT
THE COMMITTEE AND AT THAT THE
SPONSORS CONSIDER TECHNOLOGICAL
COMMERCIAL VISIBILITY BECAUSE
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY
CRITICAL.
IF WE'RE GONNA MOVE FORWARD IN
THIS AREA THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN RESTRICT
HIS OF THE CALIFORNIA FOOD
PRODUCERS AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF
A MOVING FORWARD I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT FOOD SAFETY ISSUES
CONCERNED ABOUT I'M REPORTING
AND CRADLE TO GRAVE -- IN JUST
AGAIN LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
ON NARROWING THE DEFINITIONS IN
THERE IN THE SCOPE THE BILL TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CANNOT HAVE
SOME SIX AT THE END OF THE
PROCESS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON COOKING HOURS ON
BEHALF HOUSEHOLD AND COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION WITH IMPOSE
LAST MINUTE POSITION THANK YOU.
CENTER JOE ACTOR MEMBERS ON
BEHALF THE PLASTICS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION -- WE AGREE WITH THE
TWENTY THIRTY GOALS OF YOUR BILL --
WE BELIEVE WE CAN BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION.
BUT WE THINK WE NEED A
DEFINITELY MORE STRUCTURE AND
DIRECTION BEFORE WE PUT THIS
OVER TO CAL RECYCLE.
HOPE TO WORK WITH YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AFTER SHE
GERINGER WITH AGRICULTURAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA ALSO
RESPECTFULLY AND OPPOSITION FOR
SOME OF THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY
STATED AND HOPE TO WORK DURING
THE SUMMER RECESS AND NOT AROUND
IN THAT STAKEHOLDER PROCESS.
TO TRY TO ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE
FOOD SAFETY SCOPE ISSUES THAT
HAVE BEEN MENTIONED THANK YOU.
AT WRIGLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
OPPOSES BUT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORS --
DURING THE STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
THANKS.
I AM KEVIN MESSNER WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF HOME APPLIANCE
MANUFACTURERS WANT TO BRING A
LITTLE DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE ON
APPLIANCES THAT ARE DELIVERED TO
THE HOME.
A REFRIGERATOR.
WAY THOSE ARE SOLD FOR THE US
AND CANADA THERE ARE SOLD FROM
THE FACTORY TO A DISTRIBUTOR
REGIONAL DISTRIBUTOR A LOCAL
DISTRIBUTOR THEN TO A U. S.
NATIONAL US CANADA.
RETAILER.
AND THEN THEY ARE DELIVERED TO
THE HOME.
SO THEIR REQUIREMENTS IN THE
BILL THAT REQUIRE THE
MANUFACTURE TO PROVIDE HOW MUCH
IS SOUL WHAT QUANTITY IS SOLD IN
THE STATE.
AND THEN WITH THE RECYCLING
RATES ARE THEY HAVE THEY ARE
COULD PROTECT THEIR MANY STEPS
BEHIND.
ON THE ON THE STREAM OF COMMERCE
ON WAY TO DO THAT SO THEY CAN'T
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION I
PROBABLY DON'T KNOW IT SO THE
BILL IS CREATING REQUIREMENTS
FOR MANUFACTURERS THAT.
REALLY CANNOT BE MATT AS ONE OF
THERE ARE SOME TECHNICAL THINGS
THAT COULD BE RESOLVED TO JUST
MAKE SURE THAT WHAT'S REQUIRED.
CAN BE GIVEN BY THE
MANUFACTURERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DON KHAKI MCCUE CAP
CAN ASSOCIATES ON THE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION C. M. T.
A. AS WELL AS THE DISTILLED
SPIRITS COUNCIL ALSO IN
OPPOSITION TO THE REASONS STATED
BUT LOOK FORWARD TO THE
PARTICIPATING AND MYSTICAL.
THANK YOU.
MAYBE WE ON BEHALF OF THE
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS COUNCIL
ALSO OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS.
OKAY LET'S CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING
BRING IT BACKTO ME MEMBERS IF
YOU HAVE QUESTIONS.
MISSED BUT SEVEN CENTER BATES
HAVE QUIT ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR ON TEN AB.
ALL RIGHT YOU MAY CLOSE.
WELL I REALLY DO APPRECIATE ALL
THE THE INPUT FROM FROM
EVERYBODY WEEK I  ACTUALLY
WOULD PARTICIPATE IN A
STAKEHOLDER MEETING MYSELF --
LAST WEEK AND AND THERE WILL BE
ROBUST DISCUSSIONS HAPPENING
WITH ALL THE VARIOUS FOLKS FROM
THE ADVOCACY SIDE FROM THE
HOLLERS FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
FROM THEIR SECOND COMMUNITY AND
THEN FROM INDUSTRY -- AND WE'RE
GONNA BE WORKING REALLY HARD
OVER THE NEXT -- MOTHER. TO TO
TO TRY TO PULL TOGETHER FEASIBLE
PLAN I THINK THAT -- YOU KNOW I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT THE YOU KNOW THAT THEIR
FOLKS HERE WHO ARE STRETCHING
AND THEY'VE COME UP AND THEY
SAID YOU KNOW OF WE ALL KNOW WE
NEED TO MOVE IN THIS DIRECTION
WE ACTUALLY NEED TO TAKE
DRAMATIC STEPS IN THIS DIRECTION.
THE QUESTION IS YOU KNOW HOW DO
WE HAD A CRAFT THOSE DETAILS AND
THAT'S WHAT THE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS THAT YOU'VE.
HEARD ALLUDED TO I REPEATEDLY IS
GOING TO BE ALL ABOUT THE END OF
THE DAY THIS IS ABOUT.
GETTING A HANDLE ON OUR WASTE
MANAGEMENT CRISIS -- PROVIDING
RELIEF FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
IN THE END OF THE DAY AND THIS
IS ONE THING I SAID TO THE
STAKEHOLDERS ONLY MATT.
HELPING TO CRAFT A A REALLY
VIABLE.
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM THAT
CAN BE SOLD AND SCALED. TO THE
REST THE WORLD.
AND WHAT I SAID EVERYBODY LAST
WEEK WAS THAT I ACTUALLY THINK
THAT WE WOULD HAVE I WOULD
CONSIDER THIS WHOLE EFFORT TO
HAVE BEEN A FAILURE.
IF WE DON'T CROSS SOMETHING THAT --
THAT THAT OTHER JURISDICTIONS
OTHER STATES OTHER NATIONS WANT
TO REPLICATE -- AND THE ONLY WAY
THAT WE DO THAT IS IF WE DO
SOMETHING THAT IS BOTH
MEANINGFUL IN TERMS OF REAL
WASTE REDUCTION.
AND ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE.
I BECAUSE OF THE JURISDICTIONS
ARE GOING TO DO IT IF THEY SEE
THISIS SOMETHING THAT'S GOING
TO HARM THEIR ECONOMIES BECAUSE
THE END OF THE DAY WE CAN BE WE
HAVE THE MOST GREEN POLICIES IN
THE WORLD BUT IF WE'RE NOT ABLE.
TO GET OTHER FOLKS TO ADOPT
THESE PLICIES ARE WE WON'T HAVE
REALLY MADE IT THE KIND OF
DIFFERENCE WE NEED TO MAKE FOR
OUR CHILDREN -- AND AND THIS IS
ONE OF THOSE AREAS ARE WE HAVE
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE -- BECAUSE
THE THE CURRENT PACE THE CURRENT.
THE CURRENT.
APPROACH IS IS IS FINALLY AT THE
STATE LEVEL.
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
REBEL.
HELD.
PROCEDURALLY I'M.
VERY QUICKLY I'M SORRY I DIDN'T
HEAR ABOUT WHETHER US.
SENATOR ALLEN YOU RESPONDED IN
TERMS OF CAL RECYCLE HAVING SO
MUCH OF FORTY IN TERMS OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION.
I BELIEVE WHICH IS STARTING WHEN
I LEFT I THINK ONE OF THE THOSE
OPPOSING IT ON BASICALLY A LOT
OF THE CONCERN IF THERE.
WHICH YOU ARE WORKING ON ABOUT
ALSO THAT ARE YEAH NO THAT'S
OKAY.
YOU KNOW.
I MEAN IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
THAT THERE BE.
THIS NOT JUST BE.
I'M SENT A GREAT STATEMENT OF
PRINCIPLES THE DON KNAPP YEAH WE
HAVE TEETH -- BUT I ALSO
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS OF BEEN
RAISING THIS IS THIS IS ONE OF
THE ONE OF THE BIG ISSUES IS
GONNA BE.
A GRAPPLED WITH THE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS.
I JUST THINK THAT HAS THE
LEGISLATORS AND REPRESENTATIVES
AROUND PEOPLE WE KEEP THE PEOPLE
INVOLVED HERE WHEN YOU
INCENTIVIZE THEM WHICH WE CAN DO
WITH VERSUS THE BUREAUCRACY
BEING ABLE TO DO THAT.
IT WILL BE MORE SUCCESSFUL SO I
WANT US TO HAVE CONTINUE TO HAVE
A MEANINGFUL ROLE IN NOW.
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE SO RESISTANT
TO GOVERNMENT TELLING THEM WHAT
TO DO -- I DON'T KNOW I GUESS
THEY DON'T LIKE US TELLING THEM
WHAT TO DO EITHER BUT MAYBE WE
DEAL WITH A SOFTER.
YOU KNOW FIVE TO LIE TO
OURSELVES BUT ANYWAY I JUST WANT
TO HAVE THAT ON THE RECORD
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
TOO SAM CENTER BATES I APOLOGIZE
YOUR THE VICE JUST I CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE LET ME HAVE THE
GAVEL TO YOU AND DOES IT MAKE
YOU IS THE PRESIDING OFFICER ON
SB.
TEN EIGHTY I MOVED THE BILL
[inaudible]
AS GREAT.
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN A. B. TEN
EIGHTY MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ALLEN
BY ALLEN HI BATES [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
SKINNER.
STERN AYE CASKEY.
BECAUSE HE I ONE CALL GIVE THE
ROLE OF AND AND WE CAN
[inaudible]
THE ONE THE PASCAL OKAY ALL
RIGHT SO THANK YOU WHAT A WHAT A
LONG AND AN EXCITING DAY -- BUT
I BUT I WILL SAY I I'M YOU KNOW.
PROUD OF THE FACT THAT I WAS
GONNA BE ABLE TO GET BACK TO
THEIR DISTRICTS FOR FOR THE JOY --
THERE IT WASN'T ALWAYS IN THE
CARDS WHEN THIS WITH THIS
HEARING WAS FIRST SET -- OKAY
LET'S START WITH ITEM ONE THIS
IS THAT WE CASKEY BILL THE
BATTLE CONVENTION WE NEED TO WE
NEED A MOTION ON THAT.
THAT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
BATES.
THAT'S OUR FORTY SEVEN SURGERY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ITEM NUMBER
ONE AS OUR FORTY SEVEN THE
MOTIONS DO PASS ALLEN.
HI ALLEN HI BATES.
BATES AYE DALY [inaudible]
HILL.
HILL AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
EARN I Y. CASKEY HI CASKEY BY
RESEARCHER DURING THE
CONSIDERATION OF AB SEVEN TWENTY
NINE I DID MAKE A MOTION THAT
WAS NOT RECOGNIZED BY YOU AND I
WOULD.
APPEAL THAT A CONSIDERATION
RIGHT NOW THAT YOU RECOGNIZE THE
MOTION I DO PASS ON A. B. A
SEVEN TWENTY NINE AS AMENDED I'M
HAPPY TO MENTION I'D JUST FOR
THE OTHER MEMBERS IT WAS NOT
RECOGNIZED BECAUSE IT WASN'T IN
THE ROOM.
I WAS PRESENTING BUT BUT YES I'M
HAPPY TO MET TO TO RECOGNIZE IT
NOW AND WHEN WE GET TO THAT ITEM
WE I'M.
WE WE WILL WE WILL.
WE WILL RECOGNIZE IT.
WITH MORE ROBUST.
THE BUS IF REQUESTED A OKAY SO
IT'S GOOD ITEM NUMBER -- TWO BUT
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO HOLD THE ALL
THE BUT WE NEED THE CONSENT
DOLLARS WELL LET'S SEE THE
CONSENT COUNTER.
AND THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS
NUMBER TWELVE THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY THREE HILL.
HILL AYE STERN.
THE SECOND THAT ARE.
STERN AYE OKAY SO WE'LL CLOSER
ANOTHER SEVEN IS -- THAT'S A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR THAT OKAY
WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA LEAVE
OTHER BASIL CAM IT'S ONE OF AND
FOR CENTER SKINNER TO ADD ON
WE'RE NOT GOOD ITEM THREE THIS
IS TINGS.
AB ONE SIXTY ONE THIS IS THE
PAPER WAYS PROOF OF PURCHASE
RECEIPTS BILL.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB ONE SIX ONE
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CHAIRED VOTING I BY ST REDDING
NO [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
EARN HI.
OKAY THAT'S FIVE TO TWO NOW WE
CAN CLOSE THE ROLE IN THAT CASE
CENTER SKINNER HAS BEEN ABLE TO
SO NEXT WE WILL GO.
I'M SO SORRY OKAY ADD ITEM TO
TAINT AB SIXTY EIGHT THIS IS HIS
EIGHTY YOUR BILL.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB SIXTY EIGHT
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE COMMITTEE.
CHAIR VOTING I TWO ZERO HILL.
HILL I SKINNER.
STERN NO STERN NO. THREE OKAY
pAND ON A THREE TO ONE VOTE NOW.
OKAY ONE MEXICO TO ADD YOUR
CURRY'S AB ONE SIXTY EIGHT THIS
ITEM NUMBER FOR THIS HAS TO DO
STREAMLINED APPROVALS.
ABILITY TO TRAVEL.
RESOURCES ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
ONE SIXTY EIGHT MOTIONS DO
PASSED THE SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE CHAIR VOTING I
BY SERVING I FOUR ZERO HELLO.
HILL AYE SKINNER.
STERN STERN HI.
S. AT SIX ZERO OKAY BETTER
PROVISIONS CANADA AND ON NOW
WE'LL GO TO SOMEWHERE QUIRK
SPILL ON THAT.
WE'LL FIND.
ONE INVOLVING AQUA AND AND FUNNY
STABILIZATION IS AB -- FOR TO IN.
OH MY GOD.
OKAY. TWO NINETY SIX AB TWO
NINETY SIX NUMBER FIVE THIS
COOLEY SPELL.
I AM NUMBER FIVE AB TWO NINETY
SIX MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
THE SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE CHAIR VOTING I
ADVISED HER VOTING I FOUR ZERO
HELLO.
HILL AYE SKINNER.
STERN STERN HI THERE HOWEVER
PERCENT CAN OKAY NOW WE'RE
ACCORDING TO ALL THIS IS THE I
AM SIXTY BEFORE -- TO ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB -- FOR TO MOTIONS
DO PASSED SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CHAIRED VOTING AYE
BATES [inaudible]
SALLY.
HILL RIGHT NOW I SKINNER
[inaudible]
STERN.
HI STERN I YOU'RE ALL THAT OFTEN
FOR CENTER SKINNER THAT US FOUR
ZERO NOW NOW WE GO ON TO THIS IS
GLORIOUS BILL.
NUMBER SEVEN AB.
FOR TWENTY THREE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB FOR TWENTY THREE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CHAIRED
VOTING I BY SERVING NO.
TWO ONE DALY.
NOW I KNOW HILL.
HILL AYE SKINNER.
STERN STERN HI.
LOOK AT FORTY TWO OKAY NEXT WAS
ON THE PRO THE HIGHLIGHT OF THE
DAY THIS IS I AM EIGHT A. B. FOR
THIRTY GALLAGHER SPELL.
ON LET'S FIRST TAKE A VOTE -- AS
HE AGREED. TWO OF AS ACCEPTING
AMENDMENTS D. THROUGH US -- I AM
OFF TO THE BILL -- AND FOR NOW
BUT LET'S SEE WHERE THE VOTES
GONNA.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB.
FOUR THIRTY QUESTION IS DO PASS
AS AMENDED THE SENATE GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
ALAN [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
STERN I IN THE VOTER HAS VOTED
UP OR LEAVE IT OPEN FOR CENTER
SKINNER THAT ON THAT'S FOUR TO
ONE NOW -- WILL NOW GO TO AYE
AYE SILVER JEWS BILL THIS IS AB.
FIVE OH EIGHT ITEM NUMBER NINE
AB FIVE OH EIGHT THE MOTION IS
DO PASS AS AMENDED DOES THERE
SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE CHAIR VOTING AYE
[inaudible] ZERO BATES.
I AM NINE AB FIVE ALWAYS USUALLY.
DRINKING WATER BILL.
BATES.
DALY.
I KNOW HILL.
HILL AYE SKINNER.
STERN [inaudible]
STERN AYE.
WHO CARES FOR A -- ONE WE WILL
CALL THE ROLL FOR SKINNER.
OKAY NOW WE'RE GONNA CHOOSE --
CARPET DEL.
CAN I WOULD ASK YOU WANT JUST
ANOTHER HE'S MOVING THE BILL.
WILL RECOGNIZE THAT MOTION --
THIS WOULD BE TO PASS TO THE
SENATE JUDICIARY.
THE BEST AMENDED AND THEN ON TO
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
AFTER REGISTERING.
THIS IS A CARGO ANYA AT FIRST.
AT ITEM NUMBER TEN A. B. SEVEN
TWENTY NINE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
ALLEN ALL RIGHT ALLEN HI BATES
NO BATES NOTES ALLEY.
KELLY HI HILL.
HILL AYE SKINNER.
THIS IS TWO SEVEN TWENTY NINE
CARPET.
SKINNER AYE STERN.
STERN AYE CASKEY.
CASKEY ICE.
CATFISH TO ONE WILL CALL THE
ROLL ON NOT.
NOW GOING TO CHANGE THE BILL --
RELATE A MINIMUM RECYCLE CONTENT
IS AB.
SEVEN NINETY TWO ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN AB SEVEN NINETY TWO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CHAIRMAN CHAIR VOTING I THREE
ZERO BATES [inaudible]
VALLEY.
HELLO NO OF THIS TEAM'S.
SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN NINETY
TWO THE NOVEL RIGHT NOW.
REMEMBER DON'T KNOW YOU WERE
SAYING BEFORE.
YES I WANT TO KNOW A NUMBER AT
EVEN IF YOU WERE HERE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THE KNOWN NOW [inaudible]
HELLO.
HELLO I THINK YOU TO STERN.
ALRIGHT AB.
SEVEN NINETY NINE OKAY WILL
CALDERON AT THAT IS NOW.
I HAD. TO FIVE TO ONE OR CALL
THE ROLL OKAY.
VETERANS AS NEXT.
ROBERT RIVAS IS STILL AB NINE
THIRTY SIX IT HAS ALREADY BEEN
MOVED BY SOME ACCOUNTS.
THIS IS ITEM.
FIFTEEN THOSE ROCK IN FACT OUT
ISN'T [inaudible]
OKAY.
I'M ON A COURSE AROUND SALAS
[inaudible]
THE TITAN SALLY.
DALY NO HILL.
NOW I SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN.
STERN AYE OKAY SO THAT'S FIVE TO
ONE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE ON THAT
OKAY THIS IS CELIS IS AB.
NINE SEVENTY SORRY JUST QUICK
QUESTION AS CHAIR OF THE IT IS
HERE NEAR ZERO AND ZERO OR ONLY
EASIER.
YOU KNOW WHAT.
THE LAST NIGHT.
RIGHT RIGHT ZERO WHEN YOU'RE.
HEROES ARE MODELED AFTER CARS
HAD [inaudible]
YEAH.
WE HAD ALL.
THE THERE COULD HAVE BEEN IN
OPPOSITION THEY THEY SWITCHED IN
NEUTRAL OKAY -- BECAUSE THE
AMOUNT OKAY OKAY NOW YOU TRUMP
HELP YEAH.
CLINTON YEAH NINE SEVENTY ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN AB NINE SEVENTY
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
CHAIRED VOTING I AM.
BATES HI BATES AYE.
HILL.
HELLO I SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN.
STERN AYE. SIX SIX TWO ZERO WILL
CALL THE ROLL ON THAT WE'RE NOT
A GOOD OF CALDERON'S -- THIS IS
AB NINE SEVENTY FIVE WE WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. FOR THAT
MOVE BY CENTERS STERN I THINK
THE CO AUTHOR.
A SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB NINE
SEVENTY FIVE QUESTION IS DO
PASSED THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
ALLEN HI ELLEN HI BATES HI BATES
I'D DALY.
HILL.
HILL AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN [inaudible]
STERN HI [inaudible]
THAT'S FIVE TWO ZERO WE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE.
ON THAT.
OKAY WILL NOW GO TO THINGS.
AND SEE IF YOUR P. RELATED BILLS
AB.
TEN FORTY SIX ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN A. B. TEN FORTY SIX
MOTION IS TO PASS CLOSE THE ROLE
IN THAT THAT IS A FIVE TO TWO
FINAL VOTE.
NOW THIS IS -- GONZALEZ BUILDING
WE JUST HEARD -- CIRCULAR
CONDAMINE PLASTICS REDUCTION AB.
TEN EIGHTY ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN
AB.
TEN EIGHTY MOTIONS DO PASS AS
AMENDED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CHAIR
VOTING HI. TWO ZERO SIX DOLLY.
HILL.
HILL AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN.
STERN I YES FIVE ZERO WILL CALL
THE ROLL ON THAT -- NOW WILL GO
TO HOLDEN SPILL.
I'M REALLY INTO -- TO WELLS OF
OIL WELLS IS AB.
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT THE MOST MOTION AS DO PASS
AS AMENDED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CHAIRED VOTING I VICE YOU'RE
VOTING I FOUR ZERO HILL.
HILL AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN.
STERN AYE.
THAT'S SEVENTY ZERO WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE ON THAT -- NOW CARILLO
THIS BILL HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCES --
MEMO BY WOOD CASKET.
THE MEMBERS ARE WE WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR FIFTEEN
HUNDRED AB.
FIFTEEN HUNDRED MOVE BY JERRY
HELL.
AND SEARCHES PLEASE KALRA ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY TWO A. B. FIFTEEN
HUNDRED THE MOTION MOST
CHRISTIAN AS DO PASSED THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE BATES.
IT SNOWED VALLEY.
HILL.
HILL AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE
STERN.
STERN IOWA CAL SKI.
OKAY HE IS IN.
CITY WALK HE SAID HE'S COMING
HE'S COMING BACK OKAY WILL KEEP
THE ROLE OF AN ANSWER.
ON THAT AS FOUR TO ONE WE'LL
KEEP DROPPING PERCENT WHAT
CASKEY.
OKAY NOW GO TO I DIDN'T USE AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE THIS US TO
DO WITH THEM WATER SOURCE FROM
CORPORATIONS CONSOLIDATION.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FOUR AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE MOTION
MOTION AS DO PASS AS AMENDED THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CHAIR VOTING I THREE ZERO BATES
HI BATES AYE HILL.
HILL AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN.
STERN HI THAT'S A SEVEN ZERO SO
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN THAT OKAY
LET'S LET'S GO BACK SIR.
IF YOU JUST ASK [inaudible]
THE NUMBER.
OKAY -- IF SYSTEM WHICH HAS
THESE FOLKS ARE LISTENING -- YOU
KNOW WILL GIVE ME A COUPLE
MINUTES IF YOU WANT TO RUN BACK
AND VOTE FOR A. B. FIFTEEN
HUNDRED WE DO NOT HAVE A VOTE --
MARK FOR HIM ON AB FIFTEEN UNDER
THE EYES WILL CLOSE THE ROLE TO
GIVE A CALL AND SEE IF YOU WANT
TO COME BACK.
OKAY LET'S GO BACK TO THE ROLE
SO THAT CENTER SKINNER CAN ADD
ON TO A NUMBER OF THESE BLLS.
THE FIRST.
ONE WE WILL -- WE'LL HAVE IS THE
BASIL CONVENTION WHEN THIS IS
WHAT COUNTIES S. R. FORTY SEVEN
ITEM.
ONE ITEM NUMBER. ONE FORTY SEVEN
FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO SKINNER.
I SKINNER NINE SIX ZERO OKAY
WILL CLOSER ON A SIX ZERO THIS
IS NEXT TEAMS EIGHTY YOU BILLS
EIGHTY AB.
SIXTY EIGHT ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
SIXTY EIGHT THE MOTION MOTION AS
DO PASSED THE SENATE GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE.
AB JEOPARDY I THREE ONE SKINNER.
SKINNER I FORTY MINIATURE VOTING
I PLACED YOUR VOTING I SIX ZERO
SKINNER.
HI. SEVEN ZERO WILL CLOSER ON
THAT COOLEY SPELL A. B..
NINE THREE TWO NINE SIX IN
NINETEEN NINETY SIX ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB TWO NINETY SIX THE
MOTION IS D. PASSES AMENDED TO
SENATE SENATE.
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE COMMITTEE.
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING I
SIX ZERO SKINNER.
SKINNER HI OKAY SEVEN ZERO CLOSE
THE ROLE ON THAT -- ASSUME
RECORDS AB.
FOUR ZERO TWO ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
FOUR ZERO TWO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CHAIRED BY VOTING I FOUR ZERO
SKINNER.
IN IRVINE.
SAYS FIVE ZERO WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE ON THAT.
GLORIOUS BILL AB FOR TWENTY
THREE SAN DIEGO COUNTY OPPOSE
CONTROL DOESN'T MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ITEM NUMBER.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB FOR TWENTY
THREE QUESTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CHAIRED
VOTING I BY SCRIBBLING NOTES.
FOR TO SKINNER.
SKINNER I FIND THE TWO BECAUSE
THE ROLE ON THAT -- GALLAGHER IS
A. B..
FOUR THIRTY ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB
FOR THIRTY THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO SENATE GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE WITH HIM HAVING
ACCEPTED MEN'S DE THROUGHOUT
[inaudible]
AB ALLEN [inaudible]
SKINNER.
I GUESS FIVE TO ONE WILL CALL
THE ROLL ON THAT.
AND THIS SUMMER CHOOSE STREAKING
WATERS BILL THIS IS ON AB FIVE
AWAY.
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB FIVE OH
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE CHAIR VOTING I
FOR ONE BATES [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
WIENER HI. ONE JEFF I WON'T CALL
THE ROLL -- OKAY HI THIS IS.
NOW THIS BRINGS US. TO NINETY
SIX CARILLO AS WELL -- HAS OUR
SERVICES AB.
FIVE FIFTEEN HUNDRED ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY TWO AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED
MOTION IS DO YOU PASS THIS YEAR
A COMMITTEE. SEVEN I PLACER
VOTED.
NO FOUR ONE LIKE CASKEY.
MAKOWSKI HI.
OKAY I THINK THAT I THINK THAT
COVERS EVERYTHING [inaudible]
ANY.
I THINK WE GOT EVERYBODY.
WE GOT HER UP ON CONSENT TO
SOMEONE ELSE.
ARIZA YEAH WE GOT SKINNER ON
EVERYTHING OKAY [inaudible]
YOU.
INTERESTING HEARING TODAY AND I
DO APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S HARD
WORK PARTICULARLY THE HARD WORK
OF OUR STAFF BOTH IN THE
MINORITY AND COMMITTEE SIDE.
HAVE YOU FOR THE JULY.
AND GO U. S. WOMEN ON SUNDAY AND
YEAH.
U. S. MAN IN THE GOLD CUP IT'S A
LOT A OTHER GOOD STUFF THAT'S
RIGHT WAS GIVEN PAID BETTER.
THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED